ASSEMBLY.
AND WE STILL HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT
A CLONING PROCESS BUT MOST OF
THE PEOPLE I KNOW WHICH IS TO
SOON NOT HAVE ME CLONED.
SO.
I'M HERE.
AND ALL THE GIANTS FOR THE DELAY
IN GETTING STARTED.
WE WILL START AS HIS SUB
COMMITTEE I KNOW A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO SIT ON THIS
COMMITTEE ARE ALSO PRESENTING IN
OTHER.
COMMITTEE SO WE WILL START AS A
SUB COMMITTEE.
OF WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WE'VE GOT
A BIG CROWD AND A HUGE --
CALENDAR FOR TODAY WE ARE GOING
TO START BY TAKING UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS IS A TWO MEASURES
THEN WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN SPILLED --
WOULD LIKE TO TRY TO CLEAR OUT
AS MUCH AS WE CAN -- WE HAVE THE
SMALLEST HEARING ROOM TODAY --
IN PART BECAUSE WE'RE STARTING
SO EARLY -- WITH -- WITH ALL THE
BILLS WE HAVE TO TAKE UP.
SO WE WILL TAKE UP -- FILE ITEM.
ONE A. B. NINE FIRST AND THEN
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB.
ONE SEVENTY NINE THEN WE WILL
TAKE UP WE HAVE A SERIES OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN BILLS.
AND THEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU.
WHO ALSO HAS A COUPLE BILLS AND
FILE WILL CONTINUE GOING UNTIL --
WE HAVE TO TAKE A NOON BREAK WE
HAVE CAUCUS.
WILL BE BACK AT ONE THIRTY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WHICH IS A
LITTLE BIGGER THAN THIS -- HAN
DA -- WE'LL HEAR FROM. FOR I AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU THAT WILL BE
OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS AT
ONE THIRTY AND HOPEFULLY WILL BE
ABLE TO MOVE THIS ALONG.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
PLEASE -- IF YOU'RE HERE FOR ANY
THESE BILLS THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO BE HEARD TODAY -- YOU'RE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO STAY BUT OF THEM
NOT BE MUCH OF INTEREST TO YOU
IS SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT. TO
AB FOUR FOUR SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI THAT'S BEEN PULLED.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY AND AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHILD THOSE BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED AND WILL NOT BE HEARD.
WE ALSO HAVE FIFTEEN ITEMS ON
THE PROMOTE PROPOSED -- AB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX BERMAN HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM CONSENT SO THAT WILL
BE HEARD -- BUT THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS ARE ON CONSENT AND I WANT
TO GIVE A MAJOR SHOUT OUT TO THE
JUDICIARY STAFF FOR WORKING SO
HARD TO PUT THESE BILLS.
IN SHAPE.
AND TO TO TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THEM ON CONSENT.
OUR FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB FIVE
THIRTY ONE FRIEDMAN FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY
EGGMAN FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO A.
B. SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT BY
SANTIAGO WITH AMENDMENTS.
FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT BY GIPSON WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM THIRTY AB --
EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR BY IRWIN FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE AB TEN SIXTY
FIVE BY BERMAN WITH AMENDMENTS
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB.
TEN SIXTY EIGHT BY COOLEY WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FIVE ELEVEN SIXTEEN
GRAYSON WITH AMENDMENTS FILE
ITEM THIRTY SIX A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN BY RAYSON.
WITH AMENDMENTS.
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR A. B.
TWELVE FIFTY ONE BY SANTIAGO
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB THIRTEEN
OH ONE BY COOLEY -- THIS A CHILD
WELFARE ADOPTION MEASURE FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIVE BY CHAU FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
TWO BY MARK STONE.
AND VITAL EXCUSE ME FILE TEM.
FIFTY NINE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN
BY TRUE WITH AMENDMENTS AND
FINALLY.
FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX BY CALDERON.
THOSE BILLS WILL BE.
VOTED ON ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
AND AT THIS POINT WE WILL START
WE'RE LEFT WITH ABOUT I THINK
FORTY NINE OR FIFTY BILLS THAT
WE'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE TO
HEAR TODAY.
SO I AM GOING TO DEFINITELY MAKE
SURE THAT WE FOLLOW THE RULES OF
THIS COMMITTEE WHICH ARE THAT
EACH MEASURE THERE WILL BE TWO
MAIN WITNESSES. TWO MINUTES EACH
AND IT TWO MINUTES -- I WILL CUT
YOU OFF -- SO PLEASE TRY TO GET
YOUR COMMENTS IN THE THOSE OF
YOU WHO WILL BE SPEAKING TO MAIN
WITNESSES TO MANAGE EACH FOR
SUPPORT.
FOLLOW BY THOSE WHO ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT TO COME UP TO THE MIKE
GIVE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
ONLY PLEASE.
I'M WOULD CUT YOU OFF I
APOLOGIZE BUT THERE'S JUST TOO
MUCH.
BUT TO MANY BILLS HERE TODAY.
WE WILL HAVE THEN TWO MAIN
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH IN
OPPOSITION AND THEN OTHERS WHO
ARE.
IN OPPOSITION COME FORWARD YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND
INDICATING OF COURSE SURE
OPPOSITION.
THIS IS -- AGAIN THE ME TO
STRESS STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION SO THAT WE CAN GET
THROUGH THIS HEARING -- BEFORE
TEN O'CLOCK TONIGHT BUT WE MAY
BE GOING UNTIL TEN O'CLOCK SO.
LET US GET STARTED AT THIS POINT
IN TIME AND WE'LL START WITH
FILE ITEM ONE THIS IS AB NINE
FIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY IT'S
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I PRESENT TO YOU EIGHTY NINE THE
SHARE ACT THE STOP HARASSMENT
AND REPORTING EXTENSION ACT
WHICH EXTENDS OF TIME FOR FILING
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
CLAIMS UNDER THE CALIFORNIA.
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
CURRENTLY HARASSMENT VICTIMS
FILE THE CLAIM WITHIN ONE YEAR
OR THE FACE AN ABSOLUTE TIME BAR
AND WILL BE UNABLE TO SEEK
ADMINISTRATIVE OR CIVIL REDRESS
IN COURT.
THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND THIS
FILING PERIOD FROM ONE YEAR TO
THREE YEARS ALLOWING VICTIMS
ADDITIONAL TIME TO SEEK THIS
REDRESS AND MAKING IT MORE
CONSISTENT WITH THE FILING TIME
LIMITS FOR OTHER ACTIONS
[inaudible]
LEGISLATURE LIKE.
LIKE MANY INDUSTRIES HAS BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH THE CHANGES IN
THE WAKE OF THE ME TO MOVEMENT
PARTICULARLY AFTER THE SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS AGAINST A
MEMBERS OF OUR OWN BODY.
HOWEVER THESE ISSUES ARE NOT
LIMITED TO THE HALLS OF
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT MOST
CLAIMS OF INJURY HAVE LONGER
FILING PERIODS AND FILING
DEADLINES FOR EXAMPLE THE TIME
TO FILE AN ACTION FOR PERSONAL
INJURY IS TWO YEARS. FOR FRAUD
THREE YEARS IN FOR CONTRACT
DISPUTES FOUR YEAR TIME LIMIT.
AB NINE IS A DIRECT RESPONSE TO
PROVIDE VICTIMS WITH AN ADEQUATE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK REDRESS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS JESSICA STANDER
SENIOR COUNSEL WITH EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND JACKIE SERRANO
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL WITH
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN IT
SHOWS SO THAT WE ARE CLEAR -- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU ARE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN
COMMENTS SIX ON PAGES FIVE AND
SIX CORRECT VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
TWO MINUTES PLEASE GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JESSICA
STENDER AND I'M AN ATTORNEY
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND SAN
FRANCISCO PROUD BECAUSE SPONSOR
OF AB. NINE FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
WE REPRESENT AND HARD WORKING
EMPLOYEES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WHO EXPERIENCE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND OTHER FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION.
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
FACE MARRIED OBSTACLES THE
COMING FORWARD MANY OF THEM FEAR
RETALIATION -- ESPECIALLY FROM
THE HARASSER HIMSELF OR HERSELF
AND THE EMPLOYER I. AND
SOMETIMES THAT THOSE FORMS
RETALIATION CAN EVEN RESULT IN
JOB LOSS.
OTHERS OFTEN DON'T COME FORWARD
BECAUSE THE TRAUMA OF WHAT
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED AND THESE
FEARS ARE PARTICULARLY
PRONOUNCED FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS
WERE OFTEN UNAWARE OF THEIR
RIGHTS -- AND AND WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO THEM IS ILLEGAL --
MANY DON'T SPEAK OUT RIGHT AWAY
BECAUSE OF THESE FEARS AND BY
THE TIME THEY FIND OUT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO THEM IS ILLEGAL
THEY'RE VERY SHORT ONE YOU'RE
SUCH A LIMITATION HAS TOLD AND
THEY'RE NO LONGER ABLE TO BRING
ANY CLAIM.
MANY WORKERS EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND NOT N A VACUUM
THE EXPERIENCE OTHER FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION AS WELL AN
INTERSECTIONAL DISCRIMINATION
BASED ON SEX RACE NATIONAL
ORIGIN IS VERY COMMON.
AND THUS IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THIS TIME MIGHT BE EXTENDED FOR
ALL FORMS OF DISCRIMINATION THAT
ARE PROHIBITED UNDER OUR FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT.
HARASSMENT IS AN INSIDIOUS HARM
THAT DENIES EMPLOYEES AN
EQUITABLE WORKPLACE VICTIMS OF
TIME TO FILE THEIR CLAIMS WITH
THE D. AT THE AGE THAT IS
COMMENSURATE WITH OTHER TYPES OF
CIVIL ACTIONS ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE BARRIERS THAT MANY
WORKERS FACE.
AND A PARTICULAR PRONOUNCE
BARRIERS THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS
FACE FOR THESE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY WITH REQUEST RIVAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JACQUI
STERN ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ALSO ONE OF THE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE.
AB NINE WILL GIVE VICTIMS MORE
TIME TO BRING THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS
CLAIMS UNDER THE FOR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT.
THE CULTURAL RECKONING OF THE ME
TOO MOVEMENT HAS MADE MANY
VICTIMS AWARE THAT THEY HAD
RIGHTS THAT WERE NOT ONLY BEING
VIOLATED BUT THAT THERE WAS A
SOCIETAL NEED TO CORRECT THE
HARMS. TO PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING TO OTHERS.
SILENCE AROUND DISCRIMINATION
HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT IS
FINALLY BEING BROKEN AND PEOPLE
NEED TO HAVE AN AVENUE TO
ENFORCE THEIR RIGHTS.
THE ONE YEAR DEADLINE WAS SET IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE WE THINK
IT'S TIME TO BE MODERNIZED TO
REFLECT THE NEEDS OF OUR MODERN
STATE.
GIVING VICTIMS MORE TIME THE
FATHER CLAIMS WILL ALLOW THEM TO
HOLD PERPETRATORS ACCOUNTABLE WE
ARE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF FOOD
STEP FORWARD NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
I'M SURE MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT FOR
THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS CAN L<c.cyan>G</c>
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIAN PLACEMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION PROUD CO
SPONSORED YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE IS A WITH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AMELIA BOKE UC SANTA CRUZ
STUDENT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATIE WHICH IT -- WE WERE
LEGALLY THAT WORK IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO AS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
SIR.
MITCH SNIDER CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MANAGE WORK ON IT SO YOU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I'M A FELLOW WITH THE IRA YOU
SEE HASTINGS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
J. NUMBERS AND CALL WITH EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AND I'M STRONG WITH A GREAT
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE CARD FOR THE COURTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MARTY MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
THAT HAVE BECOME AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WERE -- OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED ON THIS BILL WE DO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS GENERATED BOTH
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR.
REGARDING THE ME TO MOVE IN
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIMS AND I
THINK IT'S BEEN AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
VICTIMS NEEDING MORE TIME TO
COME FORWARD -- IT'S BEEN AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION BUT WE DO.
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL
WITH US FOR TWO AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION --
THE FIRST IS.
WE BELIEVE THE BILL SHOULD BE
LIMITED TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIMS -- THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE CONVERSATION -- AND THE
UNIQUE NATURE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS.
IT'S BEEN AROUND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND WE THINK THE BILL
SHOULD BE LIMITED THE BILL
APPLIES TO ALL FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT CLAIMS ALL FORMS
OF HARASSMENT ALL FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION IS NOT LIMITED TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND WHILE WE DO THINK OTHER
FORMS OF HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION CAN BE DRAMATIC.
WE DO THINK THE CONVERSATION HAS
REVEALED THERE SOME UNIQUE
DYNAMICS ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIMS.
THAT MAY WARRANT A LONGER
STATUTORY PERIOD.
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
PROPONENTS HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
SPLITTING -- FIAT CAUSES OF
ACTIONS WITH DIFFERENT STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT CONCERN BUT
THAT'S SORT OF THE NATURE OF
EMPLOYMENT CLAIMS IN THE LABOR
CODE CONTEXT YOU HAVE DIFFERENT
CLAIMS WITH DIFFERENT STATUTORY --
PERIOD YOU HAVE TWO OR THREE
YEARS FOR WAGE CLAIMS YOU HAVE
FOR YEARS IF YOU BRING UNFAIR
COMPETITION CLAIM.
YOU HAVE ONE YEAR FOR POCKET
CLAIM SO IT'S NOT UNPRECEDENTED
TO HAVE DIFFERENT STATUTORY --
PERIODS.
SO WE BELIEVE THIS BILL SHOULD
BE -- NARROWED TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS WE ALSO
BELIEVE THE BILL SHOULD CLEARLY
ONLY APPLY TO CLAIMS ON A GOING
FORWARD BASIS AND I BELIEVE MR
MCHALE HE'S GONNA TALK MORE
ABOUT THAT POINT WITH MY WITH
THOSE TWO AMENDMENTS WE WOULD
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- AND I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE IF I
COULD MISTER EVANS COMMENT THAT --
THE REASON -- FOR A NARROWING
AND OBVIOUSLY AS YOUR ANALYSIS
ADDRESSES ON PAGE THREE WITH THE
WITH THE EXTENSION THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS MOST GOOD
EMPLOYERS IF YOU WILL.
WANT TO ADDRESS THE BAD ACTORS
THE HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION OR
RETALIATION IMMEDIATELY AND A
FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN IS BY
EXTENDING IT. FOR SUCH A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME THAT IT DOESN'T
ENABLE THE EMPLOYER TO PROMPTLY
ADDRESS -- THAT THAT CONCERNED
ACTIVITY.
OF THE DISCUSSION OF YOUR OF THE
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS IS ON PAGE
FIVE OF YOUR ANALYSIS.
WHAT WE HAVE SIDE AND WE SAW IT
LAST YEAR MADAM CHAIR YOU MAY
RECALL THE DISCUSSION -- IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IRONICALLY RIGHT --
ON A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY WAS
THIS CONCERN ABOUT RESURRECTING
OR PERHAPS EXTENDING -- CLAIMS
THAT HAD ALREADY LAPSED UNDER
THE EXISTING STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS THE LANGUAGE THAT --
THE AUTHOR PUT INTO THE BILL IN
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY AND
CONTINUES A SPEAKS TO THE
REVIVAL OF LAPS CLAIMS -- AS MR
EBBING COLLUDED TO WE WOULD
PREFER A VERY CLEAR STATEMENT
THAT THE INCREASE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ASSUMING THAT -- YOU
PROCEED WITH THAT PROVISION OF
THE BILL THAT IT BE LIMITED TO
CLAIMS FILED ON OR AFTER JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TO HAVE A VERY
CLEAR DELINEATION.
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO CONCERN
OURSELVES WITH THE POTENTIAL A
REVIVAL OR IS YOUR ANALYSIS OF A
LEADS -- TO POSSIBLY EXTENDING --
TO THINGS THAT HAVE -- A NOT
EXPIRED AS OF THIS DATE SO IS
MISTER AND MAKE INDICATED WE
LET'S HOPE EXCUSE ME WE CLOSE
THE DOOR.
PLEASE CLOSE THE DOOR LET'S
CLOSE THE DOOR IT'S HARD TO HEAR
HIM AS IT IS AND IF WE COULD.
IF WE COULD HAVE THE SERGEANTS
JUST TRY TO KEEP THE DOORS
CLOSED SO WE CAN HEAR THE
TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
SO AGAIN WE WE WOULD KNOW WITH
THOSE TWO AMENDMENTS I THINK
MOST OF THE BUSINESS COALITION
WOULD REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE.
KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYOTHER WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE DíAS.
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS.
OF WE CANNOT MOVE A BILL UNTIL
WE HAVE ONE MORE MEMBER WE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM -- SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THE TWO ITEMS OF
CONCERN LISTED BY THE OPPOSITION.
IN YOUR CLOTHES.
OUR EXPERT RESPOND TO THOSE IF I
MAY.
I WOULD JUST NOTE -- MINE
UNDERSTANDING IS THE INTENTION
OF BILLS NOT TO RELAPSE CLAIMS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN EXPIRED
AND TOLD -- AND THAT'S THE
INTENTION OF AUTHORS MY
UNDERSTANDING AND THEN SECOND
WITH REGARD TO THE PROPOSITION
THAT THE BILL ONLY APPLY TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIMS -- THE
PROPOSAL FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE AS
ADVOCATES AND LAWYERS WHO WORK
ON THESE CASES -- WHICH IS
SHARED BY MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
IS THAT IT WOULD BE COMPLETELY
UNWORKABLE TO HAVE A SUCH
LIMITATIONS FOR ONE TYPE OF
DISCRIMINATION AND A DIFFERENT
SUCH A LIMITATION FOR OTHER.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT MANY WORKERS FACE
INTERSECTIONAL FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION SO MANY WORKERS
DO NOT JUST FACE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WORK OR OTHER FORMS
OF SEX BASED DISCRIMINATION THEY
ALSO FACE DISCRIMINATION OTHER
PROTECTED BASIE'S.
SUCH AS RACE NATIONAL ORIGIN AND
OTHER PROTECTED CLASSES SO WOULD
BE UNWORKABLE FOR THE D. FBIH TO
BE ABLE TO APPLY OR HAVE TO
APPLY DIFFERENT SUCH AS
LIMITATION THAT HAVE TO TRY TO
DECIPHER WHICH FORM OF
DISCRIMINATION WAS AT PLAY WHEN
OFTEN IT REALLY IS.
INTERSECTION ON NATURE.
THANK YOU AND THE THE SENATOR ON
BURKE.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
IT IS UNDERSTOOD IS NOT YOUR
INTENT TO BE ABLE TO REVIVE.
A CLAIMS ARE YOU GOING TO ADD
CLARIFYING LANGUAGES THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
IF IT.
IT'S ALREADY INCLUDED -- A
SECTION TO SAYS THIS ACTUAL NOT
BE INTERPRETED TO REVIVE LAPSED
CLAIMS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SOME.
WITH THAT IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE BECAUSE OF THE CLOSE ASIDE
LOVE TO HEAR TODAY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WHEN WE GET
A QUORUM WE WILL.
ACCEPT THE MOTION -- AND IF
THERE'S ANY CHANCE WE COULD GET
THE OF THE THE SERGEANT IF
THERE'S ANYBODY WE COULD GET TO
COME JOIN US SO THAT WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM IT WILL HELP
US.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND YOU ALSO HAVE -- ANOTHER
ITEM ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES.
FILE ITEM.
SEVEN A. B. -- ONE SEVENTY NINE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB ONE SEVENTY NINE IS A BILL
THAT MAKES CHANGES TO THE
FRANCHISE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS AND
AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS.
NEW CAR DEALERS OPERATING AS
LOCAL INDEPENDENTLY OWNED
FRANCHISED DEALERSHIPS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES EMPLOY.
OVER ONE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND IN SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE THE MAJOR
SOURCES OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE
BALANCE OF POWER BETWEEN LARGE
MULTINATIONAL AUTO MAKERS AND
CALIFORNIA'S NEW CAR DEALERS IS
A FAIR AND COMPETITIVE PLAYING
FIELD.
THIS BILL MAKES KEY CHANGES TO
CALIFORNIA'S MOTOR VEHICLE
FRANCHISE LAW INCLUDING RETAIL
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR WORK
PERFORMED UNDER WARRANTY DEALER
PROTEST TO THE NEW MOTOR VEHICLE
FORD.
REGARDING ON REASONABLE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
PROHIBITION ON BE UNREASONABLE
IT UNREASONABLE FACILITY
UPGRADES AND OTHER REASONABLE
CHANGES.
THIS BILL IS A PRODUCT OF WELL
OVER TWENTY HOURS OF
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE SPONSOR
AND AUTOMAKERS.
HERE WITH ME TO TODAY TO TESTIFY.
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS -- IS
CLIFF ACOSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES PLEASE OR
LESS WILL DO THAT.
TO MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS CLUB
CONSTANTLY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
NEW CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION.
TRY TO BE AS BRIEFAS I CAN --
CALVARY FRANCHISE LAWS ARE
IMPORTANT.
THEY HAVE BEEN AROUND SINCE THE
EARLY SEVENTIES THEY HELP
BALANCE THE INEQUITIES BETWEEN
MULTINATIONAL CONGLOMERATE AUTO
MANUFACTURERS [inaudible]
IN THE DEALERS WHO ARE STILL
OPERATING AS MOM AND POPS IN
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS -- AB -- ONE SEVENTY
NINE TO YOU MADAM CHAIR LOOKS
FAMILIAR -- THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S
ALMOST EXACTLY THE SAME AS A
BILL LAST YEAR I THAT --
MYSTERIOUS SO WONDERFULLY
CARRIED FOR US -- THAT WAS
ULTIMATELY VETOED -- AND DESPITE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT SO THIS YEAR
WE GOT DOWN TO IT WE BELIEVE
WE'VE ADDRESSED THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO MESSAGE BY DEALING WITH --
HOW YOU CALCULATE LABOR RATES --
WE GO NOW FROM A WISCONSIN MODEL
WHICH IS WHAT WE HAD LAST YEAR
TO A MODEL THAT NOW CONFORMS
WITH THIRTY FOUR OTHER STATES --
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS ADDRESSES
GOVERNOR BROWN TO VETO MESSAGE.
AND WE BELIEVE WE'VE COME TO AN
UNDERSTANDING -- WITH THE AUTO
MAKERS WHO -- ARE GONNA COME UP
AND SPEAK IN A MINUTE -- AND FOR
THAT.
I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS BUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY BUT
WHEN YOU GET A QUORUM AND CHECK
THING.
WITH THIS PLACE MADAM CHAIR AT
THE DIRECTION OF THE CHAIR THE
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THE BILL.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR -- WORKING WITH US
EARLIER THIS YEAR -- TO ADDRESS
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT WE SAW
ON THE BILL LAST YEAR WE THINK
THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE STILL POSES A
MUCH BETTER PRODUCT THEN THE
BILL THAT WAS BEFORE YOU LAST
YEAR.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- TO ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF YOU'D
STEP FORWARD KIM STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE CIVIL
JUSTICE IS A SEASON OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
IRAN PLANNING ON YOU HAVE SEEN A
NATIONAL WARRANT CORPORATION.
I WAS MOST AMENDED WE HAD A
PRODUCTIVE MEETING LAST WEEK
WITH SPONSORING.
RESOLUTION THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR
THANK YOU.
I ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS ANY QUESTIONS.
CURRENT APPRECIATE THE
APPRECIATE YOUR ROOM.
BRINGING THE BILL BACK IN THE
WITH THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE
IN THE AFFECTED THE TEAM'S
EVERYBODY'S ON BOARD I THINK
THAT THIS IS A VERY POSITIVE
STEP FOR CONSUMERS AND ALSO FOR
THE INDUSTRY ITSELF SO.
WITH THAT IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
I LIKE YOUR COMMENTS MADAM CHAIR
WITHOUT TO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE VERY GOOD AND
WHEN WE GET OUR QUORUM -- WE
WILL CERTAINLY -- ENTERTAIN THAT
MOTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SHAKE YOUR BREVITY.
ALL RIGHT TO DOWN ONLY A HUNDRED
MORE TO GO [inaudible]
SO -- NEXT WE'RE GOING.
TO TAKE UP I THINK A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S BILL.
OF FILE ITEM.
THREE AB.
FORTY FOUR GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WE DID
RECEIVE OF OVER TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED INDIVIDUAL LETTERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL SINCE OUR
LETTER DEADLINE -- IN MORE
CONTINUE TO COME INTO THE
COMMITTEE BUT DEADLINES OF GOTTA
HAVE SOME MEANING SO I'M JUST
ANNOUNCING THAT -- ALTHOUGH --
THEY WERE A LITTLE BIT LATE BUT
CLEARLY THERE ARE PEOPLE
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE.
AND SO WITH THAT -- PLEASE SIR
FEEL FREE -- TO PRESENT ON FILE
ITEM.
THREE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
ABOUT HALF OF THEM WERE IN THE
HALLWAY READY READY TODAY -- I
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB FORTY FOUR
WOULD MAKE IT UNLAWFUL TO SELLER
MANUFACTURE A NEW FOR PRODUCT IN
THE STATE.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
YEARS INCOMING -- WE HAVE HEARD
FROM MAJOR RETAILERS WHO
ATTEMPTED TO FINE HUMANELY
SOURCE -- FOR WE'VE KNOWN FROM
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GONE UNDER COVER
FOR YEARS IN THE FOR INDUSTRY.
THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO CREATE --
AND WE'RE TO YEAH AND TO BE
ASSURED OF HUMANELY RAISED FOR
NOW TO BE CLEAR WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT FOR FROM
DOMESTICATED ANIMALS.
LIKE GO TO HOW -- IN SHEEP THOSE
UNDER OUR BILL ARE ALLOWABLE TO
BE SOLD WE'RE ALSO NOT TALKING
ABOUT WHETHER OTHER HIGH
PRODUCTS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR
FROM ANIMALS THAT ARE RAISED OR
TRAPPED IN THE WILD SPECIFICALLY
FOR AND ONLY FOR THEIR FOR
ANIMALS LIKE FOX.
AND BEAVER AND SEAL AND OTHER
ANIMALS WHO ARE SOMETIMES
TRAPPED IN THE WILD AND LEFT FOR
DAYS TO SUFFER IN LAKE TRAPS OR
RAISED IN SMALL CRAMPED CAGES
WHICH ARE VERY CONTRARY TO THEIR
NATURES WILD ANIMALS.
IMMENSELY RUSS LAUDER JUST FOR
THE USE OF THEIR FOR WE HAVE OUT
NOW HAVE SO MANY OTHER PRODUCTS
AVAILABLE TO US FROM PH<c.cyan>-</c>
FOR THE TO WHICH NOW IS AS REAL
LOOKING IS REAL FIRST SO REAL
LOOKING THAT CONSUMERS HAVE
SOMETIMES BEEN FOOLED INTO
BUYING WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS --
FOR FOR ONLY TO FIND OUT THAT IT
WAS REAL FUR I'M KIND OF A
REVERSIBLE AS WHAT USED TO
HAPPEN IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR IS NOT
IN KEEPING WITH THE VALUES THE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE EXPRESSED OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THROUGH THEIR OWN
LEGISLATION THROUGH BALLOT
PROPOSITIONS CALIFORNIA'S
THEMSELVES HAVE PLACED ON THE
BALLOT MEASURES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH.
THAT IT THAT A. BEARING HANDS
HAVE ENOUGH ROOM TO LIVE
HUMANELY THAT FARM ANIMALS HAVE
ENOUGH ROOM TO MOVE AROUND IN AN
AUTOMOBILE IT CABS AREN'T RAISED
IN SMALL CASE -- PENS FOR THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES THEY'VE EXPRESSED
THAT DESIRE TO KNOW THAT IF A
PRODUCT IS SOLD ON THE SHELVES
IN CALIFORNIA AND IT HAS ANIMAL
PRODUCTS.
THEY WANT TO KNOW THAT THAT
ANIMAL WAS RAISED HUMANELY AND
SLAUGHTERED HUMANELY WE CANNOT
MAKE THAT GUARANTEE OUR CITIZENS
WITH FOR PRODUCTS AND THAT'S
REALLY THE BOTTOM LINE.
SO RETAILERS LIKE GUCCI AND
MICHAEL CORES JIMMY CHOO ARMANI
BURBERRY VERSACE DIANE VON
FURSTENBERG AND MANY MORE HAVE
SAID THAT THEY'RE GOING FOR FREE
WE BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA AS A
TRAILBLAZER SHOULD BE THE FIRST
ONE OUT OF THE GATE AS A STATE
TO SAY.
WE KNOW THAT FOR THAT COMES INTO
OUR STATE FROM ASIA FROM EASTERN
EUROPE THERE'S NO WAY OF
GUARANTEEING THAT THAT WAS
SAFELY YOU'RE HUMANELY SOURCED
SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW IT
TO BE SOLD.
IN OUR STATE LASTLY MAJOR
POPULATION CENTERS LIKE LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO HAVE
ALREADY GONE FOR FREE THAT'S
RELATED THAT'S WRIST.
THAT HAS CREATED A PATCHWORK OF
REGULATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT'S UNTENABLE WE THINK NOW WE
SHOULD STREAMLINED TO MAKE IT
STATE WIDE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FOUR AS PJ
SMITH DIRECTION OF FASHION
POLICY WITH THE HUMANE SOCIETY
AND VERONICA RASKIN DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY WITH ANIMAL HOPING
LEGISLATION.
WITHOUT A RETURNS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MY NAME'S PJ SMITH ON THE
DIRECTOR OF FASHION POLICY FOR
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES OF PRO CO SPONSOR OF AB.
FORTY FOUR FOUR DECADE I'VE
WORKED WITH A TOP APPAREL
COMPANIES FROM PRADA TO TJ MAX
TO IMPLEMENT POLICIES THAT ARE
GOOD FOR ANIMALS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
WHEN THESE COMPANIES EXAMINE THE
FUR TRADE CLOSELY THEY QUICKLY
REALIZE THERE'S NO WAY TO
HUMANELY SOURCE?
FOR AND THEY GO FOR FREE WHICH
SO MANY HAVE.
AS WELL CONSUMERS ARE REJECTING
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATE WITH ANIMAL
CRUELTY BUT RATHER THAN
PREPARING FOR THOSE CHANGING
TASTES THE FUR TRADE HAS CHOSEN
TO CREATE SMOKE SCREENS TO COVER
UP THE IMMENSE SUFFERING IT
CAUSES.
THE LATEST GREENWASHING ATTEMPT
IS CALLED FOR MARK WHICH IS
SIMPLY A CODIFICATION OF EXIT
EXISTING ABUSIVE PRACTICES THE
FUR TRADE IS TRYING TO
LEGITIMIZE.
UNDER FOR MARK ON DOMESTICATED
ANIMALS ARE STILL CRAMMED
IMPAIRED CAGES FOR THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES ARE CALLED IN STEEL LIKE
COLD TRAPS FOR DAYS WITHOUT FOOD
OR WATER.
FOX'S RACCOON DOGS ARE KATE
KILLED BY AN ELECTROCUTION AND
MAKE OUR CRUDELY GAS THESE OTHER
PRESCRIBED METHODS OF SLAUGHTER
UNDER THE FOR FOR MARK.
NO MATTER HOW THE FUR TRADE
TRIES TO SPIN IT THESE PRACTICES
ARE CRUEL AND THEY'RE DONE
BECAUSE THEY'RE CHEAP AND THEY
DON'T DAMAGE THE PELTS.
LAST WEEK IRELAND'S GOVERNMENT
AGREED TO PHASE OUT FOR FARMINGWITH THE MINISTER OF AGRICULTURE
SAYING IT IS CLEAR THAT THERE'S
BEEN A SOCIETAL SHIFT IN
EXPECTATIONS IN RELATION.
TO IN RELATION TO THE SECTOR IN
RECENT THAT NEARING EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT FARMING MINK IS
COUNTER TO GOOD AND A WELFARE.
TAKING THESE CONSIDERATIONS INTO
ACCOUNT IT IS CONSIDERED TIMELY
TO COMMENCE THE PHASING OUT OF
THE INDUSTRY IN IRELAND.
NEARLY A HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
VETERINARIANS AGREE ENOUGH
SUPPORTED AB.
FORTY FOUR WITH THIS PASSAGE OF
IT WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB FORTY
FOUR CALIFORNIA CONSIDER FIGHTS
POSITION AS THE NAY STREET
NATION'S MOST INNOVATIVE IN
HUMANE STATE WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VERONICA RAF KIND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AT
ANIMAL HOPE AND LEGISLATION.
OF OUR WORK INCLUDES
INVESTIGATIONS INTO FOR FARMS
MARK CHIANG OUR FOUNDER HAS
HIMSELF BEEN UNDER COVER AND FOR
FARMS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
HE HAS BEEN TO FOR FARMS IN
CHINA IN FINLAND HE HAS BEEN ON
SHOPPING EXPEDITIONS IN CANADA.
ARE FOOTAGE INCLUDES ANIMALS
BEING SKINNED ALIVE.
AND WE'RE NOT THE ONLY ONES WHO
HAVE DOCUMENTED AND HUMANE
CONDITIONS IN THE FOR INDUSTRY.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS IMAGES AND
VIDEOS FROM GROUPS ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
THAT SHOW THE ERECTION A REVIEW
TO PULL CRUELTY THAT IS A
REGULAR OCCURRENCE ON OFTEN PART
OF STANDARD PRACTICE ON FOR
FARMS.
THE TRUTH IS THAT THERE IS NO
SUCH THING AS ETHICAL.
FOR THIS IS AN INDUSTRY WHERE
BEST CURRENT PRACTICE INVOLVES
KEEPING WILD ANIMALS IN VERY
SMALL CAGES FOR THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES.
THEIR FEET NEVER TOUCHING THE
GROUND.
THIS ENVIRONMENT LEADS TO
ABNORMAL REPETITIVE BEHAVIORS
SELF MUTILATION AND
CANNIBALIZING OF CAGE MADE.
THESE BEHAVIORS ARE INDUCED BY
FRUSTRATION REPEATED ATTEMPTS TO
COPE WITH LIFE ON A FOR FARM.
IT'S ALSO AN UNREFUTED FACT.
THAT BEST CURRENT PRACTICE
INCLUDES KILLING ANIMALS BY
GASSING IN AN ELECTROCUTION WELL
FIRST STANDARDS THAT ARE PART OF
FOR MARKETS BEEN PROPOSED BY THE
OPPOSITION.
EVEN INCLUDE PERCUSSIVE BLOW TO
THE HEAD OF A POSSIBLE KILLING
METHOD FOR SICK OR INJURED
ANIMALS SUCH AS MINK OR FOX IS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT FACT OF ALL
HOWEVER IS THAT THIS IS
COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY.
IT'S WHY CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO AND TWENTY
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES HAVE MOVED
AWAY FROM.
FOR HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE BANNED
THE IMPORT OR UPS OR SALE OF
PRODUCTS FROM CERTAIN ANIMALS
INCLUDING ELEPHANT IVORY WE
DECLARED CERTAIN PRACTICES TO
CRAWL TO BE TOLERATED LEADING TO
BANDS ON FAR GRIND SHARK FAN.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO LEAD WHEN IT COMES
TO PROGRESSIVE POLICY AND THE
HUMANE TREATMENT OF ANIMALS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME ON IS VERY BUSY TO HATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE ABOUT.
RIGHT WE DO HAVE I BELIEVE A
QUORUM SO TO GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH THE CORPSMAN PASSED
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THIS BILL
AT THAT POINT.
JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE
BORDERS -- RUSSELL RUSSELL HERE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE JONES
MONNING STERN UMBERG.
NUMBER HERE WHITE HOUSE HERE
WHAT HEALTHY HERE RIGHT A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WOULD LIKE.
TO NOW GO AHEAD AND OF TAKE A
ACCEPT A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- SENATOR GONZALEZ
MOVES AND WE WILL LARA TAKE A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE PORGES TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES MONNING STERN
UMBERG NUMBER I Y. CASKEY WHAT
HAS HE I ALL RIGHT FIVE VOTES
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT BUT
WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS -- VERY GOOD --
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THIS.
THE MANAGER MATT ROBINSON WHICH
ARE YOUR INTO WE ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE WITNESSES IF YOU'D STEP
FORWARD YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION WHEN SOME WITH THE
X. IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARCY BERMAN WITH SAVE A BUNNY
RABBIT RESCUE.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
COOPER COMPASSION COMPASSIONATE
BETA RECOLLECTION EVERYWHERE I
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SONNY DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I
JUST WALKED ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES BECAUSE I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT.
OF BANNING FOR IN CALIFORNIA.
AN EXAMPLE CITED BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WOULD DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I ALSO JUST WALK A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILES TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND THE RIGHT TO
RESCUE ANIMALS.
JOE ANDY WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I ALSO MUCH A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILES TO BE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT.
ATTY FRANKEL DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I FULLY SUPPORT AND
COMPRESSION TO ANIMALS.
BOTH PROCEDURAL OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA -- FROM DIRECT DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE -- AND SUPPORT.
OR ITCOULD BE ALL O'DONNELL AND
I'M WITH CAPE CENTER FOR ANIMAL
PROTECTION AND EDUCATION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JERRY AND SO WITH CENTER FOR
PROTECTION FOR EDUCATION ANIMAL
PROTECTION SUPPORT.
VICTORIA WOODS FROM FARE -- FROM
SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA AND I'M
FROM DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE
AND I FULLY SUPPORT THIS.
WHEN THE BRAMBLE REPRESENTING IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMALS I ALSO
MARCHED A HUNDRED FIFTY MILES
AND I RIVER AND ALSO WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVER PLEASE?
THANK YOU THANK YOU. TO A
WALDRON A WITH THE X. SEE AND
COMPASSIONATE BAY FROM ON THE
CREEK IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE STORY WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AND CHAU FROM MOUNT VIEW HERE
WITH THE XP AND I FULLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND URGE YOU TO THE TO
THE RIGHT THING PLEASE.
THANK YOU SIR.
NO SMITH WITH BLOOMBERG OPINION
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEND YOU THIS MONDAY THE DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I ALSO WALKED
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILES. TO
EXPERIENCE ANIMAL SUFFERING I'M
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RUNNING A COLOGNE WITH DRUG
SECTION EVERYWHERE AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIND OUT OF LA YOU WANNA CREEK
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE.
THANK YOU.
AND THE SUGGEST SANTOS WITH THE
XC -- IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VERONICA SALAS DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THE FEEDING NUMBER FRIENDS FOR
ANIMAL JUSTICE AT THE AP.
THANK YOU WHAT.
AND FOR A WOMAN'S FRIEND FOR
ANIMAL JESS'S ANTI EXCEED.
AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEWS ON THE GO CONCERNED CITIZEN
WITH THE XP IN MULTIPLE GROUPS
AND FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU PASSED IT THANK YOU.
KAREN RUBIO FROM LOS GATOS
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH DIXIE AND
OTHER COMPASSIONATE GROUPS I'M
ASKING FOR YEARS FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
DIANA NAVON FROM BERKELEY.
WITH THE XPERIA FUNDING.
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NATALIE Là MAP FROM NAPA AND
FULL SUPPORT THANK THANK THANK
YOU.
ROGER THE SUIT FROM MOUNTAIN
VIEW CALIFORNIA OF A DIRECT
ACTION EVERY THAT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT BILL THANK YOU.
ARIEL RYAN FROM DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AMY FAN OF ALL WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KOREAN KAELIN FROM FOLSOM FINE
WITH PAUL GUIDEBOOKS AND WE
SPECIALIZE IN CONTINUING
EDUCATION FOR CERTIFIED ANIMAL
BEHAVIORISTS.
AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CURRENT ALLOW THE ACTIVISTS TAX
PAYER AND AGAINST VIOLENCE TO
ANIMALS HE'S FOR HELPING THANK
YOU.
LESLEY GOLDBERG ELSE RIDEAU
CALIFORNIA.
A NUMBER OF DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND COMPASSIONATE BAY
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU.
CALDERON BECAUSE SUMMER FROM
BERKELEY AND DRESS THIS WAY
BECAUSE I WALKED A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES TO BE HERE TODAY.
AND LIKE ALL THE CALIFORNIA'S I
ENCOUNTERED A SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY NAME IS CHRIS CLAVIS I ALSO
JUST TALKED A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KEITH YOU DO LITTLE
I'M FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I
ALSO WALKED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILES AND JUST SO YOU KNOW WE
ACTUALLY ARRIVED AT THE CAPITOL.
A FINISHING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND GRADUALLY ADDED RIGHT
THERE THANK THANKS SO MUCH WHEN
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRIANNA MARTELLO SO
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
WALKED A HUNDRED FIFTY MILES IN
SUPPORT OF THE CELL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RACHEL ZIGGLER I'M
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
ALSO WANT.
BUDGET FIFTY MILES TO BE HERE
AND I HOPE THEY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANKS SO MUCH.
READ OKAY AILING FROM FALLS MY
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.%
THE REQUESTED IN NEVADA
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
MY BUDDIES MOVIE AND BRIDGES WHO
WILL NEVER BE KILLED AND SKINNED
ALIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LACKEY SIDE NEVADA CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATH MICKEY FREE BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I MEAN ORGANIZED WITH
DIRECTX NEVER AND I WALKED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILES TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL SOUNDS LIKE A
FUN TRIP THANK YOU MY NAME'S ON
THERE ARE FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I WALKED FOR
SEVEN DAYS AND A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES TO BE.
HERE IN SPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CINDY AVAILABLE
SOME FROM SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORTED THE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILE MARCH TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M TIFFANY WORTHINGTON I'M
FROM SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA AND I
ALSO CAME UNDER FIFTY MILES
SEVEN DAYS TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HI MY NAME'S CHRIS RODRIGUEZ
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA WITH
THE XC AND I'M ASKING THE SPORT
A. B. FORTY FOUR THANK THANK YOU
AND YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO WALK A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILES. TO
CONNECTING READY CASKEY FROM
BERKELEY.
WITH COMPASSIONATE BEING DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS ROCKY
CAL FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT AB
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS CAROL OLSEN I'M
FROM FOR MY CALIFORNIA AND I
CAME TO SHOW MY SUPPORT FOR THE
A. B. FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S DEBRA MEREDITH.
I'M FROM OUT OF CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M LINDA MIDDLE SOURCE THEY
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL REPRESENTING.
ANIMAL DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL
AND D. AXES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I AM NOT ABLE CLEAN FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I'M WITH DIXIE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HI TIME KIRK NELSON FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M WITH THE XC AND I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA Là YOU
I'M FROM BERKELEY WITH THE XC
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SHY ANTI FROM WALNUT
CREEK CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND URGE YOU
TO DO SO AS WELL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRIBLE AND I
SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
SIR.
HI MY NAME IS MAX USHER ARM FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI I'M PAULA SANTA MARIA -- FROM
FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA WITH THE
ACSI AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
ALEX ON TO RIO FOR SALON AND
CONNIE AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM INTO NEW MORE FROM SAN
MATTEO CALIFORNIA I'M WITH THE
XC AND ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
AB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
I'M SEAN SHOULD PARA FROM LOS
ALTOS HILLS CALIFORNIA ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT THE BILL IS THE
ANIMALS DON'T WANT THANK YOU BYE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STACY PLACATE IS I
FLEW UP HERE FROM SAN DIEGO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL FROM A
T. S. C. THANK YOU.
I'M JIM GARDNER MORE TO LOSE A
FROM BERKELEY WITH DIXIE PLEASE
SUPPORT HIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
VERONICA ZAMBRANO Là MORE
CALIFORNIA WITH THE X. SEE A
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS LAUREN AYE SALAS SOME
FOR MORE MORE CALIFORNIA WITH
THE XP PLEASE SUPPORT AB FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU MA'AM.
I'M CHRISTOPHER ROW FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND ASKED TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA EHS I'M FROM
CINEMA COUNTY AND I'M WITH THE
ACSI AND ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THE
SPELL THANK YOU.
HI I MISS KEREN FROM PALO ALTO
AND WITH DIXIE AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB.
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
MICHAEL IS L. FROM SAN BENITO
COUNTY AND WITH THE X. SEE AN
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SCOTT YOUNG FROM
SADDAM MY COUNTY AND WITH THE X.
EIGHT I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO I'M VICTOR ECHO FEE AND
THE I SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MOLLY FLANIGAN FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WITH THE
ANIMALS PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
I'M SAYS FROM HALF MOON BAY
PLEASE SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
I'M EMILY ROMERO NAME AN
ORGANIZER WITH THE X. SEE AN
ORGANIZER WITH AREA ANIMAL SAVE
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SERGIO FRANCO
RESIDENT OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JORGE MAS YEAH I
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO I WAS BORN
IN COLUMBIA AND I SUPPORT ISRAEL
THANK YOU.
A MINISTERIAL I LIVE IN HEAVEN
BAY -- FROM UKRAINE IF YOU KNOW
GOING TO DO THIS PROBABLY NOBODY
WILL SO PLAYING CLOSER OFF THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS WHO'S GOING ON
FROM FREMONT I BELIEVE THAT
AFTER WE'VE DONE FOR WE SHOULD
ALSO BANNED THING.
Là THERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARSHALL THAT
FIELD THROUGH IN FROM SAN DIEGO
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU FOR FILLING OUT FOR CIVIL
RIGHT FOR YOU LEAVE WE THANK BY
FAMILY BREAK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS RACHEL FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS FILM THANK
YOU LEASE MAKE THE DISTRICT
THANK YOU.
NAME AND LOCATION PLEASE I THINK
YOU GOT IT GOTTA GET MOVIN THANK
NAMES CURRY AND FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I SUPPORT THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S DAN STORY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IN WITH THE X. SEE AND
LET THE ANIMALS LIVE THANK YOU.
HI JOHN CAMERON DUBLIN
CALIFORNIA.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
SIR MUCH APPRECIATED I'M GLEN
DANIELSON I'M FROM HARBOR NEAR
HALF MOON BAY CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DONNA PRESTON AND I
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AARON EVANS
ON BEHALFOF ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AND GET THE LEVER
FROM OAKLAND AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARKET SLEEPER
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
I'M TAMMY YOU I'M FROM NEARBY
WOODLAND CALIFORNIA AND I'M
ASKING FOR YOUR YES.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ONE OF FOR THE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I THOMAS CHAIN FOR SOME CISCO
ALMOST DIED FOR THIS BILL THE
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FIVE LST FROM MIDDLETOWN
CALIFORNIA AND I'VE BEEN WAITING
FORTY YEARS.
THANK YOU FORTY YEARS FOR THIS
THANK YOU VERY SINCE HIS
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU.
MAXINE MAN TOWN BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI I'M MEGAN STEIN FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I MARCHED A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES TO GET HERE AND TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SOUNDS LIKE A GREAT
PARTY I GOT TO SAY HI.
I'M SCOTT GILBERTSON FROM OVERLY
MINNESOTA AND I ALSO MARCHED A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RAIN NINE ELEVEN DALY
CITY IN A SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EMILY AND I'M FROM
REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
AB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSE FUN TIME
FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THOMAS HENDRICKSON
FROM REDDING CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS AMIN MUHAMMAD I'M
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AFTER
TWO BUNNIES AT HOME.
AND I SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JAY CUBS FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M SUCH A THREAT FROM DALY
CITY AND I SUPPORT FOR BàN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CORRIE OWLAND I
LIVE IN BERKELEY I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR ANIMALS
ARE SENTIENT BEINGS NOT
COMMODITIES THANKS VERY MUCH.
SANDY MAIL FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT AB
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S ANASTASIA MAIL FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA I'M PART OF
THE TEAM THAT WALKED A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES TO BE HERE AND I
SUPPORT.
EIGHTY FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
pCALIFORNIA ORGANIZER TECH ACTION
EVERYWHERE AS FOR AB FORTY FOUR
AND I WAS NOT BE TO BE HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
APPARENTLY THAT'S AN ISSUE.
C'MON FORWARD PLEASE.
MY NAME IS A BIO WE CLARA FROM --
AND MAYBE A I SUPPOSE AB FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM AT FROM I'M FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AND DOUG FULLER LIVE IN BERKELEY
AND AND HI.
THANKING YOU FOR BEING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL LIKE I AM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM VERY CHEN IF YOUR FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HI I'M IN THE FUNDING FROM ONE
THE CREEK AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
PLEASE SUPPORTED TO THANK YOU.
AND CASSIE KING FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WITH DIXIE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR
THANK THANK YOU.
JOHN FROM MEYER FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
I'M SHY AND DANNER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
BOB I GALLERY OF A RESIDENT OF
WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA AT A
PROUD MEMBER OF DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND WITH THE SOY WAY
REPORT AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
AB.
FORTY FOUR THANK THANK YOU SIR.
EVEN HAMMER FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU -- PROSOPIS FROM WEST
SACRAMENTO HERE FOR SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
VICTORIA GIVE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND COMPASSIONATE BAY FASHION
DOESN'T JUSTIFY CRUELTY THE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALEXANDER TAYLOR FROM SAM CISCO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RYAN TAKEN FROM SAN RAMON I
SUPPORT EIGHTY FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU SIR.
MAKAYLA PICKET CAM SAID WELL YOU
DON'T HAVE TO TIPTOE UP.
I SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
I AM HAS THE STUDENT S. ACTS
THEY AND I SUPPORT EIGHTY FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU.
BUT I'M STILL IN WELLS
REPRESENTING STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS FOR ANIMAL
LIBERATION IT SUCKS THE
UNIVERSITY WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
KATIE NAP SAN FRANCISCO SPCA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHAT DO YOU I'M A STUDENT YOU
SEE SHANKER'S I'M SUPPORT EIGHTY
FOUR FOUR THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO SENATOR.
IN A BUS.
HERE IS AN INDIVIDUAL EXPRESSING
MY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I MEAN FOR ME HAVE A SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR LEASE OPPOSING THE
MY A BILL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL --
WAIT A MINUTE HOLD ON HOLD ON
HOLD ON WE'RE RIGHT NOW JUST
HEARING THOSE IN SUPPORT.
SO IF YOU WANT TO OPPOSE YOU
GONNA HAVE TO SIT DOWN AND WAIT
YOUR TURN.
SO IF THIS IS STILL SUPPORT THIS
IS A SUPPORT POSITION OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES MICHAEL GOLDBERG WITH
COMPASSIONATE BAY IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THE BILL
AND THEY EITHER MYSELF OR ALL
THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO CAME UP
THANK YOU SIR WERE PAID THANK ON
US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO HAVE
ANYONE THAT WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT IF YOU'D STEP FORWARD TO
WITNESSES PLEASE TWO MINUTES
EACH.
THE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING.
WHO WANTS TO START?
ALRIGHT MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MORNING BEFORE I START LET ME
JUST MAKE ONE THING PERFECTLY
CLEAR NO WHEN I REPRESENT.
NO FARMER NO RANCHER NO CONSUMER
SUPPORT ANIMAL CRUELTY THE CRIME
IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S A CRIME
EVERYWHERE DECENT PEOPLE LIVE.
I'M HERE TODAY. TO APPEAL TO
YOUR REASON AND YOU RISK I GIVE
US YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE SURE MICHAEL SENATE MOM
I'M A LAWYER IN CALIFORNIA.
RENDON REPRESENT A REPRESENT
VARIOUS INTEREST IN THE FOR
INDUSTRY OKAY NAY RESTLESS
POINTS.
I'M HERE IS GOING TO APPEAL TO
REASON.
AND TO YOUR RESPECT FOR THE RULE
OF LAW THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE.
IT HAS THE POWER TO REGULATE THE
WELFARE OF EVERY ANIMAL IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THIS BILL REACHES MUCH
FARTHER THAN.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH IN THE STATE?
THE BILL'S AUTHOR IS ACTUALLY ON
RECORD SAYING SHE'S CO TRYING TO
POLICE WHAT HAPPENS IN CHINA.
THE BILL ANALYSIS SAYS IT'S
INTENT IS TO SENSIBLY MINIMIZE
AN ETHICAL TREATMENT OF ANIMALS.
AND THAT'S A VALID OBJECTIVE.
BUT IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DISINGENUOUS WHY BECAUSE NO
MATTER HOW HUMANELY THE ANIMALS
ARE TREATED NO MATTER WHERE
THEY'RE TREATED HUMANELY.
NO MATTER HOW OTHER EVER TREATED
THIS BILL WILL STILL BE ON CALL
FOR PRODUCTS FOR EVER.
TAKE FOR FROM DENMARK.
THIS BILL TREATS THE MAIN
PRODUCERS THERE ONE OF THE
LEADING PRODUCERS IN THE WORLD
AS IF THEY'RE BARBARIANS.
DOES THIS LEGISLATURE THINK IT
CARES MORE FOR THE ANIMALS AND
DENMARK AND THE PEOPLE OF
DENMARK.
THEN THERE LEGISLATURE'S.
THOSE LEGISLATORS THE
SUBSTITUTES YOUR JUDGMENT FOR
THAT OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THOSE ANIMALS.
THERE AT LEAST THREE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEMS WITH THIS BILL FROM A
LEGAL PERSPECTIVE FIRST IF YOU
WANT TO PROTECT EVERY ANIMAL.
OVER WHICH YOU HAVE LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY.
THAT REGULATE THE WAY ANIMALS
ARE TREATED RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S HOW YOU SET AN
EXAMPLE THAT'S HOW YOU LEAD.
NOT BY VIOLATING THE COMMERCE
CLAUSE AND PUTTING UP BARRIERS
TO TRADE.
JUST A WEEK AGO THE SUPREME
COURT ISSUED A DECISION IN
TENNESSEE WINE SPIRITS THAT THE
CONSTITUTION WAS ADOPTED FOR
REMOVING STATE TRADE BARRIERS
BECAUSE STATES NOTORIOUSLY
OBSTRUCTED THE INTERSTATE
SHIPMENT OF GOODS THAT THE
SUPREME COURT.
SECOND UNDER THE WORLD TRADE
ORGANIZATION A BILL LIKE THIS
WOULD BE A CAUSE FOR OTHER
COUNTRY THANK YOU YOUR TWO
MINUTES IS UP NEXT WITH.
PLEASE -- MINUTES.
THANKS WHAT HAS TWO MINUTES --
MY NAME IS KATE CAP I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE FUR
INFORMATION COUNCIL AMERICA NOT
TO ASK YOU TO KILL A. B..
FORTY FOUR BUT TO GET CERTAIN
AMENDMENT THAT IS PRESENTED TO
THE AUTHOR BECAUSE THIS BILL
WILL NOT RESULT IN ANY POSITIVE
MOVEMENT ON ANIMAL WELFARE.
HERE'S WHY AND THE LUXURY SECTOR
BUYERS ARE NOT GEOGRAPHICALLY
LIMITED IF THEY WANNA PRODUCT OF
GO WHERE THEY NEED TO GO TO BUY
IT THAT MEANS YOU'RE JUST
SHIFTING SALES OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ALONG WITH TAX REVENUES BUT
YOU'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING TO
AFFECT ANIMALS SECOND BANDS HURT
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES MOST THE
GUYS TO FOLLOW THE RULES.
YOU'RE PUTTING THEM OUT OF THE
BUSINESS BUT YOU'RE FOSTER IN
THE GROWTH OF THE ILLEGITIMATE
MARKET THE ONES THAT WON'T PAY
ATTENTION TO HANDLE WHILE FOR
GUIDELINES.
YOU CAN BET THEY'RE NOT THE ONES
ARE GOING TO PAY ATTENTION AND
YOU CAN BET THAT THIS IS GONNA
HURT ANIMAL WELFARE.
THIRD EXEMPTIONS IN THE BILL
ALLOW FOR THE SALE OF FOR FROM
CERTAIN ANIMALS IN THE USE OF
CERTAIN. FOR BY CERTAIN CULTURAL
GROUPS WITHOUT ANY STATEMENT OR
REQUIREMENTS OF THE APPLICATION
OF ANIMAL WELFARE GUIDELINES OUR
MONITORING THAT'S EXACTLY NOT
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
BUT AN AMENDMENT HAS BEEN
PRESENTED TO MISS FREEMAN'S
OFFICE FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM COVERING
BOTH WILD AND FARM FOR THIS
THIRD PARTY INDEPENDENTLY
MONITORED AND USES BLOCKCHAIN
TECHNOLOGY TO GUARANTEE
TRANSPARENCY.
MISTER JACKSON RESPECTFULLY YOU
ASKED THE QUESTION IN THE LAST
OF NATURAL RESOURCES ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THAT THE SHIPMENT
OF ANIMALS OF AND THE PRODUCT IN
FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES COULD BE
CERTIFIED AND TRACKED.
THERE IS NO INDUSTRY THAT'S MORE
HIGHLY REGULATED THIS INDUSTRY
UNDER FISH AND WILDLIFE
ADMINISTRATION U. S. CUSTOMS
ADMINISTRATION.
UNDER FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
THERE'S A FOR PRODUCT LABELING
Là OTHER SOCIETIES THERE'S A
DANGER SPECIES ACT OF THE DOG
CAT PROTECTION ACT.
I URGE YOU TO CONTACT GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TO FIND OUT JUST HOW
IRON CLAD THIS IS BECAUSE I CAN
TELL YOU WHEN MY CLIENTS KNOWN
SHIPPERS HAVE GOODS SHIPPED IN
HERE IF THEY EVEN ADD AN EXTRA
S. ON THE SCIENTIFIC NAME.
OR HAVE TWO PAIRS OF SHOES IN A
BOX AND ONE DOCUMENT ONLY SAYS
ONE ITEM.
THAT SHIPMENT IS HELD IT IS IRON
CLAD SO YOU CAN ABSOLUTELY
CERTIFY THAT WHAT IS IN THE
PACKAGE AND THE DOCUMENTATION
MATCH AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE
CERTIFICATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN THREE
MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GRAIN AND FEED
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES PLEASE.
NAME AND AFFILIATION HI MY NAME
IS THE AB AVAILABLE FOUR YEAR I
WON THE FIRST STORE I HAVE
WORKERS.
THANK GETTING READY TO RETIRE
AND THEY TAKING EVERYTHING FROM
UNDER ME.
THANK YOU OPPOSED TO FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVE ARIANNA I
AM FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOES RAINY ECHO
FROM GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
I OPPOSE THE BILL FOR THE SMALL
COMPANIES THAT ARE YOU LOOKING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THANK
YOU [inaudible]
FOR MONEY [inaudible]
FROM.
GLENDALE HIGH SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE THE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MY BILL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU Q..
MY NAME IS STEVE DOES LEARN FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I POSES
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RAPHAEL MEANT BEEN
I'M IN FROM FAIRMONT AND AFTER
WITH THIS BILL Q..
MY NAME IS JOHN I PRESENT MYSELF
AND THAT BOTH HIS BILL BECAUSE
DOUBLE TRIPLE THE STATE'S
ECONOMY AND BECAUSE IMPLEMENTED
A BRIDGE NEXT WITNESS PLACE I'M
GREG'S 	C FROM VENTURA
COUNTY CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS
BILL I URGE THANK YOU.
COMPROMISE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ART
TAYLOR I'M FROM SACRAMENTO I A
CLOSE AB FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
SIR.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU BYE
MIKE IS THIS IS THANK YOU.
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE
[inaudible]
WE MY NAME IS ERIN HER FROM
GLENDALE HIGH SCHOOL AND AYE
OPPOSED HIS BILL.
SURE.
RENDON NELSON DICKSON CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
BENJAMIN HUNTER POMONA
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
CONOR NERO CHICO CALIFORNIA AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BUT I'M TRYING TO FOR A FROM
CHICO CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL THANK YOU.
NAMES CHRIS FERNANDO FROM TO
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSES BILL THANK
YOU.
SIR FOSTER I LIVE IN THE TOWN
SACRAMENTO AND AYE OPPOSED TO
BILL NURTURE OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
PRIMARY ROADS AND FROM LIVE OAK
IF YOU FOR ALMOST HAILING FROM
SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
LISA GARCIA SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA -- I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SMALL BUSINESSES
LEAVING OUR STATE I WORRIED
ABOUT YOU THINK WORRIED ABOUT --
PEOPLE THAT WILL BE ON YOU FOR
IT AND AS YOU EXHALE
INDISTINCTLY ELSE.
OUR THREE BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
I'M A ROW HOUSE WITH THE LA
METRO IS BACK TO BURKE COMMERCE
THAT WE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
LESLIE SMITH FROM THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
RIGHT ADAM STUDENT AT SEA AS YOU
SACRAMENTO AND OPPOSES BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAMES CONOR WILSON
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE GRADUATE
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
SIR.
RICK STEVENSON FROM SACRAMENTO I
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE THERE
ARE NO EXEMPTIONS THINKING ONLY
BUSINESS OR BASIC YOU SIR THANK
YOU.
I'M GORDON TOM SICK FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE AB FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU.
MORE DESERVES AND I'M A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AND AND YOUR
HOUSEHOLDS ISN'T BEALE SIMPLE
BECAUSE BECAUSE THE TWO TIONAL
THANK YOU OUR MIND YOU ALL YOU
HAVE A LINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH THE VINEGAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
THANK YOU.
I AM A FURRIER IN BEVERLY HILLS
FOR SEVEN THE BUSINESS SEVENTY
SIX YEARS IT WOULD DEVASTATE IF
WE HAVE TO CLOSE OUR BUSINESS
FARM TEAM WAY IF YOU HAVE A NAME
THAT YOU'RE.
GETTING DOUG FINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT.
MY PARENTS SURVIVED THE
HOLOCAUST OUR BUSINESS IS SIXTY
TWO YEARS IN LOS ANGELES PAYING
TAXES ALEJO'S AB AND FORTY FOR
SLIDING OFFICER NAMED DANIEL
WALKED THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE HIGHER MIND
ALWAYS FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE AB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M TALLER ALVIS FROM L.
GROVE AND OPPOSE AB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM DAVID -- I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU ONLY THAT I THANK YOU
SIR QUESTION THAT KNOWS WHAT
SHE'S SAYING VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MATT GRAY
ON BEHALF OF TAXPAYERS FOR
IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY AND CAL
SMALL.
I WATCH LESS THAN A MILE TO BE
HERE AND I ASKED.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE DIET SENATOR
Y. CASKEY.
MADAM CHAIR WHILE THE ANIMAL
WELFARE AND SHIPPING AN
INTERNATIONAL ACTIVITIES ARE
IMPORTANT THERE BEYOND THE
PURVIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE SO I'D
LIKE TO FOCUS ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S COMPONENTS WHICH I
BELIEVE OF THE CIVIL PENALTIES.
AND ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS WE
JUST NARROWED AND AS I SEE IT
THIS IS.
A PROVISION THAT SAYS -- EACH
FOR PRODUCT CONSTITUTES A
VIOLATION AND THEN EARLIER THE
TALKS ABOUT A VIOLATION IS
SUBJECT TO A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
FEE FOR THE FIRST VIOLATION SO.
MY QUESTION IS WHEN AN
OCCURRENCE YOU HAVE OPEN UP A
BOX IN THEIR SIX FIRST IN THERE
IS THAT. ONE VIOLATION TO
VIOLATIONS THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN OR IS IT.
A VIOLATION BECAUSE THIS IN A
BOX.
THE IT SAYS EACH FOR PRODUCT IS
THIS OF CONSTITUTES A VIOLATION
SO I WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE PER
[inaudible]
ITEM.
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION AND
THE OTHER IS THE THIS EXTENDS
THE AUTHORITY TO THE CITY
ATTORNEY'S TO BRING ACTIONS.
THIS IS THAT CORRECT AND
ACTUALLY.
IT'S ALL IT'S ALL IT CAN BE
BROUGHT IN THE COUNTY BUT THEN
THE PENALTIES IMPOSED BY THE
CONTROLLER FOR DEPOSITING
FISHING GAME -- FOR PRESERVE
FINE SO IT DOES GO TO THE
CONTROL OR THE THE VIOLATION.
THE FINE GO SIT DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
IT SAYS THE DEPARTMENT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OR THE CITY
ATTORNEY OF THE CITY OR THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR COUNTY
COUNCIL THE COUNTY IN WHICH THE
VIOLATION OF SUBDIVISION.
THE COURAGE MAY BRING A CIVIL
ACTION TO RECOVER THE CIVIL
PENALTY -- YEAH.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE ITS IT'S
IT MAY MAYES SO THEY ALL HAVE
THE AUTHORITY IN THE
JURISDICTION TO DO IT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT YES CENTER GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I HAVE A QUESTION I WAS
UNCLEAR ABOUT THE ANTLERS -- CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T.
I'M GETTING A LITTLE CONFUSED AS
TO HOW THAT PLAYS OUT THERE'S A
IT'S IT'S BASICALLY CLEAR FIND
ANTLERS ARE NOT PART OF THIS
THEY'RE NOT NOT. FOR RIGHT.
YEAH AND AND THERE WERE THERE
WAS THERE WERE A LOT OF PARTS OF
THIS THAT SAVINGS LIKE IF YOU'VE
HUNTED ANIMAL I WITH A DOMESTIC
HUNTING LICENSE.
YOU CAN USE THAT ANIMALS FOR
WHAT WE'RE TRYING.
TO REALLY TARGET YOU KNOW THE IN
THE OF THE FUR INDUSTRY THAT'S
SELLING THESE PRODUCTS FOR
FASHION NOT SOMEONE WHO'S GONE
HUNTING AND BROUGHT HOME.
A DEER HEAD WITH ANOTHER.
IS COVERED BY OTHER LAWS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT OUT WITH THAT -- OF THE
CONSCIOUS ART WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI TE
MOTION IS TO PASS.
THE SENATE APPROACH -- I'D LIKE
YOU IF YOU WOULD IN YOUR CLOTHES.
I I FEEL THAT HAS SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE KEY POINTS OUT
APPROPRIATELY OUR COMMITTEE IS
TO DEAL WITH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AND LEGAL ISSUES AND I THINK
THAT -- THE EXCEPTIONS TO YOUR
BILL STRIKE THAT CONSTITUTIONAL
BALANCE -- FOR PROVIDING
EXCEPTIONS FOR RELIGIOUS
PURPOSES IF IN FACT YOU THINK
THIS IS AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
RESTRAINT ON TRADE I'M SURE
WE'LL SEE WE'LL SEE THIS IN
COURT BUT I THINK.
GIVEN THE PARAMETERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE THAT THAT YOU HAVE MET
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE THAT
WE ARE -- DIRECTED TO CONSIDER
AND SO WITH THAT IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE I WOULD JUST BRIEFLY
SAY WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF VERY
PASSIONATE ARGUMENTS ON ALL
SIDES.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
SUPPORTERS FOR WALKING A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILES TO BE HERE THAT
SHOWS THE DEPTH OF THEIR CARING.
ABOUT ANIMAL WELFARE AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT A LOT OF THE
ARGUMENTS THAT I HEARD FROM THE
OPPONENTS IF YOU SUBSTITUTED.
ELEPHANT IVORY FOR FOR YOU
PROBABLY BE ABLE TO MAKE A LOT
OF THE SAME ARGUMENTS WIDELY
REGULATING ANIMALS THAT ARE --
RAISED OVERSEAS THAT IT'S UP TO
THE PEOPLE OF THOSE COUNTRIES TO
DECIDE ABOUT THEIR WELFARE WILL
YOU COULD SAY THE SAME THING
ABOUT ELEPHANT IVORY WHERE WE
CARING ABOUT -- PRODUCTS THAT
ARE SHOULD BE REGULATING
PRODUCTS THAT ARE COMING INTO
OUR STATE I WOULD SAY THE SAME
THING ABOUT ELEPHANT IVORY.
THIS PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
THEY CARE ABOUT ANIMAL WELFARE
WE SIMPLY CANNOT GUARANTEE THE
WELFARE OF IN THESE ANIMALS HAVE
BEEN RAISED.
FOR FOR IF THEY HAD A SYSTEM OF
TRACKING THAT WAS SO GREAT.
INVOLVING BLOCKCHAIN I WOULD
HOPE THAT THEY WOULD HAVE DONE
IT BY NOW -- THAT HASN'T BEEN
DONE -- AND WE'RE STILL HEARING
ABOUT ABUSE IS NOT JUST NOT FOR
THE KURDISH PEOPLE FROM CLOTHING
MANUFACTURERS WHO'VE TRIED
HUMANELY SOURCE FOR AND FELT
THAT THEY WERE UNABLE.
TO WITHOUT I WOULD REQUEST FROM
THE REQUEST AND I BOTH.
VERY GOOD -- WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
A ONE MORE MOMENT.
FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
WHO -- IS -- COMING.
DOWN FROM AN ELEVATOR WHO -- WE
WOULD LIKE TO AT LEAST GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS HER.
SUPPORT UP I BELIEVE IT'S
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION BUT IF WE
WE COULD TAKE ONE MOMENT WE HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S.
MADE A VERY STRONG EFFORT MAYBE
HASN'T WALKED A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES BUT IN HER OWN WAY HAS.
REALLY ASKED FOR AN OPPORTUNITY
JUST TO EXPRESS YOUR OPINIONS SO
SHE SHOULD BE HERE ANY SECOND I
HOPE [inaudible]
ALL.
WELL ACTUALLY WHAT WE CAN DO IS
TAKE WE DON'T HAVE ANY MOTIONS
ON ANY OF THE OTHER BILLS SO --
CAN'T DO THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL WE'RE STILL ON THIS BILL
XIN.
IT WAS A VERY GOOD THOUGHT BUT
I'M AFRAID WE WE CAN'T -- IF
YOU'RE ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
THAT WOULD OLY.
ALLOW US TO OPEN UP FOR THE A
AND THE SUPPORT TO AND WE'VE GOT
A WHOLE BUNCH BILLS LEFT
[inaudible]
YOUR TESTIMONY.
RIGHT WE HAVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT YEAH.
I GUESS.
MA'AM WE ARE ANXIOUSLY AWAITING
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION THREE
SORRY.
J. FITZ GERALD A REGISTERED
VOTER AND TAXPAYER FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING AND FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND OBVIOUSLY FOR YOUR
FASHION ON THIS ISSUE.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WHITE KOWSKI THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE BORDERS
TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES MONNING STERN
NUMBER.
NUMBER I WAY KELSEY KELSEY I
FIVE ZERO FIVE TO ZERO OKAY SO.
AND WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU GENERAL THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU -- YEAH.
THANK YOU LET'S TAKE A MOTION ON
THE FIRST -- EIGHT REYES L. A.
B. NINE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR TO ROSS SO.
THE MOTION IS -- PETER PROCEED
PAST AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROACH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB NINE
JACKSON FIVE JACKSON AYE BOARD
JUST.
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES MONNING STERN
I'M BURKE.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY WHAT HEALTHY
I BY THIS YEAR FIVE TO ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT IS FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB ONE SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS.
WE HAVE A MOTION MOVED BY THE
SENATE TO RISE SO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS.
PASSED THE SENATE APPROACH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL JACKSON BY
JACKSON AYE BURGESS. TO RUSSELL
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING STERN -- BURKE.
NUMBER I WAKE HEALTHY OR HEALTHY
I FROM FIVE TO ZERO THAT BILL IS
ALSO OUT BUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN YOU HAVE --
FILE ITEM -- FIFTY TWO WITCHES
AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN ARE YOU TO HAVE
ANOTHER ITEM BUT THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- SO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED WITH FILE
ITEM FIFTY TWO AB FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
AUTHORIZES CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES TO ENFORCE
EXISTING WATER REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS -- A SOME THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE FOR DECADES
WHILE EACH OF THE FOUR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ARE REQUIRED BY
CURRENT LAW THE LAW IS SILENT ON
THE CONSEQUENCES OF NON
REPORTING.
NOW WHILE MOST OF OUR WATER
AGENCIES DO TAKE TH REPORTING
SERIOUSLY AND DO THEIR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AS WE REQUIRE THEM
TO DO THERE ARE SOME AGENCIES
THAT DO NOT AND SO COMPLIANCE IS
BODY.
WITHOUT EFFECTIVE SANCTIONS FOR
NON REPORTING LOCAL ENTITIES ARE
NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR LATE OR
MISSING REPORTS AND PLANS. FOR
THE MORE D. W. I. HAS NOT
CREATED OR PUBLISHED A MASTER
LIST OF ALL THE LOCAL ENTITIES
WERE PART REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH EXISTING WATER REPORTING
LAWS.
THIS MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO KNOW
THE RATE OF NON COMPLIANCE AND
WHICH DISTRICTS ARE CONSISTENTLY
NON COMPLIANT.
NOW WE HAVE ANOTHER BILL THAT'S
BEEN MOVING TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO STREAMLINE WATER REPORT
REPORTING SO THAT IT'S EASIER
FOR OUR WATER AGENCIES.
SO THERE'S REALLY KIND OF NO
EXCUSE WHAT THIS BILL DOES GIVE
OFF FRANCE FOR D. W. R. TO WORK
WITH AGENCIES IF THEY'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTY TO COMPLY.
AND REALLY WITHHOLD THE
PENALTIES UNTIL IT'S CLEAR THAT
AGENCIES ARE JUST NOT INTERESTED
IN COMPLYING WITH OUR LAW --
SAID AND THEY'RE ALSO AUTHORIZED
TO EXTEND DEADLINES AND TO WAIVE
PENALTIES ENTIRELY IF THEY FELT
FEEL THAT AGENCIES ARE MAKING
THEIR BEST ATTEMPT TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
NIKITA KARATE WITH AND ART -- IN
OUR DC TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE
EXPECT OUR TAXPAYERS TO COMPLY
WITH OUR LOSS THERE'S NO REASON
WHY PUBLIC AGENCY SHOULDN'T I
ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES PLEASE
THANK YOU TRêN MEMBERS NIKITA
CREDIT WITH THE NOT TO RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN I'M AS YOU
ALREADY KNOW THIS BILL
AUTHORIZES D. W. R. TO INCREASE
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING WATER
DATA REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AS
IT DOES NOT CREATE ANY NEW WERE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT.
IT'S SIMPLY POWERS DID OF YOU
ARE TO ENFORCE THE LAWS THAT ARE
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS.
AS YOU CAN APPRECIATE DATA HAVE
VALUE WHEN THE ENTITIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
CRITICAL WATER USE DATA DO NOT
COMPLY WITH LEGISLATIVELY
MANDATED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
INCOMPLETE AND INACCURATE
PICTURE HOW WE USE AND MANAGE
OUR WATER ACROSS THE STATE.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TARGETED
INVESTMENTS AND EFFICIENCY ARE
LOST AND THE ABILITY TO
DETERMINE THE EFFICACY OF THE
WATER CONSERVATION LAWS THAT
THIS BODY IS PASSED OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS -- IS LEFT
COMPROMISED THANKFULLY AT
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN CAN HELP FIX
THIS LEAKY WATER DATA PIPELINE
BY PROVIDING DID OF YOU ARE WITH
A TOOL TO INCREASE COMPLIANCE --
AND WE THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
WATER ISSUES MORE BROADLY OVER
THE YEARS AND OUR DRIVER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
PLEASE OKAY -- CHERRY MEMBERS
I'M JULIE HALL WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES -- WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE GOAL OF INCREASING REPORTING
TO HELP INFORM DECISION MAKING
AT THE STATE LEVEL -- WE'RE
OPPOSE THE APPROACH TO THIS BILL
TAKES A CURRENTLY UNDER THE BILL
THE FIRST WARNING A LOCAL AGENCY
WOULD RECEIVE FOR FAILURE TO
SUBMIT ONE OF THESE REPORTS ON
TIME WILL BE A CIVIL PENALTY OF
A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WELL CERTAIN AGENCIES MAY
QUALIFY FOR MITIGATION OF THAT
PENALTY THE PENALTY IS UNLESS
THE FIRST STEP TO COMPLIANCE
WITH THE WHICH IS A
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARSH
RESPONSE TO A LATE INFORMATIONAL
REPORT OR PLAN -- IN ADDITION WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL SET A NEW
PRECEDENT IN THE WATER CODE
THERE ARE NO OTHER INFOMATION
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THE
RESULT IN AN IMMEDIATE CIVIL
PENALTY.
IN THE VERY SELECT INSTANCES
WERE SOLD PENALTY AUTHORITY WAS
PROVIDED IN STATURE HER LATE
INFORMATIONAL REPORT.
THE STATUE PROVIDES AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE REPORTING
ENTITY TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
BEFORE THE PENALTY IS ISSUED.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROVIDE THE
SAME PATHWAY TO COMPLIANCE
INSTEAD THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
THE STATE TO FIND FIRST AND THEN
ASK QUESTIONS LATER -- WE SHARED
MEMBERS WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
THAT WOULD INCLUDE IN THIS
PROCESS AND NOTIFICATION TO THE
LOCAL ENTITY OF THEIR FAILURE TO
SUBMIT A REPORT. TO ALLOW THEM
TIME TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE ON
THEIR OWN BEFORE THE CIVIL
PENALTIES ISSUED.
THIS ALTERNATIVE WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL ENTITY TO CORRECT THEIR
MISTAKE WITHOUT HARSH PENALTIES
AND WOULD LIKELY INCREASE
OVERALL REPORTING COMPLIANCE.
WE HAVE THE OTHER WILL CONSIDER
THESE AMENDMENTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH HER AND HER STAFF ON A MORE
GRADUAL APPROACH TO COMPLIANCE --
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS [inaudible]
AGAIN OF THE PENALTIES ARE THE
FOCAL POINT AND THE GOAL OF
COURSE IS TO INCREASE COMPLIANCE
WITH THIS PENALTY -- GIVEN THE
WE NEED TO HAVE THESE REPORTS SO
THAT WE CAN FOR FILL THE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT CAN FILL ITS DUTIES
AYE I THINK THAT MAKES EMINENTLY
GOOD SENSE AND I'M SURE YOU'LL
CONTINUE WORKING TO THE EXTENT
THERE MAY BE SOME WAY.
TO FIND AN ACCOMMODATION HERE
BECAUSE I THINK THE ULTIMATE
GOAL IS.
A GOOD ONE AND IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER OPTIONS GREAT OTHERWISE.
I THINK THE WEIRD CLEARLY THIS
BILL IS IS AN IMPORTANT EFFORT
TO GET TO THE GOAL THAT WE ALL I
THINK AGREE ON SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE MINIMUM SURE I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BELL
AND I WANTED TO CONVEY TO YOU
INO THE AUTHOR THAT.
WHEN WE HAVE -- D. W. R. COME
BACK TO THE BUDGET NEXT YEAR FOR
THE FUNDING THAT I'VE MADE A
NOTE TO ASK THEM A QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
THE CONDITIONS TO VERY --
INFORMATION ABUSING WHETHER THEY
CONSIDER WAVING THE FEES ARE
REDUCING ON ALL THE EPISODES
GOING FORWARD VERY GOOD ALL
RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M SORRY.
SENATOR RAWSON.
IF IF THE AUTHOR IF YOU COULD
JUST ANSWER THE QUESTION.
THAT'S BEEN RAISED ABOUT.
THIS WOULD GO STRAIGHT TO A FINE
AND YOU KNOW ANY OPPORTUNITY.
TO CORRECT -- CURE THE THE ISSUE
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT
ABSOLUTELY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION THANK
YOU FIRST OF ALL THE BILL SAYS
THAT IF THE FIGHT IS NOT TO
EXCEED ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS IT
DOESN'T SAY IT HAS TO BE A
THOUSAND DOLLARS IT'S NOT TO
EXCEED.
SO IT'S UP TO DATE OF YOUR BASED
ON KIND OF THE SITUATION TO MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION IT ALSO HAS A
WHOLE LIST.
OF REASONS THAT THEY WOULD WAIVE
THE FINE FOR INSTANCE ONE OF
THEM SAYS IT WITHIN THIRTY DAYS --
AT THE AGENCY CAN NOTIFY YOU
HAVE YOU ARE THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE TIMELY THAT'S A
CONDITION FOR WAITING IF YOU
LOOK AT PAGE THREE OTHERS ON THE
WHOLE LANI THROUGH -- RIGHT DOWN
TO GOSH GOES DOWN THE I THINK
THERE ARE THREE OR FOUR SAMPLES.
THANK YOU YEAH THERE'S A WHOLE
LIST INCLUDING IF THERE WAS EVER
QUITMAN FAILURE IF THERE WAS ANY
KIND OF BREAK DOWN ON THE AGENCY
SIDE THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF OUTS
HERE -- AND WE ARE STREAMLINING
IT SO IT SINCE THEY CAN NOW
REPORT ONCE OR TWICE A YEAR.
THE DATE TO BE PRETTY EVIDENT TO
THEM SO LEADING UP TO THIS AND
THIS IS IMPORTANT INFORMATION
FOR US TO HAVE AS WE MOVE INTO
DROUGHT AND ARE.
CHANGING THE WAY THAT WE WANT TO
AGENCIES TO THINK ABOUT -- WATER
USAGE THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT SO THERE ARE WE THINK
THAT THERE'S PLENTY OF OUTS IN
HERE FOR AGENCIES THAT YOU KNOW
NEED HELP.
ON ITS THE GOAL IS COMPLIANCE
THE GOAL IS NOT TO TRY TO GET A
THOUSAND DOLLARS OUT OF THE
WATER AGENCIES SEEKING.
YEAH ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WILL
ACCEPT THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES AND
IS OUR MOTION.
MOTION BY CENTER WHY CAO SKI THE
MOTION IS.
DO PASSED TO SENATE APPROACH
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE I'M AN ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
TWO A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE BORGES'S
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES MONNING STERN
I'M BURKE.
NUMBER AYE WIECKOWSKI RECALLS
THE AYE BY THE ZERO FIVE TWO
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN YOU
HAVE ONE MORE BILL AND I
APOLOGIZE THEY JUMPED OVER THE
FIRST TIME IT'S FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH IS AB.
ELEVEN FORTY TWO FILE ITEM.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
THEIR ANALYSIS AND FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THE BILL I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THE BILL AS OUTLINED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
TRANSPORTATION CONTINUES TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S GREATEST
CONTRIBUTOR TO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THE TRANSFER SET
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR NOW
ACCOUNTS 440% OF THE STATE'S
TOTL EMISSIONS.
AND THE NUMBER IS GROWING IT'S
THE ONE AREA WERE CALIFORNIA'S
REALLY GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION -- CALIFORNIA IS
CLEARLY NOT ON THE TRAJECTORY TO
MEET A TRANSPORTATION GHG
EMISSION TARGETS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
CARDS SB ONE FIFTY REPORT
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES PREVENTING THE STATE.
FOR MEDIA TRANSPORTATION GOALS
ONE WAS AT THE STATE AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT DATA TO ACCURATELY
MODEL AND PLAN FOR TNC.
AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO REQUIRES
CALIFORNIA'S NPOS. TO INCLUDE
METRICS ABOUT TNC IS AS PART OF
THE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
THAT THE TRANSPORTATION PLANS TO
INCLUDE INCLUDE MEASUREMENTS
REGARDING BARRIERS.
UTILIZATION OF PUBLIC TRANSIT
INCLUDING TRANSIT FREQUENTLY
PARKING AND FACILITIES FOR
BICYCLES.
IN ADDITION AB FORTY TO DIRECT
THE CPUC TO CONSIDER THE NEEDS
OF NPOS AND OTHER STATE MOTOR
LOCAL AGENCIES IN PLANNING AND
MEETING THEIR SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY GOALS.
WHEN DECIDING ON TNC DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS?
NPOS IN OTHER TRANSPORTATION
EIGHT ENTITIES NEED APPROPRIATE
DATA IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT THE
POLICIES TO REDUCE THE USE OF
SINGLE OCCUPANCY VEHICLES.
INCREASE PUBLIC TRANSIT
UTILIZATION AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
BASICALLY YOU CANNOT PLAN FOR
WHAT YOU DO NOT KNOW.
IF YOU IS AN AGENCY DON'T KNOW
HOW UBER AND LIFT ARE AFFECTING
YOUR COMMUNITY YOU CAN'T MAKE
PLANS TO HELP YOUR COMMUNITY
MOVE.
MOVE AROUND THEIR CITY BETTER
THIS UPDATE TO THE REQUIREMENTS
OF REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANS
AN ADDED DIRECTION FOR THE CP
UC'S REGARDING TNC DATA
REPORTING WILL IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OF
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES.
AND WILL HELP CALIFORNIA MEET
ITS LONG TERM CLIMATE
TRANSPORTATION GOALS.
I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THE IMPORTANT ISSUES HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE SP ONE FIFTY REPORT WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY YOU'D PROTECTING
USER DATA.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR DANIEL BARRETT ON
BEHALF OF THE SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND LINDA
COMMERCIALLY AND ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BY MY SCHOOL TOLD.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE -- GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS -- MY
NAME IS DANIEL BROWN I'M HERE
WITH SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON TRACK TO
MEET ITS GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION -- GOALS FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
AND AB. ELEVEN FORTY TWO WELL
ADDRESS GAPS IN CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION EMISSION
REDUCTION STRATEGIES BY
REQUIRING REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN THE MEASURE
TRIPS MADE BY TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES.
AND IDENTIFY COMMUNITY SPECIFIC
BARRIERS THAT REDUCE UTILIZATION
OF PUBLIC TRANSIT.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
P. YOU SEE TO CONSIDER LONG TERM
PLANNING NEEDS. TO STAND ABOUT
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES.
OF NPOS AND OTHER LOCAL AGENCIES
WHEN DETERMINING THE DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR TNC.
IS REQUIREMENTS ARE ESSENTIAL
FOR REACHING CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM TRANSPORTATION AND CLIMATE
CALLS WE ARE CHEN AYE ABOUT ON
ELEVEN FORTY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
A GOOD MORNING SENATORS AT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND THANK YOU
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN'S
AT LEADERSHIP ON THIS IS THIS A
CRITICAL I'M MY NAME IS ON THE
COMMISSION WITH A CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION HERE AND
URGING YOUR AT YOUR SUPPORT ON
AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO AND WHAT'S.
BEEN SAID HERE READY IS A
CRITICAL POINT WHERE WE'VE BEEN
REPEATING THIS AND OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR WHEN WE'VE
LEARNED THAT WE'RE NOT READ
REACHING OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION -- GOALS -- IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND SO ANY
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN TAKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE IS CRITICAL.
AND AT THE REASON IS THAT WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING IN A COMPREHENSIVE WAY
AND WE KNOW THAT TNC HAVE BECOME.
AN IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
PICTURE AND AS WE ARE ADVANCING
A TECHNOLOGIES AND DIFFERENT
MODES OF OF SHARED MOBILITY THIS
IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT AND
EQUIPPING OUR REGIONALAGENCIES
TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THIS MORE
CLOSELY AND MODEL.
I'M MORE ACCURATELY IS A
CRITICAL AND IMPRINT -- POINT
AND SO WE ARE DRIVE OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT STEP FOR DAMON
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
NIKITA CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS COURTNEY
JENSEN ON BEHALF OF TECHNET AND
THANK YOU -- TO THE COMMITTEE
AND TO THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE IN THE
ANALYSIS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS AROUND -- YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE THINGS THEY THAT WE
CONTINUE BELIEVE NEED TO BE
CLEANED UP -- THE BILL -- THE
DATA SHARING REQUIREMENTS IN
THIS BILL WHEN IN IN THE SECOND
HOUSE AND SO IT'S BEEN SORT OF A
QUICK PROCESS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
DATE IS ACTUALLY NEEDED AND WHAT
PER PACK PRECISE PURPOSE IT'S
NEEDED -- FOR THE RIDE CHER
INDUSTRY ENABLES MOBILITY FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS AND
WITH ANY OF THESE PLATFORMS IS
DATA THAT WE UNDERSTAND CAN BE
USEFUL FOR PLANNING PURPOSES
HOWEVER THOSE USES MUST BE
BALANCED WITH THE SIGNIFICANT
RISK CREATED BY SHARING OF GEO
LOCATION.
AND MOVEMENT DATA OF PASSENGERS
AND DRIVERS WITHOUT ADEQUATE
PROTECTIONS THIS DATA CAN BE CAN
INCLUDE DETAILED ORIGIN AND
DESTINATION INFORMATION TIME
STAMPS AND MILES TRAVELED.
TRIP DATA IF NOT SUFFICIENTLY
AGGREGATED COULD POTENTIALLY BE
USED TO ESTABLISH AN
INDIVIDUAL'S TRAVEL PATTERNS AND
POTENTIALLY REVEAL SENSITIVE
INFORMATION.
THE BILL DOES LIMIT THE USE OF
DATA TO ASSESS THE IMPACTS OF
TNC IS AND FOR SUSTAINABLE A
COMMUNITY PLANNING BUT AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN IN THE BILL'S
VERY.
BROAD AND VAGUE AND THAT COULD
JUSTIFY MANY ON WARRANTED AT
USES IF THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
IS TO BE FOR TRANSPORTATION ARE
SUSTAINABLE THE LADY PLANNING
PURPOSES THEN WE NEED TO MAKE
THAT EXTRA CLEAR IN THE LANGUAGE
OF THE BILL.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THAT WITH THE AUTHOR
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS DATA CANNOT BE USED FOR
LOCAL REGULATORY PURPOSES SUCH
AS LEVYING FEES OR TAXES --
FINALLY I JUST WANNA MAKE IT
CLEAR CITIES ARE NOT HELD TO THE
SAME SECURITY AND PRIVACY
STANDARDS WITH RESPECT TO WHO
DATA CAN BE SHARED WITH AND HOW
IT CAN BE USED.
AND THEREFORE THE BILL COULD --
CREATE SIGNIFICANT REST FOR TNC
EASY USERS PRIVACY AND SECURITY
THE BILL DOES HAVE SOME LANGUAGE
AROUND THE RELEVANT DATA SHARING
PROTOCOLS -- BUT WE CONTINUE
THANK YOU LEAVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE US OVERTHROW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TECHNICS COMMENT SPECIFICALLY
AROUND THE DEFINITION OF
AGGREGATE DATA.
AND THE CPC PROCEEDINGS
CURRENTLY UNDERGOING AT THE SI
PC RIGHT NOW SO THERE'S A
CURRENT MULTI YEAR.
A REAL MAKING PROCESS OF THE CPC
RELATED TO DATA SHARING
INCLUDING A DEFINITION OF
AGGREGATED.
AND THE RULE MAKING PROCESS AS
PROVIDED HAS BEEN INCLUDED INPUT
FROM THE ENTITIES THAT ARE
SOUGHT. TO BE PROTECTED BY THIS
BILL INCLUDING CITIES PLANNING
AGENCIES AND RESEARCH
ORGANIZATIONS.
THESE ENTITIES COMMENTS FILE
PERCENT IS PROCEEDING IN OTHER
STATEMENTS FOR TRIP DATA HAVE
SHOWN THE FAR REACHING INTENT OF
HOW THESE ENTITIES MAY USE THE
INFORMATION.
INCLUDING BY MONETIZING TNC ATA
POTENTIALLY IMPLICATING FIFTH
AMENDMENT ISSUES.
THE CPSC PLANS TO ISSUE PROPOSED
DECISION ON THE SCOPE OF TNC
DATA SHORTLY WHICH WILL HAVE
CONSIDERED AN INCORPORATE THE
PERSPECTIVES OF THE MANY
STAKEHOLDER SOUGHT TO BE
ADDRESSED BY THIS BILL.
ON INCLUDING ON THE SCOPE OF
AGGREGATED DATA AND THE
DEFINITION AND THIS LEGISLATION
WHEN UNFORTUNATELY INTERFERE
WITH THAT PROCESS THE ULTIMATE
DECISIN.
ALTHOUGH WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO ADD
AGGREGATION LANGUAGE TO THE BILL
TO AVOID THESE ON INTENSE ACOSTA
CONSEQUENCES IF THIS BILL WERE
TO PASS IT IS IMPORTANTTO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO THE PC
REGARDING METHODOLOGY ON
EDUCATION.
OTHERWISE THE CPC MAY BE LEFT
WITH NO CHOICE BUT TO SHARE DATA
IN A WAY THAT THREATENS THE
INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY CONCERNS THAT
BEEN RAISED BY MY COLLEAGUE IN
THE PAST -- AND RESULT IN THE
OTHER POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OUT
BY MY TECHNET OFFER INFORMATION
THAT CONSTITUTES WHAT IS A VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
TRANSPORTATION DATA.
THIS NEW ONE HAS BEEN CAPTURED
BY THE CPC'S REMAKING PROCEEDING
AND WE THINK THAT SHOULD
CONTINUE AND FOR THE THOSE
REASONS AND OTHERS CAL CHAMBER
CONTINUES TO OPPOSE AB ELEVEN
FORTY TWO THANK YOU I SWEAR THE
CAL CHAMBER TEACHERS THEIR
PEOPLE HOW TO TALK SO FAST.
WE GET THE GUIDANCE WITHOUT
BREATHING SO I'M VERY IMPRESSED.
ALL RIGHT OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU WOULD STEP
FORWARD PLEASE NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
ACCORDING TO THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
BILL YEAH I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HAVING A CONVERSATION
WITH US IN THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT WHAT AFFILIATE
MYSELF WITH THE CONCERNS BOTH OF
TECH THAT THE CHAMBER REGARDING
BOTH.
PURPOSE SPECIFICITY FOR DATA
COLLECTION AS WELL AS ITS USE
AND SHARING WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE WORKING UP ON
TIGHTENING UP THAT LANGUAGE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THIS SITE TO HIM HEARTENED AT
THE CONCERN OF THE INDUSTRY IN
THE CHAMBER WILL PROTECTING --
INFORMATION.
AND CERTAINLY THIS THEIR CONCERN
HERE IS THAT THE THE TERM DE
IDENTIFICATION THE DEFINITIONS
TOO EXPANSIVE OR IS THERE WILL
BE A BILL TODAY WHERE THEY CAN
ARGUE THAT VERY DEFINITION IS
TOO NARROW.
SO -- ALWAYS.
NIMBLE -- CERTAINLY -- I WANT TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS.
THE ISSUE BEFORE US IT REALLY
DEALS MORE WITH THE PRIVACY.
ISSUE AND YOU'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS INFORMATION IS USED
FOR ITS INTENDED PURPOSE WHICH
IS TO DO PLANNING.
AND NOT TO CONTINUE STOCKING AND
MONITORING PEOPLE SPECIFIC
BEHAVIOR AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT -- THE AND I THINK THAT
THESE AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE -- AND I THINK THAT
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS WE
DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES WE ARE
REMINDED OF THE PRIVACY.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO.
I AM PLEASED THAT YOU HAVE
AGREED.
TO THOSE AMENDMENTS -- AND AS I
UNDERSTAND THEIR INTENDED TO
PLACE A FLOOR SO THAT THE
INFORMATION IS PROTECTED BUT
CERTAINLY DON'T FOR CLOSEST
CEILING.
THAT WOULD ENSURE SUFFICIENT
DATA IS STILL AVAILABLE THAT'S
THE THAT'S SORT OF THE FIND THE
BALANCE WE'RE LOOKING AT I THINK
THIS.
ACHIEVES THAT SO -- IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS ANY ANY CONCERNS
CENTER ON SOME -- READY TO MOVE
THE BILL I WAS JUST.
IF I WAS FOLLOWING THE
OPPOSITION EVEN IF IT'S NOT
ADEQUATELY DE IDENTIFIED THAT
MEANS THAT THE CITY WOULD HAVE
TO SELL THAT INFORMATION TO A
THIRD PARTY.
THAT THEY WOULD USE IT FOR SOME
SORT OF ECONOMIC GAIN I GUESS
BECAUSE OF THE OR OR THE CITY
WOULD GO AFTER PEOPLE FOR
OUTSTANDING.
TAXES AND PARKING TICKETS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO OF COURSE
I THINK THEY AMENDMENTS.
GODDESS THERE IS WITH THE RAISE
CONCERNS ALL MOVE THE BILL VERY
GOOD END OF NOTING TO THAT --
THAT IS PART OF THE CONCERN THAT
WILL SEE AND OTHER BILLS WHERE I
THINK THE CHAMBER MAY BE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT BUT IT'S
ALWAYS INTERESTING.
SENATOR TO RAZA YEAH I JUST WANT.
TO REINFORCE I THINK WE'RE BOTH
YOU AND FEDERAL HEALTHCARE ARE
SAYING IS.
WE'RE SORT OF ON THE FLIP SIDE
OF SOME OF THESE BILLS AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
THINGS THAT I ADVOCATE FOR OUR
CONSISTENT.
YOU KNOW NO MATTER WHAT THE
ISSUE OR OR THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT
UP.
BUT IT DID.
RAISE THE QUESTION OF HOW WELL
THIS COULD BE USED AND SO MANY
OF THE OTHER -- BILLS TOUCH ON
THAT IS HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
THE INFORMATION IS NOT USED
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS.
YOU KNOW FOR VIOLATIONS OF
THINGS THAT THEY COULD BE
ACCUSED OF AND SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M MOSTLY CONCERNED ABOUT AND
THAT SEEMS TO BE THAT THERE'S
ALWAYS CERTAIN COMMUNITIES THAT
GET HIT THE HARDEST WHEN IT
COMES -- TO TO THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS SO I GUESS I JUST WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU WE'RE MOVING IN
THE DIRECTION OF MAKING SURE
THAT IT IS [inaudible]
NARROW ENOUGH.
THAT WE DON'T OPEN UP THE DOOR
FOR OTHER USES.
THANK YOU I I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION I WOULD SAY FIRST OF
ALL I I DO AGAIN WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE ADDED TO THE BILL.
WHICH DO REQUIRE THE DATES TO BE
AGGREGATED SO THAT THERE WILL BE
DATA THAT TELLS THE CITY'S
BASICALLY WITHIN AN HOUR HERE'S
HOW MANY TNC THAT YOU HAD GOING
FROM ONE ZIP CODE INTO ANOTHER.
AND THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IS
GRANULAR AS THE INFORMATION CAN
GET.
SO THAT IS VERY PROTECTIVE ALSO
GIVING THEM THE INFORMATION THAT
WE BELIEVE THEY REALLY NEED AND
WE BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
GIVING P. HE SEES P..
RIGHT NOW THE DIRECTION SORRY
CPUC.
THE DIRECTION -- TO SAY LISTEN
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
AS FAR TOO BROAD TO BE USEFUL
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
CITIES NEED TO NOW -- MORE OF
THIS INFORMATION SO THAT THEY
KNOW IF THEY HAVE TRANSIT GAPS
IF THEY NEED TO RUN ADDITIONAL
BUSES HOW THEY CAN REDUCE
CONGESTION ON THEIR STREET AND
WHAT THE CONGESTION IMPACTS
MIGHT BE A TNC IS THAT ARE
CIRCULATING WAITING.
FOR A SPORTING EVENT AND FOR
INSTANCE THAT THE CITIES HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW THAT INFORMATION
AND THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY IN
DOING THAT WHILE PROTECTING.
THE DATE OF USERS I WOULD ALSO
SAY THOUGH THAT I THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE THINK
ABOUT THE PRIVACY THAT WE DO
TAKE A STEP BACK AND SAY WE'RE
GOING TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
CITIES USE DATA.
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT ON
THE WHOLE AS OPPOSED TO LOOKING
AT SORT OF EACH INDIVIDUAL PIECE
OF IT THERE SHOULD BE MORE OVER
ARCHING SORT OF HOLISTIC
LEGISLATION RATHER THAN
SUBJECTING EVERY SINGLE BILL. TO
US SORT OF THAT TEST AND THAT'S
WHAT THE PRIVACY LEGISLATION DID
LAST YEAR AND I THINK THAT
THERE'S OTHER -- BILLS LOOKING
AT THAT AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH THE CHAIR THAT YOU
KNOW -- YES IS A CONCERN ABOUT
HOW CITIES AND HOW PUBLIC AT
LEAST USE THAT AND THERE'S A LOT
OF CONCERN ABOUT HOW PRIVATE
ENTITIES OR USE IT WILL BE
DEALING WITH THAT THE THIS VERY
DAY SO THANK YOU AND WE'LL TAKE
THAT IS YOUR CLOSE APPRECIATED
AND WE ARE I THINK.
BEING CONSISTENT HERE THAT'S THE
REASON THAT WE ASKED FOR THOSE
AMENDMENTS IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET
THE INFORMATION BUT YOU DON'T
NEED TO KNOW EVERY PERSON'S
PERSONAL INFORMATION WE DON'T
WANT YOUR SELLING IT -- THE
CITIES THE CASH NOBODY HAS TO DO
THAT TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL AND THAT'S WHY THE
AMENDMENTS ARE THERE AND WITH
THAT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS LET'S MOVE.
OTHERS A MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT A.
B. ELEVEN FORTY TWO JACKSON HI
JACKSON I'VE WERE JUST TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING STERN UMBERG.
NUMBER AYE WHY KELSEY KELSEY I
BY THE FIVE TO ZERO THE BILL SO
THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR MEASURES AND WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
IF WE NEED TO LEAVE -- I'M SORRY
THAT I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY -- WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FORGIVE ME.
US ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP AB -- TWENTY
FIVE IT'S FILE ITEM.
TO THANK YOU -- FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US ON
THIS I THINK THIS IS A AGAIN IN
THE SAME THEME WE WERE JUST
DISCUSSING INFORMATION SHOULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE BUT WE NEED TO
PROTECT THE INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY
RIGHTS TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN.
AND CERTAINLY TO COMPLY WITH THE
CCP A A BILL ABOUT WHICH I KNOW
YOU KNOW ABSOLUTELY NOTHING --
HAVING BEEN A WORKING ON IT FOR
SO MANY MONTHS SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FOR BEING HERE AND I IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN YOU ARE ACCEPTING IS
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARTICULATED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
THAT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PROCEED
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
ENSURING MEMBERS SELL AB TWENTY
FIVE CLARIFIES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
OR CCPA.
EXCLUDES INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
PERSONAL INFORMATION HAS BEEN
COLLECTED BY BUSINESS IN THE
COURSE OF THEIR ACTIVITIES FOR
THE BUSINESS AS A JOB APPLICANT.
TO AN EMPLOYEE OF OWNER OF
DIRECTOR OF OFFICER OF MEDICAL
STAFF MEMBER OF WILL CONTRACTOR
OF THAT BUSINESS BUT ONLY TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEIR INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED IN USE SOLELY. FOR
PURPOSES RELATED TO THOSE
ACTIVITIES SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THE CCPA THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS REQUESTS.
FOR A FURTHER CLARIFICATIONS ON
THIS RIGHTS OBLIGATIONS
ESTABLISHED BY THE CCPA.
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE HAVE EXPRESS
THAT THE CCPA COULD BE READ TO
APPLY TO CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR
CAPACITY AS EMPLOYEES OR IN
SIMILARLY SITUATED CONTACTS TO
CAPTURE THEIR EMPLOYEE DATA.
WELL WE NEVER ENVISIONED THIS
BEING AN ISSUE THIS HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED AN S. DRAFTED AND
EMPLOYEE ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT FOR EXAMPLE.
COULD REQUEST THAT COMPLAINTS
ABOUT HIM OR HER A BE EXPUNGED
FROM COMPANY FILES.
HELLO THIS CLASSIFICATION AND
STATURE WOULD ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS RETAIN THEIR RIGHTS
UNDER THE SEA CPA IN THEIR
CAPACITY AS CONSUMERS.
NOW ANOTHER ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED AS THE CONCERNED THAT
HIGHLY SENSITIVE INFORMATION
SUCH AS CREDIT CARD A SOCIAL THE
NUMBERS COULD FALL INTO THE
WRONG HANDS WHEN A REQUEST IS
MADE. FOR SPECIFIC PIECES OF
INFORMATION THAT THE BUSINESS
HAS COLLECTED ABOUT A CONSUMER.
ALL THIS CONCERN EXTENDS TO THE
DISCLOSURE OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION SUCH AS A CONSUMERS
BROWSING HISTORY ARE.
WITH OTHER HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS OR
OTHER USERS OF A SHARED DEVICE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE
INFORMATION COULD LAND IN THE
HANDS OF AN ABUSIVE -- SPOUSE OR
PARENT OR A ROOMMATE FOR THAT
MATTER WHILE THE CCPA REQUIRES
THAT A BUSINESS COMPLY.
ONLY UPON RECEIPT OF VERIFIABLE
CONSUMER REQUEST THE CONCERN
RAISED IS THAT A BUSINESS MAY
NEED TO COLLECT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE REQUESTING
CONSUMER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION IS SENT TO
THE RIGHT PERSON ESPECIALLY.
WHEN A BUSINESS HAS NO DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP -- WITH THE
CONSUMER OR IN SITUATIONS
INVOLVING A SURE HOUSEHOLD OR
DEVICE.
PART OF THE SOLUTION IS TO ALLOW
A BUSINESS TO REQUIRE CONSUMERS
TO USE AND ESTABLISH A CAL A TO
EXERCISE YOUR SEATS.
A RIGHT NOW BY DOING SO IT HELPS
TO PREVENT THEM FROM PROVIDING
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO RAW
INDIVIDUAL.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY FIVE FOR THE
CLARIFIES THAT HOW BUSINESS
SHALL COMPLY WITH THE CONSUMERS
REQUEST FOR SPECIFIC PIECES OF
INFORMATION SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FOR HIS --
I'VE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GLAD TO SEE THE CHAMBER HERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THERE BUT
WITH CAL CHAMBER TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT.
WITHOUT THE CLARIFICATION
OFFERED BY AB TWENTY FIVE THE
DEFINITION OF CONSUMER THOSE WHO
HAVE RIGHTS UNDER THIS LAW.
COULD BE INTERPRETED TO INCLUDE
PEOPLE ACTING IN THE CONTEXT OF
THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
THIS IS PROBLEMATIC FOR THREE
REASONS FIRST THE COSTS FOR
BUSINESSES WILL BE EXORBITANT
IMAGINE A FAMILY OWNED
RESTAURANT THAT SERVES A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY TABLES PER DAY.
WITHOUT THIS FIX IT MAY HAVE TO
OPERATIONALIZE THIS EASY PAY FOR
ITS KITCHEN AND WAIT STAFF.
IN A BUSINESS WITH HIGH TURNOVER
IN LOW PROFIT MARGINS SECOND IS
INCREDIBLY BROAD LAW WAS
DESIGNED FOR CONSUMERS NOT
EMPLOYEES.
IMAGINE AN EMPLOYEE MAKING A CPA
ACCESS REQUEST THE BUSINESS
WOULD HAVE TO GOING TO THE
EMPLOYEES OFFICE AND SANNED
EVERY PAPER DOCUMENT GATHER ALL
THE EMPLOYEES INTERNET SEARCH
HISTORY PRODUCE ALL THE
EMPLOYEES EMAIL ARCHIVES.
EVEN IF THE BUSINESS IS DOING
NOTHING WITH ANY OF THIS
INFORMATION.
THIRD THERE WILL BE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
ACCESS TO PERSONAL INFORMATION
THE EMPLOYMENT CONTEXT IS
ALREADY ESTABLISHED IN
CALIFORNIA LAW BUT WITHOUT THIS
FIX THIS EASY PAY WOULD ALLOW
SEPARATED SPOUSE WHO'S PART OF
THE HOUSEHOLD TO GAIN ACCESS TO
AN EMPLOYEE'S PAYROLL RECORDS.
GIVING EMPLOYEES THE RIGHT TO
DELETE CERTAIN INFORMATION COULD
BE PROBLEMATIC AS WELL FOR
EXAMPLE EMPLOYEE CASKET BUSINESS
SILLY ACCUSATIONS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
OR TO DELETE INAPPROPRIATE EMAIL
SENT TO A CO WORKER BEFORE
LAWSUITS FILED.
THIS EASY PAY LEGAL CLAIM
SECTION WOULD NOT APPLY.
FURTHER THIS BILL PROACTIVELY
ADDRESSES PRIVAY CONCERNS IN
THREE WAYS FIRST SOMEONE IS BOTH
AN EMPLOYEE AND CONSUMER
BUSINESS WILL STILL RETAIN
AUTHOR CCPA RIGHT.
AS A CONSUMER.
SECOND THE BILL STRONGLY
ENCOURAGES BUSINESSES NOT TO USE
EMPLOYMENT DATA BEYOND THE
EMPLOYMENT CONTEXT BECAUSE
EXEMPTION ONLY APPLIES WHEN
EMPLOYMENT DATA IS COLLECTED AND
USED SOLELY FOR EMPLOYMENT
PURPOSES.
AND FINALLY THE RECENT SUNSET
AND DISCLOSURE AMENDMENTS ADDED
AT THE REQUEST OF LABOR UNIONS
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WHILE THIS IS
NOT THE RIGHT FIT FOR EMPLOYEES.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THEM TO FIND A BETTER SOLUTION
EMPLOYMENT PRIVACY NEXT YEAR.
MEMBERS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WE HAVE CHEN HELPER --
WITH THE ONLY PAPER TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF WE
GET INTO THAT IN THE DEBATE
PROCESS THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN
JOE GOOD WHEN AND I'M THE
FOUNDER AND CEO OF A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD STAFFING COMPANY EXACT
STAFF BASED OUT OF WOODLAND
HILLS CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE MET BEFORE HIM.
I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
THE AMERICAN STAFFING
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OUR
INDUSTRY THAT EMPLOYS OVER
SEVENTEEN MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR
THREE MILLION IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE JOBS PEOPLE.
STAFFING FIRMS MATCH MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE LOOKING FOR WORK WITH
CLIENTS THAT NEED HELP TO FILL
POSITIONS IN EVERY SKILL AND
PROFESSION.
THE C. C. P. A. AS WRITTEN WILL
MAKE IT HARDER FOR STAFFING
FIRMS TO PLACE PEOPLE IN JOBS I
WANT TO SHARE A QUICK STORY WITH
YOU ABOUT VIVIAN SHE'S THE
MOTHER OF SIX TEENAGERS.
WHO IS RETURNING TO THE
WORKFORCE BECAUSE SHE WAS GOING
THROUGH A DIVORCE?
SHE CAME TO MY OFFICE AND SHE
WAS LOOKING FOR A JOB SHE WAS
EMBARRASSED BECAUSE SE FELT HER
STAY AT HOME SKILLS WERE
RELEVANT IN THE WORKPLACE.
I SPENT TWO HOURS WITH HER GOING
OVERALL FOR TASKS IS YOU'RE DONE
AS A STAY AT HOME MOM AND SHE
LEFT CONFIDENT THAT SHE WAS
RELEVANT IN THE WORKPLACE THAT
AFTERNOON I GOT A CALL FROM A
CLIENT LOOKING FOR A
RECEPTIONIST.
VIVIAN STARTED IN THAT JOB THE
NEXT MORNING AND TODAY SHE'S THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF MARKETING OF
THAT FIRM.
WHY I BRING THE STORY UP IS
BECAUSE FILLING JOBS QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY IS ESSENTIAL FOR MY
CLIENTS AND MY EMPLOYEES CCPA
PRETENDER THAT BY TREATING
EMLOYEES AND JOB APPLICANTS AS
CONSUMERS?
WHICH WOULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
COMPLIANCE COSTS AND BURDENS TO
MY BUSINESS AND MAKE CONFUSED
JOB SEEKERS AND SLOW DOWN THE
HIRING PROCESS WHICH COULD COST
THEM JOB OPPORTUNITIES.
SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE MINE WOULD
HAVE TO HIRE COMPLAINTS
ATTORNEYS TO COMPLY WITH THIS
LAW.
THIS IS A BARRIER TO ENTRY FOR
OTHER WOMEN LIKE ME TO START
THEIR OWN STAFFING BUSINESS AND
PUT OTHER PEOPLE TO WORK FOR
THESE REASONS I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IF WE
ONLY HAD MORE WOMEN IN THIS KIND
OF SUCCESSFUL ROLE IN THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IT WOULD
CERTAINLY BE NICE WHEN.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF
YOU'D STEP FORWARD PLEASE NAME
AND AFFILIATION.
I'M SURE MIKE BELOW ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAW
COUNCIL AND THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GARY COOPER REPRESENTING AM AND
HEALTH CARE IF IT LARGEST
HEALTHCARE STAFFING COMPANY IN
THE COUNTRY IN FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HAD SENT OVER HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
BUT HAVING COME AFTER THE
NATIONAL PAYROLL REPORTING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY HAD ON BEHALF OF COMP TIA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT'S THE NUMBER OF CALVARY
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FUSING.
JOANNE BUT IN COURT REPRESENTING
THE INVESTMENT COMPANY INSTITUTE
AND SAYS MUCH IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANNA BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARIA SPERBER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SO A TECHNICIAN SUPPORT THANK
YOU IF WE CAN WITH INTERNET
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS WALDRON HAVE THE
ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIMMY WHAT WITH A CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TIM LYNCH FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT
SOFTWARE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ADDRESS AND WE HAVE THE
INTERACTIVE ADVERTISING BUREAU
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VETERAN PALMER ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
RAINY PARKING HAVE THE CONSUMER
DATA INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICROBES HAVE THE CALIFORNIA'S
STAFFING PROFESSIONALS AND THANK
YOU.
CHRIS OSWALD ASSOCIATION OF
NATIONAL ADVERTISERS WORK THANK
YOU.
STEPHANIE MORAL CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY ASKED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
FEELING GRIEVES WITH ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AT THE HILTON CALIFORNIA LAND
TITLE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHRIS MORE SOFTWARE AND
INFORMATION INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEPARATE ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER MEMBERS DOES A
PERSON HAVE A CALIFORNIANS FOR
CONSUMER PRIVACY WILL HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
WE JUST WANT EXPRESS ARE PRETTY
PATIENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER JALEN
HIS TEAM.
FOR WORKING WITH US IN THIS
PROCESS THANK YOU.
OUR AFFECTS JOHNSON OF COMMON
SENSE MEDIA WE WANTED TO THINK
REMEMBER CHAO FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL AND WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON IT.
YES THOSE IN STRONG NEUTRALITY
FLEECE.
THE OTHER KOREAN REPRESENTING
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE WOULD LIKE
TO THINK THE AUTHOR HIS STAFF
AND MY COUNTERPARTS AT BUT THE
INTERNET IS A STATION IN THE
CHAMBER FOR QUITE A FEW HOURS TO
GET TO THIS POINT THANK YOU --
YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION VERY MUCH HERE
IN STRONG NEUTRALITY WE'VE.
FIVE WE'VE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION THANKS TO THE
AMENDMENTS REFERENCE IN THE
ANALYSIS WE DO THINK IT'S A
SMART COMPROMISE THAT
ESSENTIALLY FORCES US ALL TO
THEN GO SHOOTING TABLE TO FIGURE
OUT THE BROADER FIX HERE.
TO THE MUCH BIGGER VERY SCARY
ISSUE OF EMPLOYER SURVEILLANCE
OF WORKERS IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN AROUND SINCE HENRY FORD BUT
THANKS TO SOME ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY IT'S BECOME MUCH
BIGGER ISSUE IN RECENT YEARS AND
SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING OVER
THE NEXT YEAR SO TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE FIX IS GONNA BE WHERE.
THE CCPA NEEDS TO BE STRONGER
WHERE THERE'S SOME ROOM TO MOVE
AND FIGURE OUT HOW IT -- IS MORE
DIRECTLY TARGETED TO WORKERS BUT
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE AUTHORS
OFFICE TO WORK WITH US AND
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AS WELL AS
THE SUPPORTERS AND COMMITTEE
STAFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RENE BAYARDO S. HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE IN THE
CHAMBER FOR WORKING WITH US WE
WE DO THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
SERIOUS SUBJECT ON THAT WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS.
WORKPLACE SAFETY THANK YOU AT
THIS POINT IF PEOPLE COULD JUST
GIVE THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
I THINK WE GET THE GIST OF THAT
STRONG NEUTRALITY AND WE'RE
GONNA KEEP WORKING ON THE BILL
THANKS CAN WAY ON HOW.
CALIFORNIANS LIMóN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO STRONGLY
JOLLITY THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
COMMINGLED WITH CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
COLLEGE AS IT WAS UPSTAIRS AND
ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
THE PROBLEM.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WITH THIS IS BEEN A A
TOUGH EFFORT I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I WANT TO
THANK STAFF AS WELL.
AS WELL AS THE THE VARIOUS
INTEREST GROUPS THIS IS A VERY
TRICKY ISSUE.
BECAUSE AS AND AS EMPLOYERS
THERE IS DEFINITELY A GOOD
REASON -- TO BE ABLE TO GET.
SOME INFORMATION ABOUT ONE'S
EMPLOYEES AND WE'VE TRIED TO
LIMITED THOUGH TO THE SCOPE OF
FOR PURPOSES OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
AND THE THE OTHER COUNTERVAILING
FACTOR IS THAT WITH SURVEILLANCE
AS WAS NOTED WE CAN DO A LOT
MORE THAN JUST KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT AN EMPLOYEE IS GOING OUT TO
LUNCH BETWEEN TWELVE AND ONE WE
CAN KNOW WHERE THEY'RE GOING.
WE'RE WHO THEIR MEETING WHAT
THEY'RE EATING.
AND THESE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
BECAUSE WE PUT AS EARLY SUNSET --
ON THIS BILL -- IF YOU WILL THAT
THIS WILL BRING THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER BECAUSE THIS IS THIS IS
REALLY AGAIN TECHNOLOGY HAS
MOVED US WELL BEYOND.
JUST KNOWING JUST PUNCHING IN.
SHOES ME PUNCHING IN AND
PUNCHING OUT THE CLOCK IS A
PERSON TIMELY OR THEY ARE THEY
TAKING THAT THE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THEY'RE ENTITLED TO OR THEY
TAKING MORE.
THOSE ARE THE ISSUES WE USED TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT BUT WE CAN DO
A LOT MORE NOW AND I LOOK
FORWARD.
TO THE THE EFFORT THAT MOVING
FORWARD TO BALANCE THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS. TO
TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS AND FOR
OUR FRIENDS IN THE LABOR
COMMUNITY ON BEHALF OF EMPLOYEES
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
DISCUSSION THAT WE NEED.
TO IT CONTINUE GOING FORWARD SO
WITH THAT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSER IN LESSER ANY QUESTIONS.
NO OUR USE THAT AS A CLOSE WE
SHOOT THAT'S FAIR ENOUGH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL IN IT
LET ME CLOSE ON THIS NOTE I THIS
HAS BEEN A YOUR LONG PROJECT I
WANT TO JUST TAKE A MINUTE TO
THANK ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS.
ARE WHO HAVE BEEN VERY --
WILLING AND ABLE TO COME TO THE
TABLE AND YOU KNOW NEGOTIATE.
AND ARE YOU KNOW I ALSO LIKE TO
COMMIT MYSELF TO WORKING ON THE
EMPLOYEE SURVEILLANCE SITUATION
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
AND IT'S A IT'S A TOPIC THAT
REQUIRES A BROADER DISCUSSION.
GOING FORWARD AND I YOU KNOW WE
DO HAVE A ONE YEAR TO WORK ON IT
SO I I INVITE THE FOLKS TO COME
TO MY OFFICE YOU KNOW I I KEEP
AN OPEN DOOR SO -- TRULY WE NEED
TO CURRENT ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE PERTINENT TO IN
THAT PARTICULAR SPACE SO OB SO I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AGAIN AND
SUPPORTERS AND AND YOU ARE
YOURSELF OUT AMOUNT CHAIR AND
YOUR TEAM.
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY X.
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING US WITH
THIS PROCESS -- I WANT THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR AND I JUST WANT.
TO CLOSE BY SAYING THAT YOU HAVE
INDICATED ALL ALONG YOU WANTED
THIS TO BE A CONSENSUS BILL AND
I APPRECIATE THAT IT IS.
AND SO I TRUST THAT THE BILL
WE'RE VOTING ON TODAY WON'T BE
AMENDED.
TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL ITEMS
WITHOUT CONSENSUS FROM ALL THE
RELEVANT PARTIES I THINK IS A
GREAT PLACE. TO STOP AND TO TAKE
A DEEP BREATH AND THEN TO MOVE
FORWARD IS AS AS NEEDED -- AND
WE ALL AGREED IS NEEDED BUT THIS
I THINK GETS US TO THAT SWEET
SPOT.
OF FOR THE TIME BEING AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT WITH THAT.
I JUST WANT TO ADD TO THAT
BECAUSE THIS COULD BE A VERY
EXEMPLARY PROCESS.
OF THE VARIOUS INTERESTS THAT
HAVE BEEN.
TACKLED ON AND I THINK EVERY
SINGLE BILL THAT'S GOING TO COME
UP THAT HAS TO DO WITH A PRIVACY
IN THIS.
IS THERE AN OPPORTUNITY THERE TO
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS TO GET
AT THE PLACE WHERE WE NEED TO BE
SO I WANT.
TO CONGRATULATE THANK YOU ALL.
ALL RIGHT -- THERE'S A WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WHAT COUNTY DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY
FIVE JACKSON JACKSON AYE BORDERS
TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING STERN AMBERG.
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY WHICH HAS
THE I FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO I WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS -- IF YOU GIVE ME
JUST A SECOND TO CHECK WE MAY
HAVE TO STOP FOR CAUCUS -- SEE
WE HAVE ANOTHER BILL HOLD ON ONE
SECOND GIVE ME ONE MINUTE
.
ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE TO GO TO
CAUCUS WE WILL RECONVENE AT
LET'S TRY.
FOR ONE FIFTEEN WE DO THAT WE
HAVE ALL THE FILES AS ONE THIRTY
WE GOT TO GO WITH THE FILES SO
WE'LL BE BACK IN ROOM. ONE
TWEVE ONE TWELVE AT ONE THIRTY
YES AND WE ARE GOING TO TAKE IS
A SPECIAL ORDER BUSINESS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE BILL ON
RENTERS WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
CLEAR THE THE ROOM AS QUICKLY AS
WE CAN AND THEN WE'LL.
FINISH UP WITH YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER AND WE
ARE IN RECESS
HERE THIS MORNING THE ORDER OF
BUSINESS FOR THIS AFTERNOON WILL
BE AS FOLLOWS WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN FIRST
THAT.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRUE.
THEN WE WILL HEAR THE REST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHARLES BILLS
WHICH ARE FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
THREE EIGHTY FOUR AND THEN FILE
ITEM.
FIFTY SEVEN AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO AND AFTER THAT WE'LL BE BACK
IN FILE ORDER.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT
EVERYONE PLEASE -- TRY TO COME
IN AND OUT OF THE ROOM AS
QUIETLY AS POSSIBLE AND KEEP ALL
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE THIS ROOM
IS.
VERY VERY DIFFICULTY HEARING
WHEN THE DOORS OPEN AND THERE'S
A LARGE GROUP OF PEOPLE -- IN
THE HALLWAY IN FACT YOU CAN HEAR
THEM NOW LITTLE WHEN THE DOOR
OPENED SO THERE WOULD BE MOST
APPRECIATED AND I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY.
THAT -- EACH MEASURED FOR EACH
MEASURE WE WILL HAVE TO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH IN
SUPPORT.
IF WE COULD KEEP THAT DOOR
CLOSER WOULD REALLY BE HELPFUL.
TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
IN SUPPORT AND THEN WILL HAVE --
THOSE WHO ALSO ARE IN SUPPORT TO
STAND IN LINE AND COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE WITH YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
INDICATION OF YOUR SUPPORT.
WE WILL THEN HAVE THE OPPOSITION
COME UP TO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH AND THEN THOSE IN A
OPPOSITION -- TO COME TO THE
MIKE AND GIVE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION -- AND INDICATE
OPPOSITION ONLY.
WE HAVE THE SOME FORTY FIVE
BILLS LEFT TO BE HEARD SO I AM
OF THE APOLOGETICALLY BUT FIRMLY
GOING TO HAVE TO CRACK THE WHIP.
TWO MINUTES EACH AND THEN I'M
GONNA CUT OFF THE TESTIMONY.
NO SPEECHES NOTHING MORE WHEN
YOU COME UP TO THE TO THE
MICROPHONE OTHER THAN YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND INDICATING YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION DEPENDING
UPON WHAT GROUP IS UP AT THE
TIME.
SO -- WITH THAT WE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM. FIFTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. TO TWO WITNESSES PLEASE.
TWO MINUTES EACH.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR LET ME
FIRST BEGIN WITH SOME THANK YOUS
THANK YOU FOR SETTING THE
SPECIAL ORDER -- AND WANT TO
THANK YOU ALSO FOR THE DEEP
ENGAGEMENT THAT YOU HAVE
PERSONALLY PUT INTO THIS ISSUE
YOUR STAFF HAS A FOR ALL THE
WORK THEY'VE DONE ON THIS BILL --
I'M GONNA START BY ACCEPTING ALL
OF THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
AND ALSO TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO THANK ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
HAVE BEEN ENGAGE.
IN THIS -- THE COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BUT AS WELL
AS OTHERS -- PARTICULAR
REPRESENTING THE RENTAL HOUSING
INDUSTRY WITH HIM WE HAVE DEEPLY
ENGAGED.
WE ALL KNOW IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WERE IN THE MIDST OF THE WORST
HOUSING CRISIS IN STATE HISTORY.
WITH INCREDIBLE HOUSING DEMAND
OVER THE PAST DECADE THE MEDIAN
RENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAS
INCREASED BY OVER A THIRD.
WHILE MEDIAN INCOME HAS REMAINED
FLAT.
OVER HALF OF ALL RENTERS AND
OVER 80% OF LOW INCOME RENTERS
ARE RENTBURDEN.
PAIN OVER A THIRD OF THEIR
INCOME TOWARD RENTS.
FAMILIES WERE MAKING THE
IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE EVERY MONTH
BETWEEN PAIN FOR ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS.
WORKING FOR BASIC NECESSITIES.
WE'VE ALL READ IN THE PAPERS
THAT ARE HOMELESS POPULATIONS
ARE INCREASING BY DOUBLE DIGITS
ACROSS THE STATE WITHIN THIS
PAST YEAR.
AN UNCONSCIONABLE FIGURE DRIVEN
LARGELY BY THE INABILITY OF MANY
INDIVIDUALS TO PAY THE RENT.
AND WE HAVE ALL HEARD AND READ
TOO MANY STORIES OF TENANTS
FACING RAN HIKES.
OF 10% 20% 50% A 100%.
THIS BILL AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
IS A CRITICAL PART OF THE
SOLUTION THERE TO HELP THE BILL.
I'M GONNA SCRIBE HALF OF THE
BILL GOING TO ASK MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER GRAYSON TO DESCRIBE THE
SECOND.
SO FIRST OF ALL OF ONE PART OF
THE BILL IS AN ANTI RENT GOUGING
POLICY IT IS NOT RENT CONTROL.
IT'S A POLICY DESIGNED TO
PROTECT MOST OF OUR STATES
FIFTEEN MILLION TENANTS WHO DO
NOT HAVE RENT CONTROL AGAINST
AGREE JUST RENT INCREASES WHILE
ALLOWING LANDLORDS TO MAKE A
FAIR RATE OF RETURN.
IT'S MODELED AFTER A CALIFORNIA
LAW THAT IT'S BEEN THE BOOKS FOR
A HUNDRED AND FORTY YEARS THAT
HAS PROHIBITED PRICE GOUGING
ABOVE 10%.
AFTER AN EMERGENCY OR NATURAL
DISASTER LIKE A FIRE OR AN
EARTHQUAKE.
THE KEY ELEMENTS OF THE ANTI
RENT GOUGING POLICY WOULD
ESTABLISH A CAP ON ANNUAL RENT
INCREASES SET AT 7% PLUS THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX INFLATION.
WHICH IS GENERALLY TWO AND A
HALF 23% A YEAR FOR A TOTAL OF
NINE AND A HALF 210% A YEAR.
OUR BILL WOULD EXEMPT SOME SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT OVERLY BURDEN IT
EXEMPTS NEW CONSTRUCTION FOR TEN
YEARS SO AS TO NOT TO GET IN THE
WAY OF NEW HOUSING THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED.
AND THIS BILL SUNSETS AND THREE
YEARS GIVEN US THE CHANCE TO RE
EVALUATE AT THAT TIME.
I NOW LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES MY FELLOW JOINT
AUTHORS WHO WILL SPEAK TO THE
BILL'S OTHER MAIN COMPONENTS.
WHICH WERE REQUIRES JUST BECAUSE
TO VICTOR TENANTS MR GRAYSON.
THANK YOU SIR OF THE FLOOR IS
YOURS IF WE COULD.
WE WILL BE AN EXPEDITIOUS
FABULOUS REMEDY IS MY FRIEND AND
I WILL.
I WOULD CHOOSE PART A OF OF THE
SECOND HALF ANTI GOUGING IS ONE
SIDE OF THE TENANT PROTECTION
CORNING THE OTHER IS JUST
BECAUSE THE FICTION.
AB FORTY NEEDED TO REQUIRES A
LANDLORD TO LISTED BECAUSE IN
THE WRITTEN NOTICE TO TERMINATE
A TENDENCY.
IF THE TENANT HAS OCCUPIED THE
PROPERTY FOR TWELVE MONTHS OR
MORE THIS IS THE SENATE -- THIS
ISN'T THIS IS ESSENTIAL.
AS A PROTECTION BECAUSE IT
GUARANTEES DUE PROCESS OF LAW.
AND GUARDS AGAINST ARBITRARY
RETALIATORY OR DISCRIMINATORY
EVICTIONS WHILE IT IS LEGAL FOR
A LANDLORD TO EVICT SOMEONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN THE IT'S
ILLEGAL BECAUSE THEY ARE A
MEMBER OF A PROTECTED CLASS A
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
OR BECAUSE THEY FILE A HABIT IT
HABITABILITY COMPLAINT.
IT IS LEGAL TO EVICT THEM FOR NO
CAUSE AT ALL.
IT IS EASY TO IMAGINE A
SITUATION WHICH A LANDLORD
ACTING IN BAD FAITH COULD USE
THIS LOOPHOLE TO MASK THE
INTENTION BEHIND A TRULY ILLEGAL
EVICTION.
AND LET'S BE CLEAR THIS BILL
SIMPLY EXTENDS THE DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE GRANTED TO
ATTEND IT WAS COVERED UNDER A
LEASE AGREEMENT.
LISTING OF BECAUSE IN A FICTION
IS NOT A BURDEN TO LANDLORDS IT
IS THE EXACT STANDARD THAT
APPLIES TO THE MAJORITY OF
TENANTS IN THE MAJORITY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IF INTENDED FAILS TO PAY RENT
REACHES THE TERM OF THE LEASE
MISTREATS PROPERTY COMMITS
REPEATED NUISANCE VIOLATIONS OR
CONDUCTS ILLEGAL ACTIVITY ON THE
PROPERTY THEY CAN BE A VICTIM
JUST LIKE UNDER EXISTING LAW.
THIS BILL ONLY COVERS A SPECIFIC
SITUATION WHERE A LANDLORD
DECIDES TO REMOVE IT AND AND
CANNOT ARTICULATE A REASON WHY
THEY NEED TO DO SO WE ALL AGREE
THAT A PERSON SHOULD NOT THE
VICTIM OF THE AFFECTED BECAUSE
OF THEIR RACE.
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER IDENTITY
OR BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN A
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
WE HAVE A STRONG FOR HOUSING LAW
IN PLACE. TO PROTECT AGAINST
THESE HARMS BUT ANY PICTURE
WITHOUT BECAUSE COMPLETELY
NEGATES THE EXISTENCE OF THOSE
PROTECTIONS I'D LIKE TO TURN --
THE REST OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM OAKLAND TO EXPLAIN HOW THE
HUMAN COST IMPACTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA THE FLOOR SHORES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES A FEW WORDS BUT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO SPECIFIC TO
THAT JUST BECAUSE PROVISIONS
PROTECTIONS AGAINST RENT GOUGING.
AND UNJUST EVICTIONS GO HAND IN
HAND WE NEED.
BOTH THERE ARE POLICY PAIR YOU
CAN'T HAVE ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER
IF WE HAVE JUST BECAUSE
PROTECTIONS ALONE.
THEN AGREE JUST RENT INCREASES
CAN CAUSE A TEND TO BE UNABLE TO
AFFORD RENDON ULTIMATELY LEAD TO
A QUOTE UNQUOTE ECONOMIC.
EVICTION SIMILARLY STANDALONE
RENT AND TAKE OUT IN PROTECTIONS
CANNOT HELP KEEP FAMILIES IN
THEIR HOME TO THE LANDLORD CAN
AFFECT A TENANT FOR ANY REASON
OR NO REASON AT ALL SO WE NEED
BOTH.
AN A. B. FORTY TWO PROVIDES BOTH
OF THESE POLICIES SIDE BY SIDE.
OUR HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT
LIMITED TO JUST A SUPPLY PROBLEM
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT OUR
HOUSING CRISIS HOLISTICALLY IN
USE EVERY TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
TO BRING RELIEF TO AS MANY
CALIFORNIANS AS POSSIBLE WE CAN
STIMULATE SUPPLY AND SUPPORT
TENANTS A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO IS A CRITICAL PART OF THAT
SOLUTION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOTH
THANK YOU THANK YOU TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
HELLO MY NAME IS SASHA GRAHAM
AND I'M WITH THE HOUSING NOW
COALITION.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN I WAS
LIVING IN A HOME WITH MY SON IN
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA.
THAT I HAD BEEN LIVING IN FOR
NEARLY TEN YEARS WITHOUT ANY
ISSUE.
IN MAY OF THAT YEAR THE PROPERTY
WAS SOLD TO A NEW OWNER WITHIN A
MONTH MY RATE WAS INCREASED OVER
A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN ONE FELL SWOOP A HUNDRED AND
50% RATE INCREASE.
MY INCOME AND NOT INCREASE BUT I
SCRAPE TOGETHER THE MONEY TO PAY
THE RENT IN FULL AND ON TIME.
BUT EVEN THOUGH THE NEW LAN OR
HAD INCREASED MY RANT THAT WAS
NOT ENOUGH.
THEY WANT TO SELL THE PROPERTY
AND THEY WANT TO FLIP IT.
WITHIN TWENTY DAYS THE LANDLORD
GAVE ME A NO CALL THE ELECTION
TO BE OUT OF OUR HOME WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS.
AT THAT TIME I WAS EXPERIENCING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT MY JOB.
AND I WAS FIRED FOR FIGHTING AND
DEFENDING BACK DEFENDING MYSELF.
EVEN THOSE ABLE TO FIND A JOB
WITHIN A MONTH AND A HALF REYES
HAD RISEN SO HIGH THAT I CANNOT
AFFORD A SECURE.
AFFORD A SECURITY DEPOSIT
ANYWHERE.
MY SON AND I BECAME HOMELESS FOR
THREE YEARS.
WE WERE FORCED TO LIVE IN A SAFE
AND STABLE CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE
WE COULDN'T AFFORD ANYTHING MORE.
WOULD MOVE FROM COUCH TO COUCH
BY CONTINUE TO WORK AND STARTED
UNDERGRADUATE SCHOOL AT UC
BERKELEY.
IT WAS TRAUMATIZING.
MY SON OF SUFFERS FROM DEEP
DEPRESSION FROM HAVING
EXPERIENCED SUCH INSTABILITY SO
EARLY IN HIS LIFE AND EACH DAY
IS A STRUGGLE FOR HIM.
IT IS NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT WHEN
I SAY THAT AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO COULD LITERALLY SAVE LIVES.
THEY CAN SAY FAMILIES FOR MENTAL
ANGUISH AND DESPAIR.
IT COULD PROVIDE PHYSICAL SAFETY.
WE CAN ALLOW OUR CHILDREN TO
GROW UP TO BE THE BEST VERSION
OF THEMSELVES WITHOUT THE TRAUMA
OF LOSING A HOME.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO PREVENT RING
DOUSING WE MUST ALSO PROTECT
FAMILIES ARE BEING ARBITRARILY
EVICTED WHEN THEY HAVE DONE
NOTHING WRONG.
HOW'S IT HUMANE THAT WE AS A
SOCIETY ALLOW LANDLORDS TO THROW
PEOPLE ONTO THE STREETS FOR NO
REASON OTHER THAN PROFIT.
DOUBLE DIGIT INCREASES OF
FAMILIES BECOMING HOMELESS EACH
YEAR THE MONETARY COST OUR
COMMUNITIES IS EXPONENTIAL.
LET ALONE THE MENTAL SPIRITUAL
AND EMOTIONAL COSTS THAT THE
FAMILIES THEMSELVES ARE GOING
THROUGH.
THAT I AND MY SON HAVE GONE
I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PASS AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE TWO MINUTES
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BRYAN ACOSTA ON BEHALF
OF EACH ACTION AND A BROAD
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS WHO
ABOUT SPONSORING AND SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE.
MERGING YOUR ARE YOUR AYE VOTE --
JUNIOR I WROTE ON BEHALF OF THE
SEVENTEEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
TO RENTERS WHO WILL BENEFIT FROM
THESE.
REASONABLE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AND AS THE AUTHORS HAVE
DESCRIBED.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE A
BILL THAT HAS BOTH PROTECTIONS
FOR MARIN COUCHING IN
PROTECTIONS FROM JUST BECAUSE WE
JUST HEARD THE STORY.
OF ONE RENTER AND WE HAVE BEHIND
US.
MANY OTHERS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
IMPACTS OF FOR LACK OF
PROTECTIONS IN THIS AREA.
IN THIS JUST BECAUSE PIECES SO
CRITICAL BECAUSE IT CLOSES A
LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW THE LOOPHOLE
THAT ALLOWS.
FOR A FICTION.
THE LOOPHOLE THAT IS A LOOPHOLE
THAT ALLOWS A FICTION BASED ON
RETALIATION.
BASED ON DISCRIMINATION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
THE COUPLE WHO GIVES BIRTH TO
CHILDREN WHO GROW INTO A FAMILY
WHO WERE SUDDENLY FIND AND NO
CAUSE OF ACTION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THE YOUNG.
MAN WHO BECOMES A TEENAGER AND
SUDDENLY THE MANAGER DOESN'T
LIKE THE WAY HE LOOKS AT HIS
FRIEND'S LOCKER TALKING ABOUT.
THE NEW OWNER WHO BUYS THE
PROPERTY AND WANTS TO QUOTE
CHANGE THE COMPLEXION OF THE OF
THE OF THE COMPLEX. FOR THE
TENANT WHO COMPLAINS TOO MUCH
THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT PROTECTED
UNDER CURRENT LAW THEY'RE NOT
PROTECTED FROM EXTREME RENT
INCREASES THIS BILL WILL DO BOTH
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ORIGINALLY ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF YOU'D
COME FORWARD PLEASE WILL CREATE
A LINE SO THAT YOU CAN --
TESTIFIED.
AND IF WE COULD DO A GO AHEAD
START NAME AND AFFILIATION CA
AND WE TRY TO CLOSE THE DOOR IF
WE CAN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI.
ALSO HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
REVEREND MAC SHORE UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH IN SUPPORT OF
THIS.
THANK YOU REVEREND NEXT WITNESS
PLACE IF YOU COULD COME ON UP
DON'T BE SHY BE READY TO GO THE
NEXT PERSON GOOD AFTERNOON.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME AS
WELL BUT ON SALAS SIMONTON AND I
FROM THE CENTER LIST AND WITH
ACE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S ELIZABETH YOU REPAIRED
WITH AS HERE YOU TEND TO ONE
WHERE 54% OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
RENTERS AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
WHEN IS BRIDGE PLAYER I'M WITH
CASSIE I TEND TO ONE AND THAT I
WORK FOR SEXUALLY FRESCO
DISTRICT WE HAVE CHILDREN THAT
ARE HOMELESS OF HIS LIKE YOU
WORK?
RENDON CREASES I SPORTS BOOK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
STAND UP FOR YOUR EYE Là I MAKE
THAT THAT IT CAN'T THE LAW HOW
TO ACT ON THE PROTECTION THEY
GIVE ME ANOTHER MINUTE IT'S IN
MY THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE HISTORY
SUPPORT AV FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PATRICIA COME FROM
A SOMEBODY POINT THANK YOU.
I'M I DO JENKINS FROM HERITAGE
PARK RIDGE OF RICHMOND AND I DO
APPROVED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IS MY WITH THIRTY SECONDS UP FOR
YET I'M GONNA LIVE A OUR BABY
GOT THE ONLY THING.
LEGENDADO FOR FAR MORE.
ACCORDING TO THE NOTES SO THAT I
CAN IN MY FOLDER THANK YOU YEAH
I WANT.
TO MAKE YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THE NUMBER JOSE. FOR THE POCONO
PLATEAU OUR ALARM WHICH OF
BETTER.
SOME IN THE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU
SIR.
THANK YOU COME ON UP TO THE MIKE
SO WE CAN HEAR UNITES UNLOCK
ELSA STEPHEN REA AGO RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA HERITAGE PARK IN
FAVOR FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS CECILIA OUT A GUY
FROM THE LOS ANGELES HYPE IS I
PASS AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- CARLOS
RAIN -- FROM LOS ANGELES AND I
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU.
RESERVOIR GUESTS FROM A POINT
AND I'M SUPPORTING THIS THEM.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THERE YOU GO THANK
YOU.
WILLIAM CASEY WITH FACE HOUSE
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CLAUDIA RAILS.
AND I SUPPORT FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK MY RANK IS THANK YOU
MATH OF MY EARLY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MAHDI AT OUR YES
AND I'M FROM SAN DIEGO AND I'M
SUPPORTER OUT THEY AB. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
A MINIMUM VOLUME FROM SAN DIEGO
ACE -- AMONG STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF WITHOUT FOR TEENAGERS TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY NAME IS GERRY MILLER ADDING
IS TIMES OFFERED THE CORPORATE
LANDLORDS AND I SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU SIR.
LEVEL WILL AS SOMEONE ACE
ORGANIZER AND A COUNCIL MEMBER
FROM THE CITY OF RICHMOND AND I
SUPPORT FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M HI MAKE CATTERY LIVE IN
CONCORD CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M WITH ACE AND I SUPPORT.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
NAMES ISRAEL APPEARS ON WITH THE
ACE OAKLAND AND I'M IN SO STRONG
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU RENTS STUDENT HIGH
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DUKE YOU CAN PULL IT
MY NAME IS AN OUT OF THE CASE I
AM.
AN APPLE YEAH THE HI IT'S A BIG
AVE.
IN A COUPLE TO TEN BY THOSE THE
OAKLAND THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM ANY GARCIA FROM AIDS WITH
ACE OAKLAND AND I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE CONSIDER THESE
TESTIMONIES AND PASS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARYLAND IS AS LASSEN
THIS A EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
NO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE NOT GONNA
KIDS HI MY NAME IS CHILDREN NO
CHILDREN IF YOU'RE WITH ADULTS
IF YOU WITH THE DAHLE TWO DOGS
CAN SPEAK.
LET'S HAVE THE DOLLS YOU CAN
STAND WITH THEM YOU CAN STAY
WITH ADULTS PLEASE.
THERE YOU GO OKAY.
THE NUMBER IS NOT A ALSO DO EVEN
WITH LITTLE SON HILLIS EVEN CALL.
I BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO SUPPORT
YOU AND I LOVE IT I THOUGHT SUCH
AND THEY THOSE THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
NEXT PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JACKSON YODER I'M
WITH ACE SACRAMENTO AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
CURRENT EVENTS ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME TMG PARTNERS AND
SANTA PROPERTIES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER OF SELLING
THE MONTHS BUT LAST YEAR'S I'M
FROM RICHMOND CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS LAURA WITH A
SACRAMENTO NAY SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BOB THE GRASS I'M
FROM CONCORD CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT FOUR TEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS SHEA I AM WITH ACE
THE ACLU BOARD OF SACRAMENTO AND
CENTER POPULAR DEMOCRACY AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANDREA MATTEO AND
I'M WITH EAST LOS ANGELES AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ABIGAIL -- FROM
ACE TO I'M FROM LOS ANGELES AND
I CAME TO HEAR TO SAY TO VOTE
YES ON A BEFORE YOU.
TO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SERGIO VARGAS I'M
AN ORGANIZER WITH A SET OF LOS
ANGELES AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHN ABOUT HOW TO
THOUGH WITH ACE IN SACRAMENTO
AND I'M IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEFFERSON MCGEE I'M
WITH SACRAMENTO A CINNAMON'S THE
ASK FOR SUPPORT FOR FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS RICARDO JIMENEZ
INCOME FROM MY LATE NIGHT
LAUNCHES BORDER NAY BEAST.
FORTY EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS PATTY SHAW I'M A
MEMBER OF SACK AT AND SAINT
MARKS LOCAL ORGANIZING COMMITTEE
TO AND HOMELESSNESS I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA LIVING ST I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMUNITY GROUP ACE WE ARE CO
SPONSOR OF AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FRANCIS GUITARS WITH A
CALIFORNIA ACE MEMBER IN SUPPORT
OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SIR AND DAY TEACHER THANK YOU.
THIS I AM HOMELESS FROM LOS
ANGELES.
AND I SUPPORT.
AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONLY GOT TROUBLE YOU'RE FROM LOS
ANGELES.
IN A SUPPORT.
THERE YOU GO FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS GINA MASSEY AND I'M
WITH OF THE EIGHTH ACTION
COALITION AND I SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND
ENCOURAGE ALL THANK YOU.
I'M ONLY SHARON FROM ACE.
LOS ANGELES AND I SUPPORT.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS JOE STRING ON I'M
FROM A LOS ANGELES I'M IN HERE.
SUPPORT FOR FORTY A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
RACHEL WALLACE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
CALIFORNIA'S THE BUILDING
BECAUSE CONSTRUCTION STRAIGHT
COUNCIL ALSO YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MORE SECONDS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR WAS IN A CAR MUCH ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IS
STRONGSUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SAM
RENDON MAYES I'M A MEMBER OF
FACE AS WELL AS THE POMONA
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY CENTER AND
PUSH SWITCHES POMONA UNITED
FIRST THEY WILL HOUSING.
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SEVEN ANDERSON ON WE HAVE
A SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JZ DEAN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I GUESS THE LEGACY OF CRANES ON
BEHALF OF NONPROFIT ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS MONTEREY
WITH CALIFORNIA BE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARILYN J. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES AND LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI THERE MY NAME IS A READ A
JONES ON WITH ACE OF LOS ANGELES
I'M ALSO WITH THE BEALES SEE
WHICH IS THE BALL IN THE MARCH.
CREE JOB BRANCH OF THE LOS
ANGELES TENNIS UNION I'M ALSO
HERE AS A FOUNDER OF CC MCA
WHICH IS CONCERNED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS FOR CHESAPEAKE APARTMENT.
I REPRESENT FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE UNITS AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU MA'AM.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH SEVEN
HUNDRED WE HAVE OUR SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
ANYA LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY ONE OF
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A CAP RACY TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA TECH
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MEGHAN ABLE ADVOCACY DIRECTOR
TECH EQUITY STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ON A VALENTINE ON BEHALF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU --
RUBBER COPELAND SECOND TENANTS
UNION SECOND HOMES ORGAN
MANAGEMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BEVERLY ROBERTSON --
WITH AIDS AND I SUPPORT.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
KNOW THAT MEANS TO LIVE THANK
YOU.
MY MY MY NAME IS BARBARA PINTO
I'M A REPRESENTATIVE FROM A SAN
DIEGO AND I'M STRONG SUPPORTER.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MA'AM.
OR JOB TO TELL WHAT TO SHOULD GO
FAR GONE -- HIS NAME IS --
SOLDIERS HIGH FROM A PEN --
OAKLAND ASIA PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK AND HE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME'S TINA ROBINSON I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN A LANDLORD AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MANY FRANCISCO DO I KNOW SOME --
LANDLORD AS WELL AND I'M ALSO
WITH ACE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ELENA TO RIDE LOW UNITY CHAPLAIN
EMERITUS I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
JORDAN DANGERFIELD AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
SIR -- I'M TYLER SURELY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL RIGHT THANK
YOU YOU CAN SPEAK UP THEIR FOLKS
SO WE CAN HEAR YOU NICE ALLOWED.
IRA CAL IN HERE ENCOURAGE --
WITH COURAGE CAMPAIGN CHRISTIAN
PAIN IN OUR ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION MEMBERS ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO MAILINGS AND YOU KNOW
CHAVEZ AND ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND THE WE WERE
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A SEVENTY I WAS WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS USA REPRESENTING
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND ORGANIZED
PEOPLE IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE A SOLEMN
REPRESENTING THE UC DAVIS BELOW
SEND CENTER FOR FILIPINO STUDIES
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DIVINE GILLIAN
HATE FROM VALLEJO CALIFORNIA I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M TONY THAT THOUGH SO I AM AND
BUT LEVEL CALIFORNIA'S SOLANO
COUNTY I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS IMAGES
TO A SON AND I LIVE IN NOW BUT
THE WHOLE CALIFORNIA.
I'M A TENANT.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANKS SO MUCH.
I'M MARIA CORA FROM VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
OLANO I'M WITH PECO CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING TEN PLUS CHAPTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS FOR NON MELISSA AND
I'M HERE FOR TO PARK ON I'M IN
THE GRANTED THAT BUT STRAWBERRY
HERE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MOSES BRING
YOUR AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
NUMBER.
OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY GOT IT THANK
YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS RIGHT TO GAG AND I
AM A GRADUATE STUDENT UC DAVIS
AND I'M HERE FOR THE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AS WELL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT CLEARY --
PRODUCT RESIDENT OF SANITY.
A MEMBER OF PACKED AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ROBERTA RYAN I AM A RESIDENT OF
FREMONT CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT
FAITH IN ACTION EAST BAY AND I'M
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
A ROOF SOBRE TOLD BUT I SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WAGED HAVE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI ALEX MIX THOUGH -- VALLEJO
RESIDENT OF A MEMBER OF THE
GROUND SAKE.
FILIPINO IMMIGRANT.
WORKER ORGANIZATION I'M IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MICHELLE PARASITE WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE SPROUT A CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND ALSO A
LANDLORD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW BAKER
PLANNING CONSERVATION THE IN
STRONG SUPPORT TAKING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I I'M HESITANT TO **** BUT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE
IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SEEING SEEING NONE.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
IF YOU'D STEP FORWARD.
YOU GET TO CHOOSE TO WITNESSES
MAXIMUM TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND THEN WE'LL JUST HAVE PEOPLE
WITH THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS DEBORAH CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
LET ME FIRST START BY SAYING
THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
OWNERS WHO ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
BY THEIR TENANTS WOULD VIOLATE
THE STANDARDS HERE SET FORTH IN
THIS BILL EVEN THE PRIOR VERSION
OF THE 5% WE DON'T BELIEVE
OWNERS WOULD VIOLATE THAT
STANDARD.
IN OUR BIGGEST CONCERN HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THAT WE DON'T MAKE A
BAD PROBLEM WORSE BY SCARING OFF
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA WE
WANT BALANCE AND WE WANT
STABILITY.
WE NEED PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO ENCOURAGING NEW
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE PROVIDING
ADEQUATE SUPPLY IS THE ONLY WAY
TO PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR
CURRENT AND FUTURE TENANTS?
WE DON'T WANT TO SCARE OFF
DEVELOPMENT WE DON'T WANT
DEVELOPERS TO GO TO OTHER STATES.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR CURRENT
CALIFORNIA BASED MEMBERSHIP AND
BUILDERS HAVE ALREADY DECIDED
THAT IT'S TIME TO MOVE ON TODAY
I WAS PLANNING TO HAVE A SPEAKER
WITH ME HOWEVER.
SHE TOOK HER BUILDINGS TO TEXAS.
WHEN WE HAD TWELVE HUNDRED UNITS
MOVED TO TEXAS EIGHT HUNDRED
HAVE MOVED TO UTAH AND ELEVEN
HUNDRED HAVE MOVED TO COLORADO
AND NEVADA TO START THEIR
PLANNING PROCESS THERE?
WITH ORGANS IN NEW ADOPTION OF
ITS 7% CAP AND ANNOUNCEMENTS
THAT THEY MAY GO LOWER.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN A 38% DECLINE
IN MULTI FAMILY INVESTMENT OVER
THIS ONE YEAR PERIOD.
WE CAN'T LET CITIES OFF THE HOOK
PLACING BLAME ON LANDLORDS IS
CERTAINLY THE EASY ANSWER.
BUT BY PROVIDING PLACES FOR
PEOPLE TO LIVE HAS BECOME ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST.
UNRESOLVED CHALLENGES IN THE
STATE WE'VE ALREADY REJECTED
SOME VERY IMPORTANT BILLS IN
THIS LEGISLATURE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE DECLINING
HOUSING GIVING IN TO NAME BE
OPPOSITION.
WE NEED TO LINK AB FORTY NEEDED
TO TO HOUSING PRODUCTION.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO SET A
STATE WIDE CAP.
WE NEED TO MAKE CLEAR TO
BUILDERS AND DEVELOPERS THIS IS
OUR NEW STANDARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TEN AYE PLEASE
CLOSE.
THANK YOU. TWO MINUTES PLEASE
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE A
SHELF CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION CALORIE
CHAIR PRESENTS ABOUT TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND PROPERTY OWNERS OF MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
THOUSAND UNITS STATEWIDE.
ASSOCIATION BEEN UP OF SMALL
MEDIUM AND LARGE PROPERTY OWNERS
ALTHOUGH SMALL MEDIUM MAKE ABOUT
75% MEMBERSHIP WE'RE FULLY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ON EFECTIVE SOLUTIONS IN
A BALANCED APPROACH.
BUT WE DON'T FEEL AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IN ITS CURRENT FORM
IS A BALANCED APPROACH WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED WITH THE JUST
BECAUSE POLICY HAS BEEN AMENDED
INTOTHE BILL AND WE WOULD POINT
OUT THAT JUST BECAUSE BILLS
FAILED TO PASS BUT THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY THIS YEAR DURING
HOUSE.
OF ORIGIN DEADLINE WE'RE NOT
NEED ACTION BUSINESS IT'S
EXPENSIVE AND IT'S VERY TIME
CONSUMING THE CURRENT EVICTION
PROCESS TAKES ON AVERAGE FOUR TO
SIX MONTHS IN COSTS ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE IN
LEGAL FEES.
UNDER JUST BECAUSE WE CANNOT
EASILY REMEDY THE SITUATION FOR
GOOD TENANTS WHAT OTHER TENANTS
VIOLATED THE LEASE AGREEMENT
FEELING TO PAY RENT FREE
NUISANCES OR CONDUCTING CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THIS HURTS GOOD TENANTS%
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
COME OUT OF THE BILL.
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE BILL WITH
THE MEN FROM CPI PLUS FIVE TO
SEE TÁI PLUS 7% THERE ARE
SEVERAL CRITICAL ELEMENTS WE'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS.
FIRST EXEMPTION FOR OWNERS OF
TEN SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES
ONLY SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO ALL
OWNERS INCLUDING LLC'S ARE
TRUSTS AND ALL PROPERTY TYPES
INCLUDING UNITS.
EXEMPTION OWNER OF TEN HOMES
WHO'S DOING QUITE WELL WELL
FORCING OWNERS OF DUPLEXES OR
FOR PLEXUS TO COMPLY WITH THE
COURT REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL
WE BELIEVE IS UNJUST POLICY.
SECOND WHEN IT COMES TO MARKET
IMPACTS AND MAKING SURE WE ARE
HUNGRY NEW CONSTRUCTION WE'D
LIKE TO SEE A TEN YEAR OLD AN
EXEMPTION IS CURRENTLY IN THE
BILL FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION TO BE
EXPANDED.
SO THAT WE DON'T NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE HOUSING SUPPLYING
CALIFORNIA WORK WE'VE ALSO
DISCUSSED MEANS TESTING WITH
REGARD TO RELOCATION FEES AS A
MORE BALANCED SOLUTION.
FINALLY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
SHOULD BECOME TO DEAL WITH
SENATE'S CRITICAL FOR OUR
MEMBERS OF C. COMES A STATEWIDE
STANDARD BY ESTABLISHING
PREEMPTION ONA GO FORWARD BASIS
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THE STABILITY
IN THE FORM OF A CONSTITUTIONAL.
CONCURRENT AMENDMENT SO WE DON'T
FACE THE THREAT OF HAVING THE
PERCENTAGE ROGER DOWN YEAR AFTER
YEAR WITHOUT YOUR POST ABOUT
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON A CHURCH JACKSON
MEMBERS CREAM THREE CM HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE PROPONENTS
BUT REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
UNTIL IT AS AMENDED PER THE
PARAMETERS ARE CONCEPTUALLY
COMMIT TO INCLUDE LANGUAGE IT
SATISFIES OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU
SIR.
THANK YOU KNOW BUT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON PARTICIPATION OF GREATER
LOS ANGELES IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBER RANKING SOON
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES EAST
BAY RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION
AND THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
OF ORANGE COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
BENCHER MEMBERS PACMAN WITH
AARON READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU.
HI ROBERTA MORE ONE OF TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE HERE -- FROM BAY
AREA HOUSING NETWORK WERE SMALL
MOM AND POPS I'M A SINGLE MOM I
HAVE A FOUR PLEX HOPING TO USE
IT FOR RETIREMENT SOME DAY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES SPECIALLY
JUST BECAUSE OF ACTION IT'S NOT
GOOD FOR ANYONE.
JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL RENTAL HOME COUNCIL WHO
ARE THE INSTITUTIONAL OWNERS OF
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES FOR RENT
COLLECTIVELY ON ABOUT. FIFTEEN
THOUSAND HOMES IN THE STATE WE
ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAMANTLY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION THANKS.
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESSES MOVE IT
IF WE COULD TO I GOT FORTY FIVE
MORE BILLS TO DO SO.
FROM REDWOOD CITY AND I'M HERE
TO AGAINST AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU
MA'AM RENTAL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS HOLLY.
FOLKS NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY
PLEASE.
ANY SOUTH FROM SAN JOSE I'M
STRONGLY AGAINST AB ONE THANK
YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
A FIRM PALM BAY AREA HOME UNLESS
NOW.
ONE GAINES RENT CONTROL OKAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GAINES
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I'M SOMEBODY SO I'M COME FROM
OUR SERVER TO CALIFORNIA AGAIN --
SEVEN FOUR SO I'M SORRY. ONE
FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE -- PROBLEMA
SUNNYVALE I'M AGAINST OF AB ONE
FOUR EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
FROM THE COMFORT OF FRIEDMAN SO
THEN CONTROL KILL THE HOUSE
MARKING TO BE A VERY BAD AS
AFTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS LINDA CHANDNI NOT LET
ME THAT I AGAINST AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU RAIN CAN
TAKE YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
MY NAME TO WIN THE LOUIS I'M
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THAT THE AND YOUR
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THE BOTTOM NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
SEVEN THANK YOU EXCUSE ME X.
WITNESS PLEASE WEEK. FOURTEEN
I'M SORRY WE'VE GOT TO GO ON
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE NAME
AND AFFILIATION.
I'M CHARGE AGAINST A P..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SIR AND APPRECIATE -- HANK YOU
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLACE JASON --
AND FROM -- UNICITY.
I'M A GAS A. B. FORTY TWO THANK
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS JOHN FROM OAKLAND NO
AB ONE FOUR EIGHT EIGHT TWO NINE
THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WOULD PLACE.
NEXT.
MY NAME IS A FRONT CALL I'M FROM
A RICHMOND CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
TO GO AGAINST A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU CONTACT. EIGHTY THREE
D. E. C..
DOLE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
I HAVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO FOLLOW SOMEONE
FIFTY CO. EIGHTY ONE ONE EIGHT
TWO THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS NO AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE ME YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION.
HOW ABOUT YOUR NAME AN AFFILIATE?
TELL US YOUR NAME AND WHERE
YOU'RE FROM [inaudible]
ONLY YEN.
HI LIANE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
MY NAME IS PETER J. PAN.
I'M HERE I'M OPPOSED TO AB ONE
FOUR EIGHT TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH
THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS CHEN MODEST BILLS X.
I. N. AND MAY I AM NOT OPPOSED
TO A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO I'M IN THE MISS KOREA THAT
CAME FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
NO AB ONE FOR A TWO AND A. Q.
WINE COUNTRY Q. SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE NAMES GORDON LAW
I'M FROM COLORADO I'M.
HERE TO A KEY IS THE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS.
MY NAY SNEEZE SARAH I'M FROM
BERKELEY.
AND A. B. FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
SO HELLO CENTERS SO I'M FROM
RICHMOND MY NAME IS AGREES HAN --
THOUGH AB ONE FOUR EIGHTY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE KILLINGS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUSAN WALL FROM
AMANTE COUNTY NOW AB FORTY
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU HOUSE THANK
YOU FOR THE HOUSES THANK YOU
MA'AM.
NEXT WITNESS MY NAME IS ANGELA
JOHN FROM A SAN JOSE.
PLEASE I AM AGAINST THE A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
YES IT BY THE DAYS WHEN.
HE PLEASE.
ROLL THE REFUND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
HI MY DAYS YOU SEND CHAIR AND
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND LOW
AB ONE ONE FOUR EIGHT TOOL THANK
YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
MY NAME IS.
ON THE WALL AND I COME FROM A
SOME UNTIL -- THE RENT CONTROL
IS UNFAIR FOR THE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
NEXT WEEK MY NAME IS AMANDA
LEóN AND NOW I'M FROM ON THE
RATE COUNTY AND NO AB ONE FOUR
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS HI MY NAME'S DIANE
WHEN I AM FROM COM MONTEREY
COUNTY.
AND THOUGH AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO LOW EGGMAN CHILLS THANKS SO
MUCH APPRECIATED NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME SEVENTY I COME FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY NO AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT WITNESS.
A. P. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ITS
LIFE WHAT IS YOUR NAME SIR.
AB MY LAST NAME THE KHôNG DEAL
AND COUPON BAY AREA THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE NAME
AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WOULD.
WHAT IS YOUR NAME SIR
[inaudible] FOUR HEY.
YEAH -- SORRY THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NEXT WITNESS PLACE.
MY NAME IS REALLY AMY CONSTANTIA
I COME FROM SACRAMENTO.
I CAN MAY I SAY NO AND EIGHTY
AND BE QUALITY AND I DO THINK
YOU MA'AM.
MY SERVICE -- WILLIAM TâM FROM
FREMONT.
HI I'M HERE I STRONGLY ATKINS --
A A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS.
I SOME SUBMISSIONS SINGLE
[inaudible]
AB.
ONE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME BY AND I'M COME FROM SAN
FRANCISCO [inaudible]
I AB ONE CLUB A TO TO THANK YOU
IS IT.
A LOT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS.
IN LAW NO ON EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT HI MARSHALL PHONE
SERVICES GO TO NOTE IN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ACCORDING WINE FROM
THE SENATE COLOR.
AND NO A. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EDWARD YANG FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND BURLINGAME NO.
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS TONY TEN A COUPLE OF
A SUDDEN THIS.
LOW AB EIGHT FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS LEO WONG OF COME ON
SUNDAY NIGHTS.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
ENEMIES ISLAND CHAIN FROM SAN
JOSE.
I AM AGAINST THE AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE GIVE IT
SHELVE FROM US SAN FRANCISCO
REGIONALLY TIE ONE NO ON A. B.
XIN ONLY PLEASE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
FOLKS I'M GOING TO CUT OFF THE
OPPOSITION IF I CAN'T GET YOU
JUST TO GIVE ME YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION OKAY MY NAME IS
DAN I'M FROM LOS GATOS THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME'S HOLO FROM.
SEVENTY TWO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU SIR.
BUT THAT IS FAN FONG FREMONT
CALIFORNIA NO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO RIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANKS SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
LEAVE FROM SAN FRANCISCO KNOLL
AB ONE FOUR EIGHTY TWO THANK
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS SAYING PAYING MILLION
FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
A. B. FORTY EIGHT BEING COOL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE MY
NAME'S WINNIE PHONE FARMS --
SIMPLE NO CITY NO A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS KHAN ACHING
COME FROM SOME CISCO NO A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MA'AM THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
I'M CALLING FROM SERVICES GOAL
NO EIGHT THREE FOUR EIGHT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SIR.
HELLO FROM BURLINGAME KNOLL
FOURTEEN AB.
FOR EIGHTY TWO MY NAME SON Q..
FOR IMPORTING CAM NO AB FORTY
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS THE CALLING PARTY
FROM CENSUS CALL.
LOW EIGHTY BE FORTY IN.
THANK YOU MA'AM. EIGHT NAME
MANUALLY AS SIMON SAYS.
NO AB.
ONE FORTY TWO THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE I'M DO YOU MAY
CHIANG CAME FONG SALAS AND ALL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MA'AM.
HI MY NAME'S TENSION FROM SAN
JOSE YEAH I'M STRONGLY AGAINST
AB EIGHTEEN OF EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS THERESA DO GIVE US
SOME PHYSICAL COMEDY IN PROBLEM
ONE CENTER.
WE WE HAVE.
EXCUSE ME NO THE NAME AND
AFFILIATION THANK YOUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE WELL I JUST. ONE
OF THE OKAY YET THEY SAY.
IF YOU CAN.
YOU REPRESENT THE THIRTY PEOPLE
HERE SO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SAY
THERE [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
DO WE HAVE BEEN MORE WITNESSES.
IF I DID.
WE HAVE AND NOT THE THIRTY
PEOPLE.
THANK YOU IF THAT ALL COME
FORWARD IF YOU CHOSE TO IDENTIFY
ALL THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED IF YOU
COME FOR YOU GET SOMEONE WHO'S
GOING.
TO IDENTIFY YOU AND SO YOU WON'T
EACH HAVE TO COME IN
INDIVIDUALLY THIS WOULD BE.
YEAH WHY DON'T YOU HAVE THEM
RAISE THEIR HANDS AND THEY THEY
TAKE -- DECILE LIVE I'M NOT WITH
THE COLLAPSE NO NO.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH I'VE MUCH
APPRECIATED.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WHO HAVE NOT.
COME FORWARD AND RAISE THEIR
HANDS.
IS THIS A NEW GROUP ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE SOMEONE WHO CAN SPEAK
FOR THIS GROUP WILL ALL OF YOUR
ALL OPPOSE LONG BILL ARE YOU
THAT MY CISCO PRISON THOUGH A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND THE
RENT CONTROL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO BEFORE EACH OF YOU GETS UP IS
SURCHARGE.
I'D LIKE WHAT HERE'S WHAT I'D
LIKE YOU TO DO IT I AM ASSUMING
YOU'RE ALL NO NOT STOCK.
YOU'RE ALL OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO COULD I JUST HAVE YOU
RAISE YOUR HAND THOSE OF YOU'VE
COME IN ARE YOU OPPOSED.
TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED.
MY NAME IS BRANDY -- NO.
GO HEAD AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
FUND DALY CITY.
A LITTLE ON AB FOR FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ARE WE'VE ALREADY GOT
A GROUP WHO'S ALREADY INDICATED
THEIR OPPOSITION.
THAT LAST ONE AND THEN WOULD NOT
LIKE TO HAVE THAT GROUP BELIEVE.
YOU'RE YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
MASON HALL FROM SOME BUSINESS
GOAL WITH THE STATE.
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU WHEN YOU HEARD THAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU ARE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS OUR
LIFE BECAUSE USUALLY MALES ABOUT
THE MEN BECAUSE YOU ONLY MA'AM
EXCUSE ME MA'AM I'M GOING TO
STOP THE OPPOSITION NOW IF I
I'VE ASKED SEVERAL TIMES IF
YOU'D FOLLOW MY RULES IF YOU'RE
NOT WILLING TO DO IT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE ANY MORE
TESTIMONY YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE.
MY NAME CINDY.
AFTER THE TWO IS TO BE A A TURN
BAY AREA HOLD ON I TO WORKS
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT THAT
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS.
MY CHINESE HE MYERS JOBS SOME
NONSENSICAL FIVE EIGHTY ONE
FORTY EIGHT TWO TOLD LOCAL.
THANK YOU. SIX NEXT WITNESS
PLACE MY NAME IS ANGELA TOM.
I'M CAME FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M NOT OPPOSED.
TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SO MUCH ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS AS SERGEANT IF
THERE'S SOMEBODY.
IF WE COULD GET.
IS SURE AN ORGANIZER WHO COULD
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF ALL OF THESE
FOLKS AND WE CAN HAVE THEM RAISE
YOUR HANDS HOLD ON ONE SECOND
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY PLEASE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION MY NAME IS FLOATING
LONG I COME FROM SOMEONE CISCO.
BY PHONE ONE THOUGH CONTROL
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS A RAY PAN I CAME FROM
THE SAN FRANCISCO.
I WAS A NEW OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE --
CONROY MENLO PARK PLEASE VOTE NO.
ON FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SIR.
MY NAME ES SIR I COME FROM SAN
JOSE I WILL FOR NO A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS LEE BOB
DONNAN SIR.
I KNOW WAIT UNTIL NO THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I AM VERY BIG CALL OF FARMS AND
THE SIX THE CO ON THOUGH AND
THEN -- ABA FORTUNATE TO TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TIM PAM FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
NO CONTROL RANGE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
I AM TO NEARLY IN HER FRIEND'S
SON SONS SO SHE GOAL A NO RING
CONTROL THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS.
MY NAME IS LAYING.
ON SOMETIMES SICKO LOW CONSERVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME JAN I COME FROM A SAN
JOSE I SEE NO L. A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM APPRECIATE
IT NEXT WITNESS PLEASE NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY.
MY NAME IS THE PHONE TWO YEAH
CONFERENCE I MESSAGE GO.
AB ONE FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE COME ON
FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
YELLING YEAH ARE COME FROM OUR
SEVEN SIX GOAL [inaudible]
KNOLL. EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND MY NAME IS SO
AND I COME FROM FEMA AND I THINK
THE GOING CONTROL CUES AND ONE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WAS THAT THE SHE LED TO CONQUER
MY NAME IS.
ONE HUNDRED AND TEN DAYS -- FOR
HIS FARM CONCORD AND SHE ASK
ANSWERING CAN THINK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS CALDERON OF FROM
DISCOURAGE BAY.
I'M AGAINST A RENTAL CONTROL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE COME ON
FORWARD.
THANK YOU MA'AM. ZERO SUFFERS.
SEVEN SEVEN SIX AND LITTLE A. B.
FOR THE SEVENTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU NEXT.
NEXT WITNESS.
I AM SEE WHILE THEM.
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
LOW A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TOLD
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAM I WANT LAURIE HI FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
KNOLL AB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO
PULL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME'S ANGELINA CHILD.
I COME FROM SENTENCES SCHOOL.
HELLO A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE I AM ALLEN FONG FROM HIS
ROLE NO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS THOMAS LINE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE NO A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SIR NEXT WITNESS.
MINOR MEDICAL CALL FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NO AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
UNANSWERED INDYCAR COME FROM THE
SUMMER SIX GOLDEN THOUGH EIGHTY
FOUR TO EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS BECKY G. FROM SAN
FRANCISCO THE BILL ON EIGHT BE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TOOL THANK YOU
MA'AM NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS THE MARY AND LEIGH
I'M COME FROM SAN FRANCISCO I
SEE NO FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS.
OKAY.
MY LAMBERT USING MORE HAVE COME
SEVEN C. SICKLE -- WE AND
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
ON FEB Là.
MY NAME'S DAINTY I COME FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NO AB.
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHEILA THANK.
OUR NO N. A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS A TYPE HOME COME FROM
SAN FRANCISCO LOW A. B. FOURTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MADE A YOUNG SAN
FRANCISCO NO ON AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
WITNESS MY NAME THE POLICY JOHN.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO NO AB FORTY
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS JACK CONGA AND FROM
SAN FRANCISCO.
NO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME SEVEN MILE.
I FOUND THAT SOME MONTHS AGO.
HUSSEIN GLORIA EIGHT BE FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOUR TOLD THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
MINE INDIA AND THEN.
SOMEONE SAYS YOU GO LOW.
NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS.
MY NEAR IN REGION LONG SALAS IS
YOU CALL LOW A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WITNESS MY NAME IS COREY
SAU WONG I'M COME FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MAIL NOT AB FORTY TWO
NO.
AP FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS MY NAME IS
A THREE AND TEN I'VE LEARNED
SOME A CISCO Là AB FORTY ID TO
HOLD.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUING ME I'M FROM L.
WORLD NO ON A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
I'M TONY RICH AND I'M PRESIDENT
OF THE SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS ON
THE BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION WE
ALL ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO I THINK
HOUSING KILLER THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT NEXT FIRST NAME IS ALBERS
SURE FROM US IN THE CAR KIND.
AND KNOLL AB FORTY TWO THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
HI CAM FINE I'LL COME ON THE
ISSUES GOAL MIGHT INVESTED IN
THEM ALL -- HI MAKE USE THAT
FORTY EIGHT EIGHTY THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MA'AM.
AND TO DO A LITTLE. EIGHT AND A.
B. I'M. ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO THANK
YOU NEXT WHEN I IN MY LET ME
SAID MY YEAH I AM CAME FROM
SEVEN SEAS CALL LOW A. B. FORTY
EIGHTY TOLD LOOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH MEXICO NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE WALL THANK YOU MRS COLO AB
ONE FULL EIGHTY TOTAL RAN
CONTRARY TO SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE RICHARD FOR MOST OF A
CISCO.
AGAINST FORTY EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
NO EIGHTY OUT FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TOWARD EN LOS AND TEN AND UNDER.
BOARD NAME IN A NAME WENDY WALL
FROM SURREY ACOSTA COALITION FOR
GOOD NEIGHBORHOODS WE HAVE FORTY
THOUSAND UNITS ONE FORTINO RENT
CONTROL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS SOME SENTENCES
GOAL.
SHAME ON THE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
ALLOW FROM SAN FRANCISCO NO AT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MA'AM THANKS SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS.
NO A. B. FOURTEEN A WHAT IS YOUR
NAME PLEASE MY NAME IS THE
CEILING THANK YOU WHERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATED NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME'S HAS ON CALL.
COME FROM SOME A CIRCLE -- KNOLL
ON BABY. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS.
VIEW OF ARMS EMESIS COLD NO A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
SIR.
I'M JEANNE UP A MOVIE THIS NO
RENT CONTROL THANK YOU MA'AM.
TV IN FROM SAN JOSE NO RING
CONTROL THANK YOU ALL AB LIKE
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YEAH THAT THE TALL FROM ALSO SAY
NO RENT CONTROL THANK YOU SIR
NEXT WITNESS.
NAME IS ORIGINALLY I'M FROM THE
SAN JOSE POLICE VOTING NO ON AB
FORTY EIGHTY TOLD BECAUSE LIKE
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED THANKS
SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
FIND ANYTHING TEND NOT.
I AM FUNDS THE COMMANDO NO AB
FORTY EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU MA'AM
APPRECIATE IT NEXT WITNESS.
THIS IS A MULTI YEAH I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO NO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS ELLEN I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
IT'S GONNA BE VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS I'M SURE MEMBERS
RAND MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED TO MAKE IT
STRONGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO I DARE ASK.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
OUR TO WE ARE ARE YOU HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING SEEING NO
FURTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
LET'S BRING IT BACK. TO THE
DYESS -- CLEARLY AN ISSUE OF
GREAT CONCERN AND PASSION ON
BOTH SIDES NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
I'VE BEEN A LANDLORD I'VE BEEN A
TENANT I KNOW THIS.
FROM BOTH ANGLES IF IT WERE ONLY
TRUE THAT ALL LAND WERE LORDS
WERE GOOD PEOPLE -- AND MANY ARE.
BUT WE DO HAVE A HOUSING
SHORTAGE AND WE NEED TO BALANCE
HOW WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS IT I
BELIEVE LANDLORDS SHOULD HAVE
ROOM. TO OPERATED A REASONABLE
PROFIT AND SHOULD HAVE
SUFFICIENT CONTROL OVER THEIR
PROPERTIES TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
OUT BAD TENANTS I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY DISAGREES WITH THAT.
I THINK THEY IT THIS BILL AS
AMENDED AS YOU'VE WORKED VERY
HARD TO MAKE IT HAPPEN -- GIVES
LANDLORDS -- PLENTY OF ROOM TO
REYES FRANCE SOME MIGHT ARGUE
TOO MUCH ROOM.
WE HAVE TO HER RECOGNIZE TO
PEOPLE ARE HURTING IN OUR
ECONOMY HOMELESSNESS RIGHT NOW
IS NO JOKE IT'S GETTING WORSE --
I WAS COMPELLED BY THE TESTIMONY
THIS WOMAN TO WORK HARD TO
MAINTAIN A STABLE HOME FOR
HERSELF AND HER SON -- I KNOW
THAT WE ARE SEEING A HUGE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SENIORS.
WHO ARE HOMELESS NOW FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THEIR LIVES NOT
BECAUSE THEY ARE DRUG ADDICTED
OR OF MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS BUT
THERE THAT ONE PAYCHECK AWAY
THEY CAN'T MAKE THE RANT THE
RAIN GETS INCREASED?
AND THERE HOMELESS AND THEN
THEY'RE OUT ON THE STREETS AND
WE ALL HAVE TO MEET THOSE
CHALLENGES OF HELPING THOSE
PEOPLE MAINTAIN A BASIC.
LEVEL OF HUMAN DIGNITY -- SO
IT'S CLEARLY A CRISIS I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
LANDLORDS CAN STILL -- GET RID
OF PROBLEM TENANTS -- THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT TAKES
AWAY THE ABILITY TO GET RID OF A
TENER DOESN'T PAY THE RENT -- TO
IS A IT SUFFICIENTLY DISRUPTIVE
OF THE OF THE A HOME IN THE AREA
IN WHICH THEY'RE LIVING -- THE
JUST BECAUSE CONTINUES FOR
EXACTLY THE SAME AS ITS EXISTING
GROUNDS.
OF FAILURE TO PAY RENT BREACH OF
LEAST COMMITTING WASTE CAUSING A
NUISANCE.
IN OTHER WORDS UNDER THIS BILL
LANDLORDS WILL.
ABSOLUTELY BE ABLE TO GET RID OF
BAD TENANTS -- I THINK THE U. AT
THE EXEMPTIONS ARE PRUDENT SMALL
TIME MOM AND POP LANDLORDS ARE
GENERALLY LEFT OUT IN RECENT
CONSTRUCTION IS ALSO LEFT OUT
WHICH I THINK.
ADDRESSES THE CONCERNS ABOUT --
PEOPLE NOT BUILDING THERE ARE A
LOT OF REASONS THAT WE'RE NOT
SEEING MULTI FAMILY.
HOMES AND APARTMENTS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ONES BY THE WAY HAS TO
DO WITH THE FEDERAL TAX LAW.
BACK IN THE EIGHTIES WHEN WE
TOOK AWAY THE X. CELEBRATED
DEPRECIATION.
SCHEDULE IT TOOK OUT A HUGE
AMOUNT OF THE PROFIT THAT
BUILDERS AND CONSTRUCTION WOULD
HAVE AND WE SAW A HUGE DROP IN
THE NUMBER THESE HOMES THAT WERE
BUILT SO.
I'M NOT SURE THERE'S ANY ONE
ISSUE -- BUT THERE ARE SERIES OF
THEM AND PERHAPS -- WE CAN
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AT SOME POINT
BUT THAT'S NOT YOUR BILL TODAY
SO I I SUPPORT THE BILL I
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY.
OF EVERYBODY HERE I APOLOGIZE
FOR AND CUT YOU OFF BUT WE DO.
TWO THIRTY AND I'VE GOT NOW
FORTY FOUR OTHER BILLS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO BEFORE MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT I GUESS -- BUT I'D LIKE
TO OPEN IT UP IF THERE ARE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AND THEN --
WE WILL.
TAKE A A MOTION IF THAT IS SO --
DESIRED.
SENATOR GONZALEZ -- I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD -- AS
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS YOU KNOW
A LARGE CITY LIKE LONG BEACH --
TO RIGHT BEFORE I LEFT THE
COUNCIL BROUGHT FORWARD A
RELOCATION ASSISTANCE ORDINANCE
TO PROTECT THE RESIDENTS THAT
WERE IN THE DOWNTOWN LONG BEACH
AREA BECAUSE WE DID HAVE A LOT
OF THE INCREASES.
IN RENTS BECAUSE OF NEW
DEVELOPMENTS AND MUCH OF THIS
BILL LOOKS EXACTLY LIKE THE BILL
THAT WAS PASSED IN LONG BEACH
WHICH I APPRECIATE BUT EVEN WITH --
MORE NARROW RESTRICTIONS AND
AFTER LOOKING AT THIS BILL I
MEAN A SIMILAR TO WHAT SENATOR
JACKSON MENTIONED YOU KNOW THREE
YEARS SUNSET.
NO FALL AN AT FAULT --
INCLUSIONS ADD EXEMPTION ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND ESSENTIALLY --
OWNERS CAN.
INCREASE THEIR RENTS BY TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS.
WHICH IS SIGNIFICANT STILL IT'S
IT'S STILL ALLOWABLE WITH THIS
BILL.
SO WITH THAT SAID I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU -- FOR ALL
OF THE FOLKS THAT HAVE COME OUT
ON BOTH SIDES THE ONLY THIG I
HATE ABOUT THIS BILLS THAT
OFTENTIMES IT GETS DIVISIVE.
AND IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THIS
ACTUALLY PROTECTS -- RENTERS AND
ALSO LANDLORDS -- TOO MANY
EXTENSIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYTHING ELSE CENTER WHITE HOUSE
KEITH.
A QUESTION ON THE TEN UNITS SOME
IN SECTION TO THE BILL AS I READ
IT IT'S TEN UNITS BUT IT'S ONLY
SINGLE FAMILY HOUSES THERE'S NO
DUPLEXES OR ANY OTHER.
CONFIGURATION TO GET.
TO TEN THAT'S CORRECT THIS WAS --
IN PART A NEGOTIATED
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE REALTORS --
WITH THE CONCEPTUAL AGREEMENT WE
HAD FROM THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
AGAIN WE ARE OPEN TO
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE REST OF
THE RENTAL HOUSING INDUSTRY --
BUT WE HAVE NOT YET GONE THERE.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT WOULD BE A
DISCUSSION THAT YOU COULD
CONTINUE HAVING.
OUR AND SO WITH THAT IS OUR
MOTION.
ALL RIGHT -- CENTER AKOWSKI
MOVES -- JUST ONE PERSON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
BUT ME FIRST START BY JUST
THANKING ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC -- LIKE CENTER GONZALEZ
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I KNOW
EVERYONE WHO COMES TO THIS ISSUE
COMES.
FROM A GOOD LEGITIMATE PLACE AND
AND OUR HOPE IS THAT WE CAN WE
CAN STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
WHICH IS WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
DO HERE -- BUT IN THE MIDST OF
THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY OUR TENANTS NEED
RELIEF AND WE THINK THIS IS A
PROPOSAL THAT BOTH PROTECTS
TENANTS -- WITH -- JUST BECAUSE
PROTECTIONS AS WELL AS A
PROTECTION AGAINST THE MOST
EGREGIOUS RENT INCREASES WITHOUT
COMPROMISING THE ABILITY OF
LANDLORDS TO MAKE A HEALTHY
PROFIT -- IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
IN THIS BILL TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE IN SENDING YOU DEVELOPMENT
SO THAT'S WHY WE HAD EXEMPTION
UP FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION OF TEN
YEARS -- AND I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE PERSPECTIVE FROM CA THAT WE
HEARD THAT -- THEY BELIEVE THAT
MANY THEIR MEMBERS WOULD NOT
VIOLATE.
THESE RULES AND AND AND I THINK
THAT'S ALSO ANOTHER TESTAMENT
THAT WE'VE HAD IT DOWN THE
MIDDLE SO.
WITH THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING THE RENT IS TOO HIGH
AND IT VERY MUCH ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD.
ALRIGHT MADAM SECRETARY WE HAVE
A MOTION TO PASS.
IN THE TWO AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU FOLKS
FOR THIS IS I KNOW BUT NOT ABOUT
SLOG BUT IT IT'S IMPORTANT WE
GOTTA FIND THIS BALANCE HERE.
ALL RIGHT -- DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BOARD JUST TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING.
STERN.
AMBERG WHY CAL SKI BUT HEALTHY I
FIGHT TO HAVE FOUR VOTES WE NEED
ONE MORE.
THIS IS FINE.
THAT'S GOOD NOTHING MORE -- WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SHARE YOUR OWN HEART COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY OKAY
-- BUT I AM BACK
[inaudible]
IT IS --
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELL
-- YEAH ARE [inaudible]
WHAT?
THAT'S A FIFTY SIMILAR IT'S VERY
SIMILAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU
-- WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REGAIN A LITTLE BIT OF
THIS.
THE SANITY WE'VE GOT -- FILE
ITEM WITH MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM TWELVE COLLEAGUES AB.
THREE EIGHTY FOUR AND YOU CAN BE
JUST A SECOND.
THE NUMBERS OF OUR LIVES.
ALL RIGHT OF GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU THIS IS.
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
THREE EIGHTY FOUR AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE NO
AMENDMENTS.
SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO GO FORWARD
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
FOUR WOULD BRING HEALTH
INFORMATION COLLECTED BY FDA
APPROVED APPS THAT ARE USED AT
THE DISCRETION OF A PHYSICIAN.
TO BE UNDER THE PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL PRIVACY LAW.
THE FDA HAS RECENTLY STREAMLINED
THE PROCESS BY WHICH DIGITAL
HEALTH PRODUCTS ARE APPROVED
GIVING HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS NEW
WAYS TO GET USEFUL AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
POSITIONS. FOR EXAMPLE THE FDA
HAS APPROVED A DIGITAL AND
MOBILE CONNECTED INHALER THAT
CAN DETECT WHEN THE DEVICE IS
USED MEASURE THE STRENGTH OF THE
USERS AND ELATION AND TRANSMIT
THIS INFORMATION TO THE USER'S
DOCTOR.
ALSO SEVERAL FORMS OF DIGITAL
PILLS ALREADY IN USE THESE BILLS
COMBINE IN JUST DOUBLE MICROCHIP
SENSORS WITH PHARMACEUTICALS AND
COMMUNICATE WITH THE PATCH THAT
COLLECTS INFORMATION AND SINCE
IT. TO AN APP SIMILAR TO A
FITBIT.
IT CAN RECORD WHEN IN IN WHAT
QUANTITY A TRUCK IS CONSUME THE
PHYSICAL STATE OF THE PERSON
TAKING THE DRUGS SUCH AS
TEMPERATURE.
ALL ACTIVITY LEVEL AND HEART
RATE HOWEVER IN ORDER FOR THIS
KIND OF DATA TO BE CONSIDERED A
MEDICAL INFORMATION IN NORMALLY
NEEDS TO BE GENERATED BY A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
INFORMATION GENERATED OR
COLLECTED BY DIGITAL HEALTH OUT
MEETING AT THE PATIENT LEVEL AND
OUTSIDE OF THE MEDICAL FACILITY
WILL NOT NECESSARILY BE CAPTURE
UNDER THE EXISTING DEFINITION OF
MEDICAL INFORMATION.
THIS BILL EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
FOUR WILL BRING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE INFORMATION
THEY COLLECT.
UNDER CMI EIGHT BY PROVIDING
THAT ANY BUSINESS THAT OFFERS
SUCH AN APPLICATION WHAT THE
VICE TO CONSUMERS SHALL BE A
PROVIDER OF HEALTH CARE.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT SENSITIVE
HEALTH DATA IS TREATED THE SAME.
WITH THE SAME CARE AND AS STATED
THAT IS GENERATED IN THE
TRADITIONAL MEDICAL SETTING AND
PROHIBIT THAT INFORMATION FROM
BEING SURE WITHOUT A PATIENT'S --
WRITTEN CONSENT WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'M CAN MORE MONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION UNFORTUNATELY RECENT
MOMENTS HAVE INTRODUCED SOME
UNCERTAINTY SO WE REQUEST
AMENDMENTS TO RETURN TO OUR
FORMER SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THIS ORDER.
SUCH AS I UNDERSTOOD A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE THIS MOST MANAGER UNLESS
THAT'S FINE TOO ALL OF IRAQ OR
THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION KIND OF BETWEEN HER
POSITION -- WHICH REFLECTED IN
THE ANALYSIS IS A PRIOR VERSION
OF THE BILL WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF AND IN
THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE STAFF THEY
WERE VERY HARD. TO PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS
BILL FROM LAST YEAR IT'S BEEN A
TWO YEAR PROCESS -- WERE VERY
HAPPY WITH THE DIRECTION THE
BILL'S GOING WE THINK THAT THE
DATA DERIVED FROM SOME OF THESE
MEDICAL DEVICES SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED.
AS PART OF A PERSONAL HEALTH
RECORD IS PRESCRIBED BY A
PHYSICIAN IS PARTY OF COURSE OF
TREATMENT -- THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO HANDLE IT SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AND LESS THAN TWO MINUTES.
PERFECT.
NEXT WITNESS FEELING GRIEVES THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO ONE EXTEND OUR
THANKS TO THE AUTHOR AND STAFF
FOR ALL THE GREAT WORK ON THE
BILL SO FAR.
THAT WERE REMAINING OPPOSES
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE MEDICAL DEVICE INDUSTRY WE
PER FOR A FEDERAL APPROACH THERE
IS ADDITIONAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
HAPPENING FEDERAL LEVEL AND THE
RECENTLY INTRODUCED PIECE OF
LEGISLATION CONGRESS.
WOULD EXPAND PROTECTIONS AHEAD
BUT TO DIGITAL HEALTH APPS BUT
AS WE ALL KNOW CONGRESS DOES NOT
GET A LOT OF WORK DONE SO --
WITH THAT WE REMAIN OPPOSED BUT
THAT THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR
ALL THE GREAT WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M GLAD YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE TO KEEP
GOING IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WHO
KNOWS WHEN ANYTHING.
GOOD WILL HAPPEN OUT OF
WASHINGTON SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION IS THERE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS.
THANK YOU FOR THE GOOD WORK ON
THIS I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PEOPLE DO EXPECT THAT
THERE ARE HEALTH INFORMATION.
IS GOING TO BE.
MAINTAINED AND N. KEPT -- IN
CONFIDENCE AND TO I THINK THIS
BILL HELPS GET US THERE VERY
MUCH SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB THREE
EIGHT FOUR JACKSON JACKSON AYE
BORDERS TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I'D JONES MONNING STERN
NUMBER QUAKE CASKEY BY KELSEY I
FORTY ZERO FOUR ZERO AND HAT
BILL IS ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATORS WE HAVE ONE MORE I
BELIEVE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
IS THAT -- NO WE'VE DONE THE
MOST EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT.
AND NEXT UP WE HAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON IS HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIX AB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH SEEKS TO
MODERNIZE THE YOUTH OF THE FALL
FOR YOU THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
BY ADDING A RIGHTS THAT ARE
INCLUSIVE -- OF THE YOUTH
EXPERIENCE AND EASILY -- EASILY.
ACCESSIBLE -- TO EMPOWER THEIR
DECISION MAKING FALSE FOR YOU'D
HAVE TO OVERCOME INSURMOUNTABLE.
ODDS AND HAVE A HIGH RATE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT AND INCARCERATION.
THESE YOU HAVE FEWER PEOPLE TO
TURN TO THAT CAN HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE THAT THEY ARE ENTITLED -- TO
THROUGH THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
IN TWO THOUSAND AND ONE SB EIGHT
NINETY NINE BY LOU ESTABLISH THE
FALSE FOR YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS
AND WE THINK THE SENATOR. FOR
DOING SUCH -- AND REQUIRING A
SOCIAL WORKERS TO NOTIFY FOSTER
YOUTH OF THESE RIGHTS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN I AUTHORS
ONLY BE ON TEN SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
WAS SIGNED BY GOVERNOR BROWN AND
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO CONVENE A WORK
GROUP TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND UPDATES PROVISIONS TO THE
FOSTER YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS AND
NOW.
THROUGH AB ONE SEVENTY FIVE WE
ARE MOVING LANGUAGE THAT IS A
RESULT.
AND THAT WORKS THAT THE
WORKGROUP HAVE COME HAVE COME UP
WITH -- AND HAVE RECEIVED
FEEDBACK FROM THE S. S. THIS
INCLUDES THE RIGHTS TO GROOMING.
HYGIENE PRODUCTS THAT RESPECTS
THE AND ALSO RESPECT THE YOUTH
OF THE CHILD'S CULTURE AND
GENDER IDENTITY AND TO HAVE
ACCESS TO COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY TO
THE INTERNET. TO BE CONSISTENT
WHICH CHILDREN ATTEND THAT
PARTICULAR AGE -- MATURITY AND
DEVELOPMENT LEVELS AMONG OTHERS
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE REASONABLE -- A
PARENTAL PARENTS -- ASSIST
GUIDANCE IS WILL BE ALSO BE PART
OF THAT THE TICKET OF A FAMILY
HOMES AND LICENSE FOR FOSTER
YOUTH.
HOMES.
REASONABLE. TO HAVE THE CHILD TO
WANT TO BE ABLE UNDERSTAND --
WHAT THE ACCESS ACTUALLY MEANS
THIS BILL -- IS IT RIGHT FOR OUR
YOUTH -- AT THIS PARTICULAR
POINT IN TIME WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE YOUTH ARE
RESPECTED AND ALSO THEIR RIGHTS
ARE AND HERE TO WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES.
IS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION W'S
OF SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON
AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AND I
WILL CUT YOU OFF IN TWO MINUTES
IF YOU TRY TO GO ON MY APOLOGIES
LAURIE THANK YOU AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME IS
JORDAN SO SO THE STATE WHY
POLICY COORDINATOR FOR
CALIFORNIA YOU'VE CONNECTION.
DO YOU FLAT ORGANIZATION MADE OF
CURRENT FORMER FOX USED TO
ADVOCATES IMPROVE THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM LIKE GIPSON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON SAID FOR
THE PAST EIGHTEEN YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE.
GREAT STRIDES IMPROVE THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM THEIR EDUCATION
HIGHER EDUCATION PLACEMENT
STABILITY AND HOUSING AND IT'S
REALLY THANKS TO THE GREAT WORK
THAT YOU ALL HAVE BEEN DOING AND
FOLKS IN THIS ROOM.
HOWEVER TO CHALLENGES THAT OUR
YOUTH HAVE FACED -- EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO ARE VERY DIFFERENT TO
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE TODAY --
AND SPECIFICALLY -- AB ONE SO
FIVE WILL UPDATE AND MODERNIZE
THE FUSS YOU REBEL RIGHTS TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES ARE YOU
FACE TODAY AND TODAY I WILL PASS
MY TIME TO KIANA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIANA
ARNSBERG I'M WITH CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION AND I'M REPRESENTING
CINEMA COUNTY.
I'M HERE.
TO BESIDES THE IMPORTANCE OF AB.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE LIKELY NO --
THE FOSTER CARE BILL OF RIGHTS
WAS CREATED ABOUT EIGHTEEN YEARS
AGO A LOT HAS HAPPENED WITHIN
EIGHTEEN YEARS.
TIMES HAVE CHANGED CALIFORNIA
HAS CHANGED AND SO IT JUST MAKES
SENSE THAT WITH THOSE CHANGES
THE LAWS CHANGED TO AND WE-UPDATE THE FOSTER CARE BILL OF
RIGHTS.
THESE UPDATES INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE.
PROVIDING PROPER -- HAIR CARE
PRODUCTS -- BEING CULTURALLY
SENSITIVE FOR EXAMPLE -- ONE OF
THESE RIGHTS IS THE RIGHT TO THE
CHILD CAN BE CALLED WHICHEVER
NAME THEY PLEASE.
THIS IS ABU APPLICABLE TO ME
BECAUSE MY LEGAL NAME IS JUST
STEAM KIANA AREN'T BURKE.
I GO BY MY NEW MIDDLE NAME KIANA
BECAUSE FROM MY HISPANIC FAMILY
THEY ALL GO BY THEIR MIDDLE
NAMES JUST TRADITION.
SO IMAGINE BEING PUT INTO A HOME
AFTER GOING BY KIANA MY ENTIRE
LIFE AND HAVE THIS FAMILY TELL
ME NO YOU HAVE TO GO BY JUSTIN
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE WANT.
YOU TO BE GO BY.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER THING ANOTHER
OBSTACLE THAT FOSTER YOUTH HAVE
TO JUMP OVER.
AND IT'S JUST.
NOT FAIR IT'S NOT FAIR PRESS TO
FIGHT FOR THESE RIGHTS AND TO
STRUGGLE WHEN.
THEY JUST NEED TO BE UPDATED --
NEEDS TO BE REFLECT HOW TIMES
ARE NOWADAYS AND I'M HERE.
TO EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
NOT JUST FOR ME BUT FOR MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN FOSTER
CARE ALSO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WE'VE HAD
THE FOSTER CARE YOUTH COME I
THINK EVERY YEAR FOR NUMBER
YEARS AND THOSE STORIES ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMPELLING.
SO I THINK WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO
HELP THESE YOUNG PEOPLE IS A
CORPORATE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE ON THEIR BEHALF.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IF YOU'D STEP FORWARD NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
RESIDENTS ALICE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
RE TO WALLACE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KEVIN CAMPUS WITH THIS INCIDENT
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THAT'S HOW SOMEONE UP HERE IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
GRAB A SEAT.
LET'S SEE I THINK SOMEONE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO GIVE UP THE
SEAT VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TWO MINUTES
PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DENISE
PERSIA AND I'M A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH WHO EMANCIPATED FROM THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
THOUGH I COULD NOT RETURN TO MY
PARENTS HOME AFTER EMANCIPATION
I WAS OFTEN HUNGRY THOUGH IT WAS
NEVER HOMELESS.
I WAS ALSO INVOLVED I WAS NEVER
ALSO INVOLVED IN SEX TRAFFICKING
AND FOR THIS REASON I CONSIDER
MYSELF ONE OF THE LUCKY FEW.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN A REPORT
ISSUED BY THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
WELFARE COUNCIL.
OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM SOCIAL
SERVICES COURTS IN CHILD
ADVOCACY GROUPS EXPLAINED IN
PART THAT THE FEELINGS OF THE
CHILD WELFARE IN FOSTER CARE
SYSTEMS WITH REGARD TO THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE ARE TOO FULL.
ONE THE CHILDREN WHO PRAY TO WHO
ARE PRETTY TO EXPLOITERS OR SEX
TRAFFICKERS WERE FREQUENTLY
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN PRIOR
INVOLVED WITH.
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES AND
ACCORDING TO VARIOUS STUDIES
INCLUDING THE JOURNAL OF HUMAN
BEHAVIOR WHICH WAS PUBLISHED IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOUND A WHOPPING
78% OF SEX TRAFFICKING CHILDREN
WERE AT SOME POINT PLACED IN
FOSTER CARE SOME STILL A STUDIES
ESTIMATE UPWARDS OF 88% OF
FOSTER CHILDREN ARE SEX
TRAFFICKING TO TODAY.
THE AVERAGE AGE OF A SEX TRAFFIC
TO GET DIVERT REPORTED MISSING
TO THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
MISSING EXPLOITED CHILDREN IS
FIFTEEN YEARS OF AGE CHOOSE ME
COULD I ASK YOU JUST TO GET TO
THE TO THE POINT REGARDING THE
BILL.
IF YOU WOULD FOSTER CARE
CHILDREN ARE INHERENTLY ON
TRUSTING THINK ABOUT IT.
FOSTER CHILDREN DO NOT TRUST ANY
ADULTS CERTAINLY NOT ANY FOSTER
PARENT NO MATTER HOW WONDERFUL
THOSE PEOPLE ARE.
OR ANY OTHER PERSON CONNECTED TO
THE SYSTEM THIS SHOULDN'T BE TOO
SURPRISING AS THE DOTS IN THEIR
LIFE INCLUDING THEIR PARENTS
WERE NOT TRUSTWORTHY.
INSTEAD OF THIS BILL BEING THE
FOSTER CARE BILL OF RIGHTS THIS
BILL SHOULD BE TITLED NOBODY'S
CHILD.
YOU SAY YOU WERE CREATING A
FOSTER CARE BILL OF RIGHTS AND I
HAVE MY DOUBTS THAT CAN EVER BE
DONE.
AS RIGHTS DO NOT COME FROM THE
GOVERNMENT OR LEGISLATORS OR
BILLS.
WHY DO I SAY THAT WILL YOU SEE
THE CHILD IS THE PLACE TO BE
PLACED IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
POSSIBLE SETTING REGARDLESS OF
AGE THANK YOU AS A LOCK ON THE
FRONT DOOR IS THAT RESTRICTIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOSTER
PARENT WITNESSED NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE TWO MINUTES EACH? TWO
MINUTES SIR.
PLACE.
YOUR MEMBERS MY NAME IS GREG
BIRDS FOR THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL.
JUST ONE HIGHLIGHTS MORE
CONCERNS WE HAVE WITH THIS
LEGISLATION WE ALL KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
THERE IS IS THERE TO PROTECT
KIDS FROM BEING EXPLOITED AND
ABUSED.
AND TO PROVIDE A NURTURING
ENVIRONMENT WERE FOSTER PARENTS
CAN PROVIDE GUIDANCE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHEN THINKING ABOUT THESE NEW
RIGHTS FOR FOSTER CARE KIDS?
THINK OF THEM IN RELATION TO
YOUR OWN CHILDREN WOULD YOU WANT
THE GOVERNMENT TO GIVE THESE
RIGHTS TO YOUR KIDS.
POSSIBLE A COUPLE RIGHTS WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RIGHT TO THE
INTERNET TO MAKE IN SEND AND
RECEIVE CONFIDENTIAL PHONE CALLS
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS EMAILS
TEXTING.
SNAIL MAIL.
TO I REMEMBER WHEN MY DAUGHTER
WAS ELEVEN AND SHE WANTED TO GET
ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA SITE FOR
THOSE WHO LOVED GUINEA PIGS.
SEEM LIKE AN INNOCENT ENOUGH
WEBSITE AND SO WE HAD MEN FROM
AROUND THE WORLD REACHING OUT TO
HER WANTING TO BE HER FRIEND.
GOOD PARENTS OVERSEE WHO IS
COMMUNICATING WITH THEIR KIDS.
THIS BILL PREVENTS THAT.
THE RIGHT AT ANY AGE TO GET
ACCESS THE COMP CONTRACEPTION
ABORTION SEXUAL SOLD HEALTH CARE
WITH OUT.
THE CONSENT OF ANY ADULT.
WHEN I WORK FOR A CENTER IN
ORANGE COUNTY?
I VISITED A GROUP FOSTER HOME
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS THEY
HAD WITH TRAFFICKERS CONSTANTLY
TRYING TO RECRUIT AND FORCE
FOSTER KIDS INTO PROSTITUTION.
IF THESE KIDS GET SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED OR THEY'RE FORCED TO
GET AN ABORTION BY THEIR
TRAFFICKER THIS BILL PROTECTS
THE PREDATOR FROM GETTING FOUND
OUT.
AND LASTLY THE RIGHT TO BE FREE
FROM UNREASONABLE SEARCHES OF
PERSONAL BELONGINGS I'M NOT SURE
HOW ON REASONABLE IS DEFINED
HERE BUT GOOD PARENTS.
MONITOR WHAT HAPPENS IN THEIR
OWN HOUSE.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW WITH
DRUGS OR WEAPONS ARE HIDING IN
ROOMS THAT PROTECTS EVERYONE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE AUTHOR THIS
BILL DOESN'T WANT FOSTER PARENTS
TO GUIDE TO PROTECT KIDS.
AS MUCH AS HE WANTS FOSTER CARE
PARENTS SIMPLY HOUSE THEM VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF THAT PLEASE STEP
FOR WITH NAME AND AFFILIATION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT TO YOU -- TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON A PAGE TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS WE ADDRESS THE THE
SITUATION WITH PARENTAL BEHAVIOR.
AND THE BILL SPECIFICALLY SAYS.
IN OBSERVING THE RIGHTS UNDER
THIS PROVISION FOSTER PARENTS
MUST ALSO BE MINDFUL OF THEIR
DUTY TO MEET.
THE REASONABLE AND PRUDENT
PERRANCE STANDARD SO IF
SOMETHING IS REASONABLE AND
PRUDENT FOR A PARENT TO DO --
THESE THAT IS THE PROTECTED IT
IS THINGS THAT ARE UNREASONABLE
SO I THINK SOME OF THESE
EXAMPLES ARE THINGS THAT ARE
CERTAINLY REASONABLE PARENTAL
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THOSE ARE
INCLUDED.
THE BILL ALSO SAYS THAT THE
SECTION DOESN'T REQUIRE NOR
SHALL IT BE INTERPRETED TO
REQUIRE.
A FOSTER CARE PROVIDER TO TAKE
ANY ACTION THAT WOULD IMPAIR THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF CHILDREN IN
OUT OF HOME PLACEMENT SO I THINK
THAT ADDRESSES.
OF BOTH THOSE ISSUES -- BUT IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THE CHAIR
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
MOVE BY SENATOR RUSSELL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR POINTING OUT THE
REASONABLE -- AND PRUDENT
PARENTS STANDARDS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT I WAS GOING TO COME BACK
WITH AND I'M JUST A TAKEN BACK
BY THE WITNESSES COMMENTS BY ST
ARE YOU THE NOT TRUSTWORTHY.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
I'M TRAUMATIZED BY BEING IN A IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO COME
INTO A NEED TO COME INTO A
LOVING HOME WITH A LOVING
STRUCTURE -- WE SHOULD NOT BE
REJECTING -- CHILDREN -- BECAUSE
OF THAT AND SO -- YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE OLD PHRASE LOVE
THY NEIGHBOR AS MYSELF I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION TO PASS AS EXCUSE ME
DO PASSED THE SENATE APPROACH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB ONE
SEVEN FIVE JACKSON AYE JACKSON
AYE BORDERS TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING STERN NUMBER Y.
CASKEY.
BY KELSEY I FORTY ZERO FOUR TO
ZERO WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE AND THEN
NEXT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
HAS FILE ITEM.
OF SIX FIFTEEN FOR FORTY FOUR
WHICH IS FILE ITEM SIXTY A. B.
C..
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR AM I TALKING
WAS A SAYS GOOD MORNING -- GOOD
AFTERNOON STOOD STILL AFTERNOON
WILL BE SAYING GOOD EVENING FOR
A LONG TIME TODAY I'M AFRAID BUT
GO AHEAD FILE ITEM.
SIXTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY -- NOTING THAT I AM --
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AND THIS
COMMITTEE -- THAT CAME FROM THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME ONCE
AGAIN TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR WHICH IS A
CONTINUATION.
OF MY PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITY PARA MEDICINE
PARAMEDICS -- AN ALTERNATE
DESTINATION PILOT PROGRAMS ARE
ABLE TO BE IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE.
BY WHO WILL BE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THIS COMMITTEE --
FROM THE SENATE HEALTH COMMUNITY
PER MEDICINE ALLOWS EXPERIENCE
AND SPECIALIZED OR SPECIALLY --
TRAIN PARAMEDICS TO PERFORM
OUTSIDE OF THEIR TRADITIONAL
ROLES TO ENHANCE ACCESS TO CARE --
THIS INCLUDES PROGRAM SUCH AS
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES WERE
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICS WORK WITH --
FREQUENT NINE ONE ONE USERS TO
ADDRESS OF THEIR UNDERLYING
NEEDS AND TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE CARE THAT
GETS -- TO THE ROOT OF THEIR
PARTICULAR ISSUE ALTERNATIVE
DESTINATION PROGRAMS GIVE --
COUNTIES THE FLEXIBILITY -- TO
TO TO A RATHER ROUTINE AND
MENTAL HEALTH -- AND ALSO SO
BRING FACILITY -- WHEN -- IS --
UNDERLINED AND WHEN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE MEDICAL NEEDS I
APOLOGIZE -- THIS BILL -- WAS
RESEARCH WAS BEFORE THIS BODY IT
LAST YEAR -- WE TOOK WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS SAID AND THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS BEFORE US WE HAVE A
STRONG COALITION -- THIS MEANS
THAT SOMEONE.
WHO CALLED NINE ONE ONE DUE TO
ALCOHOLISM OR INTOXICATION OR
EVEN DRUG USE WILL BE TAKEN?
TO OF A SOBERING CENTER THOSE
WHO HAVE A MENTAL BREAKDOWN OF
MENTAL ILLNESSES WILL BE TAKEN
TO THAT BEHAVIOR HEALTH FACILITY
SO THOSE INDIVIDUALS WON'T HAVE
TO GO AND SIT IN AN EMERGENCY
ROOM FOR HOURS AT A TIME.
THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS WILL BE
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY AND THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO ASSEMBLY BILL OF
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR IT GIVES
LOCAL AGENCIES THE AUTHORITY TO
DEVELOP -- THESE PROGRAMS AND
REQUIRES AT THE STATE AUTHORITY
TO DEVELOP A MINIMAL MEDICAL
STANDARDS.
IT IS A THOUGHTFUL AND BALANCED
APPROACH THAT GIVES LOCAL
AGENCIES FLEXIBILITY WHILE
ENSURING A HIGH STANDARD OF CARE.
IS GIVEN TO EACH AND EVERY
PROGRAM THIS BILL IS RIGHT.
UP OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
PATIENTS WHO NEEDS TIMELY ACCESS
TO CARE BY THE HANDS OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WE TRUST WE TRUST OUR
PARAMEDICS WHEN WE DIAL 911- IF
SOMEONE'S HAVING A HEART ATTACK.
WE TRUST OUR PARAMEDICS WHEN
SOMEONE IS HAVING A STROKE OR
CAR ACCIDENT -- THOSE WHO NEED
MEDICAL ATTENTION RIGHT AWAY AND
SWITCH TO TRUST THEM WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO THIS PARTICULAR
BILL -- FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR HERE
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA -- PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY POSITIONS
WITH SELF PRODUCE.
WHEN IF YOU WOULD FOCUS ON THE
ISSUE BEFORE US WHICH IS THE
IMMUNITY ISSUE ABSOLUTELY --
SENATORS MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CRISTINA I'M ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
I WILL THE CITY BRIEFLY ON THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRING
THIS BACK BEING COMMITTED TO
THIS ISSUE.
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO WHY
THIS BILL IS IN YOUR COMMITTEE
THE BILL APPLIES EXISTING
COMMUNITIES THE PARAMEDICS ARE
PROTECTED FROM IN A PRE HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY SETTING DOES NOT
EXTEND THOSE COMMUNITIES BEYOND
THAT.
ONLY IN THE PRE HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY SETTING FOR THOSE
PILOTS THAT ARE NOT PRE HOSPITAL
DOES NOT APPLY WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU AND I I
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE CLEAR ON WHAT.
IS AND IS NOT BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY YOU DON'T NEED
TO RELITIGATE THIS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WE'RE HERE ON THE
LIABILITY THANK YOU SIR IF YOU
COULD.
ADDRESS THAT INJURED TO MADDEN
REPS IN THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THE MAYOR CALLED EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS WE WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THAT PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WERE IN SYNC WITH
THEM AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE VERY GOOD THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IF YOU'D STEP UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
WITH YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM TURN
MEMBERS MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR THE CURE ROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
MARIETTA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HARPER SUCH DOES HERE BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RENDON MARGIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WANT TO THANK THE OUT FOR ALL
THE WORK WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
YOUR MESSAGE TODAY FOR THE CITY
OF ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WELL GREAT YOU GOT UP YOUR VERY
FAST THANK YOU SO MUCH TWO
MINUTES EACH AND IF YOU TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE BEFORE US SAID
BE MOST HELPFUL.
SURE -- MY NAME IS DR MARYANN
COSBY AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
NURSES ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA IN A HAS SUPPORTED
THE CONCEPTS OF ALTERNATIVE
DESTINATION AND COMMUNITY PARA
MEDICINE PROJECTS FROM THE
BEGINNING WHEN OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WERE OPPOSED TO
THEM.
WE OFTEN STOOD ALONE IN SUPPORT
OF HIGH QUALITY INTEGRATED CARE
FOR PATIENTS IN NEED OF
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT CARE IN PRE
HOSPITAL CARE AS WELL AS THE
OTHER COLLABORATIONS IMAGE AMONG
OTHER EMERGENCY CARE PROVIDERS.
HOWEVER THIS BILL WOULD
EFFECTIVELY UNDERMINE THESE
EFFORTS BY CHANGING THE
COMPOSITION OF THE EMS
COMMISSION EVERY MOVE OUR SEAT
AT THE TABLE.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO OFFER OUR
GUIDANCE AND EXPERTISE ON A
VARIETY OF EMERGENCY CARE ISSUES
WHETHER INVOLVE STROKES ARE IN
MY REGULATIONS OR OTHERS AND HOW
TO DETERMINE OPTIMAL DESTINATION
FOR TREATING VICTIMS.
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY NURSES
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN WORKING TO
AMEND THE BILL TO REMOVE THE
PROVISION THAT WOULD ELIMINATE
OUR ROLE IN THE EMS COMMISSION.
HOWEVER SINCE IS PREVENTION
PROVISION HAS NOT BEEN REMOVED
WE OPPOSE THE LEGISLATION.
THE CURRENT VERSION OF AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR COMPLETELY
ELIMINATES THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY NURSES SEAT AT THE EMS
COMMISSION A POSITION WE HAVE
HELD.
SINCE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AS
THE PREMIER EMERGENCY NURSING
ORGANIZATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD IT'S DIFFICULT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WOULD REMOVE
OUR VOICE FROM THE COMMISSION.
IAN A ADVICE IS THE COMMISSION
ON EVIDENCE $ED
PRE HOSPITAL AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT PATIENT CARE
REGARDLESS OF WHO ELSE IS ON THE
COMMISSION.
THERE WILL BE NO PERSON WITH
GREATER EXPERTISE REGARDING
EMERGENCY NURSING THAN THE AND A
MEMBER THAT IS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR.
WE ARE PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATION
WHO WORKS TO EDUCATE AND
ADVOCATE FOR SAFE PRACTICE AND
SAFE PATIENT CARE.
AS AN INTERNATIONAL PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION IN OVER FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA
OUR VOICE ON THE COMMISSION FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS WE WOULD
LIKE TO KEEP OUR SEAT AND WE
RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST THAT YOU OPPOSE THE BILL
IN THE CURRENT FORM AND EXCEEDED
RESTORE THE BORDERS OF EMERGENCY
THANK YOU VERYMUCH THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT NEXT WITNESS MADAM
MADAM CHAIR MEMBER STEPHANIE
ROBERSON ON BEHALF OF HE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECT OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT -- TO
YOU -- THE AUTHOR HAD STATED A
SITUATION WHERE PARAMEDICS AND
EMTS OPERATE IN THE PRE HOSPITAL
SPACE WE'RE LITERALLY TALKING
ABOUT PARAMEDICS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE DESIGNATED TO TELL YOUR
LOVED ONES YOUR GRANDDAUGHTER
YOUR GROUND SIGN WHETHER OR NOT
THEY GET TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
BECAUSE THE EXPECTATION RIGHT
NOW IS PATIENTS GO TO THE
HOSPITAL GET TRIAGE AND THEY GET
SENT ELSEWHERE THIS WOULD
LITERALLY FLIP THAT ON ITS HEAD
SO I JUST WANT EVERYBODY TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH.
THIS IS LITERALLY PARAMEDICS IS
MAKING THE DECISION THAT NURSES
AND DOCTORS MAKE RIGHT NOW AS TO
WHERE PATIENTS AGO.
YOU KNOW ON PATIENT SAFETY I
JUST WANNA STATE REALLY QUICKLY
THERE THERE HAVE BEEN OVER
THIRTEEN RESEARCH STUDIES THAT
FOUND SIGNIFICANT RATES OF UNDER
TRIAGE BY EMS PERSONNEL RATES AS
HIGH AS 32%.
ON THE TRANSPORT OF PATIENTS TO
ALTERNATE DESTINATIONS AND I
WANT EVERYONE TO REMEMBER THAT
PATIENTS WHO CALL 911- OR MORE
LIKELY TO BE CRITICALLY ILL AND
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED.
THIS IS A MUCH MORE SECURE
POPULATION OF PATIENTS THAT COME
BY AMBULANCE AND AT THE END OF
IT ALL AGAIN WE DO NOT SUPPORT
THE USE OF PARAMEDICS WHO WE
WORK WITH THEM EVERY DAY.
THE TREMENDOUS WORK THEY ARE
REVEALED WE VEERED IN THIS
BUILDING AND RIGHTFULLY SO BUT
THE SHOULD NOT BE OPERATING IN
THE SPACE AND TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE WHAT SHOULD BE BEFORE.
PARTICULAR COMMITTEES THEY
SHOULD WANT TO BE IN P. THIS IS
A SCOPE OF PRACTICE BILL WE
FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE.
ORGANIZATION HAS LOOKED AT THESE
PILOTS FOR SIX YEARS SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THIS BILL WE HAVE
LOOKED AT THE DATA AND THE DATA
THAT WE HAVE COMPILED DOES NOT.
STATE THAT THIS SHOULD BE PUBLIC
POLICY STATEWIDE AND WE ARE A
DATA DRIVEN ORGANIZATION WERE SO
I IN SPACE WERE NURSES YOU ARE
SOME OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE THIS
BUILDING WE LOOK AT DATA BEFORE
WE MOVE FORWARD ON THE SOLUTION.
AND THE DATA DOES NOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD WE'RE
LOOKING AT POPULATIONS WHERE
THEY DIDN'T TAKE UP.
YOU KNOW ON SOME OF THESE PILOTS
ON NOT A SIGNIFICANT COHORT OF
FOLKS WE'RE LOOKING AT ENGLISH
BY SPEAKING MALES NOT REFLECTIVE
OF CALIFORNIA SENATE IN THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WITH RESPECT
LIMIT OPPOSE FOR HAPPY TO TALK
TO YOU IF YOU THAT THIS IS BILL
MOVES FOR THANK YOU.
VERY VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU WOULD STEP
FORWARD PLEASE.
BRING A BRASS HERE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
SERVICES AT HOME WHERE POLICE
RIGHT NOW WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
NEW AMENDMENT LANGUAGE AND WILL
BE LOOKING AT THE BILL THAT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE PLEASE
STEP FORWARD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR ME
DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED -- AND WE
ARE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE NEW
AMENDMENTS THE SPONSOR AND
AUTHOR OF WORKED VERY HARD WITH
US THE COUNTIES YOU ON THIS BILL --
ONCE WE SEE THEM AND PRINT A FEW
SMALL ISSUES BUT AGAIN -- WE ARE
STILL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT
LOOKING FORWARD TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR -- BETSEY ARMSTRONG
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION AND THE
MS ADMINISTRATORS I'D LIKE.
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT AS A
SIGN MY COMMENTS WITH MY COUNTY
COLLEGE THANK YOU SO MUCH MUCH
APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHARGING HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE SAME POSITION
AS HE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND JOHN ARE YOUNGER WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PARAMEDIC FOUNDATION
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OUR BRING THIS.
OR DO YOU WANT TO COME FORWARD.
I APOLOGIZE MAN CHAIR FOR BEING
LATE BUT THE UNITED FIREFIGHTERS
OF LOS ANGELES CITY PROBABLY --
SUPPORT THIS I'M I'M SORRY FOR
BEING LATE BUT OR NO PROBLEM
THIS IS THE WORST THING THAT
SHOULD HAPPEN TODAY I'LL BE VERY
HAPPY.
WITH THAT LET'S BRING THIS BACK
TO THE DIET SO OF ONE OF THE
REASONS I WANTED.
TO KEEP THIS VERY LIMITED IS
THIS IS A BATTLE BETWEEN TWO
GROUPS OF PEOPLE I ADORE.
AND IT'S IT'S BEEN A QUOTE
UNQUOTE TURF BATTLE FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME -- YOU KNOW THE THE
NURSING PROFESSION IS.
IT IN MY OPINION HAVING HAD TO
GO THROUGH EXPERIENCES WITH LOVE
ONE'S GOING TO THEIR ILLNESSES
AND ALL I JUST THINK.
THE NURSES ARE THE GREATEST OF
UNSUNG HEROES AS ARE THE EMTS IN
THE FIREFIGHTERS BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN THROUGH MANY.
OF THOSE EXPERIENCES PERSONALLY
AS WELL AND I SUSPECT MANY OF US
HAVE SO -- THESE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKING WERE TAKEN IN THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE I DO HAVE A
CONCERN THOUGH I HAVE TO DEVIATE
JUST A LITTLE BIT FROM MY
CONCERN ABOUT LIABILITY ONLY.
THE REPORTS THE DATA SHOWING
THAT DAD -- EMTS MAY HAVE UNDER
SERVED PEOPLE OR WHAT WAS THE
WORD UNDER -- UNDER A PRESCRIBED
OR TREATED UNDER TREATED.
A PEOPLE WITH A AFTER NINE ONE
ONE CALLS.
CAN YOU RESPOND TO THE DATA
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THE QUESTION
OF THE QUESTIONS SAFETY IS
REALLY PARA MODELING ALL OF US
AND THAT YOU KNOW THAT'S A
QUESTION THAT IS OF PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE TO MY MEMBERS AS WELL.
AND IF AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO HAS
BEEN THE INDEPENDENT EVALUATOR
THESE PROGRAMS FOR THE LAST FOUR
AND A HALF YEARS.
IF YOU REVIEW EVERY REPORT THEY
WILL THEY WILL ASSERTIVELY AND
AFFIRMATIVELY SAY THEY HAVE BEEN
ZERO ADVERSE PATIENT OUTCOMES.
THE REASON FOR AUSTIN PILOTS IS
TO TEST THESE INNOVATIVE MODELS
AND I THINK THEY'VE PROVEN OUT
ITS THEY'VE DEMONSTRATED THIS IS
AN EFFECTIVE MODEL.
AND WE ARE NOT OPERATING IN THE
FIELD ABSENT THE DIRECTION OF
PHYSICIANS THAT'S HOW WE OPERATE
NOW IS PARAMEDICS WE DO NOT DO A
SINGLE INTERVENTION IN THE FIELD
WITHOUT.
THE EITHER THE STANDING ORDERS
OR THE ORDER THAT WE RECEIVE WE
CALL A BASE HOSPITAL IN AN
EMERGENCY SETTING IN THAT.
SCENARIO IS UNCHANGED HERE THEY
HAD ALSO PATIENTS.
ELECT TO BE TRANSPORTED
SOMEWHERE ELSE IT IS NOT A
MANDATORY TRANSPORT SO IF THE
OPPOSITION WANTS TO COME BACK
AND RESPOND TO THAT AND THEN I
PROMISE CENTER WHY BECAUSE HE
WILL GET BACK TO THE ISSUE AT
HAND.
WHICH IS THE LIABILITY ISSUE
THAT IS WHAT IS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE -- WOULD YOU READ DO
YOU HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT I
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE MADAM
CHAIR HEALTH SIDE OF THAT THE
PURVIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE.
YOU KNOW THAT'S FINE AND MOM AND
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE REPORTS THAT --
MRS MOMMA HAD.
POINTED TO FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS THE ISSUE FOR US IS.
IN ORDER TO KNOW IF A PROGRAM IS
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE RAW DATA.
RAW DATA AS YOU ALL KNOW IS THE
DATA THE WRONG NUMBERSYET
BY RESEARCHER BEFORE UNDERGOES
ANY TYPE OF STATE STATISTICAL
ANALYSIS WE DON'T HAVE THAT SO
MY QUESTION IS AND WE VAST UCSF
FOR SIX YEARS WHERE'S THE RAW
DATA THEY WILL GIVE IT TO US WHY.
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
HIDING WILL BE ON THE RECORD BE
SET IT WE SENT SEVERAL REPORTS
OF FOR US.
AND TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW HOW
THESE PILOTS HAVE BEEN UNDER USE.
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR US
STATE OF NEW MEXICO PULLED OUT
OF THIS PILOT PROJECT THE END OF
THE DAY IT DIDN'T SAVE MONEY.
IT DIDN'T PROVIDE SAFE PATIENT
CARE THAT TO ME SAYS YOU OUGHT
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT WE ALWAYS
LOOK AT WHAT OTHER STATES DO
THEY PULLED OUT OF THIS.
THANK YOU SO MY UNDERSTANDING
THERE'S STILL A PILOT -- THERE
THERE IS A TERMINATION DATE AND
IT'S MY HOPE AND EXPECTATION
THAT WE GET THAT DATA SO WE CAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S NOT BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE BILL LET'S ASSUME
THAT WE WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET
THAT SENATOR WHITE HOUSE AND
CHAIR MASS THIS ROBESON ROVER
SEND IF SHE AGREES WITH THE
LIMITED JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE FACT THAT THE
LIABILITY.
REMAINS THE SAME IN THESE
DIFFERENT -- PSYCHIATRIC.
FACILITIES ARE HOSPITALS ARE --
WHATEVER SEEMS LIKE A FAIR
QUESTION.
JUST JUST ON THE LIABILITY YOU
THINK THAT THEY THEY HAVEN'T
CHANGED IT REMAINS THE SAME. FOR
THE PARAMEDICS.
YOU DON'T THAT THAT OBVIOUSLY
HELPS I MEAN THERE'S A MINUTE SO
WERE TAKEN AND HEALTH COMMITTEE
THAT HELPS THE BILL BUT AGAIN.
YOU KNOW IF I COULD JUST FOCUS
AND DISSECT ONE BILL ON AND
NARAL ISSUE IT WOULD BE A LOT
EASIER FOR ME MY OB WILL BE.
BUT HE'S BUT I HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE OVER ARCHING POLICY AND YOU
KNOW WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME IN
THESE HEARINGS TALKING ABOUT
ISSUES THAT FALL OUTSIDE THE
PURVIEW.
A NO RESPECTFULLY MANAGER SO I
HAVE TO THEN LOOK AT THE BROADER
POLICY IN FOR US IT DOESN'T ADD
UP.
I'D MANAGER ITEM FAULT THE
WITNESSES AT ALL I'M JUST YEAH
RIGHT I UNDERSTAND AND I HEAR I
HEAR WHERE YOU'RE LOOKING AT I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE GOT IT WE GOT
IT WELL WE GOT A FOR THE
LIABILITY I UNDERSTAND CLEARLY
THAT THE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND.
AGAIN THAT SWEET SPOT SOMEWHERE
THERE -- HAVE BUT THIS IS A
TOUGH ISSUE BECAUSE IT REALLY
DOES LOOK LIKE AT THIS SORT OF
THING CROUCHING ON THE THE KIND
OF CARE THAT IS PROVIDED BY BY
OUR OUTSTANDING NURSES AS WELL.
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD -- ONE
WE'RE CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT NEW
MEXICO -- WANT TO POINT THAT OUT
AND INTO ONE OF THE WITNESSES
TALKED ABOUT A SEAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT LIVES -- THIS IS
CALIFORNIA'S STATE FEDERATION
LABOR HAVE WELL ABLE QUALIFIED
EXPERIENCED NURSES -- AND TOOK
IN TERMS OF THAT BODY -- THAT
THEY CAN SUE SOMEONE TO BE PART
OF THIS PARTICULAR -- ONBOARD
AND SO -- WE BELIEVE AGAIN THAT
THIS IS RIGHT -- TO MAKING SURE
THAT -- ONE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
HAVING MENTAL ILLNESSES -- DON'T
HAVE TO SET UP IN EMERGENCY
ROOMS HOURS AND AT A TIME WHEN
THEY CAN GO TO A SPECIALIZED
FACILITY TO GET THE KIND OF HELP
THAT THEY NEED AND THE SAME FOR
THOSE WHO ARE INTOXICATED.
OR UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF DRUGS --
NOT SITTING IN EMERGENCY ROLE
FOR TIME FOR HOURS AT A TIME
THEREFORE THE EMERGENCY ROOM
SHOULD BE DOES SHE KEEP WITH THE
CONTINUITY OF EMERGENCIES
EMERGENCIES OF OUR LOVE WAS
GOING.
WHO'S HAVING HEART ATTACKS
STROKES GUNSHOT ACCIDENTS THOSE
ARE THE EMERGENCY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND THIS WILL FREE UP THAT
STAFF TO THE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHAT I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE I HOPE YOU'LL CONTINUE WORK
IN THIS BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
ALL BASICALLY ON THE SAME TEAM
HERE ON THIS.
WITH THE SAME GOAL -- THERE IS A
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY A. B.
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BARGES TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING STERN NUMBER WHAT
CAL SKI BUT HAS THE AYE ORDERS
OR VOTES WE WILL.
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU -- FOR
THE TESTIMONY.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ.
YOU GET TO PREEMPT YOU'RE
CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO BECAUSE
YOU ARE FIRST UP AND HE'S
PATIENTLY BEEN WAITING.
FOR BUT YOU ARE.
I FILE ITEM FOR WHICH IS AB
FIFTY ONE SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PROCEED AND WITNESSES.
AGAIN I WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
TWO MINUTES TO WITNESSES ON EACH
SIDE AND WE'VE GOT TO KEEP TO
THAT TODAY BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH
OF THIS CALENDAR.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'M YOU'VE SEEN THIS
BILL BEFORE.
LAST YEAR IT WAS PASSED IN
UNFORTUNATELY VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR BUT AB -- FIFTY ONE
WOULD END THE USE OF THAT.
FORCED.
ARBITRATION -- AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT OUR LEGISLATURE'S
PASSED IN THE STRONGEST WORKER
PROTECTIONS IN THE COUNTRY GET
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PAY INEQUITY
DISCRIMINATION WAGE THEFT AND
OTHER AGREE JUST LABOR
VIOLATIONS.
BUT THESE LAWS ARE WORTHLESS IF
THEY CAN'T BE ENFORCING COURT OR
BY STATE AGENCIES LIKE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER BECAUSE AN EMPLOYER
HAS FORCED THEIR WORKERS TO SIGN
AWAY THEIR RIGHTS IN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS IN ORDER TO KEEP
THEIR JOBS.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY SAY THAT
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
SIGNED NOW WOULD BE IN PLACE IT
JUST COULDN'T BE A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT -- BOTH SIDES UP
OBVIOUSLY COULD COULD
VOLUNTARILY ENTER INTO AN
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT --WITHOUT
ALL THAT MY WITNESSES SPEAK.
GOOD AFTERNOON TWO MINUTES EACH
AND YOU DON'T TO USE THE FULL
TWO MINUTES BUT I WILL BE
CUTTING YOU OFF AT THAT POINT SO.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ONE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL WHEN I THINK THE MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS ADD THIS BILL
IN BEING SUCH A GREAT ADVOCATE --
IN TERMS OF FORCE ARBITRATION
ITS IMPACT ON WORKERS -- AS SHE
SAID AB FIFTY ONE ASSEMBLY
ENSURES THAT WORKERS ARE
REQUIRED TO SIGN FORCE
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT FOR
CLAIMS SUCH AS HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION PAY EQUITY WASTE
EFFORT DELEGATION.
OTHER WORK WORKER PROTECTION
LAWS WE HAVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYERS ARE
USING FORCE ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS CLEAR THE SKYROCKETED
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS BACK IN
TWENTY TWELVE IT ONLY COVERED
ABOUT 16% OF WORKERS BUT AS OF
TODAY.
WE KNOW THAT FORCE ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS REQUIRE FOR OVER 60%
OF CALIFORNIA WORKPLACES AS
INCREDIBLY LARGE NUMBER OF
PARTICULARLY COMPARED TO HELP
YOU REQUIRED BACK IN -- TWENTY
TWELVE WE ALSO KNOW THAT --
STUDY AFTER STUDY SHOWED THAT
FORCE ARBITRATION AGREEMENT IS
INFORM THIS -- FAVORABLE FOR
WORKERS WE KNOW THAT WORKERS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO BRING CLAIMS AND
FORCED ARBITRATION WE KNOW THAT
THE WORTH A FEW WORKERS WHO DO
ARE LESS LIKELY TO WIN.
AND IF YOU WORKERS WHO BRING A
CLAIM AND TO WIN WITH
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS IN DAMAGES
THAN THEY OTHERWISE WOULDN'T
QUIRK -- BUT THE AT THE ANALYSIS
DID A GREAT JOB OF LOOKING AT IN
EXPLAINING HOW THIS BILL IS
DIFFERENT FROM HAS ITERATIONS OF
THE BILL AND HOW -- THE CASES
THAT RELIED ON BY SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS ARE AND NOT APPLICABLE
TO THIS NEARLY TAYLOR VERSION OF
THE BILL WE THINK THAT THE THAT
WE KNOW THE STATE'S CAN DO.
VERY LITTLE IN TERMS OF FORCE
ARBITRATION OF WAY FEDERAL
PREEMPTION BUT WE FEEL THAT THIS
BILL IS NARROWLY CRAFTED
NARROWLY TAILORED TO AVOID THAT
FEDERAL PREEMPTION MY IT DOES
NOT -- IT DOES NOT PROHIBIT
FORCED ARBITRATION IT AS I AM
VALITY ANY SUCH AGREEMENT IN
FACT THIS BILL LOOKS SAID
EMPLOYER BEHAVIOR BEFORE THE
AGREEMENT IS EVERYTHING SIGN --
SO FOR THESE REASONS OF WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK REVIVAL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JACKIE STERN AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE TO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTY ONE THE REMARKABLE RISE OF
FORCE ARBITRATION THE WORKPLACE
IS THE RESULT OF MULTIPLE
SUPREME COURT RULINGS THAT HAVE
ALLOWED BUSINESSES TO EXPAND ITS
USE.
INFORMATION ABOUT FOUR TO
RETREAT IN A SCARCE HOWEVER
BECAUSE IT TAKES PLACE OUTSIDE
OF OUR PUBLIC COURT SYSTEM.
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA
STARTED REQUIRING ARBITRATION
FIRMS WITH CLIENTS IN THE STATE
TO PUBLISH LIMITED DATA ABOUT
THEIR CASES.
AN ANALYSIS OF THE LARGEST FIRM
IN THE U. S. HANDLING ABOUT 50%
OF ALL EMPLOYMENT CASES SHOWED.
THAT ABOUT EIGHT WITH EIGHT
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND NINE
COMPLAINTS WERE BROUGHT BY
WORKERS IN A FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
THE ARBITATORS AWARDED MONETARY
DAMAGES TO WORKERS AND ONLY ONE
POINT 8% OF THOSE CASES WITH
ALMOST 70% BEING SETTLED THROUGH
UNSPECIFIED MEANS.
THIS IS THE REAL RESULT OF
FORCED ARBITRATION.
AND THIS IS THE VERY LITTLE DATA
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
THE BIGGER RESULT IS REALLY
CLAIM SUPPRESSION BECAUSE A
MAJORITY OF THESE CASES WILL
NEVER MOVE FORWARD.
AND SIMPLY GO AWAY.
AB FIFTY ONE WILL ENSURE THAT
WORKERS HAVE A CHOICE BEFORE
WAVING THE RIGHTS IN THE
WORKPLACE AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IF YOU PLEASE STEP
FORWARD TO THE MIKE WITH YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MAP I WITH THE
TEAMSTERS IN SAG AFTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH US
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I HAD THE CONTENTS ON BEHALF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN BACON AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BOTTOM REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN A
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND WEIGHING ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
RUTH SILVER TOBY SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WAGE THEFT COALITION AN
ALEXANDER COMMUNITY LAW CENTER
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
I'M SORRY CHALLENGES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE SEE THE CHAMBER.
THERE SHE IS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER PEREIRA BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB FIFTY
ONE OUR PRIMARY CONCERN AN
ARGUMENT IS THAT THIS BILL IS
PRINTED -- WHEN I TESTIFIED
ABOUT IT LAST WEEK I WAS PRETTY
CONFIDENT AND NOW I'M EVEN MORE
CONFIDENT GIVEN THE FACT THAT --
NEW YORK ACTUALLY PASSED A LAW
LAST YEAR THAT SAID AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT YOU
CANNOT HAVE AN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT THAT -- REQUIRED
ARBITRATION OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CASES AND JUST LAST WEEK THE
UNITED STATES -- SOUTHERN
DISTRICT COURT OF NEW YORK CAME
DOWN AND SAID THAT IS PRE EMPTED
BY THE FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT
YOU CANNOT PUT A SPECIAL
LIMITATION ON THE FORMATION OF
AN ARBITRATION AGREEMENT WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT AB FIFTY ONE
DOES SIMILAR TO THAT.
LAW THAT WAS PASSED BY NEW YORK
IN SIMILAR TO AB THIRTY EIGHTY
LAST YEAR WHICH GOVERNOR BROWN
VETOED AND SAID THIS PLAINLY
VIOLATES FEDERAL LAW.
IT PLACES A SPECIAL RESTRICTION
ON THE FORMATION OF AN
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT YOU CAN
HAVE A LOT OF OTHER EMPLOYMENT
CONDITIONS THAT ARE SIGNED AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT YOUR
SALARY YOUR BENEFITS -- EGGS AT
LEAVE OF ABSENCE IS.
HOW YOU'RE GOING DIED TO BE
TERMINATED AND THOSE CAN ALL BE
MADE AS A CONDITION OF A
CONTRACT OR A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT BUT THIS BILL SAYS
YOU CANNOT HAVE ARBITRATION
CLAUSES AS A CONDITION OF A
CONTRACT? TO IT DOES PUT A
SPECIAL LIMITATION ON THE
FORMATION OF ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS IS THE ISSUE THAT
JUSTICE KAGAN CAME DOWN AND SAID
IN THE CONDUCT NURSING CASE THAT
WE ARE CONCERNED WITH NOT JUST
ONCE A CONTRACT IS FORMED ON ITS --
ENFORCEMENT OF IT BUT HOW A
CONTRACT FOR A PATRICIAN IS
FORMED AND YOU CANNOT PUT
SPECIAL RESTRICTIONS ON IT -- SO
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT IT WILL BE
PRINTED IF IT IS CHALLENGED IN
COURT AND IS PRE EMPTED I DON'T
SEE HOW THIS BILL BENEFITS
EMPLOYEES IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T
BENEFIT EMPLOYERS AS IT'S GOING
TO CREATE.
UNCERTAINTY WITH REGARDS THE
ENFORCEMENT OF ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS AND WILL LEAD TO MORE
LITIGATION COSTS I'M IN ONE
ISSUE THAT I DID WANT TO ADDRESS
AS IT WAS REYES LATIN LAST
COMMITTEE HEARING.
IS WELL WHAT DO EMPLOYERS HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT ALL THEY HAVE TO
DO IS FOLLOW THE LAN AND THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO
LITIGATION -- I CAN UTILIZE THE
DYNAMICS DECISION AS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF EMPLOYERS WHO FALL
THE LAW WE'RE DOING EXACTLY WHAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER OFFICE
TOLD THEM TO DO WITH RESPECT. TO
CLASSIFYING INDIVIDUALS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN THE
BRELO DECISION A SUPREME COURT
DECISION COMES DOWN THE NEXT DAY
IT CHANGES EVERYTHING AND
THEY'RE HELL RETROACTIVELY
LIABLE FOR FOUR YEARS.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED AND IT'S NOT JUST AS
EASY THANK YOU SO MUCH TIME WITH
A LOT THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
HIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
ARBITRATION IS -- JUST LEGAL
FAIR EFFICIENT MEANS OF
RESOLVING DISPUTES -- IT IS NOT
THE SAME AS BRINGING A LAWSUIT
BUT THE PARTIES INVOLVED GET TO
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM NEVER THE
LESS THERE THAN PAT IN FACT BEEN
EMPIRICAL STUDIES THAT SHOW AND
EMPLOYMENT CASES PLAINTIFFS
RECEIVE ROUGHLY THE SAME AMOUNT
AN ARBITRATION THAT THEY WOULD
IN A CIVIL LAWSUIT BUT IN.
FACT FEEL LIKE THEY'VE GOTTEN TO
LIKE HAVE THEIR DAY IN COURT
EVEN THOUGH IT WASN'T ACTUALLY
COURT -- THAT CHAMBER
ARTICULATED THAT VERY VALID
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL BEING --
IN -- PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL LAW
BUT WE STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH
THE IDEA THAT ARBITRATION IS
LESSER OR UNFAIR JUST AS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU WOULD STEP FOR
WITH YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
ONLY PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARIA
SPERBER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
NICKEL.
A LONG DAY FOR ALL OF US NICOLE
RISE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES A
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
ARE POSE FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPOSED RIGHT COURSE IN
RESPONSE TO THAT LAST ARGUMENT
IF IF THIS IS SUCH A GREAT
SYSTEM THAT EMPLOYEES WOULD OPT
INTO IT.
SO -- I SORT OF THINK RETHINK
THAT -- ONE I'M NOT SURE IF IT
MAKES YOU A POINT BUT BUT
CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW THE COURT CASE DID COME
DOWN IT DID IT DID.
IDENTIFY THAT -- THESE -- WERE
NULL AND VOID THE THE THE
POSITION AGAIN SORRY I WONDER IF
YOU COULD.
COMMENT ON THAT AND AS FAR AS
DYNAMIX GOES I DON'T THINK THIS
IS A DYNAMIC SITUATION AT ALL
BUT IF YOU WOULD.
TO ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR
PROBLEM ABOUT PREEMPTION -- THIS
THIS LAW WAS SPECIFICALLY
WRITTEN IN ORDER TO AVOID
PREEMPTION THE ONLY -- CONDITION
WERE SETTING IS THAT IT'S
VOLUNTARY AND LAST I CHECKED AND
LAW SCHOOL A CONTRACT SHOULD BE
ENTERED INTO VOLUNTARILY -- IT
DOES NOT SAY THAT A WORKER
CANNOT SIGN AN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT IT DOES NOT SAY WHAT
HAS TO BE OR CANNOT BE AN
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT UNLIKE THE
NEW YORK LAW WHICH SPECIFICALLY
SAID IT COULDN'T COVER SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS WE
KEPT OUR IS VERY BROAD IT JUST
SAYS THAT IT HAS TO IT CANNOT BE
I'M FORCED UPON A WORKERS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT -- WE
THINK THAT'S NARROWLY TAILORED
WE PASSED A LOT OF BILLS IN THIS --
IN THIS HOUSE TO TAKE ON AT
MISGUIDED FEDERAL AT LEAST AND
SO AM I OF COURSE THIS WILL BE
LITIGATED THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT BUT I THINK WE WILL
PREVAIL AND I THINK I WORKERS
WILL BE BETTER BECAUSE OF IT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO THROW IN I
THINK I IT HAD ASKED FOR THIS
ONCE BEFORE IF THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS I WOULD LIE TO JOIN
IN I THINK THAT THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM.
SHOULD ALLOW CHOICE --
ARBITRATIONS ARE -- BASICALLY.
A SET FORTH WHERE ONE DOESN'T
GET TO EXERCISE WHAT I THINK IS
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO GO
TO COURT -- AND SO I AM
INHERENTLY OPPOSED TO THEM I
KNOW THAT -- AS I MENTIONED AT
THE LAST HEARING BY BEEN
OVERRULED BY THE SUPREME COURT
WHOEVER THOSE FOLKS ARE.
AND BUT I THINK THAT -- OF AS WE
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE MORE
CAREFULLY THE REALLY PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT WHETHER OR
NOT. TO TO AGREE TO ARBITRATION
TO AGREE TO WAIVE THEIR RIGHTS --
TO REDRESS OF GRIEVANCES IN A
COURT OF LAW -- AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THE THE BALANCING
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET IT MAY BE
IT MAY BE BY THIS COURT THAT'S
BEEN SO LOADED WITH ANTI.
YOU KNOW EMPLOYEE.
GEN JUSTICES THAT UP.
MAYBE IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE
SUPPORTED ALTHOUGH I IT'S MY
HOPE THAT IF WE KEEP ON PUSHING
WILL ACTUALLY GET BACK OUR
RIGHTS.
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE OUR OWN
CHOICES AND WHETHER OR NOT WE
WANT TO LITIGATE OR ARBITRATE
THAT SHOULD BE THE CHOICE AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS HIM PERHAPS.
IF THE ARBITRATION SYSTEM IS
THAT GREAT THE IT WILL GET MORE
BUSINESS THAN THE LEGAL SYSTEM
BUT RIGHT NOW -- TO FORCE PEOPLE
INTO ARBITRATION LIKE I JUST.
I DON'T SEE IT I I CANNOT
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT COULD EVER
BE CONSIDERED CONSTITUTIONAL BUT
APPARENTLY IT HAS MAYBE HAVE TO
GO BACK AND READ ALL THE CASES
BUT NOT FOR WHAT WE GET PAID ON
THIS JOB SO.
AND ALSO JUST IN ALONG WITH
LITIGATOR ARBITRATE WE ALSO WANT
THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER -- AND AND
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF WORKERS AT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT -- IS
AVOIDED ARCHITECT TAKEN AWAY
FROM WORKERS AND OBVIOUSLY WE
BELIEVE IN LABOR COMMISSIONER --
SIR WHITE HOUSE KEY FOR BY
SENATOR RAZA PERHAPS I MISS READ
THE HAD THE BILL BUT YOU'RE
ALLOWING FOR YOU'RE NOT ALLOWING --
EMPLOYERS TO FORCE EMPLOYEES TO
WAIVE THEIR THE RIGHTS FOR
FUTURE DISPUTES REGARDING
HARASSMENT THERE'S IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT AL FUTURE DISPUTES IS
HARASSMENT.
DISCRIMINATION CIVIL RIGHTS
RETALIATION AND LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS THIS IS JUST THE I
MEAN THERE COULD BE OTHER
DISPUTES IS I GUESS IS MY
QUESTION THAT.
COULD BE YOU COULD.
ARGUABLY FOR SOME PARTY TO WAIVE
THEIR RIGHTS IF IT WAS IN.
THAT POCKET.
YEAH.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING RIGHT
NOW WE ARE WE LIVE.
THERE THERE MAY BE SOMETHING
TENSION ONLY LAST YEAR IT'S
INTERESTING TO HEAR THE CHAMBER
THIS YEAR BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO GET US JUST
TO DO IT ON HARASSMENT ISSUES
LAST YEAR WHEN THEY CARED MORE
ABOUT THE ME TOO MOVEMENT.
AND DIDN'T ONE LOOK LIKE THEY
WERE TRYING TO GET SEXUAL
HARASSERS -- TO BE ABLE TO BE.
HIDDEN THEN THAT'S WHAT
ARBITRATION DOES -- BUT IN AND
SO WE WERE VERY CEAR THAT IT'S
NOT JUST TRANSMITS
DISCRIMINATION IT'S WAGE THEFT
IT'S ALL THE ISSUES THAT A
WORKER MAY FACE AND IN NEED RE
AB TO REDRESS EITHER.
THROUGH LITIGATION OR LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THE LIST IS SUPPOSED TO BE IN
CLOSE ABOUT.
AND IF I'M MISSING SOMETHING.
SO SENATOR SO I HAVE TO EXCUSE
MYSELF MY APOLOGIES BECAUSE
THEY'RE LIFTING THE CALLS IN
PUBLIC SAFETY AND I WILL BE BACK
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS OF THE MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS SENATE ROTH I JUST
WANNA MAKE A COMMENT AND I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT.
IS SIMPLY MEMBERS IS BEING IN
THIS ISSUE.
YOU KNOW COMING OUT OF THE LABOR
MOVEMENT ARBITRATION IS THE WAY.
TO RESOLVE DISPUTES WHEN THERE'S
A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT SO THERE IS.
GREAT VALUE IN GOING TO
ARBITRATION PRISON WHEN YOU KNOW
THAT YOU'RE ON AN EQUAL FOOTING.
AND THE PROBLEM IS WHEN YOU KNOW
THAT YOU'RE TOTALLY ON A ON
EQUAL FOOTING.
IS WHEN BEING FORCED TO USE THE
ON THE PEOPLE.
OPTION IS WORDS RON AND WORKING
PEOPLE KNOW WHEN IT'S EQUAL AND
WHEN IT'S ON THE COOL SO I I I
DON'T WANT THIS TO GET.
CONFUSED AS FAR AS THE VALUE OF
ARBITRATION IS BOTH THE MEANT.
TO NOT TO USE UP -- YOU KNOW
ATTORNEYS AND FORMAL COURT
PROCEEDINGS IF YOU CAN RESOLVE
SOMETHING SO.
YOU KNOW -- THE PROBLEM IT IS
NOW AS OF YOU KNOW YOUR COERCED
INTO AGREEING TO IT AND THEN
THERE FOR YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE.
OF FAIR SYSTEM SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THEM SOME WOMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SB I'VE AT
THIRD.
WE WOULD LEAVE NEED A MOTION.
SMOOVE BY CENTER GONZALEZ.
ASSISTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FIFTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON.
GORGEOUS TO RUSSELL RUSSELL I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D JONES
MONNING STERN.
UMBERG.
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI HI BUT
HEALTHY I ITS MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER.
SIXTY THREE WE'RE GETTING FOR
EYES WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THE MEMBER GONZALEZ -- LET'S
MOVE TO IMMIGRATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON THE IN THE
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN PROHIBITS CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FROM MAKING
THEIR DATABASES AVAILABLE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITH
ACCESS TO THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM OUR CLASS ARE ALLOWED TO
ACCESS INFORMATION FROM DRIVERS
LICENSES OR IDENTIFICATION CARD
RECORDS INCLUDING NAME DATE OF
BIRTH RESIDENTS AND OR MAILING
ADDRESS AND PHOTOS.
NEWS REPORTS OF AN COVERED THAT
I ACE HAS -- BEEN ACCESSING THE
STATE RUN DATABASES CONTAINING
INFORMATION ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
WITH LICENSES THAT WERE MADE
AVAILABLE UNDER AB SIXTY DESPITE
THE FACT THAT WE TOLD AB SIXTY
LICENSE HOLDERS THAT IF THEY HAD
NOT -- BROKEN THE LAW THAT THEY
WOULD NOT.
BE AS ACCESSED OVER THE WEEKEND
NEWS REPORTS ALSO REVEALED THAT
ICE HAS BEEN SCANNING MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS DMV PHOTOS WITHOUT
THEIR KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT.
THIS IS A BREACH OF PUBLIC TRUST
WE MUST IMPLEMENT GUIDELINES TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WE
NEED TO PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
RECENT AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
SPECIFYING THAT THE PHOTOGRAPHS
ARE INCLUDED AMONG THE DATABASE
INFORMATION AND TO ALLOW ACCESS
TO INFORMATION AND DATA BASES
FOR IN IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES ONLY PURSUANT TO A
COURT ORDER OR WHEN IT PERTAINS
TO SOMEONE. FOR WHOM A FEDERAL
JUDICIAL ARREST WARRANT HAS BEEN
ISSUED I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORTERS AND WAYS TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL AND AND
ENSURE THAT WERE JUST PROVIDING
THAT PROTECTION FOR IMMIGRANTS
THAT WE PROMISED THEM -- WITH ME
TODAY IS A DOCTOR POLICY IN
ADVOCACY FOR SURE LETTERS OF THE
AND GIVEN -- WITH REGARD TO THE
AMENDMENTS IS OUTLINED ON PAGE
TEN OF THE STAFF REPORT.
ARE THOSE ACCEPTABLE.
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
I'M SURE THEY ARE.
YOU GOTTA ADDING CO AUTHORS
MARGIE RIGHT NOW YES LONG AXIS
YES ABSOLUTELY -- ACCEPTED.
I TRUST FIRST WITNESS -- FORTY
SEVEN IMMIGRATION FORMA
ENFORCEMENT HAS OF ALL FROM
HUMAN ENFORCEMENT TO AUTOMATED
ENFORCEMENT WE SAW THAT BIG THAT
WOULD SECURE COMMUNITIES A A
PROGRAM CREDIT UNDER THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION IN WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
ESSENTIALLY BECAME -- ICE AGES
BY JAZZ BOOKING INDIVIDUALS INTO
COUNTY JAILS AT THESE AUTOMATED
SYSTEM HAS AS A RESULT IN THE
RUSSIAN BETWEEN TRIES BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
FURTHERMORE SINCE IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB SIXTY CHIRLA HAS HER OF
CASES IN WHICH BY WILL BROUGHT
TO ATTENTION BY MEMBERS AB AND
WE BOUGHT THOSE THOSE THOSE
CASES THE DMB IS STEPPING WHICH
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THE NOT HAD
ANY KAMALA WRECKER.
THEY ONLY HAD AND THE PROTECTION
ORDER AND OUT OF SIGHT OUT OF NO
WHERE ICE SHOWS UP ON THEIR
HOUSE AGE AND AND ESSENTIALLY
THE POOR SOME OF THOSE MEMBERS.
HAVE FURTHER MORE WE HAVE SEEN
THAT THE FEDERAL AGENCY IN THIS
CASE ICE AND DHS THEY'RE TRYING
TO CIRCUMVENT SOME A STEP
PROTECTIONS FROM AB SIXTY TO THE
TENSION.
TO DETENTION CENTERS THE TRYING --
TO TO ESSENTIALLY TO COME BANG A
STATE LAW FOR THOSE REASONS WE
FEEL THAT THIS IS BILLED AS
NECESSARY TO AGAIN BARRICADE TO
TRUST OF IMMIGRANT COMMITTEES OF
GET THEY CAN'T.
GET A DRIVER LICENSE AND FOUR
DAT REQUEST AN EYEFUL THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB --
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN ONE THE
AMENDMENTS WAS CLARIFYING A
WARRANT IS IN THE REST WILL NOT
ICE YEAH ABSOLUTELY YEAH RIGHT.
GISELE PLEASE NO I BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
<c.magenta>EGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND</c>
SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER THAT'S
GOT YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JESSICA STERN OR THE GREAT
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
JIM WHEN BURKE FOR THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THEY'RE ABOUT THIRTY SO YOU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO YOUR
SUPPORT.
CHAT ENTERS THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT
EXCELLENT LET'S HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
AS AMENDED.
RETURN MEMBERS CHORUS ALSO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION -- WE
JUST -- AGAIN RESPECT WE FEEL
THAT THIS IS AN OVERLY BROAD
ATTEMPT TO LIMIT INFORMATION
SHARING AMONG LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHERIFF'S NOT ENGAGING
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT BUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVELS NEED TO BE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE ABOUT PERSONS --
WHO HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES OR
RESPECTED WHO ARE SUSPECTED TO
HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES?
AND WE THINK THIS BILL
POTENTIALLY -- DOES TOO FAR INTO
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
OF THE AUTHOR HAS BROUGHT UP
WITH RELATION TO DRIVER'S
LICENSE FILES AND THAT SORT OF
THING AND THERE MAY BE A WAY TO
ADDRESS THAT BUT AS THE BILL
SITS RIGHT NOW WE WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPOSED TO ACT
A. B..
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN ALRIGHT
LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS.
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
SO MOVED BY SENATOR RUSSELL.
ASSISTANT PLEASE CALL YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THIS IS THE THIS IS THAT YOU MAY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY THREE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN JACKSON
GORGEOUS RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING STERN UMBERG WAY
CASKEY THERE'S THREE VOTES WILL
KEEP THE WORLD OPEN FOR THE AYE
KELSEY KELSEY AYE.
BY KELSEY I THERE ARE THREE
VOTES WILL KEEP ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SOME NUMBER
GONZALEZ THAT'S ODD TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO HORSES THIS IS AB.
ONE TWO FIVE EIGHT IS ITEM
NUMBER SIX IN OUR PANEL AGAIN.
LET'S LIMóN OUR TESTIMONY IN
OUR DISCUSSION TO THE
JURISDICTION OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE UNLIKE THE OBSERVERS
MAY [inaudible]
THAT'S A SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE'LL DO OUR BEST TO BE
EXPEDITIOUS GOOD JOB HOPEFULLY
SOMETHING BACK ON ON SCHEDULE --
IT THANK YOU FOR YOUR UP 2%
EIGHTY TWO ONE TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH WILL STRENGTHEN LONG
STANDING PROTECTIONS AGAINST THE
SLAUGHTER CALIFORNIA'S WILD AND
DOMESTIC COURSES BY REQUIRING --
FIRST ASSIGNED A MUST BE POSTED
ANYWHERE HORSES ARE SOLD SAME
THE SALE OF COURSES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION
IS A FELONY.
SECOND ANY PERSON PURCHASING A
HORSE AT A CALIFORNIA PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE AUCTION MUST SIGN A
STATEMENT UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY A KNOWLEDGE IN THE GREEN
TO COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA
EXISTING MAN.
ON SLAUGHTER FORCES THIRD OPTION
OPERATORS MUST PROVIDE ACCESS TO
SELL RECORDS IN SWORN STATEMENTS
UPON REQUEST BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
ANIMAL CONTROL AGENCIES AND
HUMAN HUMANE OFFICERS AND
FINALLY THE AUCTION OPERATORS
MUST EXAMINE HORSES FOR
IDENTIFICATION PREFER IDENTIFY
PURPOSES THIS WOULD INCLUDE
BRANDS TATTOOS IT'S GAIN OF
COURSES MICROCHIPS.
IF YOU THESE ARE FOUNDED IN FIND
INFORMATION MUST BE POST ON THE
OPTIONS WEBSITE OR FACEBOOK
PAGES OPERATORS ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO LEAVE INFORMATION
ONLINE FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
FOLLOWING THE INITIAL POST WITH
ME TODAY TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
CASES AND WHY WITH THE AMERICAN
WILD HORSE CAMPAIGN AND MAKING
GAINS IN THE AUCTION COURSES
RESCUE.
HI SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
SUZANNE ROY WITH THE AMERICAN
WILD HORSE CAMPAIGN.
AND I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
OUR THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR GLORIA
FOR AUTHORING THE BILL AND ARE
CO AUTHORS.
ASSEMBLYMAN WELL MEMBERS WALDRON
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH CERVANTES
CHOI CALL AROUND LEVINE.
AND SENATORS CHIANG PORTANTINO
AN HERTZBERG -- AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT SEEKS TO BETTER PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S WILD AND DOMESTIC
FORCES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA HAS
AMENDED AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
SEVERAL TIMES TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDER.
CONSIDERATION ISSUES RAISED BY A
RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS WE BELIEVE
AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT AS AMENDED
STRIKES A GOOD BALANCE OF MAKING
SOME MODEST PROGRESS.
TOWARD MORE MEANINGFUL
PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA'S
HORSES WELL NOT UNDULY BURDENING
HORSE RELATED ENTITIES OR
JEOPARDIZING ANY EXISTING
PROTECTIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION ARE BOTH NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL -- THE THE LAST
PROVISION THAT MR GLORIA
MENTIONED IS SIMILAR TO
LEGISLATION THAT WAS SIGNED.
IN MAY IN NEW JERSEY WITH THE
INTENT OF FACILITATING
IDENTIFICATION A RESCUE OF
FORCES AT AUCTION AND EFFORTS TO
REUNITE -- HORSES LOST IN
MISSING MORSE'S WITH THEIR
OWNERS.
A MICROCHIP SCANNING IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE IT'S BECOMING THE
PRIMARY MEANS OF IDENTIFICATION
FOR HORSES WITHIN THE HORSE
INDUSTRY PLEASE NOTE THAT AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT DOES NOT REQUIRE.
WALL OWNERS TO MICROCHIP THEIR
HORSES IT MERELY REQUIRES ANY
EXISTING MICROCHIP TIP
INFORMATION TO BE POSTED.
ON OUR EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIA LAW ARE COMBINED WITH
ADVOCACY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
FOR ENACTMENT OF LEGISLATION TO
PREVENT THE U. S. FOREST SERVICE
FROM SELLING WILD HORSES WITHOUT
LIMITATION ON SLAUGHTER.
AND TO PROHIBIT THE EXPORT OF
HORSES FROM THE U. S. FOR
SLAUGHTER SO WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'D
LIKE TO KNOW WE HAD A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE HERE EARLY THIS MORNING.
AND OUT OF RESPECT FOR YOUR TIME
WE SENT THEM HOME AND SAID WE
WOULD REPRESENT MUCH APPRECIATE.
SO MUCH THAT SCORES YOU LOTS OF
BROWNIE POINTS NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE TWO MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'D SURE JACKSON
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT MY NAME IS
MEGAN GAINES AND I RUN AUCTION
HORSES RESCUE A CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT BASED IN LOS ANGELES.
I'VE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES
RESCUING IN NETWORKING MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED HORSES FROM
CALIFORNIA AUCTION SINCE.
TWENTY ELEVEN MY RESCUE WORK IS
TAKING ME TO SEVEN AUCTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
DESPITE THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIX
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
PURCHASE OF HORSES FOR SLAUGHTER
CONTINUES TO BE BUSINESS AS
USUAL FOR LOW AND HOARSE TRADERS.
MANY FINAL HORSES TO KILL BUYERS
WHO SELL THEM TO A THIRD PARTY
OUT OF STATE.
THE THIRD PARTY THAN SHIPS THE
HORSES OUT OF THE COUNTRY TO BE
SLAUGHTERED IN MEXICO OR CANADA.
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR WORSE IS
THAT THESE AUCTIONS IS
HEARTBREAKING ONCE LOVED AND
DOTED ON HORSES ARE DONE WHEN
THEY BECOME TO OLDER SORE.
SENT TO AUCTION BETRAYED BY THE
VERY PEOPLE THEY'VE TIRELESSLY
WORKED.
FOR INSTEAD OF A SAFE RETIREMENT
OR AT THE VERY LEAST HUMANE
EUTHANASIA THESE POOR HORSES ARE
LEFT TO FEND FOR THEMSELVES OF
THE AUCTION.
THEIR HORSES PAST THEIR PRIME
WITH VARYING ISSUES AND THEY'RE
HEARTLESS LEASE SO HEARTLESS WE
SOLD WITHOUT HESITATION.
MOST WIND UP ON THE SLAUGHTER
TRUCK IN THESE HORSES DESERVE SO
MUCH MORE.
I AM PARTICULARLY THANKFUL FOR
THE ID REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL.
MANY CALIFORNIA HORSES SLIP
THROUGH THE CRACKS IN OUR SOLE
TO SLAUGHTER YOU WITH AFTER
VIOLATION OF LOCAL RACE TRACKS
IN THE SLAUGHTER AUCTION
POLICIES.
OVER IS IDENTIFIED THE ATTACK TO
BRANDER MICROCHIP HAS A FAR
HIGHER LIKELIHOOD OF BEING
RESCUED.
HOWEVER MANY OPTIONS GO OUT OF
THEIR WAY TO RESTRICT THE
RESCUERS ACCESS TO THIS OFTEN
LIFESAVING INFORMATION.
AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT'S
IDENTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS WILL
GIVE RESCUERS A CHANCE TO
IDENTIFY HORSES AND HOPEFULLY
GET THEM TO SAFETY.
THIS BILL IS A MODEST APPROACH
TO REDUCING THE NUMBER OF COURSE
IS GOING TO SLAUGHTER AND I
BELIEVE IT WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE I SINCERELY URGE YOU
TO PASS AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON KEREN L<c.cyan>G UNDER.</c>
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
SUFFICIENT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EMILY APPARENT FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER FANG ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO HUMANE
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KATIE NAP ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO SPCA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT A IF YOU
COULD JUST STEP ASIDE AND LET
THE BUT THE OPPOSITION COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
JOHN LEVEL AND I'M TESTIFYING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EQUINE COUNCIL.
THE CALIFORNIA HORSEMAN'S
ALLIANCE.
OF PACK.
HUMANE FARMING ASSOCIATION
POLITICAL ANIMALS THE SAVE THE
HORSES FOUNDATION AND FORMER
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY MICHAEL BRADBURY.
ALL F THE ACTUALLY WAS VENTURA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY DRIVES
I'M SORRY THAT'S OKAY.
COMIC I HEARD YOU YEAH -- ALL OF
THESE GROUPS [inaudible]
WERE.
STRONG SUPPORTERS AND ACTUALLY
FROM THE BEGINNING.
OF THE CREATORS OF PROPOSITION --
SIX THAT -- FOR BIDS THE
SLAUGHTER OF HORSES FOOD FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION THAT MEASURE
PASSED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT I WILL
POINT OUT THAT NONE OF THE
GROUPS LISTED IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
HAD ANY ASSOCIATION OR ANY
SUPPORT OF PROP -- SIX WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT HAS PROVISIONS THAT
ACTUALLY WE CAN PROPOSITION.
SIX OF ONE OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT JUST JUMPS OUT.
OF THEM.
THERE'S PROVISIONS WITH RESPECT
TO IRREGULARITIES IN PURCHASING
OF HORSES WE ARE BUYERS.
BUT RATHER THAN PROP SIX THIS
BILL HAS LANGUAGE IN IT
PERMITTING A CIVIL PENALTY.
OF ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE THE
DEFAULT FOR PEOPLE TRYING TO
AVOID ACCOUNTABILITY MY WIFE
WHEN I TALKED TO HER ABOUT THIS
YEAR'S A WICKED SENSE OF HUMOR.
SHE REFERRED TO THAT IS THE JEFF
ABSTAINED CLAUSE -- TO THE BILL
OF A AND AND THAT'S WHAT IT IS --
THE THE OTHER PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL UNDER CURRENT LAW --
AUCTION HOUSES ARE ARE ARE ARE
REQUIRED TO KEEP PAPERWORK FOR
TWO YEARS THIS CUTS IT TO ONE
YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
LOVE -- HI AND ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE GOT TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS -- FOR ANY
QUESTIONS -- I DID WANT TO ASK
IF YOU FEEL.
AS THE PROPONENTS AT THIS
WEEKEND'S PROP SIX AND IF YOU'D
RESPOND TO THAT ARGUMENT.
NO IT DOESN'T NOT IN ANY WAY --
THAT WAS A WHEN WE SAID ON THIS
JOURNEY TO MAKE THIS LEGISLATION
THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY THE TOP
PRIORITY IS BEEN THROUGH
MULTIPLE LEVELS OF LEGAL
REVIEWING INCLUDING.
NUMEROUS LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
REVIEW AND IT DOES IT DOES NOT
IMPACT PROP SIX IN ANYWAY.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT THEY
PROVISIONS NO NO NO NO SO THOSE
PROVISIONS THAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO OUR PENAL CODE SECTION FIVE
NINETY EIGHT SUBDIVISION C..
AND D. WHICH ARE STILL IN THE
EXISTING LAWS THAT CORRECT.
ALL RIGHT -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MISTER JONES [inaudible]
HI.
IT'S A SOMEONE OF A BILL AND AND
I I UNDERSTOOD I'M JUST HAVING A
REALLY
I'M STRUGGLING WITH THE UNDUE
BURDEN IT'S PUTTING ON OTHER
FOLKS ARE PARTICIPATING IN THIS --
MY FAMILY ALSO -- HISTORICALLY
NINE CALIFORNIA MORE BUT MY
WIFE'S FAMILY IS -- YOU KNOW
SOLD HORSES BY HORSES.
AND YOU KNOW TO MAINTAIN THE IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE IT'S TO ME IT'S
IT'S CAUSING UNDUE BURDEN AND
THEN IF THE PEOPLE DON'T COMPLY
WITH THIS.
LANGUAGE EXACTLY -- THE MILLERS
ENFORCEMENT.
POLICIES IN PLACE HERE SO THAT'S
KIND OF WHERE I'M STUCK ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
BRIEF RESPONSE AND PERHAPS YOU
CAN RESPOND IN YOUR CLOTHES ON
THIS -- BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF A
AN AMORPHOUS TYPE OF CONCERN IT
WHICH YOU CAN CERTAINLY IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL I KNOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ANNOUNCED IT
WAS GOING TO COMPLETELY
EVISCERATE THOSE PROTECTIONS OF
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THEY'VE.
RETRACTED THAT BY.
THIS ADMINISTRATION NEVER KNOW
WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO GO BACK
AGAIN SO I THINK THIS IS A KIND
OF OF PROTECTION -- THOUGH IT'S
WERE PROBABLY UNABLE TO
COMPLETELY STOP THE PRACTICE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
IN A WILL ACCEPT THE A MOTION TO
THIS BILL.
YOU SAID IT PERFECTLY MANAGER
WHOSE I FASTER AYE VOTE VERY
GOOD ALL RIGHT -- IS OUR MOTION.
SO MOVED BY US SENATOR GONZALEZ
THIS IS THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE PORGES RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING STERN I'M BURKE
WHITE HOUSE E.. THREE ONE THREE
TO ONE HOW WILL PLACE A BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU FOLKS THANK YOU
MISTER LEVEL.
AND NEXT TO THE MR GLORIA.
YOU HAVE -- FILE ITEM.
FORTY TWO A. B..
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR EXPAND CHAIR
I'LL JUST DIVE RIGHT IN MY MY
WITNESS COMES FORWARD OKAY AND
REMINDING WITNESSES PLEASE NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES EACH.
WE'VE ONLY GOT FORTY TWO BILLS
LEFT TO GO.
ONLY GOT ONE AND I'M SURE HE'LL
BE BRIEF -- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
AND STAKEHOLDERS FOR THE TIME
AND ATTENTION TO THIS BILL --
THE THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND
CONSIDERATIONS BROUGHT TO MY
OFFICE HAVE BENEFITTED THIS BILL
IMMENSELY AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
WILL CHOIR PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
RETAIN PUBLIC RECORDS THAT ARE
TRANSMITTED BY EMAIL. FOR AT
LEAST TWO YEARS THIS WILL
CLARIFY EXISTING PUBLIC WRITTEN
RECORD RETENTION LAW AND BRING
IT INTO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
MAY OF NINETEEN YEARS INTO IT --
I WANT TO PUT A AND I WOULD BE
PERFECTLY CLEAR THAT THE ONLY
EMAILS IN MY BILL IS INTERESTED
IN OUR THOSE CONTAIN INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE CONDUCT OF THE
PUBLIC'S BUSINESS.
PREPARED OWNED USED OR RETAINED
BY ANY PUBLIC AGENCY.
EMAILS ARE CRITICAL TO
CONDUCTING THE PUBLIC'S BUSINESS
AND TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS
REPUBLIC RECORDS NEED TO BE
PROPERLY APPLIED TO THEM.
CURRENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
AGENCIES HAVE RADICALLY
DIFFERENT BUT BUT EMAIL
RETENTION POLICIES IN MY HOME
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO SOME CITIES
KEEP THEIR EMAILS FOR AS LITTLE
AS THIRTY DAYS WHILE OTHERS KEEP
THEIR EMAILS INDEFINITELY.
THE NEW UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
RIGHT RECENTLY SETTLE LAWSUIT
AFTER THEY APPROVED A POLICY
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
DESTRUCTION OF THOUSANDS OF
EMAILS PRIOR TO THE TWO YEAR
REQUIREMENT.
THIS IS A MEDICATION WAS
EXTREMELY COSTLY SOME OF THOSE
EMAILS ARE LIKELY SUBJECT
DEPENDING PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST.
AND LIKELY THEY WILL NOT ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE POLICY BUT
SHOWS WHY THERE'S A REAL NEED
FOR THIS PARTICULAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IF NOTHING ELSE TO
CLARIFY EXISTING LAW.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN EMAILS ARE
EQUAL RELEVANCE TO PAPER RECORDS
IS INSANE TO ME THAT I HAVE TO
SAY THAT IN PUBLIC BUT IT IS
TRUE AND YOU ALL KNOW IT.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR INSURERS
THAT ARE PUBLIC RECORD RETENTION
REQUIREMENTS ARE PROPERLY
APPLIED TO EMAILS GIVEN THE
INCREASING IMPORTANCE IN HOW
PUBLIC AGENCIES CONDUCT THEIR
WORK.
A GENE EIGHT GEN YOUR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPERS PUBLISHED --
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION IS HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON ALWAYS
A PLEASURE TO SEE YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JIM YOU WERE WITH A CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE A CLEAR
STANDARD FOR THESE EPHEMERAL
COMMUNICATIONS AND AS MORE AND
MORE THE PUBLIC'S BUSINESS IS
BEING DONE THROUGH EMAIL BY
STAFF BY ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
THE LIKE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS. TO THAT
INFORMATION SO THEY UNDERSTAND
HOW POLICY IS BEING DEVELOPED
AND ALSO IT -- IS A GOOD
INDICATION IF THERE ARE
NEFARIOUS THINGS THAT ARE GOING
ON A PREVENT CORRUPTION.
AND OTHER TYPES OF BAD BEHAVIOR
FROM HAPPENING BOB IT'S A CLEAR
BILL AS THE ASSEMBLYMAN SAID IT
ONLY APPLIES TO THOSE EMAILS
THAT ARE USED IN THE CONDUCT OF
THE PUBLIC'S BUSINESS AND
NOTHING ELSE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESS THE PLEASE STEP FOR WITH
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION YES --
TRACY.
ROSENBERG ON BEHALF OF OPEN
PRIVACY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND IT STILL IS.
TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS TING
HUTCHINGS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- ALSO HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION --
IT.
FIRST OF WANT TO START OFF BY
THANKING BE AUTHORED STACK WE
REALLY HAVE OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS HAD ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS.
GOING BACK AND FORTH I I THINK
QUITE FRANKLY OUR OUR
INTERPRETATION -- BILLING WHICH
WE STILL BELIEVE THERE IS SOME
AMBIGUITY -- YOU KNOW -- THAT
THAT WE'RE WE'RE HAVING SOME
CHALLENGES WITH AS FAR AS THE
THE VOLUME OF EMAILS THAT WE
HAVE TO RETAIN OVER TIME AND
REALLY A CALL ALL COMES DOWN --
TO THE ABILITY FOR NOT ONLY
LARGE BUT SMALL PUBLIC AGENCIES
TABLE TO STORE THOSE EMAILS --
ADDITIONALLY REQUIREMENTS WOULD
HAVE THE AGENCY RETAIN ALL
DUPLICATE EMAILS -- AS AN
EXAMPLE AN EMPLOYEE SENT AN
EMAIL WITH A LARGE DOCUMENT.
ATTACHED YOU KNOW THAT COULD BE
FOR EXAMPLE P. ARE ABLE -- TO
TWENTY RECIPIENTS AND RATHER
THAN KEEPING JUST THE EMAIL THAT
WAS SENT -- WHICH HAS THE RECORD --
THE AGENCY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
STORE ALL TWENTY ONE EMAILS OF
THAT DOCUMENT ATTACHING IF
SOMEONE WERE TO APPLY YOU KNOW
WITH A SIMPLE THANK YOU. TO
APPLY ALL THAT'S ANOTHER TWENTY
ONE EMAILS THAT WOULD HAVE TO
RETAIN AGAIN -- IT'S IT SOUNDS
REALLY PRETTY INNOCUOUS BUT WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT -- THE COST OF ON
PREMISES STORAGE -- THE AMOUNT --
THAT LOCAL AGENCY SAID PAPER
CLOUD STORAGE IT CERTAINLY IS
SOMETHING THAT WORK AT THAT WERE
AYE I'M CONCERNED WITH.
THAT SAY WE DO APPRECIATE THE
OFFER AUTHORED HIS STAFF -- AS
CONTINUE TO WORK TO WORK WITH US
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND
SHOULD THE BILL BEFORE TODAY WE
WOULD WE WOULD HOPE TO CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS I SHOULD
MOVE TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU'D STEP FOR WITH NAME AND
AFFILIATION MIXING ANTON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
JEAN HARRIS YOUR TEAM AFTER THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIAN
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
COURSES ALONG WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
FOR THE REASONS STATED IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
JAPANESE OVER THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ALSO OPPOSED THANK YOU.
AFTER JASON BRAND OF WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION
REPOSE AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRINGING THE BILL
BACK TO THE DYESS -- WELL I I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE --
INSURING THAT THE SCENE MALES
WILL BE RETAINED FOR TWO YEAR
PERIOD THAT MAKES VERY CLEAR TO
PEOPLE -- I KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME
OTHER BILLS DEALING WITH THE P.
R. A. AND JUST THE WHOLE NOTION
THAT WE'RE GOING TO TRY.
TO COMPLY WITH THAT COMMITMENT
TO TRANSPARENCY THAT I THINK IS
SO IMPORTANT IN THIS STATEMENT
IS THE THE RIGHT IN THE
EXPECTATION OF THE PUBLIC AT THE
SAME TIME THOUGH -- YOU KNOW
THERE ARE.
SOME OF THESE COSTS AND CONCERNS.
ABOUT COMPLYING IS A RESULT AND
I'M WONDERING -- IF -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA COULD RESPOND TO
THOSE TO THOSE CONCERNS.
YOU KNOW.
SHARE LIKE MANY OF OF MEMBERS
YOU COMMITTEE I SERVED IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS OF COST PRESSURES AT
THE SAME TIME IT'S TWENTY
NINETEEN MADAM CHAIR -- YOU HAVE
MORE DOCUMENTS ON YOUR PHONE --
THAN SOME OF AGENCIES WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
A AND THAT DOES CREEP ME OUT A
LITTLE BIT I HAVE TO ADMIT.
THAT WILL BE DELUSIONAL IS
PRIVACY BILLS A LITTLE LATER.
YES YOU WILL ENSURE YOU HANDLE
IT -- WITH A BOMB HERE IS IT
JUST I MEAN FROM YOUR LIPS TO
GOD'S EARS I HOPE THAT'S TRUE
THE FACT THE MATTER IS THIS BILL
STRIKES OF OF REASONABLE MIDDLE
GROUND AS I MENTIONED IN MY OWN
ON IN MY OWN HOME COUNTY.
WE HAVE JURISDICTIONS THAT KEEP
EVERYTHING I'D IS OBVIOUSLY NOT
COST PROHIBITIVE TO THEM -- THEY
HAVE FOLKS WHO ARE IN MY
JUDGMENT TRYING TO HIDE
SOMETHING BY ONLY KEEP IT FOR
THIRTY DAYS WERE STRIKING A
REASONABLE MIDDLE GROUND THAT
SOME JUDICIAL PRECEDENT -- AND
FRANKLY THAT WILL MAKE IT
CHEAPER THAN THE LITIGATION THAT
MANY OF THESE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE ALREADY
DEALING WITH -- I AM NOT.
MY GOD IF YOUR G. EMAIL ACCOUNT
TO KEEP EVERY EMAIL YOU'VE EVER
SENT I'M SURE THAT WE CAN FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO RETAIN THE
DOCUMENTS FROM A SMALL BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT --
SOMEWHERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ANY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS -- WILL ACCEPT THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR Y. KOWSKI THE MOTION IS.
DO PASS.
WHO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL?
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY TWO A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR JACKSON HI
JACKSON FIVE LARGEST DO RUSSELL.
GOT TO WRESTLE AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES.
JONES NO MONNING STERN NUMBER
WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WHAT HAS THE I FOUR TO ONE FOUR
TO ONE WE WILL LEAVE?
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORY YOU HAVE FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE AS YOUR LAST OFFERING
TODAY.
THIS IS A. B..
TWELVE THIRTY TWO I DO MADAM
CHAIR AND I WILL TRY TO BE BRIEF
BECAUSE MY ONE WITNESS DOES
REQUIRE TRANSLATION I RECOGNIZE
THAT TAKES UP A BIT OF TIME SO
LET ME JUST BE VERY BRIEF.
AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO REALLY
COMES IN A AND I BELIEVE YOU ARE
ACCEPTING THE THE AMENDMENTS
CONTAINED IN COMMON THREE ON
PAGE -- SEVEN THAT IS CORRECT
VERY GOOD PLEASE PRESENTED CHAIR --
THIS IS BASED OFF THE LOCAL LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
OUR CONCERNS HAVE BEEN ABOUT FOR
PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM BASICALLY
JUDGE OF FINE -- THE PART OF THE
UNITS THAT THEY HAVE UPGRADED WE
WANT EVERY COMMUNITY TO BENEFIT.
FROM THIS INVESTMENTS AND
GREENHOUSE GAS TRADITION AND
REDUCTION IN ENERGY EFFICIENCY --
BUT WE WANT TO DO THAT AT THE
EXPENSE OF LOW INCOME TENANTS --
SO THIS BILL REQUIRES IT
COMMENTS OF ASSESSMENT OF THE OF
THIS.
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE UNDERSTANDING THESE --
IMPACTS WILL THEN INFORM HOW WE
CAN MAKE SURE THIS PROGRAM --
WORKS AS IT'S INTENDED AND
FINALLY WE WANTED THIS THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE GREATER CROSS
REFERRAL AMONGST THESE PROGRAMS
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE ENERGY
UPGRADES -- FOR THE IT IT SAID
THAT COMMUNITIES CAN BOTH
HEALTHY HOMES -- IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY RESIDE IN
I HAVE A WITNESS -- IS OUT CHU
CY WHOSE COMMUNITY LEADER --
WITH THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK -- AND HIS
TRANSLATOR IS CAN HANG WITH THE
KEY IS A CAN YOU ORGANIZED WITH
THE SAME ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU AND IF WE COULD TRY TO
KEEP IT.
TO IS MINIMAL AS WE CAN.
REALIZING THE TRANSLATION ISSUE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR.
USE IN MY SHOES AND MY SHALL
HALL.
WAS JOHN GEORGE WAS HIGH.
IN WAS TO THE APRON.
FIFTH TWENTY SHE'LL.
WHAT TO THE ORDER OPEN AND CAR
AND SHE HUNG JUDGE?
AFTER EVERYONE ON MY NAME'S
SOLDIERS HIGH COMMUNITY LEADER
ALL OF ASIA PACIFIC DOMINANT
MENTAL AT WORK AND ALSO RESIDENT
OF OAKLAND.
LIMóN A GOOD PARTY SHARE THE
GOOD SHOULD SHEILA CAN GO FIX
ALL QUALITY FICTION.
AND YOU'LL ASSURING THAT YOU'LL
HANDLE CALLS OUT FOR YOU DO YOU
SHOULDN'T ACTUALLY TOOK A YOU
MEAN THAT ONLY COULD YOU FIND A
HYUNDAI.
IS WITH A HIGH NEAR KHAN ACADEMY.
**** SHOULD SHE SEE THE SHE
PLEASE HOLD WHAT THE HOMES OF
SEE YA READ.
THE PROJECT WILL DO THE TRICK --
I WANT TO SHARE SOME STORIES AND
OAKLAND CHINATOWN NEIGHBORHOOD
THERE ARE A LOT OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES IMMIGRANT -- FAMILIES
TO LISTER AND A LOT THEM OFTEN
LIVE IN.
LOW QUALITY AND HAZARDOUS --
LIVING CONDITIONS.
COMMON ARE YOUR CREDIBILITY
COLUSA PEOPLE COULD BE A
DAUGHTER YOUR SUBJECT TO
JUDICIAL.
COLUSA.
SAW ALL THE LITTLE SHARIA. FOR
YOUR WHOLE TO THE SENATE ON THE
JEWS AGO FOLLOWED IT'S ALL OF
THE WIND SHEAR COUNTER YOU'LL
YOU'LL DO YOU GO TOLD SHE SHOT.
AND I WILL GO OVER THIS WHERE --
OFF THE IS IT FAIR COMMON TO
HAVE ROOF LEAK -- POOR
VENTILATION -- WHERE THEY WILL
LIVE IN A?
ROOM WITH NO WINDOWS AND ONLY
VENTILATION WILL PULL IT -- WILL
PLAY A LOT OF THE OLDER OR A LOT
OF NOISES BECAUSE THEY LIVE
ABOVE A LOCAL SUPERMARKET.
SO.
THAT'S WHY THEY WILL --
CHILDRESS HI AL WANTS TO SHARE
SOME OF THE STORIES THAT
HAPPENED IN CHINATOWN.
YOUR YOUR JOURNEY WOULDN'T
USUALLY IN A CREAMY IN KENTUCKY
THE YEARS WITHOUT TELLING HER
FATHER CONFLICT YOU'LL FIND.
YOU ALMOST TO A TEE BALL HOW DO
TO JEAN KNEW THAT ISSUE SHINGLE
KINDA PUT INSIDE SO I UPON
SWITCHING OVER TO SUPPORT
CLAMPING WOULD.
TALK TO GET YOU TO ARGUE TO FIX
ALL GOOD YEAH.
HE JOHN RG THE TO ME THESE ARE
THE THINGS YOU CAN CALL AND A
LOT OF THESE LOW QUALITY --
LIVING CONDITION WHICH AND UP --
IS REALLY HARD FOR FAMILIES TO
FRY HIS FOR REALLY HARD FOR
PARENTS TO PAY IN THE FUTURE FOR
THE KIDS.
AND OFTENTIMES THEY WOULD GO TO
THE LANDLORD AND ASKED -- FOR WE
PAIR OFTENTIMES THEY WOULD REACH
WE SEE FEEDBACK WHERE ALL --
THEY CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO IF YOU IF YOU
DON'T LIKE IT YOU CAN MOVE OUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE WILL PAY.
THAT AMOUNT FRANK.
OIL GUYS HERE TO THE LEAST OF
GLORIA ONTO THE CITRIX NOBLE
GOTTA COME THE CIVIL.
ISSUE I WANT TO THANK HILL --
KOREA FULL LEADING ARE MY ARE
COMMUNITY PHYSICIANS AND WILLIE
ARCH -- COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
SUPPORT AB -- TWELVE THIRTY TWO
TO REALLY HELP LIFT OUR
COMMUNITIES -- TO FRY AND
OFFERED HER -- FURTHER IN
CONTRIBUTING TO DISPLACEMENT --
ANGRILY CREATE A SAFE AND
HEALTHY NEIGHBORHOOD FALL OFF
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THE
SHADE -- OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S TINA ROBINSON
REGISTERING SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HI AB IN ALASKA'S ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ROOM TO SELENA'S
AND ALSO REGISTERED SUPPORT FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION IS FOR ANY HERE.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DYESS SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI.
MANAGER I HAVE NO QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE COLLECTION OF
INFORMATION AND POTENTIAL
PRIVACY IMPACTS THAT MAY HAVE ON
ON PEOPLE WHAT SHOULD BE THE
JURISDICTION OF OUR OF THIS
pALRIGHT VERY GOOD WE HAVE A
MOTION ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE.
AT FASTER AYE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS A DO PASS S.
AMENDED TO SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY WERE OTHER ISSUES WILL
BE HEARD ON THIS BASIS THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU FOR TESTIFYING.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY THREE A. B. TWELVE
THIRTY TO JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE
PORCHES TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
STERN I'M BURKE.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY WHITE HUSKY I
ALL RIGHT SIX TWO ZERO WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG NOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
HEY IF IT IF IT PLEASES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN THE SCORING POINTS
I KNOW BUT FEEL FREE TO BE OUR
NEXT STOP.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
NINE AB THREE THREE THREE AB.
THREE THREE THREE AS MY FOR FINE
COLLEAGUE FROM FREMONT SAYS THIS
REALLY IS A SIMPLE BILL.
GREAT -- IT JUST WAIT ONE SECOND
TO WE CAN CLEAR THE ROOM AND SO
WE CAN HEAR OURSELVES.
ALL RIGHT THE A SIMPLE BILL WE
HAVE A SIMPLE BILL BE VERY
SIMPLE BILL.
HAVING TO DO WITH THE WHISTLE
BLOWER PROTECTION YOU MAY BE
SURPRISED BUT NOT WHISTLE
BLOWERS WHO ARE CONTRACTED BUT
DON'T HAVE ANY PROTECTION SO
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS.
THAT CONTRACTED WHISTLE BLOWERS
WHO MAY LIVE UP IN THE NORTH
COUNTY SOMEWHERE GOING INTO
PSYCHIATRIC CENTERS -- DID TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY IS
TREATED CORRECTLY ALSO HAS
PROTECTIONS -- AS A
WHISTLEBLOWER THAT'S ALL THIS
BILL DOES -- THE GOVERNOR VETOED
IT LAST YEAR WE THINK WE
ADDRESSED THOSE CONCERNS IN THE
BILL THIS YEAR AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT WAITED ALL DAY
MEMBERS CAN AGO ALL RIGHT
UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND PLEASE --
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON.
RESIDENTS ALSO MAY HAVE THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT VERY
GOOD.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
HAD NON REGISTERED.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
I THINK THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL
AND WITHOUT OPPOSITION AND IT
FOUR OH FIVE WITH. FORTY MORE TO
GO -- WILL -- WE HAVE A MOTION --
AND LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
THE THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB THREE
THREE THREE JACKSON HI JACKSON
I'VE GORGEOUS TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES JON SNOW
MONNING STERN UMBERG.
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
LIKE US HE I FIVE TWENTY FIVE TO
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT WAS A VERY GOOD CALL.
OUR IT TO THE NEXT UP WE HAVE A
FEW BILLS I BELIEVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN WILL START OFF.
WITH FILE ITEM EIGHT WHICH IS A.
B.. THREE OH TO WE DO HAVE -- I
BELIEVE SOME AMENDMENTS.
IN THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND I WANT TO REMIND
THE WITNESSES WE ARE HOLDING YOU
TO NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES EACH
AND I WILL CUT YOU OFF MY
APOLOGIES IN ADVANCE.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MANAGER.
WE ALL SEE EVIDENCE OF THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES EVERY DAY.
WEATHER WAS THE HEPATITIS A
OUTBREAK IN SAN DIEGO WHICH
CALLED TWENTY PEOPLE AND INJURED.
SIX HUNDRED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
PASSING A MOTION AUTHORED BY
SUPERVISOR SHEILA KEWL EARLIER
THIS YEAR TO EXPAND SAFE PARKING
IN THE COUNTY.
THE HOMELESS PEOPLE WE INTERACT
WITH JUST ACROSS THE STREET FROM
THE CAPITOL IN SACRAMENTO OR IN
MY DISTRICT THE ROW OF OUR VIS
DEADLINE EL CAMINO RIEL.
ON THE BORDER STANFORD
UNIVERSITY.
WE TALK ABOUT HOW IT IS
IMPACTING OUR WORKING POOR OR
RETIREES.
BUT UNTIL RECENTLY WE DIDN'T
REALIZE TO WHAT EXTENT
HOMELESSNESS WAS IMPACTING A
VERY DIFFERENT GROUP OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
A RECENT REPORT RELEASED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE HOPE
CENTER FOR COLLEGE COMMUNITY AND
JUSTICE WHICH SURVEYED NEARLY
FORTY THOUSAND STUDENTS AT FIFTY
SEVEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
FOUND THAT 19% OF RESPONDENTS
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
THAT'S ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS STATEWIDE.
THIS NUMBER IS SHOCKING ALARMING
AND TRAGIC AND IT MUST BE A CALL
TO ACTION.
AB THREE OH TWO WOULD REQUIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO PROVIDE A
SAFE PARKING LOT ON CAMPUS FOR
THE HOMELESS STUDENTS TO SLEEP
IN THEIR VEHICLES.
THE IDEA OF PROVIDING SAFE
OVERNIGHT PARKING IS NOT NEW.
IN FACT NEW BEGINNINGS SANTA
BARBARA BASED SAFE PARKING
PROGRAM IS THE ORIGINAL SAFE
PARKING PROGRAM THAT IS OPERATED
SUCCESSFULLY FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT IT.
WHEN I WAS ON THE CALL TO CITY
COUNCIL?
THOSE WHO OPERATE SAFE PARKING
PROGRAM SUCH AS NEW BEGINNINGS
SAFE PARKING LA.
DREAMS FOR CHANGE IN SAN DIEGO
AND LIFE MOVES IN SAN JOSE ALL
SUPPORT A. B. THREE OH TWO AND
RECOGNIZE THE POSITIVE IMPACT OF
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE FOR
HOMELESS STUDENTS.
UNDER AB THREE OR TWO EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WILL
BE PROVIDED BROAD FLEXIBILITY TO
DEVELOP AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
THAT MEETS THE LOCAL NEEDS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES.
AB THREE OH TWO ALSO IMPORTANTLY
SPECIFIES THAT IT IS THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT HOMELESS
STUDENTS WHO USE THE OVERNIGHT
PARKING FACILITIES.
BE CONNECTED TO AVAILABLE STATE
COUNTY A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND COMMUNITY BASED
HOUSING FOOD AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES.
WHEN THE BILL WAS HEARD AND
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE I
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS WHICH?
ADDED A MINIMUM NUMBER OF UNITS
THAT A SUDENT MUST BE ENROLLED
IN TO USE THE OVERNIGHT PARKING
FACILITIES ADDED A SUNSET DATE
OF DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO WITH
REPORTING.
AND ADDED AN OPT OUT FROM THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO IMPLEMENT SPECIFIED
HOUSING ASSISTANCE ACTIVITIES
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT CHAIR
IN HER COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK AND THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF
THIS BILL.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS PROVIDED
IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH INCLUDE
THE FOLLOWING KEY COMPONENTS.
ADDRESSING LIABILITY BY GRANTING
THE APPROPRIATE MEASURE OF
IMMUNITY IN STATUTE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN
LIEU OF A LIABILITY WAIVER.
THIS IMMUNITY DOES NOT APPLY TO
GROSS NEGLIGENCE INTENTIONAL
MISCONDUCT OR VIOLATIONS OF
OTHER PROVISIONS OF LAW.
INCLUDING SOME MINIMAL
SAFEGUARDS AND ASSURANCES THAT
STUDENTS FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
RULES ADOPTED BY THE DISTRICT.
AS IN ALICE'S POINTS OUT THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL GIVE DISTRICTS
GREATER CERTAINTY ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF THEIR POTENTIAL
LIABILITY.
PROVIDE MORE CLARITY TO THE
PUBLIC IN AFFECTED STUDENTS THAT
PREVENT UNNECESSARY COSTLY
LITIGATION.
I ALSO WANT TO BE SURE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL IS
ASKING COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO BE
MORE THAN THEY EVER HAVE ADD TO
IN THE PAST.
BUT WE ARE AT A SITUATION IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE ALL HAVE TO
DO MORE THAN WE'VE EVER DONE
BEFORE.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
AB THREE OR TWO IS NOTHING TO
CELEBRATE.
IT'S SAD.
THE FACT THAT WE'RE EVEN
DISCUSSING THIS IS A REFLECTION
OF CALIFORNIA'S FAILURE OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS TO BUILD THE
HOUSING NECESSARY TO MEET THE
NEEDS.
OF OUR GROWING POPULATION.
BUT WE CAN'T LOOK AWAY OR V<c.cyan></c>
THIS ISSUE JUST BECAUSE IT MAKES
US FEEL AWKWARD.
THE REALITY IS THAT STUDENTS ARE
SLEEPING IN THEIR VEHICLES OR
EVEN OUT ON THE STREET.
TONIGHT.
AND WHEN WE DON'T TO PROVIDE A
SAFE PLACE FOR THEM TO SLEEP.
OR WE OPPOSE A SHORT TERM
SOLUTION LIKE A. B. THREE OR TWO
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE
ENTIRE HOUSING CRISIS.
WE FORCE THE STUDENTS TO STAY IN
THE SHADOWS AND DARK ALLEYS AND
INDUSTRIAL PARKS WHERE THEY ARE
MOST VULNERABLE.
AB THREE OR TWO IS NOT A
SOLUTION TO THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS BUILDING MORE HOUSING IS.
BUT THAT WILL TAKE YEARS THEN IN
THE MEANTIME THERE ARE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS RIGHT NOW.
TONIGHT.
AND WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE THEIR SITUATION A
LITTLE BETTER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I'M HONORED TO BE
JOINED BY TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO
KNOW ONLY TOO WELL WHAT ARE
HOMELESS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ARE FACING.
A SICKLY A CARTER A RECENT
STUDENT PORTAL COLLEGE IN Y
DISTRICT WHO IS HERE TODAY TO
SHARE HER STORY AND EXPERIENCE.
AND THE ISSUE HERE A HYATT
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOMELESS YOUTH PROJECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- TWO
MINUTES EACH IF YOU WOULD THANK
YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO
START BY SAYING HOW HONORED I AM
TO BE HERE TODAY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND A COMMNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO FACED HOMELESSNESS
LAST YEAR.
MY NAME IS ALI A CARTER I
RECENTLY ENLISTED IN THE ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD AND JOIN THE
LECTURE SHINS UNION.
I'LL BE ENTERING AN
APPRENTICESHIP AFTER BOOT CAMP.
I WAS A STUDENT AT FOOTHILL
COLLEGE IN JUST COMPLETED MY
LAST CLASS JUNE TWENTY SIX WHILE
I WAS A STUDENT I WAS ALSO
HOMELESS.
A FEW YEARS BACK I DECIDED TO
FINISH MY EDUCATION IN ORDER FOR
ME TO DO SO I HAD TO SACRIFICE
HOUSING SO I COULD FOCUS ON
ACCOMPLISHING MY GOALS.
MY HOMELESS JOURNEY BEGAN IN
EARLY TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN I WAS
FORCED TO LIVE OUT OF MY CAR
WHERE I FELT VERY UNSAFE.
I PARK MY CAR IN A JUNK YARD AND
GILROY SOMETIMES I SLEPT IN
WALMART PARKING LOT OR IN FRONT
OF AN I HOP.
BUT OFTEN WILL BE TOLD I HAD TO
LEAVE.
I COULD NOT LIVE AT HOME WITH MY
FAMILY BECAUSE THEY SUFFER FROM
SEVERE SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES
THEREFORE MY CAR WAS MY ONLY
OPTION.
A TYPICAL DAY BEGAN WITH THE
SHOWER CAMPUS ONE CHECK.
YES AGENCY CLASSES THAT
AFTERNOON SPEND AT THE LIBRARY
SO I COULD USE WIFI FOR
COURSEWORK.
COMING EVENING I HAD TO FIND A
PLACE TO PARK AND SLEEP FOR THE
NIGHT.
HOMELESSNESS HOMELESSNESS
PRESENTS AN OBSTACLE WHILE
PURSUING EDUCATION THIS OBSTACLE
BECOMES EVEN MORE FORMIDABLE
WHILE PURSUING OTHER GOALS WHICH
IN MY CASE.
WERE MILITARY ENLISTMENT AND
OCCASIONAL TRAINING.
WELL I HAVE OVERCOME THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SELDOM MY STORIES
NOT UNIQUE.
THERE ARE MANY MORE STUDENTS
STRUGGLING WITH HOMELESSNESS
RIGHT NOW.
AB THREE A TWO WOULD HELP ME
IMMENSELY SAFETY SECURITY AND
ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND
RESOURCES OFTEN TAKEN FOR
GRANTED SUCH AS RESTAURANTS AND
FACILITIES FOR PERSONAL HYGIENE
ARE JUST SOME OF THE BENEFITS.
AB TWO WOULD HAVE A LOT AB THREE
OH TWO WOULD HAVE ALLOWED ME TO
PURSUE MY EDUCATION WITHOUT AND
DURING DE HUMANIZING EXPERIENCES
AND VIOLENCE IN A LOT ME TO
BETTER MAINTAIN.
THE DIGNITY THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO
OUR EXISTENCE AS HUMAN BEINGS.
AB THREE OH TWO IS INVALUABLE
FOR HOMELESS COLLEGE STUDENTS I
AM HONORED TO HELP BRING
AWARENESS AND HOPE YOU SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO MY STORY.
THANK YOU I'M REMINDED.
ONE SOME OF US OLDER FOLKS WERE
IN COLLEGE THE PEOPLE LIVE.
IN THEIR VW BUSES FOR TIE DYE
SHIRTS AND PROBABLY SMOKED WAY
TOO MUCH GANJA.
AND BUT THEY WERE HOMELESS
CASSETTES THAT'S WHERE THEY
WANTED TO BE AND NOW WE FIND SO
MANY STUDENTS.
WHO ARE HOMELESS WHEN THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE AND I THINK THAT'S
THE PRE SHAKE YOUR STORY?
SO A NEXT WITNESS PLEASE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME MISSION
HER HEIGHT AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOMELESS YOUTH
PROJECT.
AND OUR GOAL IS TO TREAT
POLICYMAKERS ON THE NEEDS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS I'M HERE TO SPEAK
SORT OF AS A SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT ON THIS.
ISSUE OVERNIGHT PARKING ACCESS
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
SO WE KNOW NEARLY ONE IN FIVE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE ALMOST AS IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE PAST YEAR.
AND RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THE
STUDENTS ARE WORKING.
THEY JUST ARE MAKING A LIVING
WAGE.
IN ADDITION TO COMMUNITIES A
SUMMER BERMAN MENTIONED LGBT
STUDENTS STUDENTS TO SERVE IN
THE MILITARY LIKE CELIA -- AND
THOSE WHO ARE PREGNANT PARENTING
ARE PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY
HOMELESSNESS.
WHEN WE SURVEYED COMMUNITY
COLLEGE HOMELESS LIAISONS LAST
PRING THEY SAID THAT HOUSING IS
THE GREATEST NEED OF THE
STUDENTS THEY SERVE?
AND THE HARDEST NEED FOR THEM TO
MEET.
WHEN WE FAIL TO PROVIDE FOR
STUDENTS THEY ARE FORCED TO
DECIDE BETWEEN FOOD AND BOOKS OR
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION?
AND WE TALK WITH STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THEY
OFTEN BEMOANED THE LACK OF SAFE
SPACES TO EXIST.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT ALLOW
STUDENTS TO SLEEP IN THEIR CARS
EIGHTY THOUSAND OF THEM ALREADY
ARE.
IT WILL ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A
SAFER SPACE TO SLEEP WHILE
CONNECTING TO THEIR INSTITUTION
OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
AS WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT POINT
TIME COUNT NUMBERS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE WE ARE NOT ON THE CUSP
OF ENDING HOMELESSNESS.
WHAT WE FOCUS ON LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS WE NEED TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY BE EMPLOYING HARM
REDUCTION STRATEGIES TO
MATERIALLY IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE LIVING OUTSIDE AND IN
THEIR CARS?
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE
INTERIM STEPS TO REDUCE THE HARM
CREATED BY OUR LACK OF HOUSING
STOCK NOW.
WELL IT'S NOT THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM TO END
HOMELESSNESS IT'S EVERYONE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
AND TO RESIST CONTINUED IN
ACTION.
I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR IS BIASED
TOWARD ACTION IN ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS OF COLLEGE HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR STATE WELL UNDERSTANDING
AT THE FIRST STEP TOWARD
CONNECTING THESE STUDENTS TO
HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF SERVICES
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
FOOD STEP FOR WITH YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY.
EGGMAN CAP WITH WEIGHT SINCE AND
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNE COLLEGE
SPONSORING AND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BUT I'M CHAIR MEMBERS SAID JOHN
DORY ON BEHALF OF THE LAW
FOUNDATIONS SILICON VALLEY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR LOSE MANTE WITH
CALIFORNIA MEANS TRANSPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEVEN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IS PART
THANK YOU.
THE SONG LOWER THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY CIRCLE WITH THE STERN
TRUSTEE CAUCUS AMONG CALIFORNIA
MANY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M SURE
MEMBERS MARTHA CARRERA
REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KRISTIN POWER THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I LET HIM KNOW THAT I'M
REPRESENTING NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BOLIVIA'S MAJOR FROM THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARGO ARGO AND A LITTLE WITH THE
FEDERAL POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YOU YOU'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
SIT HERE FOR THE FIRST TWO
WITNESSES -- FEEL FREE.
TO WE CHECKED TWO MINUTES OR
LESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT AFTERNOON
WAS AT EFFORT ON BEHALF ME
COLLEGE LEAVING CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TO
RESPECTFULLY PROVIDER CONCERNS
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR WE
PARTNERED WITH THE SYSTEM OFFICE
RELEASED THE HOPE LAB SURVEY.
REFERENCE BY MISTER BERMAN AND
MENTIONED IN THIS ANALYSIS THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT OUR GOAL WAS
TO GALVANIZE STATE LEADERS TO
ADDRESS.
ENTRENCHED EQUITY RESOURCE
ISSUES REFORM CAL GRANTS. TO
COVER LIVING EXPENSES AND CALL
ATTENTION TO THE NEED TO FIND
MORE APPRENTICESHIPS EDUCATIONAL
AND SUPPORT SERVICES.
LIKE THOSE THAT HELP STUDENTS
LIKE CELIA. FOR THE PATH OF
STABLE HOUSING.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE BEEN
DISHEARTENED BY THE FACT THAT-ALL THIS SOBERING DATA HAS DONE.
IS LEAD TO THE RECLUSION OF ARE
HOMELESS STUDENTS TO PARKING
LOTS.
MANY STUDENTS ALSO SHARE THIS
PERSPECTIVE.
AS KELLI THE STATE WIDE SOON
TRUSTEE AND MEMBER OF THE
STUDENT SENATE PUT IT.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT CLASS WARFARE.
THE STATE HAS DECIDED WHOSE
NEEDS BILL ADDRESS AND IT'S NOT
THOSE OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
BEYOND EQUITY ISSUES WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL'S
RELIANCE ON THE BROKEN UNFUNDED
STATE MANDATE SYSTEM.
AS A RESOURCE TO IMPLEMENT.
IMPLEMENT THE BILL'S PROVISIONS.
WHILE OTHER COLLEGES RECOGNIZE
COMMITTEES LOOKING AT LIABILITY.
GIVEN SCARCE RESOURCES IT IS NOT
FEASIBLE TO MAKE GOOD FAITH
EFFORTS TO PROTECT OUR STUDENTS.
FROM CRIME THEFT ROBBERY OR RAPE.
UNDER EXISTING CONDITIONS.
IN TURN THIS BILL WILL EXPOSE
COLLEGES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LIABILITY IN
LAWSUITS.
THE BILL CREATES NEW SECURITY
AND SAFETY CHALLENGES SUCH AS
THE NEED FOR TWENTY FOUR HOUR.
MONITORING [inaudible] EIGHTY A
RESTROOMS -- IN PARKING LOTS.
TRIGGERING OF HOUSING LAWS.
AND QUESTIONS ABOUT MANDATED
REPORTERS.
CURRENT OPT OUT PROVISIONS ALSO
CANNOT BE MET BY OVER 90% OF
COLLEGES.
WITHOUT A THOUGHTFUL PLAN TO
READ TO BUILD HOUSING
PARTNERSHIPS.
POSSIBLY FIND FACILITIES HOUSING
AT OUR COLLEGES.
OR TO REFORM FINANCIALLY
PROGRAMS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THE LEADERS
OF THE STATE OF THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS DAVE
GEORGE I'M THE CEO OF THE
SCHOOLS ACCESS LIABILITY FUND.
WE ARE A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY --
OUR MEMBERS -- COLLECTIVELY
EDUCATE ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BETWEEN K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I'VE SPENT OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND RISK MANAGEMENT RISK
FINANCING AND LIABILITY CLAIMS.
FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EDUCATIONAL ENTITIES.
WELL WE SUPPORT THE BILL'S
INTENT OF PROVIDING SUPPORT TO
ONE OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT AB THREE OH
TWO WOULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
INCURRED COSTS AND INCREASED
LIABILITY IMPLICATIONS. FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
ATTEMPTED TO TRY TO MITIGATE THE
LIABILITY CONSIDERATIONS WE HAVE
RAISED.
BUT AS LONG AS AB THREE OH TWO
REMAINS A MANDATE. TO ESTABLISH
CA AS I LIVING FACILITIES FOR
STUDENTS WITHIN THEIR CARS.
THE BILL CREATES NUMEROUS AREAS
OF POTENTIAL CIVIL LIABILITY FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WELL THE BILL'S ANALYSIS
ACTUALLY LAYS OUT MANY OF THOSE
ISSUES -- WE BELIEVE IT
UNDERESTIMATES LITIGATION RISK
IN TWO WAYS.
FIRST AS NOTED.
WAIVERS OR LIMITED IMMUNITY.
OFFER LIMITED PROTECTION.
IN THE LEGAL SYSTEM.
WEATHER IS A WAIVER OR
CONDITIONAL AND UNITY.
THIS IS ALWAYS RESOLVED THROUGH
THE COURTS AND THAT IS AN
EXPENSIVE PROPOSITION ALL BY
ITSELF FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
PUBLICATIONS IS LARGELY SELF
INSURED.
THROUGH JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
SUCH AS SELF AND THEY HAVE DONE
THIS FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
THESE EXPENDITURES ARE DIRECTLY
FINANCED THROUGH GENERAL FUND
REVENUES.
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE WHEN IT IS
EMPLOYED AS A FINANCING
TECHNIQUES IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
COSTS ASSEMBLY SPREAD THAT OUT
OVER TIME.
A SECOND HIGHLIGHT IN THE CASE
THAT IS IN THE ANALYSIS WHICH IS
THE BOARD OF REGENTS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
NOTED THAT THEY ESTABLISH.
A SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP
[inaudible]
WITH COLLEGES.
AND STUDENTS AND ESTABLISHES
THIS DUTY.
AS A PRACTICAL REALITY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TWO MINUTES
IS UP.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU'D STEP FORWARD PLEASE WITH
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
THEY SURE AWESOME WEBSTER BEHALF
OF THE COAST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT RANCHO SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE KERN SAN
BERNARDINO SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO AND YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT ALL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON
BEHALF OF MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE AND NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
YOU'RE AWESOME BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF PASADENA IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNICATES
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BRINGING THIS BACK TO
THE DíAS AGAIN THE ISSUE BEFORE
US IS LIABILITY. ONE OF FOCUS ON
THAT I THINK THAT -- I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY IS THINKS THIS IS
THE PANACEA.
THIS IS A STOPGAP MEASURE SO --
I THINK WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
HERE IS TO WHAT EXTENT SHOULD
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
LIABILITY FOR MAKING THEIR
PARKING FACILITIES AND OTHER
FACILITIES AVAILABLE FOR
STUDENTS TO SLEEP IN.
THE SOMEONE WHO IS FROM
FOLLOWING THE NEW BEGINNINGS
PROGRAMME.
FOR IS IT NOW FIFTEEN YEARS JUST
FEELS LIKE YESTERDAY ACTUALLY
BUT ANYWAY THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM
WITH GETTING OLD -- OF THE
PROGRAM WORKS AND WHEN IT'S DONE
PROPERLY THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY.
ANY COMPLAINTS THERE HAVEN'T
BEEN ANY YEAH LAWSUITS FILED SO --
I THINK THAT THERE ARE THERE IS
A TEMPLATE THERE IS AN EXAMPLE
THERE ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGES I
REALIZED THAT THEIR JOB IS TO
EDUCATE BUT AT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
I'M REMINDED THAT THERE ARE SO
MANY STUDENTS WHO HAVE LITERALLY
NO WHERE TO GO AND IN FACT WITH
THE FOOD PANTRIES THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE HAVE WE HAVE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE NO FOOD AND NO PLACE TO
LIVE THAT IS JUST NOT THE WAY
SOCIETY SHOULD OPERATE.
AND WHILE I HOPE WE'RE FINALLY
STARTING TO ADDRESS THAT I THINK
WHAT WE'VE DONE HERE IN TERMS OF
THE LIABILITY.
I ISSUES ARE -- I THINK AGAIN
WE'RE WE'RE DEALING WITH THE THE
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD -- WE'RE NOT
ASKING MORE I THINK THAN JUST
THE BASIC RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
WERE A SCHOOL WOULD HAVE DURING
THE SCHOOL DAY.
SO -- I I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'VE
DONE AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL A CENTER Y. CASKEY.
S. MY QUESTION WAS IS THAT THE
LIABILITY EXIST ALREADY ON THE
SCHOOLS HAVE SOME BAD THING
HAPPENS WITH THE SCHOOL AND I
UNDERSTAND BY HAVING MORE.
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS THROUGH THE
NIGHT THAT WOULD INCREASE THE
RISK OF SOMETHING HAPPEN BUT IS
THERE SOMETHING [inaudible]
EN.
IS GIVEN THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
AUTHORS TAKEN THAT WE GIVE
NOTICE TO THE STUDENTS THAT THEY
CAN ENSURE SAFETY WE HAD MINIMUM
SAFEGUARDS.
SO THAT THE STUDENTS.
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S
THE WHAT THE RULES BEEN ADOPTED
WE GET IF THEY'RE BAD ACTORS
SAID DRINKING AND DOING THAT
THEY'RE OUT -- I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE WERE OTHER THINGS WITHIN
THE THE POLICY THE SELF INSURE
POLICIES THAT THEY HAVE WOULD BE
OTHER CRITERIA THAT WOULD --
LIMIT THAT LIABILITY OR FOR
PROVIDE.
MORE KNOWLEDGE TO THE STUDENTS
AND BEHAVIORS THAT ARE
ACCEPTABLE OR NOT -- BECAUSE
I'VE I SEE THIS IS IS AN
EXTENSION OF LIMITED LIABILITY
IF YOU ALREADY HAVE NOT CREATING
ANY NEW RIGHTS AND MAYBE I'M
WRONG.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AS WELL
I I'D IF IF WE'RE WRONG THAT I'D
LOVE TO HEAR IT FROM FOLKS AND
IF PEOPLE HAVE ANY OTHER
SUGGESTIONS.
THAT THEY WANT TO MAKE WE'VE
TAKEN A LOT OF AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL AND EVERY STEP OF THE
PROCESS.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE MORE IF
WE THINK THAT THEY'RE VALID IN
ADDRESS VALID CONCERNS.
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE GIVE
THEM A LITTLE EXTRA PROTECTION
THE UNIVERSE OF THE COLLEGES.
THAT -- WERE EXTENDING THE WORLD
WE'RE GIVING THEM A MUNITY FROM
ORDINARY NEGLIGENCE OF THERAPY
IF THEY'RE ACTING IN GOOD FAITH
NO SOMETIMES YOU JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN BUT IF
THEY'RE TAKING ALL THE NECESSARY
STEPS -- AND THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE. TO
PROTECT THE STUDENTS WHILE
THEY'RE ASLEEP.
ON CAMPUS IN THEIR CARS.
IS THE WHOLE NOTION ACCIONES
STITCHES THIS IS HARD TO IMAGINE
BUT THEY GET TO GIVE ME A LITTLE
IMMUNITY -- AS AN INCENTIVE I
KNOW NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE MORE
RESPONSIBILITY AND NOBODY WANTS
OF THOSE LIABILITIES SO THIS IS
A WAY TO SORT OF GIVE.
SOME -- ASSURANCES THAT IF YOU
JUST ACT IN GOOD FAITH AND DO
THE BEST YOU CAN ESSENTIALLY --
THAT THERE WILL BE THEIR
PROTECTION THE REGION'S THERE'S
THEIR EMPLOYEES [inaudible]
OKAY.
UNDER THE RAZA [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE WERE THAT.
THE CENTER.
IT OBVIOUSLY IS VERY BOTHERS
SOME THAT.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE.
BUT NOW HAVE THIS AS A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THESE
CONDITIONS WOULD EXIST.
FOR STUDENTS -- AND IT'S
INTERESTING ARCHER SAID FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO WELL PROGRAM STARTED
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO -- I THINK
THAT THE THINKING BEHIND THIS
OUGHT TO BE.
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE TEN TO
FIFTEEN YEARS WHAT WOULD YOU DO.
IN A CASE WHERE YOU'RE TRYING TO
PLAN FOR TEN TOFIFTEEN YEARS I
DO NOT SEE.
ANYTHING.
THAT IS GOING TO LESSEN THAT
LENGTH OF TIME [inaudible]
UNLESS.
WE IN THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE STATE MAKE IT
[inaudible]
OF SIMILAR TO A WILDFIRE
EMERGENCY.
IF WE DON'T TREAT A THAT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS. FIVE
TEN FIFTEEN YEARS.
SO WHAT.
WHAT IS THAT LOOK LIKE WHAT IS
THAT LOOK LIKE AS FAR AS
LIABILITY -- I DON'T KNOW WHEN
YOU SAY IMMUNITIES WHO'S.
THAT MEANS.
THE STUDENTS DON'T HAVE RIGHTS
AS FAR AS SUING THEM IN THE
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE A RIGHT OF
PRIVATE ACTION DOESN'T MEAN THEY
DON'T I MEAN WHAT WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IMMUNITY WHO'S GIVING.
WHO WHAT?
IS THE STUDENTS THAT WILL BE THE
ONE TO BEAR WHATEVER.
THINGS THAT MIGHT HAPPEN THERE
OF COURSE IT'S THEM THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE SCHOOL WHO
CARES ABOUT.
THE STUDENTS.
SO I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHEN YOU
REFER TO THE LIABILITY OR MUNITY
ISSUES WHOSE TAKE WHAT IS THAT
TAKE CARE OF SO.
WHO IS PROTECTED AND THAT YOU
KNOW AS FAR AS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CONCERN AND
WHOSE PROTECTED AS FAR AS?
THE STUDENTS ARE CONCERNED
THAT'S ONE QUESTION ON THE OTHER
QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF OF
FAMILY MEMBERS OF STUDENTS.
I SUSPECT THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE FAMILIES
THAT THEY UNFORTUNATELY LIVE
WITH THEM IN THE CARDS AND
SOMEWHERE ANOTHER.
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW AN ADDITIONAL
ISSUE.
SO I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO SAY IS.
THAT ALL THESE HAVE TO BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT SO THAT WE DON'T --
UNFAIRLY PUT SOMETHING ON OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT HAVE
NEVER DEALT WITH THIS BEFORE SO.
YOU KNOW THE TIME OF COURSE
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RESOURCES TO DO THIS IN THE
RIGHT WAY.
NOBODY WANTS TO JUST OPEN IT UP
IN.
YOU KNOW AND THINGS HAPPEN BAD
THINGS COULD HAPPEN SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IN DOING THIS THAT
IT'S DONE THE RIGHT WAY.
HAVING ASKED ALL THOSE QUESTIONS
IT I'M SURE YOU'LL HAVE ANSWERS
TO OF COURSE I FEEL COMPELLED TO
SUPPORT IT THIS IS NOT A A
CHOICE THAT WE HAVE.
IT'S A MATTER OF HOW ARE WE
GOING TO DO THIS.
SO THAT THOSE STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE PROTECTED IN THE
RIGHT WAY.
AND ARE WE READY HOW DO WE
PREPARE AND GET READY FOR THAT.
THANK YOU KNOW IF I MAY DIRECT
YOUR ATTENTION TO PAGE TWENTY OF
THE ANALYSIS AND TALKS ABOUT
THIS.
THE SERIES OF AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN TO ADDRESS THE
LIABILITY ISSUE -- ITEM DE SAYS
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
THAT IS IMPLEMENTED OVERNIGHT
PARKING THAT COMPLIES WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS.
OF SUBDIVISIONS BEING SEE IN
THOSE ARE THE BASICS THAT WE'RE
SETTING UP IS NOT CIVILLY LIABLE
FOR DISTRICT EMPLOYEES GOOD
FAITH ACT OR OMISSION.
THAT FAILS TO PRESENT A TO
PREVENT ANY INJURY TO A
PARTICIPATING STUDENT THAT
OCCURS IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO WIN
DURING THE HOURS OF OPERATION.
OF OVERNIGHT PARKING BUT THIS
COMMUNITY DOES NOT APPLY TO
GROSS NEGLIGENCE INTENTIONAL
MISCONDUCT OR VIOLATIONS OF
OTHER PROVISIONS OF LAW.
SO WE BASICALLY TAKEN AWAY THE
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD IF THEY
PARTICIPATE AND I'M A BASICALLY
IMPOSED A GOOD FAITH STANDARD
IT'S A LESSER STANDARD NO
QUESTION.
BUT SO LONG AS THEY ARE ACTING
IN GOOD FAITH AND COMPLYING WITH
THE BASIC REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
SET FORTH IN THE BILL -- TO ON
COVERAGE AND TO ALLOW FOR THIS.
EVENING HOUSING -- OVERNIGHT
HOUSING -- THERE THEY HAVE THAT
IMMUNITY SO WE'RE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE HIM TO DO IT AT THE
SAME TIME GROSS NEGLIGENCE AND
INTENTIONAL MISCONDUCT.
ARE NOT PROTECTED [inaudible]
CONSIDER MYSELF -- AND AND I
THINK YOU KNOW THIS DOES MEAN
THAT STUDENTS ARE YOU KNOW WILL
NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO SUE.
FOR THESE IS SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN I I WOULD THINK
FROM THE STUDENTS PERSPECTIVE
INTO SO YOU CAN SPEAK MORE TO
THAT THAT.
IS JUST A WAY SAFER THAN WHERE
THEY ARE NOW -- AND SO THIS IS A
SLEEPING BY YOURSELF -- THE
ISOLATED IN THE INDUSTRIAL PARK
OR WALMART PARKING LOT OR AMONG
THEM ALREADY WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER WITH CASKEY DID YOU HAVE
A QUESTION.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT A MOTION
WILL ACCEPT THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES
AND WITHOUT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS.
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB THREE
OH TO JACKSON JACKSON AYE PORGES
GOOD ALSO.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D
JONES MONNING STERN I'M BURKE.
NUMBER TWO I WHITE HOUSE SKI
WHAT HAS HE AYE. FIVE TO SIX
FIVE TO ZERO WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR UPS MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
OUR NEXT ITEM IS ALSO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN IS FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB.
SIX OH TWO GOING TO WATER --
WESTFIELD FEEL FREE.
SB.
SIX OH TWO FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB.
SIX OH TWO WE HAVE WITNESSES
HERE AGAIN I'M GOING TO ADMONISH
YOU TWO MINUTES EACH AND I WILL
CUT YOU OFF IF YOU GO BEYOND
THAT VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT A. B. SIX OH TWO TODAY
SB SIX SO TWO MIRRORS SB FIVE
SIXTY FOUR AUTHORED BY SENATOR
LEYVA WHICH THIS COMMITTEE
PASSED EARLIER THIS YEAR. FOR
THIS REASON AND BECAUSE THERE
ARE SIXTY SOME BILLS TO BE HEARD
IN THIS COMMITTEE TODAY I'M
GONNA KEEP MY REMARKS.
BRIEF -- BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK CENTER LEYVA FOR HER WORK
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE THE
CREATION OF INCREASINGLY
SOPHISTICATED A AYE TECHNOLOGY
HAS MADE IT SIGNIFICANTLY EASIER.
TO CREATE COMMENCING STE WIFE
LIKE IMAGES AND RECORDINGS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL APPEARING TO DO OR
SAY SOMETHING THEY DID NOT.
THE SO CALLED DEEP FAKES DISTORT
THE TRUTH MAKING IT HARDER TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN REAL EVENTS
AND ACTIONS FROM FICTION AND
FANTASY.
ALL THIS TECHNOLOGY HAS
LEGITIMATE AND BENEFICIAL USES
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
FILM MAKING.
THEY CAN BE MISUSED IN POST
PRODUCTION TO PORTRAY AN ACTOR
PERFORMING IN SEXUAL ACTIVITY OR
SHOWING MORE NUDITY WITHOUT THE
ACTORS CONSENT OR PARTICIPATION.
SIMILARLY BECAUSE THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS WIDELY AVAILABLE
ONLINE ALONG WITH STEP BY STEP
INSTRUCTIONS CAN BE USED IN A
FAIRY IS SLATED TO PICK TO BOTH
CELEBRITIES.
AND NON CELEBRITIES AND SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT MATERIAL WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT OR PARTICIPATION.
STILL PHOTOS OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
FACE CAN BE SCRAPED FROM THE
INTERNET AND SEAMLESSLY GRAFTED
ON A PORN STARS BODY AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE APPEARS TO
BE A STRONG APPETITE FOR THIS
CONTENT ONLINE.
EVEN WHEN VIEWERS KNOW IT IS
FAKE.
BEYOND NATURAL FEELINGS OF
EMBARRASSMENT APPEARING IN A
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT DEEP FAKE CAN
CAUSE IRREPARABLE HARM TO A
VICTIM'S REPUTATION JOHN
PROSPECTS PERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS.
IN A MENTAL HEALTH.
SB SIX OR TWO WOULD HELP RESTORE
CONTROL OVER AN INDIVIDUAL'S
IMAGES OR LIKENESS BY REQUIRING
CONSENT TO BE OBTAINED PRIOR TO
DEPICTING A PERSON AND SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT MATERIAL.
AND BY ALLOWING THAT CONSENT TO
BE RESCINDED WITHIN THREE
BUSINESS DAYS UNLESS CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET.
WE HAVE BEEN HAVING VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND ARE CLOSE TO AN
AGREEMENT ON AMENDMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE WORKING TO
ADDRESS THE PSEUDONYM THE PSEUDO
NAME IT THE SUD PSEUDONYMOUS.
FILING PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
WHICH SHOULD REMOVE THE REST OF
THE OPPOSITION WITH ME TODAY ARE
ACTOR MICHELLE HEARD OR IS ACTOR
MICHELLE HEARD HE'S ALSO A
NATIONAL BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
SCREEN ACTORS GUILD -- THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S
STILL AFTERNOON TWO MINUTES
PLEASE.
HI I'M MICHELLE HEARD I'M AN
ACTOR AND NATIONAL BOARD MEMBER
SACK AFTER AND A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF TIME'S UP I'VE BEEN A
PROFESSIONAL ACTOR FOR THIRTY
YEARS AND I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
TO SPEAK.
ON THIS CRUCIAL BILL I'D LIKE TO
THINK THUNDER LEVY LEVY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- BERMAN FOR
OFFERING THIS BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AB
SIX OH TWO ADDRESSES A
SIGNIFICANT AND GROWING PROBLEM
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
THAT NEGATIVELY AFFECTS ACTORS
PARTICULARLY FEMALE ACTORS.
NEW TECHNOLOGIES ALLOW CONTENT
CREATORS TO ALTER A PERSON'S
IMAGE TO DEPICT THAT INDIVIDUALS
ENGAGING IN SEXUAL ACTIVITY OR
TO APPEAR AS PERFORMING IN THE
NUDE WHEN NEITHER ACTUALLY
OCCURRED.
SO CALLED DEEP FAKE TECHNOLOGY
IS OFTEN USED AS A TOOL OF
EXPLOITATION AND HARASSMENT ON
THE INTERNET HOWEVER IT CAN BE
USED BY MAINSTREAM FILM MAKERS
AS WELL.
FILMMAKERS WITHOUT THE
MEANINGFUL CONSENT OF THE ACTORS
INVOLVED CAN DIGITALLY ALTER THE
SCENE TO SHOW MORE NUDITY OR
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT ACTS IN POST
PRODUCTION ONCE THE DIGITALLY
ALTERED FILM OR IMAGES OUT THERE
IN THE WORLD ITS NEGATIVE IMPACT
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO CONTROL.
AND THE DAMAGE CAN BE LASTING
AND PERMANENT.
MY FELLOW FOR MY FELLOW ACTORS
THIS TYPE OF NON CONSENSUAL
DIGITAL DOUBLING IS AT ITS VERY
CORE EXTREME WORKER EXPLOITATION
UNFORTUNATELY THE LAW HASN'T
INVOLVED AS FAST AS TECHNOLOGY
TO PREVENT THIS TYPE OF THING
FROM OCCURRING.
THIS IS WHY WE ARE WORKING SO
HARD TO MAKE AB SIX OH TWO AND
OTHER SIMILAR PROPOSED LAWS
AROUND THE COUNTRY A LEGAL
REALITY IF ENACTED THIS BILL
WILL TRULY HELP PROTECT
PERFORMERS AND OTHERS
POTENTIALLY HARMED BY THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO PROVIDING.
A CLEAR FRAMEWORK FOR CONSENT
AND CIVIL REMEDIES TO COMPENSATE
THE VICTIM WERE CONSENT ISN'T
OBTAIN THE GREAT THING ABOUT
THIS BILL THIS DOESN'T JUST
PROTECT PERFORMERS BUT ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO FALL PREY TO
THESE HARMFUL PRACTICES ONLINE.
OUR HOPE IS THAT THIS PREVENTION
AND JUSTICE APPROACH WILL
EVENTUALLY PUT AN END TO THIS
EXPLOITIVE.
BEHAVIOR WE'VE SEEN MORE AND
MORE LATELY IN THE DIGITAL ERA
ON BEHALF OF SAG AFTER AND MY
FELLOW PERFORMERS WE SINCERELY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROAD
FOR SAG AFTRA OR SPONSORS A BABY
SIX A TWO IS WELL AS THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT -- I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF SINCE THE COMMITTEES
ALREADY SEEN AN IDENTICAL
VERSION THIS BILL IN LATE APRIL
JUST AS AN UPDATE WE'VE
CONTINUED OR CONVERSATIONS THE
C. AND P. AND BROADCASTERS --
AND THEY'RE VERY CLOSE TO
RESOLVING THEIR CONCERNS THE
REMAINING OPPONENTS ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE DOUGH
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL WHICH WE
WERE PLANNING TO REMOVING THE
NEXT COMMITTEE.
WE ARE DR ED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WERE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. FOR ALL THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED BY THE
AUTHOR AND A PREVIOUS WITNESSES.
WE JUST REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE POINT THE ONE OF THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS A WORKER HAS
THE RIGHT TO WITHHOLD THEIR
LABOR THE RIGHT TO REFUSE WORK
WHETHER BECAUSE IT'S UNSAFE.
FOR MORALLY OBJECTIONABLE THE
WORKER BELIEVES THAT WOULD HAVE
LASTING EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL
DAMAGE TO THEM.
THE DEFENSE REALLY TAKE THAT
RIGHT AWAY FROM WORKERS REALLY
ROB THEM OF THAT IN A
PARTICULARLY INSIDIOUS WAY THAT.
AS MENTIONED DOES A LOT OF VERY
LASTING DAMAGE TO THESE WORKERS
AND WE THINK THIS IS A STRONG
BILL THAT DOES WHAT IT NEEDS TO
DO TO HELP PREVENT THIS KIND OF
THING FROM HAPPENING IN THE
FUTURE AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE I'M SURE
MEMBERS NECRO CAUGHT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND WHAT THE
PROBLEM THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION OF THE
VERY BRIEF -- WE ARE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED TO THIS BILL
CURRENTLY I'M HOWEVER AS NOTED
BY THE AUTHORED.
AND THE OTHERS SPEAKERS WE HAVE
BEEN HAVING VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS BELIEVE WE'RE
GETTING CLOSE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONSIDER -- CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MARK POWERS CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION.
ME.
TOO GOOD EXCELLENT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN STRONG
NEUTRALITY PERHAPS.
WE PAY FOR THIS YEAR ON BEHALF
OF THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA WE WERE
LISTED AS AN OPPOSITION THAT WAS
FOR THE BILL PRIOR.
TO THE GUT AND AMEND ON JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTH WE HAVE NO
POSITION ON THE SPECIAL.
THANK YOU THAT CLARIFIES THE
SITUATION MANAGER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NAMES CREEK PAGE THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION RIB.
REPRESENT THE TITLE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY WE HAVE NO PROBLEMS
WITH THE INTENTION THE BILL WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
OF DOCUMENTS ARE GENERATING THE
COURT THE MAY BE RECORDED LATER
ON IN THE WE CAN'T IDENTIFY THE
THE THE THE REAL PARTIES.
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT WILL BE
ADDRESSED THROUGH A CATCH THE
DOLE PROVISION NATURE TALK ABOUT
THAT I THINK CAN BE WORKED OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONCERN.
AFTERNOON ANNA BACK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS I'D LIKE TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH THE THIRD.
THANK YOU.
ERIN RUBBER GONE WE HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
BUT HAPPY THAT THE AUTHORS LIKE
TO WORK WITH US ON THE DOUGH
PROVISION THANK VERY GOOD THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR NEUTRALITY.
BY BRINGING THE BILL BACK TO THE
DYESS.
NO QUESTIONS -- THAT THIS IS A
VERY TRICKY ISSUE BUT A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE IN TODAY'S WORLD
IT'S JUST SHOCKING YOU GO ON
FACEBOOK READY THESE THINGS UC'S
DOCTORED PHOTOS.
I KNOW THESE EIGHTY YEAR OLD
PEOPLE DON'T LOOK LIKE THIRTY
YEAR OLD STUDS AND WHAT HAVE YOU
AND YET IT'S PRETTY AUTHENTIC
LOOKING SO.
YOU'RE NOT SURE WHAT'S REAL AND
WHAT ISN'T REAL AND THAT IS A
SERIOUS SERIOUS PROBLEM IN THE
WORLD TODAY AND CERTAINLY IN A
DEMOCRACY AND FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING -- WITH
INTEGRITY AND AND CHARACTER AND
ALSO APPRECIATE THE BILL I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUING TO
WORK ON IT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEY IF YOU
WOULD.
PREFER YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECT THAT'S FROM A VOTE RIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX OH TWO JACKSON HI JACKSON
FIVE LARGEST TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
MORNING STERN ON BURKE.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY WHAT CASKEY I
FIVE ZERO FIVE TO ZERO WE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OF THANK YU FOR
BEING HERE.
OUR NEXT ITEM I BELIEVE OF A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN IS ONE
MORE IT'S FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FOUR MIGHT HAVE THREE
MORE DID I MISS OUR THREE
MORPHOLOGIES HOLY COW.
ALL RIGHT -- I'M SORRY WE'VE GOT --
I'LL GO SO IT IS POSSIBLE ALL
RIGHT -- THERE SO YOU DO HAVE
THREE MORE BECAUSE ONE WAS
PULLED OFF CONSENT YES MA'AM
YOU'VE GOT FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR
THEN AB SEVEN THIRTY ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS THE FIRST I'D REALLY
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
OF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL
WORKING LONG HOURS OVER THE
HOLIDAY TO TIGHTEN UP THE
LANGUAGE -- AND NEAR THE SCOPE
AS WELL AS FOR CENTER ON BERG'S
PREVIOUS ENGAGEMENT IN SENT
ELECTIONS.
I WILL BE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AB SEVEN THIRTY ADDRESSES.
A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
HEADING INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTIONS.
AS MORE MORE BAD ACTORS TRY TO
INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS WITH
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS THAT SO
CONFUSION AND DOUBT THROUGHOUT
THE ELECTORATE.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE WITH
THE PREMISE THAT VOTERS HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN VIDEO AUDIO
AND IMAGES THAT THEY'RE BEING
SHOWN. TO TRY TO INFLUENCE THEIR
VOTE IN AN UPCOMING ELECTION
HAVE BEEN MANIPULATED AND DO NOT
REPRESENT REALITY.
THIS IS ABOUT SAFEGUARDING THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
THIS TASK IS ONLY BECOME MORE
CHALLENGING WITH THE INVENTION
OF PROLIFERATION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS DEEP FAKES
WHICH ARE EXTREMELY CONVINCING
FABRICATED FODIO PHOTOS.
VIDEO OR AUDIO RECORDINGS OF
SOMEONE APPEARING TO SAY OR DO
SOMETHING THEY DID NOT SAY OR DO
AS WE HEARD WITH THE LAST BILL
AS WELL.
THE ABILITY TO ATTRIBUTE SPEECH
AND CONDUCT TO A CANDIDATE THAT
IS FALSE THAT NEVER HAPPENED
MAKES DEEP FACE A POWERFUL AND
DANGEROUS NEW TOOL IN THE
ARSENAL OF THOSE.
THAT WANT TO WAGE MISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN RECENTLY THAT
VERY OLD IN CRUDE TECHNOLOGY CAN
BE USED TO DISTORT REALITY.
THE MANIPULATION OF THE VIDEO
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI WHO
SPEECH WAS ALTERED. TO MAKE IT
SEEM AS THOUGH SHE WAS DRUNK WAS
VERY LOW QUALITY BUT WAS STILL
VIEWED OVER THREE MILLION TIMES
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THIS IS THE NEW FRONTIER IN THE
MISINFORMATION WAR.
THE CARNEGIE ENDOWMENT FOR
INTERNATIONAL PEACE NOTES THAT
DEEP FAKES HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
INCITE VIOLENCE.
ALTER ELECTION OUTCOMES IN
UNDERMINE DIPLOMACY.
IN JANUARY US DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE DAN COATS
WARNED THAT DEEP FIX WILL
PROBABLY BE AMONG THE TACTICS
USED TO THIS FOR UP THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION.
AND IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD.
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON POST
IN CENTRAL AFRICA LAST YEAR A
VIDEO OF THE BONES ALONG UNSEEN
PRESIDENT ALI BONGO WHO WAS
BELIEVED IN POOR HEALTH OR
ALREADY DEAD.
WAS DECRIED AS A DEEP FAKE BY
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS AND
CITED AS THE TRIGGER A WEEK
LATER FOR AN UNSUCCESSFUL COUP
BY THE GOVERNOR HE'S MILITARY.
IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ABOUT CHEN SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC
PARTY SHARED A DEEP FAKE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
URGING BELGIUM TO WITHDRAW FROM
THE PARIS AGREEMENT IN AN EFFORT
TO ATTRACT SIGNATURES FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED PETITION.
LAST MONTH MONTH THE US HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES PERMANENT SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLIGENCE LED BY
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF.
CONVENE A HEARING ON THE
NATIONAL SECURITY CHALLENGE OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
MANIPULATED MEDIA IN DEEP FAKES.
NOTING THAT DEEP AKES RAISE
PROFOUND QUESTIONS ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY IN DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNMENTS WITH INDIVIDUALS AND
VOTERS NO LONGER ABLE TO TRUST
THEIR OWN EYES OR EARS WHEN
ASSESSING THE AUTHENTICITY OF
WHAT THEY SEE ON THEIR SCREENS.
THIS IS A NONPARTISAN ISSUE.
AT A U. S. SENATE INTELLIGENCE
HEARING SENATOR MARCO RUBIO SAID
THAT HE EXPECTED DEEP FAKES WILL
BE USED IN THE NEXT WAVE OF
ATTACKS AGAINST AMERICAN AND
WESTERN DEMOCRACIES.
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTIONS
AROUND THE CORNER WE MUST DO
MORE TO CURB THE PROLIFERATION
OF DEEP FAKES AND OTHER
MANIPULATED MEDIA.
SPEAKER MARCO RUBIO.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT CONCERNS AND I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
THROUGH THESE ISSUES.
I WOULD NOTE HOWEVER THAT NO
COURT THAT I'M AWARE OF HAS
FOUND THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT
GRANTS SOMEONE THE RIGHT TO
LITERALLY PUT THEIR WORDS INTO
MY MOUTH.
WHICH IS WHAT THIS TECHNOLOGY
DOES.
YESTERDAY I RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR AND
DEAN OF UC BERKELEY SCHOOL OF
LAW IRWIN CHEMERINSKY WHICH
SPEAKS TO THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF AB.
SEVEN THIRTY NOW WE WILL USE
THIS CLICHE SHE OR HE WROTE THE
BOOK ON IT WHEN REFERRING TO
SOMEONE WITH EXPERTISE.
WHAT THE INSURANCE KILO
LITERALLY WROTE THE BOOK ON
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW THAT'S USING
LAW SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
NONETHELESS I HAVE AGREED TO
TAKE SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE FIRST AMENDMENT
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AB
SEVEN THIRTY WOULD PROHIBIT A
PERSON COMMITTEE OR ENTITY
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF AN ELECTION
FROM.
WITH ACTUAL MALICE DISTRIBUTING
IT MATERIALLY DECEPTIVE AUDIO OR
VISUAL MEDIA OF A CANDIDATE WITH
THE INTENT TO INJURE THE
CANADA'S REPUTATION OR TO
DECEIVE A VOTER INTO VOTING FOR
OR AGAINST THE CANDIDATE.
UNLESS THE MEDIA INCLUDES A
DISCLOSURE STATING THAT IT IS
BEEN MANIPULATED.
THE BILL WOULD DEFINE MATERIALLY
DECEPTIVE AUDIO OR VISUAL MEDIA
TO MEAN AN IMAGE OR AN AUDIO OR
VISUAL RECORDING THAT HAS BEEN
INTENTIONALLY MANIPULATED TO
ALTER THE APPEARANCE SPEECH OR
CONDUCT OF A CANDIDATE.
SO AS TO CREATE A SIGNIFICANT
LIKELIHOOD OF CAUSING A
REASONABLE PERSON TO UNDERSTAND
HER EXPERIENCE THE EXPRESSIVE
CONTENT OF THE IMAGE OF
RECORDING.
IN A MATTER THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT FROM
UNDERSTANDING OR EXPERIENCE THE
PERSON WHAT IT WOULD HAVE IF THE
PERSON WE'RE SEEING OR HEARING
THE ON ALTERED ORIGINAL VERSION
OF THE IMAGE OR RECORDING.
THESE TEN THESE CHANGES ARE
INTENDED TO CLARIFY THE NEXUS
BETWEEN THE MANIPULATION.
AND THE FALSITY OF THE SPEECH
AND CONDUCT ATTRIBUTED TO A
CANDIDATE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ANALYSIS THIS AND I
THINK -- MANY OF US WE'VE HAD --
PROFESSOR DEAN CHEMERINSKY MANY
TIMES I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUARREL ABOUT HIS EXPERTISE AND
I ALWAYS APPRECIATE HIS.
ANALYSIS WHICH I THINK REFLECTS
A NUMBER THE AMENDMENTS YOU'VE
TAKEN AND NARROW THE BILL SO
THAT HE DOES BELIEVE AND I
CERTAINLY AM NOT GOING TO ARGUE
WITH HIM.
THAT IT IS NOW CONSTITUTIONAL
CERTAINLY AN IMPORTANT ISSUE SO
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. SEVEN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WOULD
BE PROUD THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION -- I'LL
START BY NOTING I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE LETTER FROM PROFESSOR
CHEMERINSKY I CERTAINLY -- DON'T.
ENJOY BEING IN THE POSITION OF
DISAGREEING WITH HIM BUT I THINK
I DO HAVE TO IN THIS SITUATION.
TO BE CLEAR WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE A. B. SEVEN THIRTY NOT
BECAUSE WE DISAGREE WITH THE
INTENT OF THE BILL FAR FROM IT
WE AGREE THAT.
PROTECTING THE INTEGRITY OF
ELECTIONS IS CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT
WE RECOGNIZE THE TROUBLING USES.
THAT DEPICTS TECHNOLOGY CAN BE
PUT TO HOWEVER WE DON'T BELIEVE
AB SEVEN THIRTY IS THE SOLUTION.
THOUGH WELL INTENTIONED AB SEVEN
THIRTY UNDERMINES THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AS IT'S OVER BROAD
INEFFECTIVE AND UNNECESSARY THE
BILL'S OVER BROAD.
BECAUSE IT APPLIES TO ANY IMAGE
OR RECORDING THAT'S BEEN
MANIPULATED -- AND AS STATED IN
THE AMENDMENTS SO THAT A
REASONABLE PERSON WOULD HAVE A
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE OF THE
EXPRESSIVE CONTENT AS COMPARED
TO THE ORIGINAL.
THIS COULD APPLY TO A WHOLE HOST
OF LEGITIMATE PROTECTED FORMS OF
EXPRESSION FOR EXAMPLE.
CONSIDER A POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENT THAT ATTACKS A
CANDIDATE FOR MISSING VOTES THAT
INCLUDES AN IMAGE OF THE
CANDIDATES WHICH THEY'VE ADDED --
A GOLF BAG CONTINUE IN THE
PERSON MISTER VOTES BECAUSE THEY
WERE GOLFING.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
COVERED BY THIS BILL EVEN IF
THEY CAN'T IT WAS IN FACT
GOLFING.
THE BILL'S INEFFECTIVE A
PROVIDES NO GUARANTEE OF
RESOLUTION OF AND CLAIMS BEFORE
AN ELECTION AND AS NOTED IN THE
NOW SAYS.
EVEN IN THE EVENT OF COURT
ISSUED A RULING BEFORE THE
ELECTION THAT'S UNLIKELY THE
STOP THE SPREAD OF THESE
RECORDINGS ON THE DARK CORNERS
OF THE INTERNET.
AND EVEN IF THE BILL WORKS AS
INTENDED IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT
LABELING SOMETHING IS
MANIPULATED GIVES LEAVES VOTERS
BETTER INFORMED.
AND PARTICULARLY IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THE MANIPULATION HAS BEEN
MINOR SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
MATERIAL -- IT COULD ACTUALLY
LEAVE THE VOTER WITH A
MISIMPRESSION AS TO WHAT IS REAL
AND NOT REAL IN THAT -- IMAGE OR
RECORDING.
FINELY THE THE BILL IS
UNNECESSARY DEEP FAKES ARE AN
OLD PROBLEM IN NEW CLOTHES THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT NEW WE HAVE
TWO VERY POWER LIKE YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE THANK YOU MANAGER
MEMBERS.
OF MY NAME'S MARK POWERS AND
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION THE
RADIO AND TELEVISION STATIONS
SERVING YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
AS I SAID ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
LAST WEEK A FEDERAL LAW
PROVENCHER BROADCASTERS FROM
COMPLYING WITH THIS BILL.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE ANALYSIS
HAS LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM AND WE WERE HOPING TO BE
ABLE TO BE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
BUT IT DOESN'T RESOLVE SOME OF
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE HAVE.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT -- WHITNEY
SAID WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
THE ACTUAL PROCESS OVERSEE SHINS
REMOVING DEEP FAKES IS GOING TO
WORK.
WHERE THERE MAY BE NO WAY TO
DETECT THEM?
AND THE TIME FRAME IS SO SHORT.
IT SEEMS WE'RE GOING TO COUNT ON
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM TO
PRIORITIZE THESE CASES AND A
JUDGE TO MAKE THE DETERMINATION
IF THE PICTURE AUDIO OR VISUAL
IS FATE.
AT THAT POINT SOMEONE SOMEWHERE
SOMEHOW AS GOING TO PROVIDE THE
MEDIA IN YOUR DISTRICT WITH THE
RULING SO THEY KNOW IT'S FAKE
HOPEFULLY.
BUT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
PUNISH THE MEDIA IF THEY SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN.
NOT JUST KNOWN BUT SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN.
ABOUT REQUIRES ACTUAL MALICE BY
EVERYONE ELSE THIS PLACE IS THE
MEDIAN THE POSITION OF A JUDGE.
AND A JURY AND THAT WILL HAND
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS AND
ADDITIONAL TACTIC TO TRY AND
FORCE ADS OFF THE AIR BY
THREATENING LITIGATION.
A DEEP THINK IS MOST LIKELY TO
HAPPEN WITH THIRD PARTY ADS
PROBABLY FROM OUT OF STATE
COMMITTEES.
SO WHEN YOUR STATIONS PUT A
DISCLAIMER ON AN AD TO AVOID THE
AB SEVEN THIRTY PENALTIES AFTER
AN OPPOSING THIRD PARTY
COMMITTEE COMPLAINS ABOUT.
AND IF THAT STATION GUESSES
WRONG AFTER THAT DISCLOSURE THEY
GET A DEFAMATION SUIT.
AS A REWARD.
THESE COMMITTEES WON'T CARE
ABOUT A REASONABLE FEES AS A
DETERRENT FOR FALSE CLAIMS
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE GONE.
LONG BEFORE THAT PROCESS SENS
THIS PROCESS REQUIRES FAX NOT
GUESSES YOUR DISTRICT MEDIA
SHOULD NOT BE MAKING A TRUE
FALSE DETERMINATION ON YOUR
POLITICAL SPEECH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I'M SURE MEMBERS KEVIN BACON FOR
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION OF CALIFORNIA WITH ALL
RESPECT TO PROFESSOR CHEMERINSKY
OUR ANALYSIS IS THAT THE BILL
DOES INTRUDE ON AND THAT'S WHAT
A GOOD LAWSUIT IS MADE OFF.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- ARE
BRINGING IT BACK. TO THE DíAS --
CENTER WHITE HOUSE CAN I ALSO
HAVE TO EXCUSE MYSELF TO GO
VOTING NATURAL RESOURCES
MANAGERS JUST LOOKING FOR SOME
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I'M PLATE
PAGE TO THE BILL IT TALKS ABOUT
IMAGE VIDEO AND AUDIO AND I
THINK I KNOW WHAT.
SO IT DOESN'T TAKE PICTURE BUT
IT I THINK I KNOW WHAT THE VIDEO
IS AN AUDIO IS DO WE HAVE AND
IT'S NOT THE FINE WE HAVE AN
IDEA OF WHAT'S.
BEING SWEPT UP OVER WHAT'S
INCLUDED YEAH GREAT QUESTION
CENTER AND A WHAT WE NEED TO BE
INCLUDED IS IS PHOTORAPHS -- SO
NOT NOT ANYTHING THAT WAS DRAWN
OR ARTISTICALLY CREATED BUT BUT
IF.
PHOTOGRAPH THAT WAS TAKEN AND
DIGITALLY MANIPULATED TO TO
CREATE THIS THIS DIFFERENT.
EXPERIENCE OR IMPRESSION ON A ON
A PERSON.
OKAY AND AND IT YEAH I'D BE MORE
THAN HAPPY -- TO YOU KNOW
CONTINUE WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE AND AND ONE THING THAT
I DIDN'T GET TO THAT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO SAY IS IS THAT --
YOU KNOW I'LL BE THE FIRST TO
ADMIT THAT THERE'S MORE WORK TO
BE DONE ON THIS BILL -- ANSWER
THE PASS OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY I FULLY INTEND TO SPEND
THE SUMMER RESOURCES SUMMER
RECESS.
CONTINUING TO FINE TUNE THE
LANGUAGE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THAT ARE -- YOU KNOW
BROUGHT UP TODAYAND THEN MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS IS NEW I
KNOW THIS IS.
GOING OUT -- YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
THIS IS NEW TECHNOLOGY THEY WERE
TRYING TO APPLY THE EXISTING
WANT TO AND AND I KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO SPEND MORE TIME.
TO GET RIGHT.
BOTH TEACHERS IN GERMAN SKIS
LETTER CLEARLY POINTS OUT ABOUT
IT WE DON'T PROTECT.
FALSE AND DECEPTIVE -- HAD A
SPEECH YES SIR IN [inaudible]
I AGREE.
MAN ARTS CENTER DRAWS YEAH -- I
AM NOT A LAWYER.
AND I DON'T PRETEND TO TRY TO
GIVE ALL THE LEGAL ARGUMENTS
HERE.
BUT I CAN SAY IS THAT IT I'M
EXTREMELY UNCOMFORTABLE.
WITH MOVING FORWARD ON SOMETHING
THAT IS SO PRECIOUS TO US. TO US.
AND HAVE YOU BEEN INVOLVED IN A
LOT OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
CAMPAIGNS POLITICAL AND
OTHERWISE.
IT'S IT SEEMS TO BE A VERY
DANGEROUS THING WITHOUT HAVING
HAD.
A MUCH MUCH MORE.
A MUCH DEEPER MUCH BROADER.
REALLY THOUGHT THROUGH -- VIEW
OF HOW WE GO FORWARD WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IT'S NOT TO
PROTECT YOU KNOW THE SCUMBAGS
THAT DO WHAT THEY DO -- AND LET
THEM GET AWAY WITH THAT IT'S
JUST TOO PRECIOUS A A RIGHT AND
SO.
I I'M WITH YOU IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BUT I'M NOT.
I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO VOTE
FOR SOMETHING IN WHICH I STILL
FEEL VERY UNCOMFORTABLE WITH.
AND JUST BELIEVE THAT WE OUGHT
TO BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT'S MUCH MORE
THOUGHT THROUGH THANK YOU BUT
THANK YOU. FOR TAKING ON THE
SCUMBAG THANK YOU SENATOR AND
AND I I UNDERSTAND.
THE CONCERN THAT YOU HAVE --
YEAH THE THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS
SUCH A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT -- IN
IN IN AMERICA AND AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY IS NOT ABSOLUTE -- AND
AND IT DOESN'T APPLY THERE ARE
EXCEPTIONS TO IT.
I THINK WE'VE NEARLY TAYLOR THE
BILL TO TO FIT THAT SWEET SPOT --
BUT I DO KNOW THAT THERE'S MORE
WORK THAT WE STILL NEED TO DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S CLEAR AND
AND SO THAT WE DON'T SWEEP UP.
UNINTENDED ACTIVITIES -- ORG
UNINTENDED SPEECH THAT WE DON'T
MEAN. TO TO HAVE SWEPT UP IN
THIS I THOUGHT YOU KNOW WHEN WE
START WERE SORT OF WORKING ON
THE BILL.
BUT I WOULD JUST GONNA TARGET
DEEP FAKES THAT WOULD AT LEAST
BE MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD BUT AS
THE SAME NEGATIVE.
IMPACTS -- AND IS THE SAME IN MY
MIND INAPPROPRIATE MANIPULATION
OF MEDIA OF CONTENT OF OFF THE
VIDEO IN THAT EXAMPLE TO TURN
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED INTO
SOMETHING THAT DID NOT -- SO --
IT YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT IT'S
IT'S STICKY -- BUT I THINK IT IT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS BEFORE
TWENTY TWENTY I DO NOT WANT TO
BE IN THE SAME PLACE THAT WE
WERE THE DAY AFTER THE ELECTION
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN WE REALIZE --
SHOOT I WISH WE TAKING THIS MORE
SERIOUSLY THIS WHOLE FOREIGN
INFLUENCE AND THEN
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN THING IS
SERIOUS AND ACTUALLY WORKS --
AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
ATTEMPTING TO DO.
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
CAN I TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES
YES SIR.
IS THERE A MOTION.
MOVED BY A CENTER -- GONZALEZ
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR JACKSON.
BORDERS TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING STERN.
I'M BURKE.
NUMBER TWO I WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
MY COUNTY BY THE ROLE OPEN --
THREE ONE THREE TO ONE IS TO
VOTE KEEP TO ROLL OPEN LET'S
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE
THIS IS AB TEN SIXTY FIVE WHICH
WAS ON CONSENT BUT WAS PULLED IN
WAS.
WE NOTICED THAT IT WASN'T ON SO
THIS IS INSURANCE TRANSACTION.
ELECTRONIC -- ELEVEN FORTY SIX
NUMBER ONE IS THE ONE AT FAULT.
OKAY SO THIS IS.
BOTH OF THEM THE THIRD.
ELEVEN FORTY SIX THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU SIR.
I WILL BE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AND PROMISED THEM MULTIPLE TIMES
IN A FAILED TO DELIVER. TO THE
CHAIR AND SENATORS ACCORDINGLY
A. B. ELEVEN FORTY SIX WOULD
MAKE EXPLICIT THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTENT WITH PASSAGE OF OUR
LANDMARK CONSUMER PRIVACY BILL
LAST YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD MAKE
CLEAR THAT A NEW MOTOR VEHICLE
DEALER MAY RETAIN VEHICLE AND
OWNERSHIP INFORMATION IN ORDER
TO SHARE IT WITH AN AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURER FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ENABLING WARRANTY WORK FOR MANY
FACTORS RECALL.
NEW VEHICLES ARE COVERED BY
MANUFACTURER WARRANTY THAT
ALLOWS FOR REPAIRS TO BE MADE TO
THE VEHICLE AT NO COST TO THE
CONSUMER LIKEWISE WHEN THERE'S A
SAFETY DEFECT RECALL THE VEHICLE
CAN BE REPAIRED AT NO COST TO
THE CONSUMER.
BUT INFORMATION SHARING IS
NECESSARY TO NOTIFY CONSUMERS
AND EFFECTUATE REPAIRS THE BILL
IS NARROWLY TAILORED ONLY TWO
ACCOMPLICES OBJECTIVE AND
CONSUMER WOULD RETAIN THEIR
OTHER RIGHTS AND CONSUMER
REMEDIES UNDER THE LAW A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ON THIS BILL INTENDED TO KEEP
THE MOTORING PUBLIC SAFE.
FIRST WITNESS MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CLIFF CUSTOM BEHALF
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION THANKS SO MUCH TO
YEAR -- CONSULTANT FOR HIS HARD
WORK ON THIS I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE PRIVACY ADVOCATES
WE'VE WORKED WITH THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE YEAR. TO MAKE THIS CLEAR
FOR CATION WE BELIEVE WITHIN THE
EXISTING SPIRIT OF THE CCP.
FOCUSED ON ON THESE ISSUES THAT
ALLOW US NEW CAR DEALERS TO
CONTINUE TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS WHEN A CUSTOMER
CHOOSES TO OPT OUT OR CHOOSES TO
DELETE THEIR INFORMATION.
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE WE CAN
STILL CONTINUE TO REPAIR THEIR
WARRANTIES ARE THE RECALLS --
FOR THAT PURPOSE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST MY VOTE -- WHEN YOUR
CHANCE?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MY
NAME IS KERR CAM I'M WITH IHS
MARKET AUTOMOTIVE.
WHILE WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONCEPT OF THIS LEGISLATION WE
DO FEEL AN AMENDMENT WOULD BE
NEEDED -- RHS MARKET AUTOMOTIVE
PROVIDES THE MAJORITY OF DATED
AUTO MANUFACTURERS FOR RECALL
OUTREACH EFFORTS WE TAKE THE
REGISTRATION AND TITLE
INFORMATION ALONG WITH
MANUFACTURER DATA.
BOTH NEW AND USED AND WE COMBINE
THAT TO FIND THE BEST ADDRESS IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE THE RECALL
NOTICE FOR THE MANUFACTURERS TO
THE CONSUMERS.
WE ARE A KEY LINK IN THE PROCESS
AND MANUFACTURERS TO RELY ON THE
STATE A WE UNDERSTAND THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A GAP
THAT'S BEEN CREATED AND IT COULD
IMPACT SAFETY.
ARE THERE FOR THE AMENDMENT IS
NEEDED SO THAT THE MANUFACTURERS
AND THE DEALERS CAN SHARE THE
DATA WITH THE RECALL SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
AND THAT WE CAN RETAIN IT AS
WELL.
WITHOUT THE AMENDMENT AS I SAID
SAFETY MAY BE IMPACTED WE WORK
ON INNOVATIVE HEIGHTS HAS MARKET --
AUTOMOTIVE WORKS ON INNOVATIVE
RECALL SOLUTIONS WITH -- NUMBER
OF AUTOMAKERS -- SIX IN
PARTICULAR -- FOR JUST THOSE SIX
AUTOMAKERS WE THERE ARE WELL
OVER ONE MILLION.
VEHICLES THAT ARE -- RECALL
OFFER THE TAKATA AIRBAG RECALL
HERE IN CALIFORNIA HOW MANY
TRUCKS YOU FOR SECOND ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE YOU
SEEKING AN AMENDMENT THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS NOT.
AGREED TO WELL THEN YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SO WILL
BECOME AT THIS POINT I'M SORRY.
I I APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL
WAS ON CONSENT TILL THIS MORNING
SO.
I'M A LITTLE RUSTY ABOUT IT TOO
BUT CLEARLY YOU'RE ASKING FOR AN
AMENDMENT THAT IT APPEARS THAT
THE AUTHORS NOT PREPARED TO TAKE.
SO LET'S GO BACK OF THEIR ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE ANY WITNESSES IT WITH CAL
CHAMBER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I'M MORE MONIQUE CONSUMER
REPORTS IN STRONG NEUTRALITY
WE'VE REMOVED OPPOSITION BASED
ON AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR WE THANK HIM FOR WORKING
WITH US.
STRONG NEUTRALITY THANK YOU I
LIKE AND STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT SO YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED WITH
AN AMENDMENT THAT THE AUTHOR
DOES WANT TO TAKE SO THAT'S
OPPOSITION HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH WE LEARNED
ABOUT THIS THIS MORNING ALSO
RIGHT.
COLLEGES AND SO.
THEY'RE THEY'RE TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE A BILL OVER NATURAL
RESOURCES WE DON'T DO THAT HERE
AND CERTAINLY NOT WITH ALL THESE
BILLS THAT WE'VE GOT SO.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS I WOULD
LIKE?
TO HAVE A MOTION -- TO TO
APPROVE THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
CONSTITUTED WITH A COMMITMENT
THAT YOU WILL TRY TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AND IF THERE'S AN
ISSUE IT WILL COME BACK TO US.
VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT --
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
TEACHING IN THE HEARING NON
LET'S GO AHEAD AND WE HAVE A
MOTION THE MOTION IS
[inaudible]
OUR IS. TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE A.
B. ELEVEN FORTY SIX JACKSON HI
JACKSON I'VE LARGEST TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ CONSOLES I
JONES.
MONNING STERN UMBERG HI NUMBER I
WHITE HOUSE SKI WITH HEALTHY I
ALL RIGHT.
TO THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE NEXT ITERATION.
THERE IS ONE MORE BILL HERE IN.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN HAS
UP  FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE A. B..
FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR OF MY
UNDERSTANDING IS SHE WILL BE
ACCEPTING AS OFFERS AMENDMENTS
THOSE CITED.
ON PAGES SIX AND SEVEN COMMENT
TWO IS THAT CORRECT YES THAT IS
CORRECT VERY GOOD.
I'D LIKE -- TO FIRST THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL OF ACCEPTING
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS INCLUDING
THE ANALYSIS.
IN ORDER FOR CONSUMERS TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
COVERED BUSINESSES ARE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A TOLL FREE
PHONE NUMBER FOR CONSUMERS TO
MAKE ACCESS.
AND DELETION REQUESTS ABOUT THE
PERSONAL INFORMATION AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED A. B. FIFTEEN
SIXTY FOUR WOULD ONLY ALLOW A
BUSINESS THAT OPERATES
EXCLUSIVELY ONLINE AND HAS A
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH
CONSUMERS.
WHO COLLECTS PERSONAL
INFORMATION FROM TO PROVIDE AN
EMAIL ADDRESS IN LIEU OF A TOLL
FREE PHONE NUMBER THIS
FLEXIBILITY WOULD ALLOW ONLINE
ONLY BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE AN
OPTION THAT FITS THE CONTEXT OF
THE CONSUMER?
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP MEANING
HOW THE CONSUMER ENGAGES WITH
THE BUSINESS GENERALLY AND WORK
WITHIN BEST PRACTICES TO VERIFY.
AND RESPOND TO REQUESTS WITH ME
TODAY IS KEVIN MCKINLEY.
NUMBER HAVE THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU TWO MINUTES OR
LESS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THAT KEVIN KELLY WITH INTERNET
ASSOCIATION.
AND CZ PAY PRESENTS A RIGID
REQUIREMENT ALL BUSINESSES MUST
PROVIDE TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR
CONSUMER REQUESTS THIS IS UNLIKE
THE APPROACHING GPR WHICH
PROVIDES WIDE LATITUDE IN ACCESS
METHODS.
REQUIRING A TOLL FREE NUMBER CAN
BE CUMBERSOME AND PRESENTS BOTH
SECURITY AND PRIVACY CONCERNS
FOR BUSINESSES RESPONDING TO
CONSUMER REQUESTS. FOR CONSUMERS
TO INTERACT VIA WEBSITE OR APP
WITH THE BUSINESS AN ONLINE
METHOD FOR ACCESS VERIFICATION
WOULD BE EFFICIENT.
THE POSITIVE AND CONSISTENT WITH
CONSUMER EXPECTATIONS -- A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR AS AMENDED --
STILL ALLOWS FOR ONLINE METHODS
IN THIS USE CASE AND ASK FOR A
VOTE.
YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON FOR CTA THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY TRADE ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ERNIE JOHNSON ATTACKMAN SUPPORT.
KELLY HIT WITH COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THERE BUT WITH CAL CHAMBER IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS OSWALD WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF NATIONAL
ADVERTISERS IN SUPPORT.
MY SHEPHERD FOR THE CAL AGING
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE WILL TAKE
IT BACK TO THE DICE WERE YOU IN
OPPOSITION -- STRONGLY TRILOGY.
I ARE A FIVE JOHNSON WITH COMMON
SENSE MEDIA WE'VE BEEN OPPOSING
BECAUSE WE WANT A TELEPHONE.
NUMBER OPTION.
I AM NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT THE
AMENDMENT THAT WAS TAKEN.
IS NOW.
IT IS TO GO BACK TO WELL WHY
DON'T YOU TELL US IT'S YOUR BILL
IT'S IT'S TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF YOU HAD IF THE BUSINESS HAS A
A BRICK AND MORTAR STORE -- AND
A AND A DIRECT AND PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CUSTOMER
THAN THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
TELEPHONE NUMBER.
BUT IF THEY EXIST ONLY ONLINE
THEN THEY CAN.
HAVE AN EMAIL.
IF THEY HAVE AN ONLINE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS.
OKAY ONLY THAT KEEPS OUT THE THE
FOLKS WHO ARE FISHING FOR MORE
INFORMATION ON SENSE WILL BE
NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
FOR ALL RIGHT -- MOTION.
MOTION BY CENTER Y. CASKEY.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING HARD TO
GET TO THE RIGHT SPOT ON THIS --
THIS IS -- A WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ON AFTER AN HOUR OF YOUR
TIME I APPRECIATED ALL AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS.
ARE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY ONE A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORCHERS RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D
JONES MONNING STERN.
I'M BURKE HI NUMBER I Y. CASKEY
WHAT HEALTHY I FIVE TWO ZERO ALL
RIGHT THAT BILL HAS FIVE VOTER
WILL HOLD A ROLL UP AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
YOU ARE NEXT.
TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I MUST
APOLOGIZE ALL MAKE SURE TO KILL
MORE OF MISTER BERMAN'S BILLS
NEXT YEAR.
IT IT WOULD BE IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AT LEAST IN TERMS OF
NUMBERS BUT WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
HAVE -- HAVE YOU HERE TO PRESENT --
IT'S FILE ITEM TEN AB THREE
SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS STUDENT LOAN
DEBT IS IN CRISIS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- TALKING OVER
ONE POINT. HUNDRED FORTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN DEBT AND
ALMOST FOUR MILLION BORROWERS.
AND THIS IS THE SECOND LARGEST
AMOUNT OF DEBT AFTER HOME LOANS
AFTER MORTGAGES AND YET THERE'S
VERY LITTLE IF ANY REGULATION.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HAD
BEEN WORKING WITH CFPB AND
TRYING TO PUT SOME REGULATIONS
AND IN PLACE WELL ACTUALLY
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF OF
EDUCATION.
THEY COMPLETELY BACKED OFF OF
ANY THOSE PROTECTIONS AND AS YOU
KNOW WE RAN SEVERAL YEARS AGO A
BILL TO BRING STUDENTS SERVICERS
INTO A LICENSING PROGRAM.
ADD IN THE MIDST OF TRYING TO A
LINE.
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSING PROGRAM
WITH FEDERAL RULES.
ALL THE FEDERAL RULES ONE WAY.
THE COMPANION PIECE TO THE
LICENSING WHICH IS LICENSING THE
STUDENT LOAN SERVICERS IS THIS
BILL AND IT'S GIVING STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF CERTAINTY IN HOW THEY'RE
TREATED BY THIS TO LOAN
SERVICERS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY HAVE
RIGHTS THAT THEY CAN ENFORCE IN
FACT THE LARGEST STUDENT LOAN
SERVICER HAS MADE IT VERY CLEAR
AND IN.
TESTIFIED IN COURT THAT.
CONSUMERS SHOULD HAVE ABSOLUTELY
NO EXPECTATION THAT THE SERVICE
OR WILL BE OPERATING IN THEIR
BEST INTEREST THAT IS SHAMEFUL
THIS IS A BILL TO FIX THAT.
WE ARE GIVING STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS SOME OPPORTUNITIES
HERE TO MAKE SURE THEY GET OUT
OF DEBT INAPPROPRIATE MATTER AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IS
OFFICIALLY AS POSSIBLE DON'T GET
DRAGGED ON THROUGH THE PROCESS
UNNECESSARILY.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU -- WITNESSES OF TWO
MINUTES AT THE MOST PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
MY NAME IS CODY UNION MY BILL
THE STUDENT LOAN BORROWER AND
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT STUDENT DEBT
CRISIS FOR ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
ONE MILLION.
SUPPORTERS IMPACTED BY THIS
CRISIS.
I'M ALSO HERE TO ECHO THE VOICES
OF FELLOW CO SPONSORS THE
STUDENT BAR PROTECTION CENTER.
I'M A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
GRADUATE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA BARBARA IN A
LIFELONG RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
SANTA CREADA.
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM IS CLEAR
FOR MY GRANDPARENTS WHO CAME TO
LOS ANGELES AS OUR MILLION
REFUGEES.
EDUCATION WAS IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT DREAM.
EVEN HELP ME ACHIEVE IT.
WHEN I GRADUATE IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AFTER YEARS OF TUITION
INCREASES I WAS CARRYING OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN DEBT?
ON TOP OF THAT MY PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS WERE SOLD DURING
NINETY THOUSAND STUDENT DEBT
THEMSELVES. THREE GENERATIONS OF
CANADIANS WERE NOW REPAYMENT IN
REPAYMENT FOR THE FIRST TIME.
WE HAD VIRTUALLY ZERO GUIDANCE
FOR A LOAN SERVICERS.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB
THREE SEVEN SIX THE STUDENT BAR
BILL OF RIGHTS BECAUSE I'VE
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND WHAT
HAPPENS TO CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES.
WHEN LOAN SERVICERS ARE ALLOWED
TO RUN AMOK?
MY FIRST TWO KNOWN BILLS OVER
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS AND I REST
MY SERVICE SERVER HELP.
AT THE TIME I WAS ELIGIBLE FOR
THE MOST AFFORDABLE FEDERAL
REPAYMENT PROGRAM.
HOWEVER I WAS MISLED ABOUT MY
OPTIONS IN PLACE A REPAYMENT
PLAN WITH HIGHER MONTHLY
PAYMENTS.
THE ALSO EXTEND MY REPAYMENT
PLAN BY OVER HALF A DECADE.
SEVERAL YEARS LATER MY LOAN
SERVICER SAYING AN EMAIL WITH
INCORRECT DEADLINE FOR THE
MANDATORY YOU THEY WERE
CERTIFICATION.
THAT MAYBE MISS AYE DEADLINE
CAUSING THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
BE ADDED TO MY LOAN BALANCE AND
MY MONTHLY PAYMENT TRIPLED.
DESPITE CLEAR FEELINGS MY LOAN
SERVICING COMPANY THERE IS NO NO
ONE TO TURN TO TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM.
I WAS NOT ALONE.
MY PARENTS WERE PUSHED INTO
FORBEARANCE AND REPAYMENT
OPTIONS AT COST THEM MORE MONEY
AND TIME.
EVEN AFTER MY MOTHER COULD NO
LONGER WORK DUE TO A DISABILITY
THE LOAN SERVICER FILL TO INFORM
THEM THAT THEY MAY QUALIFY FOR
TOTAL AND PERMANENT LOAN
DISCHARGE.
WHEN MY TWIN BROTHER FIRST
RESPONDER LOS ANGELES BECAUSE --
TO SERVE THE COMMUNITY.
HE QUALIFIED FOR PUBLIC SERVICE
LOAN FORGIVENESS.
YEAH HIS LOAN SERVICER FIELD TO
COMMUNICATE THE SUPPORT PROGRAM.
INSTEAD OF MAKING PROGRESS
TOWARDS LOAN FULL FULL LOAN
FORGIVENESS HE'S BEEN YEARS AND
BE PAYMENT THAT DID NOT QUALIFY
FOR THE PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
TURN MEMBER SUSAN MARTIN NOW
WITH CONSUMER REPORTS FORMALLY
CONSUMERS UNION ALSO VERY HAPPY
TO CO SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION
AND ALSO YOU SEE GRADUATE IN A
BAR MYSELF WHO GOT STUCK IN
FORBEARANCE LESS THAN A MONTH
AGO AND I WORK ON THIS FOR A
LIVING THESE SERVICES DO NOT
HAVE. TO FOLLOW ANY RULES AND
HAVE NO ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN THEY
DON'T PROVIDE A BASIC CUSTOMER
SERVICE.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T WITH IS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THIS LOOK VERY
ECHO TROUBLING LEE SIMILAR TO
THE HOME ON A BILL OF RIGHTS
ISSUE WHEN MORTGAGE SERVICERS
WERE LETTING PEOPLE SLIDE INTO
DEFAULT IN FORECLOSURE BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO FOLLOW ANY
STANDARDS.
WE ARE SAYING STUDENT BORROWERS
DESERVE THE SAME LEVEL
PROTECTIONS -- WE CAN SHOULD ACT
IN THIS AREA AND JACK TODAY AND
SOME IS TO THE GOVERNOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY.
HELLO TRYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER TEARS OF SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
REGGAE'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REFERENCE SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
AND I BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATT THIS THING WHEN NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM WHEN BURKE FOR THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION A
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHICH DUGGAR WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANTHONY LEE ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO SERRA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIEL CANDOR KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JOSEPH JETT OF ON BEHALF OF
CHIRLA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KRISTEN RICHARDSON MCGUIRE YOUNG
INVINCIBLES CO SPONSORS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH SK YOU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAREN LAYING ON THE OF THE
SITTING COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TWO MINUTES EACH.
HAPPENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SCOTT
YOU CAN I AM HERE ON BEHALF THIS
TUNE ONE SERVICING ALLIANCE.
WE ARE NONPROFIT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION OF STUDENT LOAN
SERVICERS IN THE FEDERAL AND
STUDENT LOAN MARKET PLACE MOSTLY
PRIVATE NON PROFIT AND STATE
AGENCIES.
OUR MEMBER SERVICE ABOUT 95% OF
ALL STUDENT LOANS ABOUT ONE
POINT SIX TRILLION OF WHICH ARE
OUTSTANDING TODAY -- BUT SOME
FACTS ARE CRITICAL IN THIS
DISCUSSION SERVICERS DO NOT MAKE
THESE LOANS WE DO NOT RECEIVE
THE INTEREST OR PROCEEDS FROM
THEM.
INTEREST RATES FOR PAYMENT
OPTIONS AND BENEFITS ARE OUTSIDE
OFOUR CONTROL FOR FEDERAL LOANS
ALL THOSE COST AND LOAN BALANCE
PROCEDURES ARE SET BY CONGRESS.
WHAT WE CAN CONTROL THE
INFORMATION THAT WE PROVIDE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THAT IS
ACTUALLY BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE AND
HAVE ROBUST PROCESSES IN PLACE?
TO RESOLVE ANY OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS THE REALITY IS A
CORNER THE CFPB THAT LESS THAN
ZERO ZERO POINT 6%.
OF ALL CONSUMER FINANCIAL
COMPLAINTS ABOUT STUDENT LOAN
RELATED ISSUES AND OF THOSE 85%
OR RESULT BY JUST EXPLAINING THE
TERMS OF THE LOAN TO THE BAR.
THOSE ARE NOT SERVICE OR ISSUES.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH CURRENT
PROVISIONS IN AB THREE SEVENTY
SIX COULD MAKE SERVICING MORE
COSTLY YOUR MORE CONFUSING FOR
BORROWERS.
FIRST THE A BILL PROVIDES BROAD
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION OUR
MEMBERS COULD BE SUED EVEN WHEN
A REGULAR REGULATORS FOUND NO
FACTUAL BASIS FOR ACTION AGAINST
SERVICERS.
AT BEST THIS COULD DECREASE
SERVICES FOR ALL BORROWERS WOULD
BE BURDENSOME ON THE TOTAL COST
OF THE LOAN PROGRAM THE PROPOSED
CHANGES THAT WE HOPE WILL BE
TAKEN WITH TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THOSE.
SECOND THE MARKET MONITORING
MISSIONS IN THE BILL OF BEEN
REJECTED BY OTHER REGULATORS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T TO COLLECT
INFORMATION WHICH MAY NOT BE
PERMITTED UNDER CONFLICTING
FEDERAL LAW AND REGULATION.
THEY ALSO CRITICIZED ANGEL
BURDENS BEST ON SMALLER
NONPROFIT SERVICERS AND ARE
DUPLICATIVE LASTLY PAYMENT
APPLICATION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET RIGHT.
BUT THE TERM IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF BORROWER IS
COMPLETELY UNDEFINED SINCE MANY
BOARDS HAVE DIFFERENT WERE
PAYMENT GOALS AND DESIRED
OUTCOMES WE PROPOSE CHANGES THAT
ENSURE THE EXACT SAME MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
INTENDED AS A CHEAP BUT ALSO
MAKES IMPLEMENTING THOSE OPTIONS
PRACTICALLY ACHIEVABLE FOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED VISIT CURVE --
POSITION ON THE BILL WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE
SUBSTANTIVE PROVISIONS BUT ONLY
AS TO THE ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS.
THE BILL ALLOWS LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES OF FIVE HUNDRED TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS PER.
VIOLATION PLUS ATTORNEY'S FEES
AND HAS A PROVISION IT'S KIND OF
A QUIZ ON A CLASS ACTION
PROVISION THAT COULD LEAD TO
LAWSUITS THAT ARE MORE ABOUT
MONEY THAN ABOUT JUSTICE.
AS YOU IN THIS COMMITTEE
PROBABLY KNOW.
OF CALIFORNIA HAS VERY --
PERMISSIVE RULES REGARDING CLASS
ACTION LAWSUITS BUT WE DO HAVE
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR A CERTIFYING
A CLASS CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS AT
THE CLASS MUST BE ASCERTAINABLE
BUT HAVE COMMON ISSUES OF ON
FACTS.
THE CLAIM OF THE NAMED PLAINTIFF
MUST BE TYPICAL OF THOSE OF THE
OTHER CLASS MEMBERS.
AND THE NAME TO REPRESENTATIVE
MUST ADEQUATELY REPRESENT THE
OTHER CLASS MEMBERS IN ADDITION
THE CLASS MECHANISM MUST BE A
SUPERIOR WAY OF RESOLVING THE
PROBLEM WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
ALLOW PEOPLE TO SEE YOU ON
BEHALF OF OTHERS SIMILARLY
SITUATED WITHOUT THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT -- PROVIDES AND THAT
MAKES US SEE JACK NERVOUS FOR
THOSE THAT REASON -- WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED PREVENT --
POSITION ABOUT THE ENFORCEMENT
SECTION AQ THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
VENTURE AND SENATORS COMMINGLED
WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
PROPER WILL SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible] FIVE OF I ALWAYS
FIND IT INTERESTING WHEN THE
DEFENSE'S ALL OR WHEN THE
OPPOSITION IS ALWAYS ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO SUE.
NOW IF YOU'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING
WRONG A LAWSUIT IS IN A WORK SO --
OF I THINK THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERN I DON'T I DIDN'T HEAR
MUCH IN TERMS OF Y. E. GIVING.
THESE CONSUMERS OF RIGHT AND
KNOWLEDGE ISN'T A GOOD THING.
COMING OUT OF SCHOOL WITH A DEBT
IN AND OF ITSELF IS A BAD THING --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
IS GENERATIONAL I DON'T KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
BACK IN THE OLDER DAYS WHEN THE
COST OF A COLLEGE EDUCATION TO
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WAS FIFTY
DOLLARS A SEMESTER -- ED THAT
THOSE TO THE OLD DAYS THEY DON'T
HAPPEN MUCH BUT NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT STUDENTS WHO WERE
LIVING IN THEIR CARS TO COME OUT
OF SCHOOL WITH THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS OF DEBT.
THIS IS OUR FUTURE.
THIS IS WHAT WE'VE DONE TO OUR
FUTURE WE'VE MORTGAGED IT TO THE
HILT.
AND THE IDEA THAT AT LEAST YOU'D
HAVE A PROGRAM HERE TO GIVE
GREATER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO
STUDENTS I THINK IT'S JUST A NO
BRAINER AND SO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THE
BILL AND I THINK THAT IF THERE
ARE CONCERNS -- AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL -- PERHAPS WE CAN BE THE
GUIDE FOR HOW TO DO IT RIGHT SO
WITH THAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION -- YOU WANTED TO MOVE
THE BILL.
WE'LL LET YOU MOVE THE BILL
BECAUSE YOU MOVED A LOT OF ON
ALL RIGHT OKAY GOOD WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER GONZALEZ.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU JUST TO SAY THAT WHEN
CALIFORNIA PASSED THE STUDENT
SERVICE OUR LICENSING PROGRAM AT
LEAST A DOZEN STATES HAVE
FOLLOWED.
OUR LEAD THEIR M<c.cyan> ÁI</c>
STATES ARE WATCHING WHAT
CALIFORNIA DOES NOW THIS IS
CRITICAL FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT WILL HAVE
IMPLICATIONS NATIONWIDE.
LET'S LEAD THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE ABOUT
THANK YOU.
ARE THE VOTE IS THE MOTION
RATHER IS TO PASS.
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. THREE
SEVENTY SIX JACKSON.
HI JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ AND SALAS AYE
JONES.
MONNING STERN -- BURKE HI NUMBER
TWO I WHAT CASKEY WHAT HAS HE
AYE FIVE THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
AND WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND AGREED TO GIVE SAN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD -- PRIORITY WHEN HE
WAS DONE WITH HIS COMMITTEE HE
HAS ONE BILL AND YOU'VE GOT.
THREE SO IF YOU IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND IF WE ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD TO GO FIRST.
CLEARLY AGE BEFORE BEAUTY SO --
WE'LL DO THAT AND I HAVE GOT TO
GO VOTE SO I'M GONNA GIVE THE
FILE ITEM. TWENTY SEVEN AB.
EIGHT EIGHT TWO FOUR AND AGAIN
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
PLEASE NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
EACH TO WITNESSES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL EXCEPT ALL THE
AMENDMENTS AND I HAVE COMMITTED
TO TAKE IN.
I HAVE I I ACCEPT ALL THE
MINIMUM SITE HAVE COMMITTED TO
TAKEN SUBMITTED AND SENATE
HEALTH.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WILL DIFFER
WHAT IS KNOWN AS PAY FOR DELAY
AGREEMENTS OR SETTLEMENTS
BETWEEN GENERIC AND BRAND.
MANUFACTURERS IN ORDER TO DELAY
MARKETING A GENERIC VERSION OF A
DRUG FOR SOMETHING OF VALUE.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR DOES THIS
BY ESTABLISHING THE STANDARD
REVIEW FOR THE COURTS TO USE
WHEN RIVER REVIEWING PAY FOR
DELAY AGREEMENTS.
THE FTC HAS SOUGHT TO USE THEIR
AUTHORITY THROUGH ENFORCEMENT TO
STOP THESE PAY FOR DELAY
AGREEMENTS.
BUT AS LONG AS TEN YEARS AGO
THEY CALLED ON CONGRESS TO ENACT
LEGISLATION TO STOP THESE TYPES
OF AGREEMENTS.
SO FAR CONGRESS HAS FAILED TO
ACT WE HAVE A CHANCE TO CHANGE
THAT IN CALIFORNIA.
THE INCREASED COST OF ANTI
COMPETITIVE AGREEMENTS AFFECTS
EVERYONE WHO PAYS FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS THE STATE.
EMPLOYERS AND CONSUMERS THE BILL
ESTABLISHES.
A PRESUMPTION THAT THESE
AGREEMENTS ARE ANTI COMPETITIVE.
THE DRUNK UP DRUG COMPANIES WILL
HAVE THE BURDEN OF PROVING THAT
THESE SETTLEMENTS ARE PRO
CONSUMER.
OR PRO COMPETITIVE THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE UNDER THE
CURRENT PROCESS IT IT HAS BEEN
DIFFICULT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACQUIRE THE INFORMATION FROM THE
DRUG COMPANIES TO MAKE THIS
DETERMINATION.
YOU WILL HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT THESE AGREEMENTS
ARE POTENTIALLY BRING.
UP A GENERIC DRUG TO MARKET
SOONER BUT IS IT REALLY ALWAYS
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
CONSUMER.
I'VE ASKED FOR EXAMPLES FROM THE
INDUSTRY AND THUS FAR HAVE THEY
HAVE NOT PRODUCED A SINGLE ONE
THAT ILLUSTRATES THE AGREEMENT
IS PRO COMPETITIVE.
YOU'LL LIKELY HEAR FROM OF
REPRESENTATIVE FROM FARMER TODAY
AND REPRESENTING FROM THE
GENERICS BOTH ARGUING AGAINST
THE BILL AND YOU MIGHT FIND
YOURSELF SCRATCHING YOUR HEAD.
SURELY THERE MUST BE A LOSER
HERE I WOULD CONTEND IT'S THE
CONSUMER.
IMAGINE FOR YOURSELF THAT A
BRAND NAME DRUG MANUFACTURER
ENTERS INTO AN AGREEMENT WHERE
GENERIC CAN GAIN ENTRY TO THE
MARKET SOONER THAN THE
EXPIRATION OF THE PATENT.
AND USUALLY THAT'S NOT THE
ORIGINAL PATTEN IT'S A SECONDARY
ONE FOR TERTIARY ONE OR ONE THIS
BEEN GOING ON THAT WERE
SOMETHING HAS BEEN EVERGREEN FOR
MANY YEARS SOUNDS PRETTY GOOD
RIGHT.
WELL NOW THE DEAL MIGHT LOOK
LIKE SOMETHING LIKE THIS THE
BRAND NAME MANUFACTURER COULD
SAY MAKE A HUNDRED DOLLARS ON
THE PRESCRIPTION.
RECOGNIZING THAT ONCE THE
GENERIC ENTERS THE MARKET THE
GENERIC MIGHT SELL FOR TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS.
THE BRANDING COULD OFFER TO
ALLOW EARLY ENTRY AT THE GENERIC
GENERIC SELLS.
FOR THIRTY FIVE THE NEAR GENERIC
WINS BY BEING ABLE TO INTRODUCE
THEIR DRUG AT A HIGHER PRICE
THAN THE TYPICAL COMPETITION
MIGHT ALLOW.
THE BRAND NAME WITH WINS BY
TAKING LESS OF A HIT.
THEY BOTH WIN.
BUT THE AGREEMENT IS ANTI
COMPETITIVE AND CONSUMERS LOSE
THIS IS A VARIATION OF POSSIBLE
AGREEMENT IT WAS ILLUSTRATED BY
THE FTC IN A HE ANY HEARING TO
CONGRESS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE YOU'LL HEAR SEVERAL
ARGUMENTS FROM DRUG COMPANIES
TODAY INCLUDING. ONE THERE IS
ONLY ONE PAY FOR TO A SETTLEMENT
IN THE F. T. C.'S A TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN REPORT ON THE SECOND
ACTIVITIES OUR THIS IS
MISLEADING.
IN THE SAME REPORT THE FTC IS
ALSO SAID THAT THE NUMBER OF
AGREEMENTS WITH POSSIBLE
COMPENSATION TO THE GENERIC.
COMPANY PROVISIONS THAT MIGHT
ACT AS COMPENSATION THE REQUIRED
FURTHER INQUIRY INTO SPECIFIC
MARKETPLACE MARKETPLACE
CIRCUMSTANCES ACTUALLY INCREASED.
TO FOURTEEN THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THESE AGREEMENTS ARE CHANGING
THE FACE OF INCREASED SCRUTINY
WHICH ACTUALLY REINFORCES THE
NEED FOR THIS LEGISLATION.
THE FTC NEEDS TO FURTHER
INVESTIGATE THESE AGREEMENTS
BEFORE THEY CONCLUDE THEY'RE NOT
PAY FOR DELAY.
SOME DRUG COMPANIES WILL ALSO
WANT GLUCK'S TO EXCLUDE GLOBAL
SETTLEMENTS FOR THIS BILL WE'RE
NOT X. ELIMINATING THESE TYPES
AGREEMENTS THE DRUG COMPANIES
MUST SIMPLY SHOW WHY THIS TYPE
OF GREEN AS PRO COMPETITIVE.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE OF POTENTIAL
GLOBAL SETTLEMENT GENERIC MIGHT
AGREE TO DELAYED PRODUCTION IN
THE UNITED STATES IN EXCHANGE
FOR BEING ABLE TO USE IN A
FOREIGN MARKET.
A WIN FOR THE BRAND NAME WIN FOR
THE GENERIC BUT ONCE AGAIN THIS
TIME IT'S A LITTLE LOSS FOR
CONSUMERS.
THE BILL BY DEFINITION RELATES
ONLY TO THE SALES OF DRUGS US
APPROVED DRUGS IN THE U. S. WILL
HAVE NO EFFECT ON THE SAILOR
PRICING DRUGS OUTSIDE THE U. S..
FINALLY YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION WE HAD A
LENGTHY DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS
AND SENATE HEALTH.
BUT LET ME ASSURE YOU THIS BILL
DOES NOT CREATE A NEW PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION.
CALIFORNIA'S ANTI TRUST LAW THE
CART RIGHT ACT ALREADY ALLOWS A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION IN THIS
BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH THAT.
WE LISTEN TO CONCERNS FROM THE
DRUG OF THE COMPANY INDUSTRY
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
AFTER EVERY HEARING ANOTHER ONE
POPS UP AND IN GOOD FAITH WE'VE
NEGOTIATED LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS WHILE ENSURING THAT
THE BILL REMAINS GOOD FOR
CONSUMERS SO MOVING FORWARD I'LL
BE TROUBLE TO LEARN ABOUT ANY
POTENTIAL NEW CONCERNS.
OF LEAD THE BILL BEFORE YOU AS
AMENDED TODAY'S A GOOD BILL AND
A MODIFY FOR THAT THE REQUEST
THE DRUG INDUSTRY FURTHER
DEFEATS IS PRO CONSUMER PURPOSE.
COST CONTAINMENT IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE AND HEALTH CARE THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED COSTS AFFECT
WHAT GOVERNMENT EMPLOYERS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY WHAT PEOPLE PAY
FOR THEIR HEALTHCARE.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR DOES JUST
THAT ENSURE THE CONSUMERS OF
ACCESS TO LOWER COST GENERIC
DRUGS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE NOW
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED THE PRICE
DRUGS BUT JUST A PRICE OF DRUGS
FOR ALL PAIRS.
THIS IS A COMPLICATED BILL BUT
AS YOU LISTEN TO TESTIMONY
PLEASE KEEP THIS IN MIND.
AGREEMENTS THAT THE LAY THE
INTRODUCTION OF A GENERIC COST
CONSUMERS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND THREATENED PATIENTS
ABILITIES TO FOR THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS IT'S A SIMPLE AS
THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE I HAVE WITH ME TODAY THE A
SOMEONE FROM THE A. R. P..
AND AND WE HAVE SOMEONE HERE
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND WE ALSO HAVE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS RUNNING A GEORGE I AM A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
SERRA I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD FOR HIS.
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
ATTORNEY GENERAL THIS ERA IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR WHICH AIMS TO REDUCE
HIGH PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS.
BY INCREASING ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST COLLUSIVE PAY FOR DELAY
AGREEMENT.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR GIVES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE A
NECESSARY TOOL TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY GO AFTER THESE
HARMFUL AGREEMENTS OR BRAND NAME
COMPANIES PAY AN ERICSSON
COMPETITORS TO STAY OFF THE
MARKET.
WHILE THESE AGREEMENTS CAN BE
ANTI COMPETITIVE UNDER CURRENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS ARE
COMPLEX.
AND THE CURRENT LEGAL FLANK
FRAMEWORK IS HAD TILTED HEAVILY
IN FAVOR OF THE DRUG COMPANIES.
UNFORTUNATELY AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHAT HIGHLIGHTED THIS PRACTICE
CONTINUES -- BETWEEN
200-013-22000 FIFTEEN THE FTC
FOUND SOME A HUNDRED AGREEMENTS
THAT COULD BE PAY FOR DELAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN STUDY THE ENACTMENT OF
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WILL
CLEARLY AND EXPRESSLY GIVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
ANOTHER TOOL. TO DETER THE
PROLIFERATION OF THESE TYPES OF
AGREEMENTS.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL BILL AIMS
TO DO FOR CALIFORNIANS -- I'D
LIKE TO TAKE A MINUTE TO CLEAR
UP A FEW MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT
WHAT THE BILL DOESN'T DO THIS
BILL DOESN'T BAN SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS WE AGREE THAT PATENTS
SETTLEMENTS WITHOUT PAYMENTS CAN.
AND HAVE BEEN HELPFUL TO
CONSUMERS ARE BILL ONLY TARGET
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS WHERE COME
COMPETITORS ARE PAID TO DELAY
ENTRY INTO THE MARKET IT IS THIS
PAYMENT TO COMPETITORS THAT
COURTS HAVE ALREADY SAID IT IS
UNLAWFUL.
THIS BILL DOESN'T EXPAND A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION PRIVATE
PLAINTIFFS -- HAVE HAD THE SAME
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THAT
THEY WOULD UNDER COULD EXISTING
LAW UNDER THE CAR RIGHT ACT
THERE'S ALSO NO STACKING OF
PENALTIES FOR PRIVATE PLAINTIFFS
ONLY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN
RECOVER PENALTIES AND THEY CAN
ONLY DO SO ONCE.
FINALLY THIS BILL DOESN'T START
SPECIAL GENERIC COMING TO MARKET
THE AIM OF THE BILL.
IS TO GET GENERICS TO MARKET
FASTER BY PREVENTING POLICE OF
AGREEMENTS TO DELAY THEIR ENTRY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON BLANCA CASTRO.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHOULD.
MADAM CHAIR JACKSON VICE CHAIR
BERGESEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ON BEHALF OF A A RP CALIFORNIA
AND THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS.
WE ASK THAT YOU TAKE A BOLD STEP
TODAY AND ARE YOU LEAD OUR
NATION BY VOTING YES ON AB EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR AND STOP PAY FOR
DELAY.
DEALS THAT ENABLE BRAND NAME
MANUFACTURERS IF YOU HER TO KEEP
PRICES ARTIFICIALLY HIGH.
PRICE IS A GENERIC DRUGS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER BRAND THEN
BRAND DRUGS SOMETIMES AS MUCH AS
85%.
AND WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE WE
ASKED OUR MEMBERS TO SHARE THEIR
PRESCRIPTION DRUG STORIES AND
I'D LIKE TO PUT A FACE ON A
COUPLE OF THE STORIES.
FROM NO WELL FROM SAN DIEGO AS
SHE SHARED THE GENERIC FOR BLOB
PLAVSIC'S COST ME ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED FOR THREE MONTHS SUPPLY.
BUT MY CARDIOLOGISTS PUT ME ON
SIROTA.
AND THAT COSTS JUMPED TO OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED FOR A THREE
MONTH PRESCRIPTION.
WHICH WILL PUT ME IN THE WHOLE
BY JUNE.
MYRTLE FROM PASO ROBLES POSSO
ROBERT SHARED.
I'M EIGHTY YEARS OLD I'M A WIDOW
LIVING ON TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT I HAVE
IN A FIB.
I HAVE TO TAKE SIROTA POSSIBLY
DIE FROM A STROKE OR HEART
ATTACK.
THIS DRUG HAS CAUSED ME TO DO
WITHOUT GROCERIES PLEASE HELP.
IT IS BECAUSE OF STORIES LIKE
THIS WHICH WE'VE HEARD FAR TOO
LONG THAT A A RP CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT.
AND I'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE OUR
FOUNDER DR COOPER'S SANDERS WAS
IN FRONT OF THE U. S. SENATE
JUDICIARY.
ON THE ANTI TRUST.
ACT AGAINST THE DRUG COMPANIES
AND THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID WE
SUBSCRIBE TO THE CONCEPT THAT
THE STATE AND FEDERAL REGULATION
SHOULD BE KEPT AT A MINIMUM.
ON THE OTHER HAND A GOVERNMENT
OF THE PEOPLE IS OCCASIONALLY
COMPELLED BY THE CRIES OF
DISTRESS CITIZENS TO COME TO THE
PROTECTION.
THE LEGISLATIVE MEANS.
SO AT THIS TIME WE ASK YOU TO
MOVE PASSAGE IS TALKING ABOUT
THE PROBLEMS LET'S AN ACT TO
PROTECT PEOPLE PEOPLE LIKE YOUR
PARENTS.
CHILDREN WITH DIABETES AND ONE
DAY MAYBE EVEN YOURSELVES.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU ON
BEHALF FAVOR A A RP TO SUPPORT
EIGHT EIGHT ABA TWENTY FOUR
ABOUT I THANK YOU OTHER SINCE
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ESPN PELLET ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
I TIM VALDERRAMA WITH THE
WHITEMAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA AND BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SERRA FLOCK
SOME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
AND HELLO GOTTEN DOLLARS ON
BEHALF OF KAISER PERMANENTE IN
SUPPORT.
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH US YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GEN FLOOR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
BRANDON MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
NO I BOTTOM -- CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
ARE COVERED WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IN SUPPORT ALRIGHT
LET'S INVITE THE OPPOSITION TO
COME FORWARD JUSTICE AB. EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS F THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE FOR SUCH A LONG DAY
MY NAME IS JEFF FRANCE SIR I'M
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AND
GENERAL COUNSEL.
OF THE ASSOCIATION FOR
ACCESSIBLE MEDICINES.
A. M. REPRESENTS THE DEVELOPERS
OF GENERIC AND BIOSIMILAR
MEDICINES IN THE UNITED STATES
WHICH CUMULATIVELY HAVE SAVE
TAXPAYERS OVER ONE AND A HALF
TRILLION DOLLARS OVER THE PAST
DECADE.
OUR COMPANY SAVED CALIFORNIANS
OVER TWENTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR ALONE AND MUCH
OF THAT SAVINGS IS DUE TO PATENT
LITIGATION SETTLEMENTS THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD LIMIT.
I'D LIKE TO MAKE THREE POINTS TO
TODAY IN MY TESTIMONY.
FIRST UNLESS IT IS AMENDED THE
BILL YOU ARE CONSIDERING TODAY
WILL DELAY THE ENTRY OF MORE
AFFORDABLE GENERICS AND BY A
SIMILAR.
AND LEAD TO HIGHER PRESCRIPTION
DRUG SPENDING MY CALIFORNIANS
AND LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU WHY.
IN ORDER TO DELIVER GENERIC
MEDICINES TO PATIENTS ARE
COMPANIES MUST EITHER WAIT FOR
DOZENS OF BRAND NAME DRUG
PATENTS TO EXPIRE.
WHAT CHALLENGE ONES THAT DO NOT
SEEM TO BE VALID?
THE PATENT SYSTEM ALLOWS A BRAND
NAME DRUG COMPANY TO GAIN
LITERALLY DOZENS OF MONOPOLY
PERIODS FOR SEEMINGLY TRIVIAL
FEATURES OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE MANUFACTURE OF
THE DRUG YOU MERA HAS AMASSED
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX PATENTS
THAT WITHOUT LITIGATION OR
SETTLEMENT HAVE ALLOWED ITS
MANUFACTURE TO GAIN A MONOPOLY
POSITION FROM.
TWO THOUSAND TWO ALL THE WAY.
TO TWENTY THIRTY FOUR A
SETTLEMENT OF PATENT LITIGATION
THAT COULD BE ILLEGAL UNDER THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW BY A SIMILAR
VERSIONS OF HUMAN ERROR AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE INSTEAD OF
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR AND THIS IS
NO TRIVIAL MATTER. FOR A DRUG
THAT TAKES IN MORE REVENUE THAN
ALL THE NFL TEAMS COMBINED.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR PRESUMES
THAT MOST OF THE PRO PATIENT PRO
COMPETITIVE PATENT LITIGATION
SETTLEMENTS WOULD BE ILLEGAL.
BECAUSE ALMOST ALL OF THEM
INVOLVE SOME TYPE OF EXCHANGE OF
VALUE TO THE GENERIC OR
BIOSIMILAR DEVELOPER THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO GET TO THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT WITNESS.
HIM STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
PROVISION THE BILL CHANGES THE
STANDARD BY WHICH YOU NEED TO
PROVE ANTI COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR --
UNDER A LAWSUIT IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T OBJECT TO CHANGING THE
STANDARD FOR GOVERNMENTAL
PROSECUTIONS BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WE OBJECT TO
CHANGING THE STANDARD FOR THIRD
PARTY PRIVATE PLAINTIFFS.
CURRENT LAW UNDER ON THE CASES
IN RECENT FOR A ONE INTO OR
CHOIR FOUR ELEMENTS IN ORDER --
TO SUCCESSFULLY PROSECUTE THEM A
AN ANTI COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR
LAWSUIT THAT THERE MUST BE A
LIMIT ON SETTLING THE GENERIC
CHANT CHALLENGERS ENTRY INTO THE
MARKET. TO YOU HAVE TO PAY THEM
SOMETHING AND THREE THAT PAYMENT
NEEDS -- TO EXCEED THE AMOUNT
THAT ANY DELAY IN THE MARKET
ENTRY WOULD PROVIDED AND THEN
FOR THE IT ALSO HAS TO EXCEED
THE REMAINING LITIGATION COSTS
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS REDUCE
THOSE FOUR ELEMENTS DOWN.
TO TWO ONE ON THAT THE GENERIC --
MANUFACTURE RECEIVED ANYTHING OF
VALUE AND TWO THAT THEY AGREE TO
LIMIT OR FOR GO PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT
MARKETING OR SALES OF THAT --
PRODUCT FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
THAT DRAMATIC REDUCTION WILL
MAKE IT MUCH EASIER FOR PRIVATE
INDIVIDUALS -- TO BRING AND
SUCCEED IN THESE LAWSUITS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT -- WOULD LEAD
TO POTENTIALLY UNJUSTIFIED
LITIGATION WE DON'T TRUST THE
THIRD PARTY PRIVATE PLAINTIFFS
AS MUCH AS WE WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR THAT REASON.
WE OPPOSE THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU DID NOT GET
YOUR OPPOSITION IN IN A TIMELY
FASHION WE WERE SENT A LETTER IN
ON JUNE EIGHTEENTH YOUR ALL
RIGHT.
CURRENTLY WE DIDN'T RECEIVE IT
THANK YOU OVERREACH NONE OF THAT
THAT'S WHY I HAD A CONSISTENT
POSITION THROUGHOUT OKAY I WAS
GOING TO ASK YOU IF THERE WAS A
REASON WHY IT WAS LATE BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE JUST MAY NOT HAVE
GOTTEN IT IT HAPPENED SOME.
OKAY.
NO NO THAT'S FINE NO NEED TO
APOLOGIZE -- ALL RIGHT OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
CAN STEP FORWARD PLEASE
REALISTIC ON BEHALF OF FARM --
WE'RE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF
BIO COM WE TO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION BRING IN
THE BILL BACK TO THE DYESS IS
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS --
AGAIN MY MY CONCERN THAT DO YOU
TRUST THE AG MORE THAN OTHER
LAWYERS BUT THAT.
INDICATES YOU DON'T REALLY TRUST
THE COURTS.
BAD LAWSUIT TO BAD LAWSUIT
WHETHER IT'S BROUGHT BY IN A G.
OR PRIVATE PRACTITIONER AND IN
FACT.
IF YOU'RE PRIVATE ATTORNEY AND
YOU'RE WORKING ON THESE CASES
YOU'RE PROBABLY DOING IT ON A
CONTINGENCY.
AND IT'S YOUR MONEY THAT YOU
LOSE IF YOU DON'T WIN SO AGAIN
WE JUST HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
WAY OF LOOKING AT AT PRIVATE THE
RIGHTS OF ACTIONS -- I LOOK AT
IT IS A WAY SO THAT THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T END UP HAVING TO FOOT
THE BILL.
TO PROSECUTE THE LEGITIMATE
CLAIMS WHEN.
COMPANIES VIOLATE THAT THE THE
LAW THAT BEING SAID -- MINOR SAY
IS THIS BILL SEEKS TO CODIFY
RECENT CALIFORNIA'S SUPREME
COURT DECISION.
THAT FINDS THESE TYPES OF
AGREEMENTS ARE PRESUMPTIVELY
ANTI COMPETITIVE AND I BELIEVE
THAT IS THE BASIS FOR THE BILL --
OTHER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MARCH IS OUR MOTION.
MOVE BY.
THE SENATOR DRAWS SO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EYE MOVEMENT.
MOTION IS A DO PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
AS AMENDED EXCUSE ME AS AMENDED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB
EIGHT TWO FOUR JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO RUSSELL
HI RUSSEL I'D GONZALEZ.
INSULTS I'D JONES MONNING STERN.
AMBERG.
NUMBER AYE WHY KELSEY WHAT HAS
HE AYE. FIVE ZERO FIVE TO ZERO
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR ATTENDANCE AND
YOUR TESTIMONY.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO BACK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LING MOANED.
OF WHO HAS.
FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN AND TWO OTHER BILLS AFTER
THAT BUT FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN IS -- AB [inaudible]
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU DO HAVE
WITNESSES SO I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND WITNESSES THAT WE ARE
HOLDING EVERYBODY. TO TWO
MINUTES EACH TO WITNESSES ON
EACH SIDE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
TURN MEMBERS AB THREE SEVENTY
PROVIDES A HOLISTIC FRAMER TO
ADDRESS BOTH PROVIDER PAIN
EQUITY AND LACK OF ACCESSIBLE
CHILD CARE.
CALIFORNIA RUNS A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR A DAY WORKFORCE BETTER
CHILD CARE OPTIONS FOR WORKING
FAMILIES DO NOT MEET THAT NEED
NOR SUPPORT THOSE WHO PROVIDE
CHILDCARE.
THIS BILL PROFESSIONAL EYES AND
CREATE STABILITY FOR FILE. FOR
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BY
MAKING QUALITY TRAINING
AVAILABLE TO ALL PROVIDERS
THROUGH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
STABILITY IS BROUGHT TO THE EASY
WORKFORCE WHEN A SOLID
FOUNDATIONIN QUALITY AND
REIMBURSEMENT IS IN PLACE AND WE
KNOW WHEN FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY CARE PARENTS ARE
MORE PRODUCTIVE IN THE WORK
FORCE AND CHILDREN.
ARE SET UP TO SECEDE LEADER IN
EDUCATION AND LIFE -- WITH ME
TODAY -- I I HAVE SOME
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL AND I
WILL LET AYE CHARLOTTE NEIL I
GIVE HER TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU I WANT
AGAIN CAUTION YOU TWO MINUTES
AND THEN I'M GONNA CATCH OFF I
APOLOGIZE BUT TWO MINUTES PLEASE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHARLOTTE
NAIL AND I'M A FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER FROM SACRAMENTO IN A
MEMBER OF MY UNION THE CPU.
PROVIDERS LIKE ME NAY COLLECTIVE
BARGINING RIGHTS SO WE CAN RUN
OUR BUSINESS IS THE RIGHT WAY
GIVE KIDS THE BST CARE POSSIBLE
I'VE BEEN A PROVIDER FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS THEY HAVE SEEN
EVERYTHING TAKING CARE OF KIDS.
IS AN ADVENTURE SURE BUT I LOVE
IT I RUN A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
CHILD CARE A LOT OF COLLECT
CALIFORNIANS DON'T WORK NINE TO
FIVE AND THEY NEED SOMEONE TO
WATCH THEIR CHILDREN.
PEOPLE LIKE DELIVERY DRIVERS
RETAIL WORKERS IN NURSING
ASSISTANTS DON'T WORK TRADITION
ON OURS THEY NEED CHILD CARE
JUST AS MUCH AS PEOPLE WHO WORK
DURING THE DAY I AM THERE FOR
THEM.
BUT HONESTLY I DO TWENTY FOUR
HOURS JUST TO MAKE IT I CAN'T
EVEN IMAGINE HOW HARD IT IS FOR
PROVIDERS WHO DON'T TWELVE OUT
OF FOURTEEN KIDS IN MY CARE ON
SUBSIDY AND I CAN TELL YOU THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE JUST TOO
LOW.
I COME UP SHORT EVERY SINGLE
MONTH EVERY MONTH I HAVE TO
DECIDE WHICH BILLS LACKEY PAY IN
WHICH BILLS I CAN'T.
I AM GOING TO PAY FOR MY HEALTH
CARE THIS MONTH OR FOOD SUPPLIES
FOR MY DAYCARE OR GAS FOR PICK
UPS AND DROP OFFS THESE ARE
EARLY LEARNING YEARS ARE CRUCIAL
FOR OUR KIDS.
I JUST WANT TO FOCUS ON RUNNING
A QUALITY DAYCARE WILL LESS
STRESS ABOUT PM BILLS WITH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RIGHTS
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS LIKE
ME COULD TAKE THE LEAD AND FIX
THAT ARE BROKEN CHARTER SYSTEM.
IS SET UP BEEN ACTUALLY THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WOULD GIVE
US MORE OF A VOICE MORE
CONFIDENCE IN MORE.
POWER TO GET ARGUES THE EARLY
EDUCATION THEY NEED AND DESERVE
THAT WOULD BENEFIT THE WHOLE
STATE PARENTS COULD GO TO WORK
KNOWING THEIR KIDS ARE GETTING
THE BEST CARE POSSIBLE AND MORE
KIDS WILL START SCHOOL READY TO
LEARN. TO GROW UP AND BE
SUCCESSFUL ADULTS AS A MEMBER OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WHO HOLES
ARE PRECIOUS FUTURE IN OUR HANDS
EVERY DAY I MATTHEW TO SUPPORT
AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT WE ARE
READY TO WORK WITH THE STATE TO
MAKE CHILD CARE WORK. FOR
PROVIDERS FAMILIES IN CHILDREN
WE CARE FOR THANK YOU. TWO
MINUTES TO THE DROP ALL RIGHT --
FURTHER TESTIMONY THE ON AIR
HERE I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SEIU
IN UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS ASKED
ME FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ONLY
VERY GOOD.
I KNOW THERE IS NO -- A
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
OF SO -- LET'S HAVE THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT COME UP NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
THANK CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BEVERLY
YOU WANT TO HAVE THE U. D. W.
ASKED ME LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY
CO SPONSORS STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
EMILY ROSENBERGER ON BEHALF OF
SEIU CALIFORNIA PROUD TO SUPPORT
SPONSORED THANK YOU.
WHICH DUGGAR WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
DOES IT IS TENDER WITH EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN WEARING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE OF ARAGON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JIM WOOD BURKE FOR THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
STEVEN WEBER WITH ASKED ME
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I KNOW THAT I MISSPOKE
THAT THERE WERE WAS SOME
REGISTERED OPPOSITION FROM -- IS
THE GROUP THE CALIFORNIA RIGHT
TO LIFE COMMITTEE ARE THEY HERE.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO UP BUT THEY
ARE REGISTERS OPPOSITION SO I
WANT TO CORRECT THE RECORD THERE
ARE YOU HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. ONE I HEARD WITH ON
WITH ONLINE ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE CHILDCARE WORKER
ABOUT ANY.
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN OPPOSITION ARE BRINGING
THE BILL BACK TO THE DYESS ANY
QUESTIONS ANY COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
IN THIS WORLD WE KNEW WHO WERE
TAKING CARE OF OUR CHILDREN HAVE
TO DECIDE BETWEEN BUYING FOOD.
ANDCARING FOR THESE KIDS AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SPORTS
FIGURES MAKING A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACTS
OVER FOUR YEARS -- BUT THAT IS
THE WORLD WE LIVE IN THE VERY
LEAST WE CAN DO IS GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK UP AND GET
AT LEAST YOU'RE.
CLOSER TO YOUR DUE THAN THAN
WHAT YOU'VE GOT NOW SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT I WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THE BILL.
AND THE LEADERSHIP THAT -- WE
SEEN OUT OF THIS YEAR ARE YOU IN
RAISING THIS ISUE AND MOVING
FORWARD SO WITH THAT.
MOTION BY SET YOU KNOW YOU'RE
LETTING HIM GET YOU GET A STEP
UP.
OKAY CENTER Y. CASKEY MOVES THE
BILL.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHENEVER.
THE MOTION IS.
DO PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT JACKSON ALL
RIGHT JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN -- BURKE.
NUMBER AYE WHY CASKEY WHAT HAS
K <c.cyan>WI. SIX ZERO SIX TO</c>
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MONN HAS
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB.
FIVE THIRTY NINE FILE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE END REGULATED INTEREST RATE
ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA HAS
LED TO AN EXPLOSION OF HIGH COST
LOANS OVER THE PAST DECADE THESE
LOANS START AT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND HAVE
INTEREST RATES FROM 1100%. TO
MORE THAN 2100% FAR TOO OFTEN
CONSUMERS ARE UNABLE TO REPAY
THESE EXPENSIVE LOANS DATA
PROVIDED BY LENDERS TO THE
SENATE BANKING COMMITTEE SHOW
THAT NEARLY 40% OF THESE HIGH
COST LOANS AND IN DEFAULT.
IN ADDITION TO THE CUT THE
CONSTANT PRESSURE FROM DEBT
COLLECTORS THIS PROCESS RESULT
IN DAMAGE CREDIT FOR THE
CONSUMER AND CAN ALSO LEAD TO
THEIR PAYCHECKS BEING GARNISH
THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS CLOSED.
AND THEIR CARS BEING REPOSSESSED
MORE THAN ONE OUT OF THREE TIMES
THESE LOANS THE PEOPLE WORSE OFF
THAN WHEN THEY STARTED I CANNOT
THINK OF ANOTHER PRODUCT THAT
PHIL SO OFTEN WITHOUT GOVERNMENT
STEPPING INTO. TO INTERVENE.
HI COST LENDERS WHO OPPOSE THIS
BILL THE THE NEED TO CHARGE SUCH
HIGH RATES TO MAKE UP. FOR THE
CONSUMERS WHO DEFAULT HOWEVER-HIGH INTEREST RATES PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN MAKING THESE
LOANS AND AFFORDABLE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THE OUTCOMES OF THIS UNREGULATED
SPACE ARE CLEAR THESE HIGH
INTEREST RATES ALLOW LENDERS TO
REMAIN SUSTAINABLY PROFITABLE
EVEN WHEN ONE THIRD OR MORE OF
THEIR BORROWERS.
ULTIMATELY DEFAULT ON THE LOAN
AB FIVE THREE NINE WILL PUT A
STOP TO THIS BROKEN INCENTIVE
STRUCTURE THE IDEA THAT
CONSUMERS WILL NOT HAVE CREDIT
OPTIONS IF THIS BILL PASSES IS
NOT REALISTIC.
THE LENDERS TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
HAVE FOUND WAYS TO OFFER
AFFORDABLE CREDIT OPTIONS TO
BARS WITH DAMAGE CREDIT OR EVEN
NO CREDIT SCORE AT ALL.
AND LET'S BE CLEAR CALIFORNIA IS
AN OUT LIAR WE ARE AMONG THE
SMALL MINORITY OF STATES THAT DO
NOT CAP INTEREST RATES ON THESE
LOANS THIRTY EIGHT OTHER STATES
HAVE INTEREST RATE CAPS SIMILAR
TO OR LOWER THAN WHAT THE BILL
PROPOSES.
I WORK HARD TO FIND A COMPROMISE
THAT COULD EARN THE SUPPORT FROM
BOTH CONSUMER GROUPS AND LENDERS
ALIKE AND EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
NINE AS A RESULT OF THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS WE HAVE A STRONG
AND BROAD COALITION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS AND VETERANS
GROUPS SUPPORT THIS EFFORT I
WILL NOW TURN MY TIME OVER TO MY
JOINT AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TIM GRAYSON WHO HAS BEEN A
VALUABLE PARTNER WITH ME IN
THESE EFFORTS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON QUICKLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR SENATORS AND TO
MY COLLEAGUE AND JOINT AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MOAN.
THANKS TO THE BANKING COMMITTEE --
ANALYSIS WE HAVE LEARNED AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT NEARLY 40% OF
TRIPLE DIGIT LOANS ENDING
COLLECTIONS ANDWHILE I'M VERY
SENSITIVE TO ACCESS TO CAPITAL
ARGUMENTS WE MUST ASK OURSELVES
OR TRIPLE DIGIT LOANS REALLY
GIVING PEOPLE ACCESS TO CREDIT.
OR THEY JUST GIVING DEBT
COLLECTORS ACCESS TO PEOPLE YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THAT THE POLICY OBJECTIVES OF
THIS BILL STRIKING GOLDILOCKS
BALANCE.
AND THAT THE GUARD RAILS FOR
CONSUMER LOANS ABOVE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL WORK ON A PRACTICAL LEVEL.
I'VE HEARD THE COUNTLESS STORIES
OF ECONOMIC RUIN AND THE STORIES
ARE ALWAYS FROM THE MOST
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
DISADVANTAGED AND THE PEOPLE
MOST IN NEED OF THOUGHTFUL
REGULATIONS THIS BILL.
IS THAT THOUGHTFUL REGULATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU -- TWO
WITNESSES PLEASE TWO MINUTES
EACH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OUT OF THE COMMITTEE.
HI MY NAME'S DARCY WHEN THE
CHEERING ON THE SPECIAL
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE GREATER SACRAMENTO.
ONLY ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S OLDEST
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS --
GOING HAS BEEN SERVING THIS
COMMUNITY FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS.
AND THE STRIVE FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS OUR MISSION IS TO
PROVIDE ECONOMIC SELF RELIANCE
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS AND PEOPLE
IN UNDER SERVED COMMUNITIES.
PAGE CRADLING HURTS OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S AGAINST OUR
MISSION.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY TO
VOICE OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY NINE WE
TWENTY MORE THAN A HUNDRED FAITH.
COMMUNITY AND VENTURE
ORGANIZATIONS LABOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND LINGERS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS HISTORIC BILL
[inaudible]
PAGE TRAILED.
LENDERS TARGET AFTER AMERICANS
AND LATINOS ARE STRIPPED WEALTH
FROM OUR NEIGHBORHOODS LESS
HARMFUL THE THESE HARMFUL LOANS
INFLAMED ALREADY SEVERE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP THAT MIGHT
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TO CLOSE.
WELL THE NETWORK OF WHITE
HOUSEHOLDS IS AROUND A HUNDRED
AND FORTY TWO THOUSAND FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS IT'S ELEVEN
DALLAS AND EVER SPEND IT'S IT'S
UNDER.
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FREE TRADE
LANDING MAKES IT WORSE THESE ONE
STOP SHOP FOR PAYDAY CAR TITLE
IN HIGH COST OF SUMMIT LOANS
TEND TO OPEN STORES IN LOCATIONS
WHERE.
HIGHER CONCENTRATIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND LATINO FAMILIES.
IN ADDITION TO THE CONSTITUTION
STORES IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
PREDATORY LENDERS HAVE UNLIMITED
RESOURCES A SPIN ON RADIO
MARKETING AND TV ADS.
TRAILER LONE SAID KAREN APR OF A
100% OR 2100% ARE NOT HELPFUL
AND THEY'RE DANGEROUS TRAPS FOR
THOSE FOR THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT UP SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE THREE NINE ENERGY TO
STAND UP FOR OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
SIMPLE YES ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE TWO MINUTES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- AS OUR GET WITH
OPPORTUNE A MISSION DRIVEN
CALIFORNIA LENDER WITH OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY STOREFRONT
LOCATIONS AND NINE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE STATE.
OUR MISSION IS FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING RESPONSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO CREDIT FOR
LOW TO MODERATE INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WHO TRADITIONALLY
SHUT OUT OF THE MAINSTREAM
FINANCIAL SYSTEM.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
CREDIT SCORE OR A MISS SCORED BY
THE BUREAUS 90% OF ALL THE
CONSUMERS WE SERVE.
LIVE IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND WE'VE HELPED OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
ESTABLISH THEIR FIRST CREDIT
SCORE.
OUR EXPERIENCES SERVING THIS
COMMUNITY IS THE REASON WE FEEL
COMPELLED TO JOIN WITH MANY
OTHER RESPONSIBLE LENDERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE THIRTY NINE THE FAIR CREDIT
ACT COLLECTIVELY THE LENDERS IN
SUPPORT OPERATE SEVERAL HUNDRED
LOCATIONS ACROSS THE STATE AND
SERVE SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
EVERY YEAR WHO ARE DEEMED TOO
RISKY TO BE SERVED BY
TRADITIONAL PROVIDERS SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SUBPRIME OR
DEEP SUBPRIME CREDIT SCORES.
SPEAKING PROPERTY WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT HALF OF OUR FIRST
TIME CUSTOMERS CAME TO US
WITHOUT A FICUS COURT ALL.
AND THE AVERAGE CREDIT SCORE FOR
THE FIRST TIME BORROWER IS WE
SERVE WHO DO HAVE A SCORE IS SIX
AWAY.
THE COMPROMISE PRICING FRAMEWORK
IN THIS MEASURE WAS VIGOROUSLY
NEGOTIATED OVER SEVERAL YEARS
AND WE BELIEVE THE STRIKES THE
OPTIMAL BALANCE FOR ENABLING
BOTH EXPANSIVE CREDIT ACCESS FOR
CONSUMERS.
AND A FAIR RETURN FOR LENDERS IN
FACT ACCORDING TO THE CBO IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY LENDERS.
MADE LOANS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
CONFORM TO THE PRICING FRAMEWORK
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL.
WE BELIEVE IN CLOSING THAT IF
THIS BILL IS PASSED IT WILL
STABILIZE AND ARE AFRAID OF
ENTERING BECAUSE OF THE
UNSETTLED UNCONSCIONABLE THE
STANDARD HERE.
ULTIMATELY THIS WILL CREATE MORE
COMPETITION AND MORE OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND WITH
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY NINE THING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE TAKE CALMLY
WITH THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PROUD SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY NINE THANK
YOU.
JUST OF THE JELLO WHICHEVER THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M REALLY RESERVOIR THAT'S HOW
YOU CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WHICH DUGGAR WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AS A THE STANDARD ACCORDS
ADVOCATES IN THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU -- MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND SPORT THANK YOU.
GREG HAYES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PATTERNS OVER HERE ON BEHALF OF
ONE MAIN FINANCIAL IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I C'MON AGAIN HERE BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF LEXICAL WORKERS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL.
AND THE WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
OF SHEET METAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAREN OVER THE SLAUGHTER COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE MORE CALIFORNIA ASKED ME IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHRISTINE ABBAS
HAMILTON YOU W. APPS MEANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRIAN FLANAGAN TO BE HAVE ONE
MARK FINANCIAL SERVICES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIEL SCHORR WITH CUT AS IN THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN RESOURCE CENTER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AS FOR SIGNS OF LIQUOR
CALIFORNIA'S FOR ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ON BEHALF OF ALL OUR
PARTNERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANTHONY LOU AND BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE SERRA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE COVERED WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BUT AREN'T IN WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOT GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO TRACK NUMBER HAVE A
CONSUMER ENTRIES CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE COULD GIVE THEM.
THANK YOU. TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR SENATORS I WOULD GET
ON A REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FINANCIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
ASSOCIATION AND ALL OF ITS
CONSTITUENT -- COMPANIES.
WE STILL REMAIN STRONGLY OPPOSED
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS -- SPLIT
MY TIME WITH MR BRAND HERE.
THE MAIN REASONS IS SIMPLY
ACCESS TO CREDIT.
AS WAS PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED AND
BANKING COMMITTEE THERE IS A
SERIOUS CONCERN REGARDING AT
ACCESS TO CREDIT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A RISK BASED
FINANCIAL SYSTEM?
AND THE INTEREST RATE IS BASED
ON THAT RISK.
YOU HAVE SUB PRIME BORROWERS.
IT'S A RISKY POOL [inaudible]
AND YOU CAP A PRODUCT AT 36%.
THE PRODUCT GOES AWAY.
DAD BEGS THE QUESTION WHERE DO
THESE BAR WAS CO BAR WAS GO.
THE NEED IS STILL THERE.
THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO AN
UNREGULATED MARKET.
WITH NO RECOURSE FOR CONSUMERS.
THAT BEGS THE QUESTION IS THAT
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
CONSUMERS [inaudible]
SO.
IN RESPONSE THE ASSOCIATION HAS
CONSISTENTLY OFFERED TO WORK
WITH MS Là MON.
MR GRAYSON.
YOU KNOW IN CRAFTING A
REASONABLE.
WAY TO CAP THIS [inaudible]
THE BILL.
NOT 36% BUT SOME WAY TO CAPTURE
THE RISK SOME WAY TO GET -- TO
ALLOW US TO MAKE A PROFIT.
AND AT THE SAME TIME PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH THE CREDIT THAT
THEY NEED. TO NO AVAIL
[inaudible]
SECONDLY.
TRUE THE LENDERS ON THE OTHER
SIDE HAVE FOUND A WAY TO MAKE IT
WORK THEY'RE CALLED ANCILLARY
PRODUCTS IN OTHER WAYS OF
RECOUPING THEIR LOSS.
IS THAT IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF
CONSUMERS.
IT'S IN I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT'S
NOT STRAIGHTFORWARD IT'S NOT
DISCLOSED.
AND IT'S ADDITIONAL FEES ON TOP
OF A COSTLY LOAN THAT'S ALREADY
TAKEN OUT BY CONSUMERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHANGES WITNESS PACER.
HI MY NAME IS EDGAR BRAND.
REGIONAL MANAGER AT CHECK INTO
CASH SO.
AND WE STRONGLY ON BEHALF TO
CHECK INTO CASH OPPOSE THE BILL
AB -- FIVE THIRTY NINE TO BE
CLEAR LIKE.
WE WERE STATE NOW IS.
THE BILL NOT HELP CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS WHO STRUGGLE BECAUSE
OF ONE REASON OR ANOTHER YOU
KNOW LUCKILY WITH ME I I OVERSEE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I AM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'M ABLE TO
WORK WITH OUR CUSTOMERS AND TALK
WITH THEM DIRECTLY.
AND BY DOING THAT I'M ABLE TO
SPEAK TO THEM AND MANY TIMES.
ALMOST ALL THE TIME IS IS HERE
THEIR STORY OF WHY THEY'RE THERE
TO VISIT US AND THEN HT THEM
HAVING THE ACCESS TO DO BUSINESS
WITH US IN GET LOANS WITH US YOU
KNOW IT WERE REGULATED.
AND ONE THING THAT I'M VERY --
PROUD OF THAT I CAN SAY IS BEING
IN THE INDUSTRY AND WORKING WITH
THEM IS THAT WE'RE VERY
TRANSPARENT WITH.
OUR WITH OUR LOAN THE RATES THAT
WE CHARGE AND WE EXPLAIN THE
LOAN TO THEM -- BUT NOT A
CUSTOMER CAN WALK INTO OUR
OFFICE -- WE EXPLAIN TO THEM
THIRTY THE LOAN WE CAN THE RATES
OF THEIR PAYMENTS HOW THE LOAN
WORKS.
AND THEY'RE VERY COMFORTABLE
WITH THE LOAN WE HAVE DIFFERENT
LOAN PRODUCTS THAT WE OFFER AND
FOR EVERY LOAN THAT WE HAVE WE
HAVE FEE SCHEDULES TO SHOW WHAT.
HOW THE LOAN WORKS WE SIT WITH
THEM AT THE COUNTER THEY ARE
ABLE TO SEE TRANSPARENTLY THE
FEES BECAUSE HOW THE LAW WORKS
THERE TOTAL PAYMENTS?
AND THEY ARE VERY COMFORTABLE
WITH THE LOAN SO.
YEAH CAPPING THAT 36% LIKE WE
WERE SAYING IS THAT THERE ARE
THOSE THERE THEY DON'T COVER
OTHER HIDDEN COSTS THAT THEY
HAVE ON THERE.
AND WITH OUR PRODUCT IS THEY GET
THE THE FULL RUNDOWN OF THE LOAN
AT IN WE'VE HAD VISITORS COME TO
VISIT US PRIOR AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SHOW THEM THAT.
ON HOW ARE LOANS WORK SO BASED
ON THE THIS IS SO SORRY ABOUT
THAT I THINK A COUPLE NOTES HERE
THAT I JUST WANT TO GO OVER IS
THAT.
WHAT'S GOING TO BE WORSE THAN A
HIGH INTEREST LOAN IS.
FAR CONSUMER IS BEING CUT OFF
FROM A LOAN THAT IS REGULATED
SITE I WANTED TO SPEAK MORE ON
PERSONALLY WITH.
HAVING THE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CUSTOMER THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE IN THIS LOAN AND AND
THE FEEDBACK WE GET FROM THEM
AND THIS ONE THING I WANT TO ADD
SO.
WITH THE CUSTOMS I WORK WITH IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA 8480% OF
OUR CUSTOMERS THE PRODUCT WORKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOU.
NEXT WITNESS WITNESSES NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE LATER
PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE IN DOUBLE
ACP OPPOSE THANK YOU.
JEFF -- COVER VERY MUCH OPPOSE
CHECKING CASH THANK YOU.
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE NASA
LOGO CHECK A CASH OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
JACK ROMERO CHECK IN A CAST
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
WHEN HE RAN CHECK INTO CASH
OPPOSED?
REBEKAH ESTRADA CHECK INTO CASH
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
MARION WERE MEDI CHECK INTO CASH
ORDER GLANCING OVER HALF OF
TRANSAMERICAN OF OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR JUST AS
ALL BAFFLING MARIN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
RACHEL SCHREIBER ON BEHALF OF
TMX FINANCE FAMILY OF COMPANIES
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PAUL BAUER ON BEHALF OF ELEVATE
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
YOU WANNA HER WITH ONLINE
LENDERS ALLIES IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MELANIE GRIFFITH WORKING TUNNEL
WATSON HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UPPER LIKE TRIBE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MANY LEE ON BEHALF OF CARE OF
FINANCIAL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
AND JR MEMBERS LAST WITNESS NOT
LEAST BALD LEAD TOLD HIM BEHALF
OF AXIS FINANCIAL IN OPPOSITION.
WELL YOU HOPE YOU'RE NOT LET NOT
LEAST AT SIX THAT'S THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
DYESS -- ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SENATOR DRAWS SO -- VERY PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL -- HERE AS
WELL AS IN IN THE BANKING
COMMITTEE.
AND I'M GOING TO SAY WHAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT OPEN MY EYES
BECAUSE IT WAS QUITE SHOCKING
WAS TO SEE SOME OF THE SAMPLE.
AGREEMENTS OR THE NAMES HAD BEEN
CROSSED OUT.
AND TO SEE THAT THE ORIGINAL
LOAN WAS I THINK SOMEWHERE
AROUND TWO OR THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THE TOTAL LOAN TO BE
PAID BACK WITH TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
JUST BLEW ME AWAY JUST.
IT'S LIKE REALLY POOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE DESPERATE.
PAIN BACK ALONE.
LIKE THAT OF THAT SIZE.
HOW DO WE HELP POOR PEOPLE BY
DOING THAT BY MAKING MAKING THEM
POOR?
AND OF COURSE YOU'RE GOING TO GO
WHERE ALSO THEY GO THEY THEY'RE
THEY'RE DESPERATE BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN HAVE RULES.
THAT HELP THEM TO GET WHAT THEY
NEED AND STILL BE SOMEWHAT FAIR.
SO -- I YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU.
OF OUR PROVIDING THE SERVICE BUT
IT'S OUR JOB IS GOVERNMENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE FAIR
RULES. FOR ALL SERVICES -- FOR
CONSUMERS -- AND THAT'S WHAT.
THAT'S WHAT I'M ALL ABOUT IN
TERMS OF OF DOING THIS AND IF
THERE ARE.
BUSINESSES THAT CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND DO THIS AT A MUCH MORE
REDUCE THAN HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
THREE UNDER PERCENT INTEREST.
THAT I THINK IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT SO.
I AM VERY PROUDLY -- IN SUPPORT
THANK IN AN ARE THAT'S A MOTION.
ALL RIGHT OF CENTER Y. KOWSKI.
HELLO THE CONSTITUTION OF
CALIFORNIA SAID SIR RATE OF USE
THREE OR HAS LANGUAGE ABOUT
THERE SHALL BE NO USURY RATES.
CHARGED ON LOANS.
IN WHEN WE ALLOW ONE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- ALLOWED THE
BANKING COMMUNITY TO IMPLODE OR
TO DE REGULATE AND THEY GOT INTO
ALL KINDS OF ACTIVITIES WE'VE
SEEN CONSUMERS HAVE BEEN.
BURIED UNDER THIS PROVISION WHEN
I WAS.
COMING TO MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
UMBERG THAT -- GE CAPITAL USED
TO BE IN FIRE SIDE ABOUT THRIFT
USED TO BE IN THIS AREA WHEN I
FIRST STARTED PRACTICING
BANKRUPTCY LAW.
AND WE WOULD GET IN THEIR FACE
AT A 15% INTEREST RATE THAT THEY
WERE CHARGING PEOPLE THAT WAS
NOT IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
NINETEEN NINETIES.
AND WE HAVE TOTALLY LOST TRACK
OF THAT [inaudible]
I 36% IS NOT A GOOD DEAL
SOMETIMES YOU NEED TO LOOK FOR
PEOPLE IN THE FACE AND SAY DO
NOT BORROW ANY MONEY.
NOBODY LIKES TO DELIVER DEBT I
DO THAT FOR A LIVING CITIZENS
OKAY FOR ME OUR DATA FOR A
LIVING NOW I DO THAT.
I WOULD LOOK.
I'M WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
BUT I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE I
GUESS I'M DOING WHAT HISTORY
LESSONS THIS WEEK IS THAT IS
THAT YOU KNOW 36% WHEN I START
PRACTICING LAW WAS OUTRAGEOUS
YOU COULD PROBABLY.
YOU COULD PROBABLY GO IN AND
JUST TERMINATE.
GET IT DECLARED UNCONSTITUTIONAL
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY IN OUR
MODERN DAY -- BUT IT'S IT'S
SOMETIMES WE NEED TO REFLECT ON
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW AT THIRTY
SIX I'M UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THAT
BUT I'VE OBVIOUSLY BEEN IN.
THIS GAME FOR AWHILE TO KNOW
THAT WE'RE LOSING SO I'D.
SORRY DON'T HAVE A QUESTION I
DON'T EXPECT I I GUESS DIG.
I COULD ASK YOU WHAT THE USE RE
RATE IS BUT I GUESS BY DEFAULT
COULD BE 36% -- UNDER UNDER THIS
SOMEBODY'S GONNA MAKE THAT
CONNECTION BUT WITH THAT -- MOVE
THE BILL.
ACTUALLY SENATOR RAZA BEAT YOU
TO IT -- BUT I WANT TO A IS
THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS ARE.
I AGREE A THE THE NOTION OF 36%
IS JUST MIND BOGGLING AND YET
THAT IS A COMPROMISE THE
110021003100% -- IS IS.
MIND BOGGLING LEE UNCONSCIONABLE
I TRIED TO DO THIS LEGISLATION
TWENTY YEARS AGO SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT YOU'VE MOVED A
LOT FARTHER THAN I WAS ABLE TO
DO WITH THE PAYDAY LENDING
INDUSTRY.
BEING INCREDIBLY POWERFUL BUT I
THINK AS YOU SEE HOW THIS SIMPLY
BERRIES PEOPLE.
THEY NEED TO BORROW MONEY FOR ON
A ONE TIME BASIS AND THEY NEVER
GET OUT OF THE WHOLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WILL
TRY TO DO AND WITH THAT -- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
AND I THINK YOU HAVE ALL HIT
MANY POINTS -- THAT RELATE TO
THIS BILL IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
BILL -- AND TO OUR CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT UNANIMOUSLY SAID
THAT THESE RICH LOANS AND
PRODUCTS WERE UNCONSCIONABLE AND
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT
RATE WAS AND SO THEY KIND OF
LOOK TO THE LEGISLATURE. TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT RIGHT RATE
IS AND WHERE WE GOT THAT RAID IS --
FROM A NUMBER OF THINGS ONE IT'S
BEEN TESTED -- IN IN THIS
COUNTRY THERE ARE OTHER STATES
WITH THAT RATE SECONDLY AT THE
MILITARY LENDING ACT.
ALLOWS FOR ACTIVE MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY ONCE THEY DISCLOSE ARE
ACTIVE MEMBERS TO RECEIVE THAT
RATE AND SO WE LOOKED AT WHERE
WE WOULD BE THIS IS A COMPROMISE
IT IS NOT A PERFECT BILL -- BUT
WE BELIEVE THAT 36% IS SO MUCH
BETTER THAN THE 100% INTEREST
RATE THAT CONSUMERS ARE GETTING --
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED -- AND AS
SEEN IN THE ANALYSIS THAT AT 36%
WE STILL HAVE.
COMPANIES THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE
THAT ARE OFFERING TWO BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF CREDIT. TWO
BILLION WORTH OF CREDIT TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THE IDEA THAT WE WON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO CREDIT -- IS NOT
A REALISTIC IDEA ADDITIONALLY
THE LEGISLATURE IS MOVING
FORWARD NEW AND CREATIVE IDEAS
I'M A MEMBER OF THE SENATE HAS.
IT IS WORKING WITH EMPLOYERS TO
OFFER DIFFERENT PRODUCTS THAT
ARE IN ALTERNATIVE TO THIS AND
THAT BILL IS MOVING THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE SO WE ARE GOING TO
SEE MORE ALTERNATIVE PRODUCTS.
BECAUSE THERE'S A RECOGNITION
THAT THIS IS A PRODUCT THAT IN
THE END TOO MANY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FAILING AND WITH
THAT -- I WON I THINK THE THE CO
AUTHORS ON THE COMMITTEE AS
CENTER CASKEY AND SENATOR -- THE
LAST SO ON AND TO THE COMMITTEE
I HAVE FOR ALL THEIR WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THERE IS
A MOTION THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE.
MA'AM SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B.
FIVE THREE NINE JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORDERS DO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ BUNDLES I'D
JONES MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN UMBERG.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY.
I KELSEY I I WILL TOO WE'RE
GONNA DO ONE MORE BILL AND THEN
TAKE ABOUT A TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
MINUTES [inaudible]
BREAK -- I'M SORRY SIX TWO ZERO
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
UP ONE SECOND IF WE COULD YOU
WAIT.
I HAVE ONE MORE.
BETTER
[inaudible]
WE'LL.
MY APOLOGIES I THINK WILL
PROBABLY TAKE A SHE A SHORT
BREAK AROUND SIX THIRTY SO WE'LL
LET THAT WILL KEEP GOING -- WE
HAVE A LITTLE THE FOOD COMING
FOR SOME OF THOSE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- SO THAT WE HAVE A
LITTLE BRAIN POWER LEFT GOING
INTO THE EVENING -- BUT RIGHT
NOW LET'S GO AHEAD WITH THIS
ITEM THANK YOUAND MADAM CHAIR
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE
WOULD REQUIRE A CHARITY TO USE
INTERNATIONAL VALUES.
WHEN REPORTING AND NON CASH
DONATIONS THAT IS LEGALLY
PROHIBITED FROM BEING USED IN
THE UNITED STATES VALUING?
A NON CASH DONATION AT U. S.
PRICES WHEN IT CANNOT BE USED IN
THE U. S. AND MAY RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT OVER EVALUATION.
PHARMACEUTICAL DONATIONS TO
CHARITIES ARE PARTICULARLY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO OVER EVALUATION
BECAUSE THEIR VALUE ON THE
INTERNATIONAL MARKET CAN BE
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR COMPARED
TO THEIR MARKET VALUE IN THE US.
AS A RESULT THE PUBLIC IS LED TO
BELIEVE THE CHARITIES MORE
SUCCESSFUL AND EFFICIENT AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE ONLY APPLIES
IN THE NARROW CIRCUMSTANCE WHEN
A NON CASH DONATION IS LEGALLY
RESTRICTED BY THE DONOR. FOR USE
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO ENSURE THAT ALL
DONORS HAVE A COMPLETE AND FAIR
PICTURE.
OF A CHARITIES OF A CHARITIES
GOOD WORK WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
TIENEN YVONNE YES AND ANTHONY
LOU WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
VERY MUCH OF A TWO MINUTE
TEACHER AT THE MOST.
I ANTHONY FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WE WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER THE
MON FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN
OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION.
AND OUR STAFF FOR HELPING
FACILITATE MANY ROUNDS OF
DISCUSSION WITH THE OPPONENTS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
BILL.
AND WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS WITH
OPPONENT AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO FIND A WAY TO ADDRESS --
THEY ABOUT.
OVER VALUATION PROBLEM WHICH I
THINK MANY AGREE IS A REAL ISSUE
THAT DESERVES ATTENTION.
WHEN I TURN MY TIME OVER -- WELL
ACTUALLY LOOMING WHEN ONE MORE
SENTENCE HERE TO OUR OFFICE
TAKES THE POSITION THAT THE
DONOR RESTRICTIONS ARE LEGALLY
BINDING AND SHOULD NOT BE
IGNORED.
BUT CHARITIES THAT ACCEPT NON
CASH DONATIONS.
THE CURRENTLY BOTH FAST BE.
AN A. I. C. P. A. ALLOW
CHARITIES TO IGNORE DONOR
RESTRICTIONS.
AND INSTEAD VALUE GIFT IN KIND
CONTRIBUTIONS USING THE HIGHEST
AND BEST USE VALUE OF THE
PRINCIPAL MARKET OF THE NINE
CASH DONATIONS.
SO AB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE IS A
BILL THAT WILL CLOSE THE GAP
THAT WAS CREATED BY THE
ACCOUNTING INDUSTRY -- CODIFY
COMMON LAW PRINCE WHAT THE DONOR
RESTRICTIONS ARE BINDING AND
WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO TANYA BUNIONS.
THE OJ.
YES GOOD EVENING THANK YOU THANK
YOU BOB MY NAME IS TINY OF IDEAS
AND ON THE SENIOR ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CHARGE OF
THE CHARITABLE TRUST SECTION.
MY SECTION HAS CONDUCTED
NUMEROUS AUDITS AND WE'VE ALSO
FILED SEVERAL ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS AGAINST CHARITIES THAT
HAVE ABUSED GIFT IN KIND
REPORTING.
ON THEY ARE USING U. S. PRICE
SAYS TO VALUE DONATIONS THAT
THEY RECEIVE FROM PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES THAT CANNOT BE USED IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THESE PHARMACEUTICAL DONATIONS
ARE GOING TO FOREIGN NATIONS AND
YET THE CHARITIES ARE USINGU.
S. PRICES TO VALUE THOSE
DONATIONS AND IT HAS RESULTED IN
RIDICULOUS AMOUNTS BEING
REPORTED.
BOTH AS REVENUE AND IS PROGRAM
EXPENSES ONE EXAMPLE WAS A D.
WARMING PALE THAT WAS VALUED AT
1000% HIGHER BUT USING US PRICES
AS OPPOSED TO INTERNATIONAL
PRICES.
UNFORTUNATELY CHARITIES ARE
TYPICALLY RATED BY TWO STANDARDS
ONE IS THE SIZE OF THE
ORGANIZATION BASED ON ITS
REVENUE IT'S TOTAL REVENUE AND
THE OTHER IS ITS PROGRAM
EFFICIENCY WHICH IS A PERCENTAGE
OF ITS TOTAL REVENUE.
USED TO SUPPORT ITS CHERNOBYL
PROGRAM AS OPPOSED TO ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE OR FUND RAISING --
ARE LAWSUIT AGAINST NATIONAL
CANCER COALITION DEMONSTRATES
HOW EFFECTIVE ABUSING GIFT IN
KIND DONATIONS USING US PRICES
CAN ARTIFICIALLY BUMP UP A
CHARITIES REVENUE.
THE NATIONAL CANCER COALITION
WAS ABLE TO INCREASE ITS REVENUE
IN TWO YEARS FROM TWELVE MILLION
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION IN
REVENUE JUST BY USING GIFT IN
KIND DONATION THAT CONSISTED OF
PHARMACEUTICAL -- DONATIONS
USING US PRICES OF THE
PHARMACEUTICAL DONATIONS MADE UP
8297% OF ITS REVENUE AND USING
U. S. PRICES THE NATIONAL CANCER
COALITION WAS ABLE TO TELL
DONORS.
THAT 97% OF ITS REVENUE WAS
SUPPORTING ITS CHARITABLE
PROGRAM WAS ONLY HALF A PERCENT
WAS SUPPORTING ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES AND LESS
THAN 2% WAS -- SUPPORTING ITS
FUNDRAISING EXPENSES AT THE USED
INTERNATIONAL PRICES THEIR
REVENUE AND THE PROGRAM EXPENSES
WOULD HAVE BEEN REDUCED 260%
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITH
DECISION SUPPORT.
ARE THESE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO WITH
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASED
TO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JIM GROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF CERTIFIED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTANTS -- SHOES THIS BILL
HAS WAS INTRODUCED WE HAVE BEEN
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND THE AUTHOR.
THEY UNDERSTAND OUR PRINCIPAL --
CONCERNED FRANK THEIR ONLY
CONCERN HAS TO DO WITH A
STATUTORY STATE ONLY CHANGE TO
GENERALLY ACCEPTED ACCOUNTING
PRINCIPLES.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW GENERALLY
ACCEPTED ACCOUNTING PRINCIPLES
ARE THE LIFEBLOOD.
OF THE ACCOUNTING PROFESSION IN
TERMS OF BOTH -- AUDITS AND TAX
RETURNS AND THE PROBLEM HERE IS
THAT THIS WILL ONLY CHANGE IT.
IN CALIFORNIA WE DO UNDERSTAND
AND RECOGNIZE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S FACE SOME VERY
EGREGIOUS SITUATIONS -- THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BUT FRANKLY
WE BELIEVE THE ONLY WAY TO
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS IT IS
THROUGH THE NORMAL PROCESS FOR
CHANGING GENERALLY ACCEPTED
ACCOUNTING PRINCIPLES.
ARE FROM -- FAST BE AND THE GAS
BE AND OTHER ENTITIES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS THE
TREE GENERAL'S OFFICE HAD THE
CHANCE TO TALK TO THESE FOLKS.
WE ARE HOPING THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BETTER
APPROACH IS TO GIVE THOSE
ENTITIES TIME TO MAKE THIS
CHANGE I'M NOT SURE THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS
FULL CONFIDENCE YET.
THAT THAT COULD HAPPEN IN AN
EXPEDITIOUS FASHION BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL SHOULD BE HELD --
THIS YEAR AND GIVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY A CHANCE TO UNFOLD
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF GEN
BRENNER VICE PRESIDENT FINANCE
WITH WORLD VISION IN THE FORMER
CHAIR OF THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE
OF CPA'S NOT FOR PROFIT EXPERT
PANEL.
AT WORLD VISION WE SHARE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE OVERVALUATION
OF PHARMACEUTICALS AND WORKED
CLOSELY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
MOANS OFFICE IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO EVALUATE AMENDMENTS.
HOWEVER THE AMENDED BILL STILL
HAS TOO MANY UNINTENDED NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES.
WE OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE
LEADERS OF THE ACCOUNTING
PROFESSION CONFIRM THE BILL
CONFLICTS WITH GAP.
THE AUTHOR WISELY RECOGNIZE THIS
CONFLICT BY EXEMPTING US GRANTS
HOWEVER CONFLICTS REMAIN FOR
UNITED NATIONS GRANTS AND OTHER
GOODS.
THE BILL FORCES CHARITIES TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN FOLLOWING GAP OR
CALIFORNIA LAW OR HAVING TWO
SETS OF BOOKS.
BOTH ARE UNTENABLE CHOICES WHICH
HAVE NO PRECEDENT IN ANY STATE
IN THE COUNTRY.
THEBILL ADD SUBSTANTIAL COSTS
COMPLEXITY AND CONFUSION FOR
CHARITIES AND OUR DONORS BY
REQUIRING CHARITIES TO DEVELOP A
SECOND SET OF UNIQUE CALIFORNIA
VALUES FOR GIFT IN KIND.
A SECOND SET OF BOOKS OBTAIN A
SECOND AUDIT.
TAX RETURN AND FUNDRAISE WITH
TWO SETS OF DONOR APPEALS.
THE RESULTING PUBLIC CONFUSION
IS ON REASONABLE.
THE BILL ALSO FAILS TO ADDRESS
OVER VALUATION OF
PHARMACEUTICALS DISTRIBUTED
DOMESTICALLY WELL SOME GOODS MAY
ACTUALLY INCREASE IN VALUE
INTERNATIONALLY.
WE RESPECTFULLY A PROPOSED TO
OPTIONS.
THE WAY THE BILL AND COLLABORATE
WITH THE FAST BE WHO SETS THE
STANDARDS TO PROVIDE A NATIONAL
SOLUTION OR SECOND WE WOULD BE
WILLING TO WITHDRAW OUR
OPPOSITION IF THE BILL WERE
AMENDED TO ALIGN WITH GAP.
WHAT PROVIDING ENHANCED GUIDANCE
TO ADDRESS THE VALUATION
CONCERNS?
WE INVITE A SOLUTION WHICH
PROMOTES GREATER COLLABORATION
UP HOLD COMMON NATIONAL
STANDARDS AND ENHANCES
TRANSPARENCY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE LET SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF
THE NONPROFIT ALLIANCE
RESPECTFULLY WE ARE OPPOSING
LESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
ERIN BONE WITH A CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BEEN IN AMERICA ALSO WITH
PROVISION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE DYESS QUESTIONS.
CENTER Y. CASKEY FROM
UNDERSTANDING THE RIGHT THE LAW.
PROPOSAL IF DRUG COMPANIES DO
NOT.
RESTRICTED USE OF THEIR NON CASH
CONTRIBUTIONS THERE OUTSIDE THE
PURVIEW OF IT.
CORRECT IT'S JUST IT'S VERY
FOCUSED VERY NARROW TO
RESTRICTED [inaudible]
DRUGS [inaudible]
OKAY.
SOME OF THE BILL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS CONCERNS ARE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO IN YOUR
CLOTHES ADDRESS THE CONCERN THAT
THE CPA'S HAVE THAT.
BECAUSE FOR CALIFORNIAN USING
DIFFERENT RULES THAT CREATES A
PROBLEM RIGHT SO -- THE WE HAVE
BEEN WAITING FOR THE NATIONAL TO
COME OUT WITH SOMETHING.
FOR TEN MORE THAN TEN YEARS AND
IT HASN'T HAPPENED AND IN -- IN
THAT PROCESS WE HAVE SEEN A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS ARISE NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT IN OTHER
PLACES SO.
WE BELIEVE THAT IF WE MOVE
FORWARD -- OTHERS WILL SEE WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS DOING WE DON'T
THINK BECAUSE THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF CASES BEING INVESTIGATED AND
ALSO FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN FOUND I
TOO HAVE BEEN CHANGING THIS
NUMBERS THAT WAITING HELPS US WE
CAN BE WAITING ANOTHER TEN YEARS --
AND IN THE MEANTIME WE DO THINK
THAT AS IS THE CASE CALIFORNIA
TENDS TO BE A BIG PORTION OF THE
COUNTRY'S MARKET SHARE SO I'M WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD THIS IS NOT
THE ONLY TIME AND ONLY PLACE --
WHERE CALIFORNIA DOES THINGS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT?
THANK YOU IN WITH THAT THERE IS
A MOTION TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE JACKSON HI
JACKSON I AM FORGES TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES NO MINING.
MONNING AYE STERN -- BURKE
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY CASKEY AYE BY.
TWO SEVEN TWO ONE SIX TO ONE
THANK YOU.
YEAH SIX TO ONE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU WE'RE GOING --
TO TO ONE MORE BILL AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A BREAK.
OF IF THERE IS SOME FOOD FOR
MEMBERS.
IN THE ROOM ONE FIFTEEN AND FOR
STAFF.
OF AND FOR THE SERGEANTS AND I
WISH I COULD SAY FOR EVERYBODY
BUT THE MY CHECKBOOK IS IN THAT
BIG MY APOLOGIES.
ALRIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD WITH --
AB AB FOUR OH THREE WHICH IS
FILE ITEM. THIRTEEN GOOD EVENING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS EIGHTY FOUR OH THREE
INCREASES THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS ARE FILING A WORKER
RETALIATION CLAIM FROM SIX
MONTHS TO TWO YEARS.
AND HAS THE ABILITY TO EEK
ATTORNEY'S FEES FOR PREVAILING
EMPLOYEES.
WORKPLACE RETALIATION OCCURS AND
EMPLOYERS TO STARS A DISCHARGE
THREATENED WITH HIS CHARS DEMOTE
SUSPENDER SUBJECT EMPLOYEES TO
AN ADVERSE ACTION FOR EXERCISING
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE LABOR
CODE.
POINTS WERE TELL YOU SHE CAN
RANGE FROM SUBTLE WORKPLACE
INTIMIDATION TO OUTRIGHT THREATS
SUCH AS THREATENING DEPORTATION.
RETALIATION IS NOT ONLY
PERVASIVE BUT ALSO A GROWING
PROBLEM TO THE CURRENT POLITICAL
CLIMATE SURROUNDING IMMIGRATION.
IN FACT IT IS TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN RETALIATION COMPLAINT
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER REPORTED
DOUBLING OF THE NUMBER
RETALIATION PLANS BASED ON SEX
RACE OR ETHNICITY FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
IMMIGRATION RELATED WORKPLACE
RETALIATION ESPECIALLY SAW A
SIGNIFICANT UPTICK FROM TWENTY
CASES IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO
NINETY FIVE CASES IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IF AN
EMPLOYEE HAS A STRONG PLANE
OFTENTIMES THE BURDEN OF PAYING
ATTORNEYS FEES CAN BE A
DETERRENT. FOR AN AGGRIEVED
WORKER ESPECIALLY THOSE WERE LOW
WAGE. TWO YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED SB NINETY SIX INTO LAW
WHICH AUTHORIZED THE COURT TO
AWARD REASONABLE ATTORNEY'S FEES
FROM THE EMPLOYER IF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
PREVAILS THIS BILL SIMPLY BUILDS
UPON SB NINETY SIX PROVIDE IN
THIS SAME RIGHT TO PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS.
TAKE THESE RETALIATION CASES
OFTEN ON PRO BONO STATUS ON
BEHALF OF WORKERS.
AB FOUR OH THREE STRENGTH AS
LEGAL RIGHTS SERVICEABLE RESERVE
FACE VALUATION AND ESPECIALLY
HELPS LOWER WAGE WORKERS ATTAIN
LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
WOULD BE TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS ROOFS OVER -- TO
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHICH
THAT COALITION AND CHRISTOPHER
SANCHEZ OF CHIRLA.
THANK YOU TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH THAT AFTERNOON I
SUPERVISE THE WORKERS RIGHTS
CLINIC AT SANTA CLARA UNIVERSITY
LAW SCHOOL COORDINATOR COUNTIES
WHICH HAVE COALITION AND LEGAL
SERVICES CHAIR.
OF THE SOUTH BAY COALITION TEN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THE LAW SCHOOL
CLASS I TEACHERS ALSO
INVESTIGATED RETALIATION CLAIMS
ON BEHALF OF THE LABOR
COMMISSION.
AT SIX MONTH RETALIATION STATUTE
IS TOO SHORT ONE OF OUR CLIENTS
AND NON UNION SECURITY GUARD AND
COMPLAINED ABOUT A HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS AND WAS FIRED
CAME TO OUR CLINIC AFTER EIGHT
MONTHS.
NUMBER BEFORE YOU GO ON WHICH
YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME.
I'VE BY NAME IS RUTH SO OVER
TOLD THANK YOU SORRY ANOTHER
CLIENT TO A LABOR A LABOR
TRAFFICKING SURVIVOR AT A
RESTAURANT RECEIVED DEATH AND
DEPORTATION.
THREATS WHEN HE REQUESTED IS
RATE WAGES BUT CAME TO OUR
CLINIC AFTER ONE YEAR IMMIGRANTS
LIVE IN FEAR OF COMING FORWARD
AND ARE UNAWARE OF THE SHORT
STATUTES SADLY THE STATUTE FOR
LABOR CODE ELEVEN OH TWO POINT
FIVE WHISTLEBLOWER CASE.
IS THREE YEARS IN COURT BUT ONLY
SIX MONTHS FOR THE SAME CLAIM AT
THE LET LABOR COMMISSION OUR
CLIENT TO SUNNYVALE ARBOR ARE
ARBY'S WORKER WHO CAME TO US
AFTER SIX MONTHS WAS FIRED FOR
ASKING ASKING FOR WAGES BUT
FORTUNATELY WAS ABLE TO FILE A
LAWSUIT.
AND SHE WAS ALSO A VICTIM OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND HIGH
DOLLAR WE EACH THAT.
THE WORKERS WE SEE TYPICALLY
HAVE SMALL CLAIMS THAT PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS WILL NOT TAKE SO THEIR
ONLY RECOURSE IS THE LABOR
COMMISSION WHERE RETALIATION
CLAIMS ARE QUALIFYING CRIMES FOR
YOU THESE AS THE LABOR
COMMISSION A CERTIFIED LIFE
CHANGING U. VISAS.
EMPLOYMENT STATUTES UNIFORMLY
AWARD FEES IN COURT ONLY TO
PLAINTIFFS UNLESS THE CASES IN
BAD FAITH AB -- FOR THIRTY WILL
PERMIT ATTORNEYS TO OBTAIN FEES
FOR CASES FILED IN COURT BUT NOT
AT THE LABOR COMMISSION
RETALIATION CLAIMS THAT THE D.
FBIH IN DEAL WELL HAVE A LONGER
STATUTE.
A TWO YEAR STATUTE IS CRITICAL
TO OUR CLIENTS TO DETER
DEPORTATION AND TERMINATION
THREATS WHEN WORKERS ASSERT
THEIR RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS TWO
MINUTES PLEASE.
THE AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
CHRISTOPHER SENSES WHICH OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS WERE PROUD TO BE A
SPONSOR OF IT BEFORE -- THREE
FOR THE MANY YEARS OF OUR
EXPERIENCE IN ORGANIZING AND
EDUCATING MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY WE HAVE FOUND THAT
IMMIGRANTS ARE VICTIMS OF CRIMES
FRAUD.
WELL AS I HAD THEIR WORKERS
RIGHTS VIOLATED IT TAKES
ANYWHERE FROM A YEAR TO TWO
YEARS FOR THEM TO BE COMFORTABLE
WITH JUST A GREEN. TO COME
FORWARD TO BEGIN THE PROCESS TO
FOLLOW REPORT OF ANY KIND THESE
ARE DIFFICULT STEPS FOR
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE MANY TIMES
INDIVIDUAL HAS TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF THEM.
HAS THE VERY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION OUT OF THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES ESPECIALLY IN THE
SETTING OF AN EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE WHICH MANY OF THEM FARE
WOULD BE USED TO READ TO BE
RETALIATED AGAINST THEM OR THEIR
LOVED ONES.
WE ALSO KNOW AS THAT SOME
COMPANIES ARE WILLING TO GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND TO THIS
INFORMATION TO INTIMIDATE
WORKERS FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN A GROUP OF
IMMIGRANT WORKERS TRAVELED HERE
TO THE STATE CAPITOL. TO SPEAK
AT ASSEMBLY LABOR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ABOUT WORKER PROTECTIONS
FOR IMMIGRANTS THEY WERE FALL
FROM THEIR HOMES TO THE STATE
CAPITOL. TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
BY BY LAWYERS REPRESENTING THE
EMPLOYER THE MARK AS BROTHERS.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT BY
EXTENDING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATION UNDOCUMENTED MENTOR
WORKERS WILL BRING CERTAIN
CLAIMS FORWARD TO THE LABOR
COMMISSION.
WILL BE ALLOWED TO FILE THE UV
SO WHICH PROVIDES PROTECTION
FROM DEPORTATION AND A PATHWAY
TO CITIZENSHIP.
IF THEY FULLY COOPERATE WITH THE
AGENCY AND THEY HAVE BEEN FOUND
TO BE A VICTIM.
EARLIER THIS YEAR TRULY
REPRESENTED THE CAR WASH WORKERS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND ORANGE
COUNTY AND FILE WHO FILED
WHISTLE BLOWER COMPLAINTS WITH
THE LABOR COMMISSION.
WHEN THESE WORKERS PREVAILED AS
A RESULT SOME OF THESE WORKERS
ARE ABLE TO OBTAIN YOU RESET IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
I'VE A?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE.
I'M SURE MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FREE TO WALLACE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND MY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JUST BECAUSE THE NUMBER HAVE
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTER INVESTOR ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL AID AT WORK AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DANIEL SHARP WITH CUT US IN THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN RESOURCE CENTER
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM -- CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO AS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF YOU'D
STEP FORWARD PLEASE TWO MINUTES
EACH.
BUT I'M SURE SENATORS BENEFIT
COME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO A BEFORE.
THREE WE HAVE NO OBJECTIONS
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HAS NO OBJECTION TO EXTENDING
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
THE ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMS.
BUT WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THIS
BILL WILL LEAD TO INCREASED
LITIGATION IN THE COURTS.
THE ONE WAY ATTORNEY'S FEES
PROVISION WILL MEAN THAT MORE
MORE THESE CASES WILL BE FILED
IN THE COURTS RATHER THAN THE
DEAL AS HE PROCESS WHICH RAISES
LITIGATION COSTS FOR ALL SIDES.
WE BELIEVE THE DEALS HE PROCESS
IS STILL IN EFFECT ONE AND
SHOULD NOT BE UNDERMINED BY
LEGISLATION THAT WILL MOTIVATE
THESE CLAIMS TO BE FILED IN
CIVIL COURT INSTEAD.
AND IT JUST A COUPLE MORE
SPECIFICS FROM THE SAME TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN RETALIATION
REPORT THAT THE AUTHOR CITED --
WHICH AGAIN THE DLC PROCESS IS
NOT A PERFECT PROCESS BUT WE
THINK THERE HAVE BEEN
IMPROVEMENTS -- IN 200-017-2500
RETALIATION CASES WERE OPENED.
THE DEAL IS THE ALSO CLOSE.
280-090-07990 SEVEN CASES AND
THE DEAL IS THE REPORT CONCLUDED
THERE WERE ONLY FOUR CASES
REMAINING UNASSIGNED AT THE END
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR WHEN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
CASES.
REMAIN UNASSIGNED -- THERE'S
BEEN OTHER RECENT CHANGES TO THE
RETALIATION PROCESS A NUMBER
HERTZBERG HAD SB THREE OH SIX
WHICH STREAMLINED A LOT OF THE
PROCESS AND HAS SOME CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR AS WELL.
THERE BEEN BUDGET --
AUGMENTATIONS FOR THE
RETALIATION UNIT SO WE BELIEVE
THE RETALIATES THE DEAL WAS HE
RETALIATION PROCESS IS EFFECTIVE
AND IF ANYTHING HAS SHOWN
IMPROVEMENT.
IN RECENT YEARS AND AGAIN FOR
THESE REASONS WERE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE A BEFORE THREE THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE HIM STONE
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TWO CONCERNS
ONE IS WITH THE EXTENSION OF
THAT.
TIME -- TO BRING A CLAIM FROM
SIX MONTHS TO THREE YEARS THAT
THE SIX TIMES EXTENSION AND
SECOND WITH A ONE SIDED
ATTORNEY'S FEES PROVISIONS FOR
THOSE REASONS WE MUST BE.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THANK YOU
NOT SURPRISED -- OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SERVICE HERE.
NOT.
NOT AT NOT EVER BUT THANK YOU
COULD TRY.
NO YOU KNOW I THINK I BELIEVE IN
OUR JUDICIAL PROCESS I BELIEVE
IN THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE TO
REDRESS THEIR GRIEVANCES IT'S
SORT OF A FUNDAMENTAL
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THAT I
CAN'T SEEM TO GET OVER -- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WHAT DO WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IF WE DO LET'S LET'S.
LET THE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MARCHING IN HEARING
NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
DIET SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KING
THERE'S NO OF AMENDMENTS ASKED
BY THE COMMITTEE BUT THERE'S A
SUGGESTION ON PAGE FIVE THE
TALKS ABOUT.
THIS TWO WAY ONE WAY --
LITIGATION IN THEN A SUGGESTION
ABOUT.
IF IT'S WOEFULLY OR EARLY
MERITLESS -- CASE.
THIS IS THE AUTHOR HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON THAT.
I BELIEVE THAT THE WAY THAT --
GROUP OF THAT FITS CURRENTLY
DROPPED IS APPROPRIATE.
ON THE THAT LANGUAGE IS STANDARD
IN EVERY SINGLE CIVIL RIGHTS AND
EMPLOYMENT LAW.
STATUTE THAT FOR INTO THE SINK
THE ONE WAY YEAH THAT THAT THAT
THE THE ONE WAY AND AS A MATTER
OF FACT.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN THE WAGE AND HOUR LAWS
WERE A TWO WAY AND THIS BODY AND
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A LAW. TO
MAKE TO EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE A
ONE WAY STATUTE AND LESS IT'S
FRIVOLOUS SURBITON BAD FAITH IF
YOU BRING A MERITLESS CLAIM OF
COURSE YOU HAVE TO PAY ATTORNEYS
FEES.
BUT IF IT'S NOT MERYL WITH MERIT
LISTED WOULD CHILL -- ALL
LAWSUIT BECAUSE AT THAT TIME
BEFORE TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
NOBODY WAS APPEALING THOSE CASES.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN ON PAGE FIVE IS
SANDERS STATEMENT OF WHAT THE
CURRENT LAW IS BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
NOT SAYING MAKING IT A TWO WAY
TO ONE WAY BUT IF IT'S?
WHAT?
APPARENTLY FRIVOLOUS THAT THERE
WOULD BE RECOVERY FOR THE
DEFENDANTS RIGHT EXACTLY AND
THAT'S STANDARD IN EVERY CIVIL
RIGHTS AND EMPLOYMENT RIGHT
STATURE EVEN IN A WRESTLE LAW.
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK THIS IS A THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF WORKERS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I THOUGHT.
VERY GOOD WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR CAN SALAS WHO'S AWAKE
AND ALERT.
AND GETS KUDOS FOR THAT WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION DO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN A
BEFORE OF THREE JACKSON AYE
JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JON SNOW MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
NUMBER I WOULD CAL SKI WHAT
HEALTHCARE BY. SIX ONE SIX THREE
ONE WEEK. SIX ONE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE --
BUT A TWENTY MINUTE BREAK AND
I'D LIKE TO ANNOUNCE -- FOR
ANYONE WHO MAY BE HERE ON FILE
ITEM FORTY NINE AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
THE BILL HAS BEEN PULLED THE
BILL WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY.
WILL COME BACK AND WE'LL START
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
HE DOES HAVE A WE'RE GONNA LET
HER SHE NEEDS GO
OUR RECESS HAS ENDED AND WE'RE
GOING.
TO SKIP HERE WITH THE THE
AGREEMENT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEEKS
WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE THE LAST
BILL -- TONIGHT FILE ITEM SIXTY
SIX AB SEVENTEEN NINETY WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THAT UP.
RIGHT NOW SO THAT WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE YOUR NEED TO GET
BACK TO YOUR LITTLE.
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS.
YOU GUYS ARE HEROES HERE IN THIS
MARATHON SESSION.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY STATING THAT
DUE TO RECENT COURT DECISION I
WILL AMEND THE LIABILITY
INSURANCE REQUIREMENT OUT OF MY
BILL AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS INJURED BY PRODUCTS
ARE APPROPRIATELY COMPENSATED.
AB SEVENTY NINETY MERS PENDING
EUROPEAN UNION REGULATIONS BY
ENSURING THAT OUR MOST BASIC
NOTIONS OF TRANSPARENCY FAIRNESS
AND DUE PROCESS.
ARE PART OF THE BUSINESS
PRACTICES OF MARKET PLACES
TREATMENT OF THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS VENDORS.
THIS BILL WILL DO THIS IN THREE
WAYS FIRST THESE BILLS ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
MARKETPLACES TERMS AND
CONDITIONS TO BE WRITTEN IN
PLAIN AN INTELLIGIBLE LANGUAGE
DESCRIBE THE GROUNDS FOR WHEN
THE MARKET PLACE CAN KEEP A
SMALL BUSINESSES MONEY PENDING
RESOLUTION OF A DISPUTE.
AND LAY OUT THE GROUNDWORK RULES
FOR HOUSE SELLERS CAN GET
PREFERENTIAL PRODUCT PLACEMENT
OVER THEIR COMPETITORS AND HOW
THOSE PREFERENCES WORK.
SECOND THIS BILLS ABOUT FAIRNESS
THIS BILL REQUIRES MARKET PLACES
TO PROVIDE SELLERS FOR THE
WRITTEN STATEMENT OF REASONS
WHEN THE SELLER'S ACCOUNT IS
SUSPENDED OR TERMINATED.
THE DETAILS THE SPECIFIC FACTS
AND CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LED TO
THAT DECISION.
THIRD THIS BILLS ABOUT DUE
PROCESS THIS BILL REQUIRES
MARKET PLACES TO PROVIDE SELLERS
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO RETRIEVE
THEIR PROPERTY BEFORE THE MARKET
PLACE DESTROYS IT.
MADAM TURN SENATORS THIS BILLS
ABOUT LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT SELL ON EACH COMMERCE
MARKETPLACES WHICH HAVE GROWN IN
SIZE.
AND INFLUENCE IN OUR RETAIL
ENVIRONMENT. FOR EXAMPLE YOU
COMMERCE MARKETPLACES EXERT A
LOT OF CONTROL OF THE SELLERS
WHO USE THEIR PLATFORM.
IT SHOULD NOT BE TOO MUCH TO ASK
FOR EXPLANATIONS IN WRITING WHEN
THE MARKET PLACES ACTIONS
INHIBIT A SELLER'S ABILITY TO DO
BUSINESS.
IN ADDITION WHEN MARKET PLACES
ACT AS THE JUDGE JURY AND
EXECUTIONER IN DETERMINING
WHETHER AN ACCUSATION AGAINST
THE SELLER WARRANTS THE
DESTRUCTION.
OF THE CELL SELLERS PROPERTY IS
ONLY FAIR THAT THE SELLER BE
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO RETRIEVE
THE MERCHANDISE PRIOR TO
DESTRUCTION.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
MARKET PLACES DECISIONS NOT A
LEGAL.
ONE IT'S BASED ON EACH
REPRESENTATIVE MARKETPLACES
OPAQUE INTERNAL PROCESS.
WELL I AM PLEASED TO LISTEN TO
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION
CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS.
CONCEPTUALLY THERE'S NO REASON
WHY MARKET PLACES SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HIDE THE BALL ON THESE TOPICS
FROM THE SMALL BUSINESSES SOLELY
AFFECTED BY THEM.
THIS BILL HAS A BROAD CROSS
SECTION OF SUPPORT FROM BUSINESS
TO LABOR AND HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IT IS CO AUTHORED BY MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
LUIS OBISPO.
AND TO DATE IT HAS NOT RECEIVED
A SINGLE NO VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY IS MARKET PRAYER
REPRESENTING THE ONLINE MARK A
MARGIN SKILLED A TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF SMALL SELLERS.
AND AT HOWARD REPRESENTING
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS USA THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU A TWO MINUTE TEACHER
IF YOU WOULD ADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAY OUT
WITH THE ONLINE MERCHANTS GUILD.
WE ARE A TRADE ASSOCIATION OF
THIRD PARTY SELLERS WHO SELL ON
AMAZON EBAY AND OTHER ONLINE
MARKETPLACES.
I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR IT -- BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS AN EXCELLENT ANALYSIS.
OF NOT ONLY WHAT'S IN THE BILL
BUT THE MARKET PLACE IN WHICH
WE'RE OPERATING.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
THAT EACH OF THE ITEMS IN THE
BILL ARE THERE BECAUSE THERE HAS
BEEN A PROBLEM THAT THIS BILL IS
NOW SEEKING TO ADDRESS.
IT IS NOT THEORETICAL LET ME
START WITH THE THE THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THAT
REQUIRE YOU KNOW A A PLANE
READING OR PLAIN LANGUAGE.
THE FACT IS IS THAT AMAZON -- IS
IT WAS DEVELOPING INVITED PEOPLE
TO BECOME THIRD PARTY SELLERS
AND TO PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
FULFILLMENT BY AMAZON PROGRAM.
THEY DID NOT PROVIDE ADEQUATE
NOTICE THAT THESE THIRD PARTY
SELLERS WERE REQUIRED TO PAY
THEIR TAXES AND NOW WHAT WE HAVE
IS A TAX -- A TAX SITUATION THAT
COULD BE IN A CAN TO ATTACKS --
AS SITUATION IN WHICH PEOPLE NOW
ARE A LIABLE FOR BACK TAXES
WHICH WILL RESULT IN BANKRUPTCY
AND MANY LOSING THEIR BUSINESSES
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
OTHER TERMS IN THE BILL.
DEALING WITH DISCLOSURE OF WHEN
SOMEONE CAN BE SUSPENDED OR
TERMINATED THIS IS NOT A
THEORETICAL MATTER THERE ARE
OFTEN TIMES WHEN THESE THIRD
PARTY SELLERS FIVE IN THEMSELVES
SUSPENDED AND DON'T KNOW HOW TO
GET OUT.
OF PURGATORY AND SO WE ARE
ASKING FOR YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE.
NOT BECAUSE WE ARE LOOKING AT
ANY SPECIAL TREATMENT BUT SIMPLY
TO ALLOW THESE THIRD PARTY
SELLERS TO KNOW WHAT THE TERMS
AND CONDITIONS ARE THAT THEY ARE
IN PLAIN ENGLISH.
AND THAT THEY ARE A ENFORCED BY
THEM THE ELECTRONIC MARKETPLACE
WE DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS AT
HOWARD WORKING PARTNERSHIPS USA
PLEASE TO SPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND I ALSO WANT TO ECHO
MISTER PRAISE COMMENTS THINKING
YOU'RE THE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT WORK AND FOR ALL OF
THEIR WORK.
FOR IN IN IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
A HEARING ON YOUR NOW SAYS ON
PAGE FIVE APTLY FRAMES -- THE
PROBLEM -- THAT SPARKS THIS BILL
IT'S IT'S QUOTED ARTICLE AND IT
SAYS FOR SELLERS AMAZON IS A
QUASI STATE ON PAGE FIVE SELLERS
ARE MORE WORRIED ABOUT A CASE
BEING OPENED.
ON AMAZON THAN AN ACTUAL CORE.
AMAZON'S JUDGMENT IS SWIFTER AND
LESS PREDICTABLE AND NOW THAT
THE COMPANY CONTROLS NEARLY HALF
OF THE ONLINE RETAIL ARKET IN
THE U. S..
ITS RULINGS CAN INSTANTLY
DETERMINE THE SUCCESS OR FAILURE
OF YOUR BUSINESS.
JOHN MEMBERS THIS BILL POSES THE
FOLLOWING QUESTIONS.
SHOULD ANY MARKETPLACE COMPANY
LET ALONE ONE THAT HAS 50% OF
THE MARKET.
LAWFULLY BE ABLE.
TO FEES AND THEN DEFINITELY KEEP
A SMALL BUSINESSES MONEY WITHOUT
EXPLAINING THE GROUNDS FOR DOING
SO.
LAWFULLY BE ABLE TO TERMINATE
AND POSSIBLY KILL SMALL BUSINESS
WITHOUT EXPLAINING THE GROUNDS
FOR DOING SO SERVE THE CHARGES
MAY BE DISPUTED.
LAWFULLY BE ABLE TO TAKE FOR
ITSELF THE UNILATERAL RIGHT TO
SEIZE AND DESTROY PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
BECAUSE OF ALLEGEDLY WRONGFUL
CONDUCT WITHOUT EVER NOTIFYING
THE POLICE.
AND UNLIKE A RETAIL STORE THAT
BUYS AND OWNS ITS PRODUCTS AND
PLACES THEM WHEREVER IT MAY LIKE
BECAUSE ITS OWN PROFIT MARGINS
AT THE STATE.
BE ABLE TO KEEP SECRET WHETHER
AN UPON WHAT TERMS THE MARKET
PLACE FAVORS ONE BUSINESS AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE OTHER.
IT IS AN UNUSUAL COALITION OF
BUSINESS LABOR AND CONSUMER
GROUPS.
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS
RESPECTFULLY NO.
YOUR ANALYSIS ON PAGE FOUR AND
SOME SHARE MEMBERS -- QUOTES THE
GREAT PHILOSOPHER STAN LEE.
GREAT POWER COMES GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS BILL GREAT
POWER COMES WITH?
EXCEEDINGLY MODEST
RESPONSIBILITY. TO ADHERE TO THE
BARE MINIMUM.
OF FAIR.
BUSINESS BEHAVIOR THANK YOU
ASKED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF YOU COME
TO THE MIKE WITH YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY -- GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS KEEP
ALLEN BEHALF CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE DO
REMAIN SUPPORT OF WITH THE RIVER
DELETION OF INSURANCE A
LIABILITY INSURANCE MANDATE
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TWO MINUTES EACH PLEASE.
THANK CHAIRMAN JACKSON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
CHARLES RIGHT ASSOCIATE GENERAL
COUNSEL FROM AMAZON.
NOW WE ARE PROUD TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
FOOTPRINT HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
WITH OVER THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
FULL TIME EMPLOYEES SUPPORTING A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SELLERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AB SEVENTY NINETY HAS BEEN
AMENDED SIGNIFICANT MATERIAL
WAYS SINCE THAT PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN IT CAME OUT OF
ASSEMBLY WE DID NOT OPPOSE IT --
BECAUSE IT WAS A VERY DIFFERENT
BILL -- AT THE TIME IT -- THE
THE REQUIRED US TO HAVE
TRANSPARENT TERMS WITH OUR
SELLERS WHICH WE STRIVE -- FOR
AT ALL TIMES -- BUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
BILL AND THESE THESE NEW
AMENDMENTS WHAT HARM CONSUMERS
IN THE VERY SELLERS THAT THE
AUTHOR INTENDS TO PER -- PROTECT
WE OPPOSE FOR FOUR REASONS FIRST
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY WOULD
REQUIRE STORES THAT OFFER
MARKETPLACE SERVICES -- TO TO
RETURN COUNTERFEIT IN ILLEGAL
PRODUCTS TO BAD ACTORS ON DEMAND.
WHEN AMAZON DISCOVERS GOODS IN
ITS?
IN ITS FOR FROM A NETWORK THAT
ARE ILLEGAL WE DESTROY THEM TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS WE GIVE COULD
WE GIVE SELLERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PURSUE TO PROVE THAT THEY ARE
AUTHENTIC. TO PROVE THAT WE HAVE
NOT MADE A MISTAKE BUT IF THEY
CANNOT DO SO WE DO IT WOULD
DESTROY THEM THIS BILL WOULD GET
BAD ACTORS A STATUTORY RIGHT. TO
DEMAND THE RETURN OF THOSE GOODS
SECOND AB SEVENTEEN NINETY WOULD
UNDERMINE.
OUR EFFORTS TO FIGHT FRAUD AND
ABUSE IN OUR STORES WE INVEST
SIGNIFICANT SUMS OF MONEY TO
FIGHT FRAUD AND ABUSE AND
PROTECT CONSUMERS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE US TO
LAY OUT IN PROVIDE ROAD MAPS TO
BAD ACTORS ON WHAT IS PROHIBITED
IT WOULD REQUIRE US TO TELL THEM
HOW WE DETECTED THEM.
IT WOULD REQUIRE IS TO TELL THEM
HOW ARE SYSTEMS OPERATE IT WOULD
UNDERMINE OUR ABILITY TO FIGHT
FRAUD AND CRIME IN OUR STORES.
THIRD AB SEVENTEEN NINETY WOULD
REQUIRE STORES THAT OFFER MARK
UP FOR MARKETPLACE SERVICES. TO
DIVULGE CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
WITHOUT IMPOSING SIMILAR
OBLIGATIONS ON OUR COMPETITORS
IT WOULD REQUIRE US TO DISCLOSE
HOW WE PRESENT THE PRODUCTS FOR
SALE IN OUR STORE.
WHICH WOULD IN TURN ENABLE BAD
ACTORS TO GAME THOSE.
SYSTEMS.
AND AND FINALLY IF I MAY AB
SEVENTY NINE IS BASED ON A
FUNDAMENTAL MISUNDERSTANDING OF
COMPETITION IN THE RETAIL SECTOR --
RETAILS AMONG THE MOST
COMPETITIVE IN AND LEAST
CONCENTRATED BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENTS IN THE WORLD BOXING
90% OF RETAIL OCCURS TAKING OFF
LAST NIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE I'M KAREN MEMBERS
COURTNEY JENSEN ON BEHALF OF
TECH MAD WE REPRESENT EIGHTY
EIGHT MEMBER COMPANY AS MANY WHO
ARE WAY.
MANY OF WHICH ARE IMPACTED BY
THIS BILL THIS BILL IS NOT JUST
ABOUT AMAZON IS ABOUT A FISH
LARGE ABROAD A NUMBER OF
COMPANIES THAT ARE IMPACTED --
SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO POINT OUT
TO THE DEFINITION OF MARKET
PLACE IN THIS BILL INCLUDES A
WHERE A MARKET PLACE SOLAR CELLS
ARE OFFERS FOR SALE SERVICES OR
TANGIBLE PERSONAL PROPERTY. TO
BE CLEAR THE BILL ENCOMPASSES
COMPANIES THAT OFFER SERVICES
NOT JUST TANGIBLE PRODUCTS AND
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS AT AS
MY COLLEAGUE HAS MENTIONED
SEVERELY WEAKENED PROTECTIONS
AGAINST COUNTERFEITS AND FRAUD
ON MARKET ONLINE MARKETPLACES.
AND WOULD ALSO REQUIRE A COMPANY
WERE TO RETURN INVENTORY TO A
SELLER WHICH MAY BE REQUIRING A
MARKET PLACE TO RETURN
COUNTERFEIT OR ILLEGAL GOODS TO
BAD ACTORS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
PRIVATE COMPANIES EVERY DAY ARE
TRYING TO AND INVESTING HUGE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY TO COME BAK.
AT THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY AND
THE SALE OF COUNTERFEIT GOODS
AND AB SEVENTEEN NINETY WOULD
EXACERBATE THAT PROBLEM THAT
WERE ACTIVELY TRYING TO SOLVE --
FINALLY AS MENTIONED THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES TO REVEAL TRADE SECRET --
ALGORITHM INFORMATION AND OTHER
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION REGARDING HOW A
COMPANY MAY RANK SERVICES
PRODUCTS OR OFFERS -- AND THE
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
DISCLOSURE PRICE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE PUT INTO THIS BILL ON
JUNE TWENTY EIGHT THEIR SEVERELY
PROBLEMATIC ARE REQUESTING AN
ELBOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE -- BUT WITH
CAL CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
KELLY HIT WITH COMP TIA AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
KELLY WITH INTERNET ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SAYING NONE
WILL BRING THIS BACK TO THE
DYESS SENATOR Y. KOWSKI.
SURE WHEN YOU.
AND COVER COUNTERFEIT MATERIALS
AREN'T YOU SUPPOSED TO TURN IT
OVER TO LAW ENFORCEMENT YES YOU
ARE [inaudible]
SO. ONE WHO TOLD AMAZON THAT
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO DESTROY IT
RATHER THAN TURN OF THE LAWN FOR
SONY ASKED ME S. THEM.
GOING THROUGH YOU MEN WITH A
CHAIR.
THANK YOU I WASN'T CLEAR WHETHER
I WAS.
BEING TESTED TO SEE HOW MUCH I
KNEW ABOUT THE SPILLED.
THE ANSWER TO THE CHAIRED PLACE
THERE'S ACTUALLY NOT A LEGAL
REQUIREMENT TURN OVER TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN WE
FIND COUNTERFEITERS IN BAD
ACTORS AND WE DO PROSECUTE --
LAW -- BAD ACTORS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS UNABLE TO
HANDLE THE VOLUME THAT WE
PROVIDE TO THEM TODAY AND IS
UNDER THE UNABLE TO PROSECUTE.
THE CRIMINALS WHO ARE WHO ARE
USING OUR SERVICES TODAY IF WE
WERE REQUIRED. TO TURN OVER
EVERY COUNTERFEIT THAT WE FOUND --
THEY WOULD BE INUNDATED WITH
COUNTERFEITS BUT THAT'S BESIDE
THE POINT BECAUSE THIS BILL DOES
NOT SAY TURN THE COUNTERFEITS
OVER TO LAW ENFORCEMENT IT SAYS
GIVE THEM BACK TO THE CRIMINALS.
UPON DEMAND.
THERE IS NO EXCEPTION FOR FRAUD
OR COUNTERFEIT IN THIS BILL IT
SIMPLY SAYS IF A SELLER ASKED
FOR IT YOU HAVE TO GIVE THE
INVENTORY BACK FULL STOP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TO MINE
JUST ENGAGING ON THAT ISSUE OF
THE RETURN AND CRIMINAL FRAUD
ISSUES.
I MEAN I THINK WITH THE CHAIR
YES.
AND I'M HAPPY TO HAVE MY WAY TO
SPEAK TO THIS AS WELL BUT YOU
KNOW IF WE HAVE A COMPANY THAT
IS THE JURY JUDGE AND
EXECUTIONER OF MAKING DECISIONS --
IT SEEMS UNFAIR TO ME TO SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO.
YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE AN EXAMPLE
SAY SOMEONE PURCHASED -- A
HUNDRED PAIRS OF NIKE'S FROM AN
AD YOU KNOW A LOT FOOT LOCKER
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS.
AND THEY SELL THEM AND SOMEONE
LODGED A COMPLAINT AGAINST THAT
AND THOSE ARE LEGITIMATE OR NOT
FRAUDULENT THEY'RE NOT
COUNTERFEIT NIKES AND THE SMALL
BUSINESS PAID FOR THAT RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW AS I UNDERSTAND IT
FROM CONVERSATIONS WITH SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
AMAZON HAS THE POWER TO TAKE
THAT IN THAT IN THAT THAT
MERCHANDISER JUST DESTROYED.
AT IF THEY SO DEEM NECESSARY
THAT'S IT THAT COST TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS WHO HAS PUT YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES INTO THIS.
WE DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR --
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT -- THE
SMALL BUSINESS SHOULD HAVE SOME
OPPORTUNITY TO RETRIEVE THOSE
GOODS I ALSO BELIEVE IF THERE'S
REAL FRAUDULENT.
ACTIVITY HAPPENING -- AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT HAPPENS RIGHT
THAT'S WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
FOR WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS YOU
KNOW AND THEY SHOULD BE ENGAGED
IN THIS PROCESS -- AND IT SHOULD
BE LEFT UP TO I THINK A COMPANY
TO DETERMINE WHAT THAT IS AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THESE GUYS WANNA.
ELIMINATE ON THAT ARE VERY
BRIEFLY PLEASE THERE'S NO
PROSECUTION AGREEMENT BETWEEN
ANY DISTRICT ATTORNEY CITY
ATTORNEY ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
I'M AWARE OF THE DELEGATES ONE
PRIVATE COMPANY.
THE ABILITY TO DESTROY PROPERTY
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS.
AND IF IN FACT THERE IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROBLEM.
WE HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ENFORCE THOSE LAWS.
SO IT IN THE CONTEXT OF A
COMPANY WITH 50% MARKET SHARE
WHERE THE AMOUNT OF COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE INABILITY OF REGULAR
STANDARD BRAND SMALL BUSINESS
PEOPLE TO BE HEARD. TO BE HEARD
THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD SEE TO
THIS POWER TO ONE PARTICULAR
COMPANIES ENOUGH WE WOULD NEVER
AGREE TO DO THIS WITH THE
GOVERNMENT THANK YOU.
MAY RESPOND ANY NO.
JUST -- IS THERE ANY OPENNESS TO
TRYING TO DISTINGUISH BETWEEN.
THE THEIR THAT THIS SORT OF GOOD
FAITH MISTAKE THAT SOMEONE ARE
TALKED ABOUT AND THEN.
THE KIND OF FRAUDULENT INTENT
BECAUSE I WORRY I MEAN THEY THEY
TALKED WITH A VOLUME CHALLENGE
WITH THE QUANTITY OF SALES
OCCURRING ON THIS PLATFORM.
IS OBVIOUS EFFICIENCIES TO WHY
THAT YEAH HERS BUT THROUGH THE
AIR PLEASE IT IS ABSOLUTELY ON
THE AT THE CHAIR IF IF YOU WOULD
JUST ONE PERSON.
WE GET TWENTY TWO BILLS ORTEGA
SO LET'S KEEP IT.
SHORT BUT CAN AND ACCURATE I'M
HAPPY TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND TO REFINED
THAT IF.
THAT'S HELPFUL THAT WOULD BE YEP.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT -- SIR MOTION.
MOVE BY SENATOR MINING WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SIX AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PORGES TO RUSSELL
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
AND I AM BURKE.
NUMBER OF IOWA CASKEY I CAN
RECALL SKI I SIX SIX TWO ONE SIX
TO ONE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'D MOVING BACK TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA HE HAS -- FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB.
FIVE OH SIX AB.
FIVE OH SIX THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT. THIRTY FIVE
OR SIX WAS REPLACE AN OUTDATED
AND INCONSISTENT CAUSATION TEST
FOR DETERMINING A CLASS DOUBLE A
CITATION FOR A LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY WITH THE MORE CURRENT
STANDARD AND DETERMINE
NEGLIGENCE.
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES A CLASS OF FIRST CLASS
DOUBLY AFTER UNDERGOING A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION OF
SUSPICIOUS DEATH AND DETERMINES
A REGULATION DESIGNED TO KEEP
THE RESIDENT ALIVE AND SAFE WAS
NOT FOLLOW DUE TO FACILITY
NEGLIGENCE AND THE NEGLIGENCE.
WAS THE LEADING CAUSE THE RESULT
IN THE DEATH THAT RESIDENT.
CURRENTLY THE LAW SAYS IT MUST
BE A DIRECT PROXIMATE CAUSE OF
THE DEATH WHICH IS A STANDARD
THAT HAS BEEN REJECTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT BECAUSE
IT IS A CONFUSING STANDARD.
THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS STILL ON
THE DEPARTMENT TO SUBSTANTIATE
THE CITATION AND RECENT MEMBERS
TAKEN PRIOR TO SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
ADDITIONALLY AB FIVE OR SIX
ADOPT STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO INCREASE LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY CITATION
AMOUNTS WHICH HAVE NOT CHANGED
EIGHT YEARS FOR CLASS BE
CITATION AND NINETEEN YEARS. FOR
CLASS A AND W. CITATIONS.
THESE INCREASES IN PENALTY
AMOUNT.
CLOSELY -- AND COUNTY NOT CLOSE
TO AFFECT THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX AS REQUESTED BY INDUSTRY.
AB FIBROSIS IS CRITICALLY%
IMPORTANT PROTECTING THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY THE THOUSANDS OF AGE
DEVELOPING DISABLED OR OTHER.
A MEDICALLY VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
BY HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE THOSE FEW
BAD ACTORS FOUND RESPONSIBLE FOR
RESIDENTS HARM OR DEATH.
WOULD BE TO REVISE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS CREEK CHILD SOME
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU A HINT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
ORANGE THE I VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHTS WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
YOU HAVE REMOVED ALL THE
OPPOSITION APPRECIATE THE WORK
IN DOING SO.
THE MOTION -- IS TO PASS. TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB FIVE
OR SIX JACKSON HIGH JACKSON AYE
PORGES TO RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN I AMBER.
AMBER I Y. CASKEY BECAUSE HE AYE
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN TWO ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN WELL DONE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
HIS -- ONE OTHER ITEM AB --
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
FORTY YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ONCE AGAIN --
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS CONCLUDED CHARTER
CITIES AND STATING INTENT TO
ENSURE HEALTH AND SAFETY.
OF DISPENSERS THE PROLIFERATION
OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC WASTE IS
HAVING A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON
OUR ENVIRONMENT AN OVERWHELMING
LANDFILLS.
THOSE TINY PLASTIC SHAMPOO AND
CONDITIONER BOTTLES ARE A COMMON
HOTEL ROOMS REPRESENT A SIZEABLE
AMOUNT OF WAYS THAT CAN BE
EASILY ELIMINATED. TO MORE COST
EFFECTIVE AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY ALTERNATIVES.
ASSEMBLY BILL THAT IS SIXTY TWO
WOULD RESTRICT HOTELS AND OTHER
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS REPLACING
SMALL SINGLE USE BOTTLES OF
SHAMPOO CONDITIONER ABOUT SOAP
IN GUEST ROOMS.
OR BATHROOMS BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE FOR LARGE HOTELS
AND GENERATE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
FOR HOTELS WITH A FIFTY ROOMS
ARE LESS.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE FACT THAT
EACH ROOM CAN GENERATE UP TO ONE
THOUSAND TINY BOTTLES PER YEAR --
THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC WEEK
WASTED DECIBEL LAMP WAS REMOVING
A SIGNIFICANT AS MUCH AS A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR JUST IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE.
ALSO IT IS NOT FEASIBLE FOR
THESE PLASTIC BOTTLES BE MANAGED
RECYCLED BECAUSE THEIR SMALL
SIZE AND RESIDUAL PRODUCT LEFT
IN THE BOTTLES WHEN.
THE AVERAGE USE OF THE AT THE
CONTENTS IS AROUND 30% AND A
BOTTLE.
SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO SUPPORTED BY
THE HOTEL INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THERE'S VALUE IN A STATE
STANDARD THAT HOTEL BRANDS
COMPLY WITH.
AND THE INDUSTRY'S ALREADY
PROVING TO BE A LEADER IN THIS
AREA WITH ME IN SUPPORT AS JOHN
CALL ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
HOTEL AND LODGING ASSOCIATION
AND I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU A HINT
THERE'S NO KNOWN OPPOSITION.
ON CALDWELL CALIFORNIA HOTEL
LODGING ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL VERY GOOD ANY.
THANK YOU ANY ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OTHER WITNESSES.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS
CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU VERY BRIEFLY I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD -- THE CITY OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY COUNTY OF
SANTA CRUZ HAS IMPLEMENTED.
NO MOTELS HOTELS HAVE GONE OUT
OF BUSINESS.
IT CONTINUES TO BE A NUMBER ONE
TOURIST DESTINATION ON THE
MODERATE EIGHT WAIT A SECOND TO
A ROOM ON I'M SORRY.
THINGS TOGETHER TO REMOTE I'M
GLAD TO CONFIRM OR DENY THAT
SAYS AND I CAN ATTEST TO THE
FACT THAT IT WORKS.
AND SEEM ANIMALS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS.
ALL RIGHT OF ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS ANYONE HAVE OF THE
SORRY TO MAKE A MOTIONS.
SENATOR UMBERG THANK YOU SIR OF
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND INTO THE
CENTER MONIES BY DO WANT TO
THANK US IN NUMBER STONE -- AS
WELL AS SUPERVISOR A FRIEND FROM
SANTA CRUZ -- FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BY SENATOR NUMBER.
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY AB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO JACKSON JACKSON AYE
BORDERS TO RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES JONES
NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN I AM
BURKE.
HI NUMBER I WOULD CAL SKI WERE
CASKEY I SIX TO ONE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE APPS
MEMBER THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER.
AND NEXT -- WE HAVE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
BURKE BURNER HAVE FOR BETH WHO
ACTUALLY.
IS A LITTLE FARTHER DOWN ON THE
LIST BUT YOU GOT HERE SO YOU'RE
OFF.
THE EARLY BIRD CATCHES THE WORM.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'D CALL 720- PM
EARLY BUT IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
ONLY ONE HERE SO HAPPY GREAT.
OUR HIT VERY GOOD FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO NOT AB.
NINE THIRTY ONE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL I
LIKE TO THINK -- MADAM CHAIR AND
HER STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
THE MOMENT SOME AND WE ARE HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND THEY'RE VERY VERY
POWERFUL ANYTHING REALLY ADDRESS
SOME OF THE OTHER CONCERNS WE'VE
HEARD IN OTHER COMMITTEES -- AS
YOU KNOW WOMEN HAVE FACED A
STARK DISCRIMINATION AND
POLITICAL SPACES AND AB NINE
THIRTY ONE IS NARROWLY TAILORED
TO JUST ADDRESS THE STORK IN A
INEQUALITY.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY ONE INCREASES THE
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN ON
PUBLIC LOCAL NON ELECTED NON
SALARIED APPOINTED BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS.
IN CITIES OVER FIFTY THOUSAND BY
REQUIRING THE FOLLOWING.
REQUIRES CITIES SHOULD NOT
APPOINT MEMBERS WITH FIVE OR
MORE SEATS WITH THE SAME GENDER
IDENTITY TO OCCUPY MORE THAN 60%
OF SEATS ON THE BOARD.
THE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS WITH
FOUR OR FEWER SEATS NOT BE
COMPRISED EXCLUSIVELY OF
INDIVIDUALS OF THE SAME GENDER
IDENTITY.
EXEMPTS BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
THAT A PRIMARY PURPOSE OF
ADDRESSING ISSUES.
OF ELEVANCE TO A PARTICULAR
GENDER IDENTIT.
AB NINE THIRTY ONE HAS A SUNRISE
DAY OF TWENTY THIRTY GIVING
LOCAL CITIES OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE A DECADE TO RECRUIT AND
ENCOURAGE MORE QUALIFIED WOMEN.
OUT ON THEIR LOCAL POINTED
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA MAKE UP 52%
OF THE POPULATION.
AND SAYS IT CITIES A FIFTY
THOUSAND OR MORE THEY OFTEN
COMPRISING EVEN HIGHER
PERCENTAGE WELL WOMEN HAVE MADE
CONSIDERABLE ADVANCES IN THE
WORK FORCE.
IN RECENT YEARS THEY STILL FACE
INEQUITIES THAT OFTEN PREVENT
THEM FROM REACHING THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL FOR EXAMPLE WOMEN TO
THIS DAY REMAIN VASTLY
UNDERREPRESENTED.
UNDER REPRESENTED ON APPOINTED
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT WITHIN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
AND ENCINITAS WERE SERVED ON THE
PLANNING COMMISSION WHEN I GOT
ON I WAS THE ONLY WOMAN.
I WOULD LEFT BECAME A COUNCIL
MEMBER.
MY SUCCESSOR WAS A WOMAN.
SHE WAS THE ONLY WOMAN SHE LEFT
BECAME A COUNCIL MEMBER WHEN I
GOT ELECTED THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND NOW IT'S AN ALL MALE BOARD.
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE SHARED
RECENTLY THAT WHILE SHE WAS IN.
LOOKING FOR TO RUN FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHE WAS TOLD SHE
COULD NOT BE ON THE PLANNING
COMMISSION OF OUR CITY.
BECAUSE AS A WOMAN THE IMPORTANT
LEADERSHIP POSITION WITH THE
DIRE OFFICE AND THEY DIDN'T
APPOINT WOMEN.
THIS IS WHY THIS BILL ENJOYS
SUPPORT OF THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S
POLITICAL CAUCUS AND MANY OF ITS
LOCAL CHAPTERS THE STATE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS.
AND EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AMONG
OTHER GROUPS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS I THINK THAT THEY
REALLY HELP -- FRAME THE BILL IN
A WAY THAT IS CONSTITUTIONAL
APPROPRIATE.
RECOGNIZING THE NEED TO HAVE
GREATER GENDER PARITY WITHOUT
IDENTIFYING A MAJORITY OF ONE OR
THE OTHER AND I THINK THAT THAT
WILL.
HELP YOU IN A LOT GO A LONG WAY
IN THIS BILL -- SO WITH THAT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WILL BRING BACK TO THE
DíAS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ IS MOVE
THE BILL.
SENATOR EXCUSE ME THAT'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT'S SENATOR
I'M.
ALL RIGHT IT'S GETTING LATE GOSH
ONLY KNOWS I HOPE IT'S NOT.
DOESN'T GET TOO MUCH WORSE BUT
AT ANY RATE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AND LET'S GO
AHEAD AND TO CALL THE ROLL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON BY
JACKSON AYE BORDERS RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES.
JONES NO MONNING MONNING AYE
STERN.
STERN AYE AMBERG.
WHITE HOUSE E. MICHAEL SKI I
FOUR ONE FOUR TO ONE WHO WILL
HOLD THAT -- BILL OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
AND MISTER RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
WE TRIED.
OF THIS IS FILE ITEM -- THIRTY
ONE AB NINE ONE ONE THAT'S
THAT'S VERY WELL DONE.
BY HIM I SUSPECT YOU HAD STAFF
PERSON STATE HEAD HANGING OUT AT
THE DESK TO TO GET TO AND THAT
NUMBER WAS A JUST SERENDIPITY
YOU'RE JUST LIBERAL BOTH A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT A LITTLE BIT OF
BOTH OF COURSE ALL RIGHT -- BUT
PLEASE PROCEED BUT I'M SURE
MEMBERS -- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB.
NINE ELEVEN I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK.
THIS MEASURES A FIRST STEP
TOWARD ESTABLISHING A SMART NINE
ONE ONE STATEWIDE SYSTEM WHICH
WILL ENABLE PERSONS TO VOLUNTARY
CEMENT VITAL HEALTH INFORMATION
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR FOR FOR
SPONSORS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER
ADULTS OR PERSON WITH MOBILITY
SENSORY.
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL AND
OR MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONSIDERED AT RISK HAVE UNIQUE
NEEDS.
AND REGULATORY REQUIRE SPECIAL
ACCOMMODATIONS ESPECIALLY DURING
CASES OF EMERGENCY OR THEY MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
CLEARLY WITH FIRST PONDERS.
IN ORDER TO BEST SERVE AT RISK
INDIVIDUALS AND MINIMIZE THE
RISK OF INJURY.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT OFFERS
RESPOND HERS FIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT EMS.
BE PROVIDED WITH A PERSON'S
BETTER HEALTH INFORMATION PRIOR
TO ARRIVING ON SCENE.
HEALTH INFORMATION WOULD INCLUDE
KNOWN MEDICAL MEDICAL CONDITIONS
OF MEDICATIONS AND EMERGENCY
CONTACTS.
EACH BEING A CRITICAL PIECE OF
INFORMATION FOR FIRST RESPONDERS.
MEMBERS THIS WILL BE SYSTEM THAT
WILL HELP KEEP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA SAFER.
AND BETTER PREPARE FOR FOR
SPONSORS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
ASTRAZENECA VICE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT.
OF U. D. W. WHO REPRESENTS HOME
HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
THANK YOU AND I'D LIKE TO GIVE
YOU A HINT AS WELL THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION SO IF YOU KEEP IT
BRIEF.
THANK MEMBERS AND AN EPIC MEDIA
MADAM CHAIR -- AGAIN MY NAME IS
**** IN AGAIN EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF UT W. WE REPRESENT
OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
HOME CARE PROVIDERS WHO.
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY AND
DISABLED IN THE COMMUNITY WHO
WOULD MOST LIKELY USE THE SYSTEM --
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I AM ALSO
THE MOTHER OF A CHILD WITH A
DISABILITY WHOSE NAME IS MANNY.
AND IS NAMED AFTER THE BILL THE
BILL IS NAMED AFTER AND I WILL
RESPECTFULLY.
STOP THERE AND IT'S A VERY GOOD
LEASES.
YES THANK YOU.
THERE'S A MOTION -- ANYWHERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF
YOU'D STEP FORWARD.
RACHEL WALLACE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE NEUTRAL AS
AMENDED WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR STAFFING COMMITTEE FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THAT
WE WILL BE NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THE MEMBER CALIFORNIA'S MAIN
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MARCHING NONE BRING BACK TO THE
DYESS ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
AND THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER I ASSUME
YOU'RE ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
YES ARE STRICTLY OUT FROM A VERY
GOOD ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS -- AM SICK TREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY ONE A. B. NINE ONE
ONE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
ROSSEL GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I'D JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN I BURKE WHY CASKEY RIGHT
HAS HE I SIX ZERO SIX TWO ZERO
WILL PLACE THAT MATTER ON CALL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
OF FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE AB.
SEVEN TO NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD EVENING.
A DENTURE AND SENATORS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB SEVEN TWO NIGHT
THE BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE THE
STATE THE TOOL TO ADDRESS
DEFICIENCY IN THE CARPET STORE
SHOULD PROGRAM.
AN IMPROVING INCENTIVE FOR
CUSTOMERS TO BUY EASIER TO
RECYCLE CARPET OR COP WHO WAS A
RECYCLED MATERIAL CONTENT.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL ARE SIMPLE
WE WANT TO GIVE CAL RECYCLED THE
TOOL. TO OVERSEE THE PROGRAM TO
MEET OUR STATE RECYCLING GOALS
SPECIFICALLY DOES WILL ALLOW FOR
A BRIDGE PLAN.
INDIA CASE ALMOST ISSUE
ORGANIZATIONS CEASES OPERATION
OR OF MAN IS DISAPPROVED.
A DV TO TO PROTECT THE CONSUMER
FEES AND CONTINUE RECYCLING THIS
BILL REQUIRED TO TRANSFER OF TO
AN EXPANDED.
THE CONSUMER FEES TO THE DEPOSIT.
INTO TRUSTS OR ESCROW TO
CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM.
DUE TO A HISTORY OF NON
COMPLIANCE WITH IS THE
REQUIREMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE RESOURCES RECYCLE AND
RECOVERY ALL CAL RECYCLE NEED
THE LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
TO MEET CALIFORNIA RECYCLING
GOAL. TO DO THIS AB SEVEN TWO
NIGHT INCREASED TO SITTING. FOR
THE CIVIL PENALTY FROM ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PER DAY TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PER DAY TO ALLOW
CAL RECYCLE TO DETER FUTURE.
OF VIOLATIONS IN ADDITION DUE TO
THE SIGNIFICANT CAL RECYCLE
STAFF TIME AND RESOURCES
UTILIZED TO HELP BRING AND DOES
PROGRAMMING INTO COMPLIANCE.
DURING THE THREE ALL OF THE
SEVEN YEARS SINCE TWO CREATION
OF THE PROGRAM.
THE CALLS HAVE EXCEEDED
DESTRUCTION -- RE 5% CAP ON
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE.
SO THE RESULT TO RECYCLING
SHIFTING RESOURCES TO SUBSIDIZE
TO COPPER PROGRAM.
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL REMOVED A
CAB AT ALLOW CAL RECYCLE TO LEVY --
QUARTERLY FEE THAT MR FULL
ADMINISTRATIVE AND FORSMAN CALLS
OFF THIS PROGRAM.
FINALLY THIS BILL DIRECTORS
DISTORT ISSUE ORGANIZATION TO
IMPLEMENT A DIFFERENTIAL
ASSESSMENT.
THERE WOULD INCENTIVIZE THE
CONSUMERS TO BUY EASIER TO
RECYCLE AND CRPET MAY OF
RECYCLED CONTENT IN THE
MARKETPLACE.
THANK YOU I THE ISSUE BEFORE US
IS THE INCREASE IN THE FINE SO
I'D LIKE TO LEAVE A IN FOCUS OUR
ATTENTION ON THAT ISSUE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BUT AGAIN THAT IS
THE FOCAL POINT OF THIS BILL SO --
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IF WE COULD HAVE YOU
STEP FORWARD.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD [inaudible]
TO AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE FOCUS
ON THE QUESTION OF INCREASING
THE FINE.
MADAM CHAIR RAINY POLLOCK IN
BEHALF OF THE CARPET AND RUG
INSTITUTE WHICH IS ASSOCIATION
MADE UP OF MANUFACTURES OF
CARPET.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE SECTION OF
THE BILL TWO OF THEM DOING WITH
DIFFERENTIAL WHICH I WON'T BRING
UP TODAY BUT THE FINES INCREASES
FROM ONE THOUSAND TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WITHOUT SHOWING
ANY NEGLIGENCE.
AND INTENTIONAL MISCONDUCT A
WRONGFUL MISCONDUCT WE WE THAT
THE CURRENT FINDS THAT ARE IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW OF THE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE BELIEVE THAT IS A
APPROPRIATE.
I IN THE PAST THERE HAS BEEN A
MINISTRY TO LAW JUDGES DECISIONS
AGAINST CARE HOWEVER IN EVERY
INSTANCE THOSE.
FINES WERE REDUCED BECAUSE WAS
NEVER ANY FINDING OF NEGLIGENCE
WRONGFUL MISCONDUCT AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS MORE OF A
PUNITIVE MEASURE ON THE PART OF
CAL RECYCLING TRYING TO INCREASE
THE FINES.
BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT ACHIEVE
THROUGH THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE PROCESS THE FINES THAT
THEY REALLY WANTED TO IMPOSE AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A PLEASE GO AHEAD
MIGHT MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF
OF MOHAWK INDUSTRIES CARPET
MANUFACTURED MEMBER OF THE OF
CARE THE STEWARDSHIP
ORGANIZATION CREATE.
THIS COMMITTEE TAKING THE TIME
TO TO HEAR THE MERITS OR LACK OF
MERIT OF OF INCREASING THAT THE
FINE AUTHORITY OF CAL RECYCLE IN
THIS IN THIS MANNER -- AS AS
METROPOLITAN REPORT -- RECOGNIZE
NOTED -- THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL IN THE AUTHOR BELIEVE THAT.
INCREASING CIVIL PENALTIES
AGAINST CARE WOULD SOMEHOW
CREATE NEW MARKETS I THINK FOR
FOR FOR REFER RECYCLE MATERIAL --
WHAT WHAT RAINY DIDN'T POINT OUT
IS THAT WHEN THIS MYSTERY LODGES
HAVE REDUCE PREVIOUS FINES
LEVIED AGAINST CARE -- THE
MINISTRY LAW JUDGES NOTED THAT
THEY CARE THE CARE IS EVEN MORE
OF A OF A VICTIM OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE RECYCLING
THE WORLD RIGHT RECYCLING
MARKETS AND NOT OF ANY IN THE
EIGHTY S. -- MALICIOUS INTENTION
AND IN FAILING TO MEET THEIR
THEIR OWN SELF IMPOSED GOALS AND
WE DON'T.
JUST ADD ONE MORE THING IS THAT --
YOU KNOW GET ITS CARE SELF
IMPOSED PLAN THEIR GOAL TO ME
224% RECYCLING RATE.
AND THEIR PROGRESS GOING UP TO
DO THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING
THAT.
SELF IMPOSED GOALS OF FREEDOM
AND LEVY FINES FOR NOT MEETING
SELF IMPOSED GOALS IT'S IT'S
SOMETHING IS WORTH NOTING THAT
CARRY CYCLE HAS A SELF IMPOSED
GOAL OF 75% RECYCLING BY THE
YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY AND SINCE THEY
MADE THAT GOAL THE WRIST THE
OVERALL RECYCLING RATES ACTUALLY
GONE DOWN SO THEY'RE THEY'RE THE
SAME VOTE AS CARE IS IN THAT
THIRD THERE'S A WORLDWIDE.
PROBLEM OF RECYCLING MARKETS IN
RATHER THAN GIVE CASH.
RECYCLE MORE AUTHORITY TO FIND
CARE WE JUST ASK THAT YOU YOU'LL
LET CARE WORK AND FIND MY
MARKETS IN AND DO WHAT THEY'RE
DOING THEY'RE RECYCLING RATE IS
INCHING UP.
OPPOSITION.
BENJAMIN PALMER ON BEHALF OF
SHAW INDUSTRIES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION BRING IT BACK TO THE
DYESS I'D LIKE OUR EXPERT ON
RECYCLING AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS OR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
WHY?
I THINK AS I READ THE BILL MADAM
CHAIR THAT IT JUST GIVES THE
AUTHORITY THE CALORIE CYCLE TO
GO UP. TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
YOU DON'T HAVE TO IMPOSE A FINE
OF FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IT WAS
TRIGGERED BY THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES -- DETERMINATION THAT
A MORE APPROPRIATE FINE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WAS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED SO I DON'T KNOW FOR
GOING TO SEE A BIG.
JUMP.
AT LEAST.
IN THIS IN THIS COMMITTEE THE
RECYCLE THE VIRAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE HAS A HAD A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON THIS ON THE
RECYCLING SEPARATE JUST WITH THE
FINES IT SEEMS TO BE IN LINE
WITHOUT OTHER FINE SIEVE.
HAVE WE'VE INCREASED THE
AUTHORITY IN OTHER AREAS SO.
AND IT DOESN'T NOTHING JUMPS OUT
OF ME IS BEING.
THANK RAGES RISHI EIGHT THAT.
OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IS OUR MOTION.
MOVED BY CENTER Y. KOWSKI.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE BE
SEVEN TWENTY NINE JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE A BORDERS TO RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ.
HI GONZALEZ I'D JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I BURKE.
WHAT CAL SKI WHAT HEALTHY I? FOR
THE ACCOUNT IS FIVE TO ONE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
YOU HAVE I BELIEVE ANOTHER ITEM
UP.
IT IS FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX AB
EIGHT HUNDRED AND WHO SANG HOME
A DENTURE THEN CENTERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
HUNDRED A BILL WHICH WILL ALLOW
PARTICIPATION IN THE SAFE AT
HOME PROGRAM. TO FILE COURT
DOCUMENT AS JANE AND JOHN DOE.
DOES THE SAVIOR HOME PROGRAM
ALLOW VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE STALKING OR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. TO USED TO
SECRETARY OF THE STATE ADDRESS
ON THEIR PUBLIC RECORD IN ORDER
TO PREVENT POTENTIAL OF CITY
GLAM FROM A FINDING THEM.
THE PROPOSAL BUT ABA HUNDREDS TO
ALLOW PROGRAM PARTICIPANT TO
EXTEND TO YOUR CONFIDENTIALITY
AND ALLOW FILING COURT MATTERS
WITH ALL FEAR.
THAT THE PARTICIPANTS NAME WILL
APPEAR ON THE PUBLIC RECORD THE
COURT RECORD.
AB EIGHT HUNDRED WILL EXPAND
THIS SAFETY NET OF PRIVACY
OFFERING THE SAFE AT HOME
PROGRAM.
AND AND GIVE PARTICIPANT A BACK
TO RIGHT SO MANY OF US TAKE FOR
GRANTED TO BE ABLE TO HELP THEIR
DAYS IN COURT.
STILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
MUCH OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THIS ITEM.
YOUR CALL SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF YOU'D
STEP FORWARD TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CRAIG PAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT THE
TITLE INSURANCE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE OF THE
INTENT OF THE BILL BUT THE
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE -- SPECIFIC
TO RECORDED DOCUMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF A COURT
DOCUMENTS THAT WOULD BE THAT WE
AND INTERPRET THROUGH THIS BILL
THAT WOULD HAVE MAYBE SET UP
SOME OF SYNONYMIZED.
WERE FICTIONALIZED NAMES ON THEM
AND THE THING THAT HAPPENS TO GO
INTO THE RECORDING PROCESS WERE
FREE TO THE TILE INDUSTRY WILL
NOT PICK THESE UP.
IN FOR CHILD SUPPORT -- WILL --
JUDGMENT LEANS OTHER LEANS OTHER
DOCUMENTS IN WHICH WE NEED THE
REAL NAME.
AND THE TITLE INDUSTRIES BIB
UNDER -- THE DEPARTMENT CHARTS
FOR COLLECTION SERVICES IS
COLLECTED AT THE FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN CHILD
SUPPORT A YEAR.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS WE DO IT IS
THROUGH DOCUMENTS LIKE THIS.
AND WERE WERE AFRAID THAT THE
PROTECTED PERSONS AND UNDER THIS
BILL WOULD PROBABLY OFTEN BE THE
ONES THAT WOULD BE PROBABLY MOST
ADVERSELY IMPACTED.
IN PROBABLY IN TRYING TO GET
CHILD SUPPORT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET MAYBE A MONEY JUDGMENT
AGAINST AN AXE AND SO WE WITH.
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A SPECIFIC
CAR ABOUT IN HERE FOR RECORDED
DOCUMENTS IN A TALK TO THE TO
THE AUTHORS OFFICE ABOUT IT
THAT'S THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THEY WERE LOOKING.
FOR THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE BELOW
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ESCROW
ASSOCIATION WERE POSE AND LESS
AMENDED I THINK THE CHIEF
COUNSEL'S ANALYSIS TONIGHT NICE
JOB OF THE TENSION BETWEEN.
KEEPING PEOPLE'S INFORMATION
PRIVATE WHO DESERVE PROTECTION
BUT SOME OF THESE DOCUMENTS
COMING OUT OF A COURT THAT ARE A
JUDGMENT THAT WILL HAVE YOU NEED
YOU NEED TO HAVE A JUDGMENT
CREDITOR AND A JUDGMENT DEBTOR
THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHO THEY
ARE.
WE'VE BEEN HAVING.
A PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR I THINK WE CAN GET
THERE WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME SIDE
OF PROTECTING THESE FOLKS -- WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DOCUMENTS OF REFLECT THAT.
IF THEY HAVE LEGAL AFFECT AS A
LEANER JUDGMENT WE UNDERSTAND
WHOSE WHOSE -- AT STAKE HERE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE DíAS AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL THIS IS A WE HAVE.
HISTORY STORIES OF THE VIOLENCE
THAT IS COMMITTED BY.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PERPETRATORS
COUNTIES THESE VICTIMS ARE
TRYING VERY HARD TO GET AWAY
FROM THEIR PERPETRATOR HAVING
THIS INFORMATION AVAILABLE IN
PUBLIC RECORDS AND WE KNOW WHEN
YOU HAVE SOMEONE TOTALLY
OBSESSED.
WITH ANOTHER PERSON AND WE SEE
THAT IN STALKING WE SEE THAT THE
THESE ARE PEOPLE TRYING TO GET
AWAY -- THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO
AVOID THEIR LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY
SINCE SO I I APPRECIATE THIS I
THINK THAT AMENDMENT PROPOSE
WILL COMPLETELY UNDERMINE THE
BILL BUT I WOULD ASK YOU TO KEEP.
A TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY SO
THAT -- IF ONE OF THESE.
VICTIMS BECOMES.
A DEAD BEAT OR HAS A JUDGMENT
AGAINST THEM THAT THEY CAN'T
HIDE BEHIND US I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE INTENT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S REALLY EVER THE INTENT
WHEN SOMEONE'S.
AFRAID OF THEIR PERPETRATOR --
SO I AM I HOPE YOU'LL CONTINUE
TALKING BUT ON THE OTHER HAND --
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND
ONE THAT'S THAT WE NEED TO
PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF STOCKING AND ABUSE
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT IS OUR MOTION.
ALL RIGHT WELL I THINK OF
SENATOR RAZA BEAT YOU TO IT --
SO WITH THAT.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I ASSUME
YOU'D LIKE TO ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON THE
AND DEFINITELY OPEN TO CONTINUE.
CONVERSATION WAS THREE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS A CONCERN
TO YOU JUST BROUGHT UP.
GOOD ALRIGHT THE MOTION THEN IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
EIGHT HUNDRED JACKSON JACKSON
AYE PORGES TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
AND I BURKE.
I CAL SKI RECALLS THE I SEVEN
SEVEN TWO ZERO WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SIR AND VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO.
I WILL START YOU OFF WITH FILE
ITEM TWENTY WHICH IS AB
.
SIX SEVENTY THREE GOOD AFTERNOON
WHAT NO I TAKE THAT BACK HOME
LOW GOOD EVENING IT'S ALMOST
GOOD NIGHT GOOD EVENING GOOD
EVENING AND GOOD NIGHT ALL RIGHT --
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX SEVENTY THREE THE BILL THAT
OFFERS MORE EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS
FOR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE NOT PAID
THEIR WAGES ON TIME AND AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU WILL BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED.
THAT IS CORRECT MADAM CHAIR WE
WILL BE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN PAGE FIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
RECEIVING A PAYCHECK ON TIME.
IS A BASE A GUARANTEE OF
EMPLOYMENT AND IT'S A MATTER OF
DIGNITY AND WORKER RIGHT.
HOWEVER WORKERS ESPECIALLY LOW
WAGE INDUSTRY WORKERS WAIT DAYS
WEEKS AND EVEN MONTHS.
BEFORE THEIR PAGES THEIR
PAYCHECKS ARE OFFERED TO THEM.
THIS YEAR THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
ISSUED THE LARGEST CITY THE
LARGEST CITATION IN STATE
HISTORY.
FINDING A CONSTRUCTION COMPANY
NEARLY TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR REPEATED WAGE THEFT
VIOLATIONS WHICH LEFT OVER ONE
THOUSAND WORKERS WAITING WEEKS
OR MONTHS FOR THEIR PAYCHECKS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THESE
EMPLOYEES HAVE NO DIRECT
RECOURSE WHEN THEY ARE NOT PAID
ON TIME.
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER IS ABLE
TO RECOVER A PENALTY FROM
EMPLOYERS WHEN WE JUST ARE NOT
PAYING ON TIME BUT ACCORDING TO
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
THIS PENALTY IS RARELY PURSUED
OR COLLECTED.
EVEN IF THESE PENALTIES WERE TO
BE COLLECTED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THE PENALTIES GO TO
THE STATE.
AND NOT THE WORKER.
UNDER AB SIX SEVEN THREE BE
AVAILABLE LEGAL OPTIONS FOR
EMPLOYEES SUBJECT IT SUBJECT TO
TO WAIT THAT OUR EXPANDED IN THE
PENALTY IN AN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING WILL BE PAID DIRECTLY.
TO THE AFFECTED EMPLOYEE MOST
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL WILL HELP
STRAIGHTEN THE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT OF SIMPLY GETTING YOUR
PAYCHECK ON TIME WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IS REBECCA DID LAKE A
WORKER AT THE MISSION BEACH CAFE
AND KATIE.
KATIE FIVE STIR STAFF ATTORNEY
AT LEGAL AID AT WORK.
SO MUCH IN TWO MINUTES TEACHER
THE MOST IF YOU WOULD AND IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU COORDINATED HERE
THESE OUTFITS SO OF HER.
VERY NICE.
LIKE IT'S OKAY ARE VERY FASHION
FORWARD VERY GOOD BY TWO MINUTES
PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KATHERINE FEASTER AND I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGALLY AT
WORK WE ARE SPROUT A PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
I'M HERE TO INTRODUCE OUR CLIENT
REBECCA REBECCA DID LAKE TO
EXPLAIN HOW IMPORTANT THIS BILL
IS FOR WORKERS AND OUR LOW WAGE
CLAIM COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS REBECCA
DID LAKE AND I HAVE WORKED IN
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY FOR TEN
YEARS.
TODAY I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCE A MISSION BEACH CAFE
A PROMINENT SAN FRANCISCO BRUNCH
SPOT KNOWN FOR ITS LONG WAIT
TIMES ON THE WEEKEND.
ALTHOUGH A POPULAR SPOT MY
COWORKERS AND I WERE RARELY PAID
IN FULL AND ON TIME DESPITE.
ASKING IN PRACTICALLY BEGGING
FOR OUR CHECKS WHICH WAS AN
EXTREMELY DEMORALIZING SITUATION
TO BE IN.
WE WERE STRONG ALONG WITH THE
IDEA THAT SOME MONEY AT SOME
POINT IS BETTER THAN NONE.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE
SAVINGS I COULD DEPEND TOO BUT
SOME OF MY COWORKERS WERE NOT AS
FORTUNATE. ONE OF MY CO WORKERS
FACE EVICTION AND ANOTHER
STRUGGLED -- TO FEED HIS FAMILY.
SINCE THERE WAS NO CONSEQUENCES
MY BOSS HAD NO MOTIVATION TO
PASS ON TIME OF FULL AND TIMELY
PAYCHECK PAYCHECK SHOULD BE THE
MOST BASIC GUARANTEE FOR ALL
WORKERS THIS IS WHY I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB.
SIX SEVEN THREE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IF YOU'D STEP FOR DAMON
AFFILIATION.
RESERVE A YELLOW WHICH ALLOWED
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION
PROUD CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JESSICA CENTER ABOUT LEGAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AND MY ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
WOMEN LAWYERS ASSOCIATION PROUD
CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
BUT HAVING CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE PROBABLY NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL THANK YOU WHILE WORKING
VICE IS WHAT'S HE DOING IN THE
SUPPORT LINE.
LAURIE PROBABLY NEUTRALIZE LIKE
THAT AS WELL ESPECIALLY
ESPECIALLY MANAGER SENSOR IS
LISTED OPPOSITION THAT IS
ANALOGOUS TO THE OPPOSITION
COALITION LETTER THAT HAD BEEN
SUBMITTED.
AND WE DO THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS SO.
AN AREA ON BEHALF OF MUTUAL YOU
ARE A TEST AND I HAVE A
CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE IN A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT GROUPS AND YOU FOR
OUR YEAR IN SUPPORT OR IN.
NO WE ARE NEUTRAL DUE TO
AMENDMENTS BUT THE ANALYSIS
NOTES OPPOSITION THERE REALLY
TRACKED THE COALITION OPPOSITION
WHICH IS NO LONGER AFFECT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
NICELY DONE ALL RIGHT I ANY.
WITNESSES IN ARE STILL IN
OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
MINING -- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GOOD WORK AND THANK MY
STAFF AS WELL WHO I'M.
SURE IF WE'RE ABLE TO HELP FLUSH
OUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES SO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I THINK
THE THE RIGHT FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIAN TO BE PAID ON TIME
SHOULD BE A VERY BASIC RIGHT AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST HERE I'VE.
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
MOTION TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB SIX
SEVENTY THREE JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE BORDERS RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ CONSOLES I
JONES [inaudible]
MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN AYE ON BURKE WE CAO SKI.
CASKEY I SIX SIX ZERO SIX TWO
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN ON
THAT.
ONE COMBINE.
PAGE UPDATED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
JUST POKING.
ALL RIGHT THE NEXT BILL UP IS OF
OF FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX A. B..
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO FORESHORES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AGAIN
PROUD TO PRESENT AND MEMBERS
PARTED WITH AND ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT WOULD INSURE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS HAVE THE
OPTION OF A STRAIGHT FORWARD AN
EXPEDITIOUS LEGAL PATHWAY TO
JUSTICE IN THE CASE OF THEIR
EMPLOYERS WRONGDOING.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL I HAVE
ACCEPTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TO
CLARIFY AND EMPLOYMENT TEENS THE
OPTION TO EITHER FILE A
COMPLAINT THROUGH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER OR PURSUE A PRIVATE
ACTION AGAINST THEIR EMPLOYER.
UNDER CURRENT LAW SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND STALKING MUST PROVIDE JOB
PROTECTIVE.
MUST BE PROVIDED JOB PROTECT THE
TIME OFF TO SEEK MEDICAL LEGAL
SOCIAL SERVICES AND REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS.
IN THE WORKPLACE A RECENT STUDY
FOUND THAT 38% OF SURVIVORS
REPORT EITHER HAVING BEEN FIRED
OR FEARING TERMINATION BECAUSE
OF THEIR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION.
AND 34% REPORT HAVING TO QUIT A
JOB DUE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CURRENTLY SUPERVISORS RESPONDING
TO THIS MISTREATMENT ARE ABLE TO
FILE A COMPLAINT WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
OR PURSUE A CLAIM UNDER THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ACT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS PAGA.
AFTER MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS OF
PROCEEDINGS THE PAGA CLAIM
SURVIVORS ARE ONLY ABLE TO
COLLECT 25% OF A ONE HUNDRED
DOLLAR FINE.
THIS OUTCOME IS NOT SUFFICIENT
FOR SURVIVORS GIVEN THAT THEY
MUST INDOOR A LINK THE LEGAL
PROCESS.
AND TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS IS
CERTAINLY NOT PROPORTIONATE TO
THE DISCRIMINATION THEY FACE IN
THE WORKPLACE.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS AND
ALTERNATIVE LEGAL AVENUE IN FORM
OF A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
KNOWN AS P. R. A..
B. R. A.'S OFFERED A ROUTE TO
ACTION THAT GOES BEYOND THE
LIMITED SCOPE OF PAGA OR A
COMPLAINT WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ENSURING THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS CAN
PROPERLY ADDRESS THE
DISCRIMINATION AND MISTREATMENT.
THAT THEY HAVE FACED IN THE
WORKPLACE HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY.
IS LARRY DOYLE WITH THE
CONFERENCE OF CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS AND CATHERINE OF
WHICH IT WITH LEGAL AID AT WORK.
VERY GOOD GOOD EVENING. TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
KATHERINE WHICH AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL AID AT WORK
THE NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF LOW INCOME WORKERS.
AND I'M HERE'S A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS FAR TOO
COMMON AND CAN BE DEVASTATING
PHYSICALLY MENTALLY AND
FINANCIALLY SURVIVORS FREQUENTLY
FIND THEMSELVES IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY MUST PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
AND FOR THEIR CHILDREN ON THEIR
OWN SOMETIMES FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN YEARS AT THE SAME MOMENT THAT
THEY NEED TO TAKE TIME OFF FROM
WORK TO RELOCATE OR TO SEEK
OTHER PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
OFTEN WHEN THEY DO THIS THEY
EXPERIENCE RETALIATION OR
TERMINATION AT WRK AND THE LAW
SAYS THIS IS A LEGAL BUT
GENERALLY THERE'S VERY LITTLE
THAT THEY CAN DO ABOUT IT.
A SURVIVOR CAN FILE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT BUT THE PROCESS IS
CONFUSING AND SLOW IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON THAT THEY HAVE TO WAIT
MORE THAN SIX MONTHS BEFORE AN
INVESTIGATION EVEN STARTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ONLY
TO INDIVIDUALS MADE COMPLAINTS
TO THE DEAL AS THE BASED ON
THEIR EMPLOYER'S FAILURE TO
PROVIDE LEAVE FOR SAFETY
PLANNING OR MEDICAL CARE.
AND ONLY EIGHT COMPLAIN THAT
THEIR EMPLOYERS FAILED TO
PROVIDE SAFETY ACCOMMODATIONS
AND BASED ON THE STATISTICS IN
THE CALLS THAT LEGALLY THAT WERE
GUESTS WE KNOW THAT THIS ISN'T
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT HAPPENING.
IT'S BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A
VIABLE ROUTE FOR SURVIVORS.
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS WORKERS FACING
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON RACE
NATIONAL ORIGIN SEX TO FIND AN
ATTORNEY AND TO SEEK JUSTICE
THERE'S NO REASON THAT SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE A MUCH
SMALLER.
OF PHYSICAL VIOLENCE SHOULDN'T
HAVE THAT SAME RIGHT. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS THE
READER ALONG HAVE THE CONFERENCE
THE CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS.
THE ISSUES ARE SET FORTH VERY
WELL IN THE ANALYSIS OF THE BILL.
BASICALLY WE HAVE A SYSTEM RIGHT
NOW WHICH PROVIDES TO REMEDIES.
NEITHER OF WHICH SEEMS TO BE --
SUFFICIENT TO THE CASE.
FILING A CLAIM WITH THE LABOR
STANDARDS.
THE COMMISSION -- IS TOO LONG
AND PROVIDES.
DOES NOT PROVIDE AN AMPLE
PROTECTION FOR THE SURVIVOR.
AND PAGA IS A REPRESENTATIVE
ACTION AND DOESN'T PROVIDE
ANYTHING REALLY FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL.
US FOR THOSE REASONS IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WE GO FOR A OF
PERMITTING PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION.
AND ALLOW.
VICTIMS -- KEYS TO SURVIVORS.
TO GET AN ATTORNEY AND TO SEEK
THE JUSTICE THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU WHAT A NOTION OF ALL
RIGHT SO -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IF YOU WOULD GIVE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION THAT'S
BECAUSE CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HAPPEN FASTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CAN L<c.cyan>G ON BEHALF OF THE</c>
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NO I PART OF MOST C. R. L. AID
FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THAT'S AWFULLY
ENERGETIC FOR THE SHOWER THE
NIGHT BUT VERY IMPRESSIVE.
NORTON DATA INTO THE WHOLE THANK
YOU MUCH MUCH APPRECIATE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
LET ME GUESS YOU DON'T LIKE THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
UNFORTUNATELY NOTAND MADAM
CHAIR I REALIZE WHATEVER THE
OPPOSITE OF PREACHING TO THE
CHOIR ON THAT ISSUE AS I I KNOW
THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING HERE --
BUT WE ARE OPPOSED UNFORTUNATELY
THE A. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
BECAUSE IT DOES CREATE A NEW
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION -- AS A
PRELIMINARY MATTER WE JUST WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE LEGISLATION
THAT ADDED THESE LEAVE
PROTECTIONS.
MADAM CHAIR YOUR SB FOUR HUNDRED
FROM.
TO TWENTY THIRTEEN ORIGINALLY
CONTAINED A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION BUT WAS REMOVED DURING
THE PROCESS BEFORE THE BILL WAS
SENT TO THE GOVERNOR.
NOT BY MY CHOICE I UNDERSTAND.
WE HAD WE HAD ALSO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL'S
LANGUAGE.
AND DUPLICATIVE CLAIMS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF.
PAYING ATTENTION TO OUR
ARGUMENTS ON THAT ISSUE AND AND
WORKING ON THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE
BEEN RAISING THAT ISSUE THIS IS
THE FIRST COMMITTEE THAT -- TOOK
THE TIME TO TO UNDERSTAND OUR
CONCERNS AND AN ADDRESS AND SO
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT -- AGAIN
WE THINK.
THE DEAL SEE PROCESS IS NOT
PERFECT -- BUT WE DO THINK
IMPROVEMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE AS I
AS I MENTIONED ON THE KALRA BILL.
DATA FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
REFLECTS THAT AT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED CASE RETALIATION CASES
WERE OPENED FOR INVESTIGATION.
THE VAST MAJORITY INVOLVE CLAIMS
UNDER LABOR CODE SECTION NINETY
EIGHT POINT SIX OR ELEVEN A TWO
POINT FIVE I'M NOT LABOR CODE
SECTIONS TWO THIRTY INTO THIRTY
POINT ONE THE SECTIONS AT ISSUE
IN THIS BILL.
ONLY FIFTY SEVEN OF THOSE
ALLEGATIONS ARE POINT 001% FELL
UNDER THOSE LABOR COULD
PROVISIONS.
AND SECONDLY WHILE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED RETALIATION CASES WERE
OPEN IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN DEAL
SEE ALSO CLOSE TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED CASES.
AND AGAIN THE DEAL IS TO REPORT
NOTED THERE WERE ONLY FOUR CASES
REMAINING UNASSIGNED AT THE END
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR.
SO ONCE AGAIN WE BELIEVE THE DLC
RETALIATION PROCESS HAS BEEN
APPROVED AND WE DON'T SEE THE
NEED TO CREATE A NEW PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO PREACH TO THE NON
CHOIR. FOR THE ANTI CHOIR I'M
NOT SURE WHAT IT IS THANK YOU%
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS AND I I WANT TO
THANK YOU AS WAS JUST MENTIONED
I DID SIMILAR LEGISLATION TO
THIS
-- I DO THINK WE NEED -- TO
TO BE ABLE.
TO AGAIN -- GOING TO COURT AND
TO TRY TO RESOLVE THESE.
CONCERNS IN A IN A WAY THAT CAN
BE MEANINGFUL AND TO HAVING
THESE OPTIONS I THINK MAKES IT
POSSIBLE.
SO ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
MOVED BY SENATOR AND SALAS.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU FOR PAVING THE WAY WHEN IT
COMES TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS IN THE WORKPLACE.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THAT ALLOWS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHOOSE WHEN AND HOW THEY WOULD
LIKE TO PURSUE THEIR CASE AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MY VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SIX A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT JACKSON
HI JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JON SNOW MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I BURKE.
I'M BURKE AYE WHY CASKEY.
BECAUSE THE I SEVEN ONE SEVEN TO
ONE AND LET'S SEE THAT BILL IS
OUT THAT I THINK IS OUR FIRST
ONE OF THE DAY IT ONLY TOOK TILL
EIGHT O'CLOCK. TO HAVE A FULL
COMMITTEE.
EXCELLENT THAT BILL IS OUT.
I WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND WILL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
WHICH IS AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE THANK YOU
DAVID.
IN SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE I'M
SORRY I I'M.
I'M A LITTLE AHEAD OF MYSELF FOR
GIVE ME.
I KNOW I'M I'M.
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT WE HAVEN'T
FINISHED THERE WHEN WE HAVEN'T
STARTED THAT WHEN YET BUT WE ARE
ABOUT TO ITS FILE ITEM FIFTY
EIGHT AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WE ARE ON A ROLL.
PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WITH ACTUALLY
STARTED IN THE DISTRICT WHICH
WAS STRANGE LOCAL AUTHORITY TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION AGAINST
LOCAL THREATS TO THE PUBLIC'S
HEALTH AND SAFETY INCLUDING TE
ABILITY FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO DIRECT THE FACILITY OR A
PORTION OF A FACILITY. TO
TEMPORARILY DISCONTINUE THE
OPERATIONS THAT COST AND
EXPOSURE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL I HAVE
ACCEPTED SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS.
INDUSTRIES CONCERNS REGARDING
IMPLEMENTATION SUCH SUCH AS
INCLUDING LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
THAT FACILITIES THAT ARE PENDING
PERMIT APPROVAL ARE NOT
PENALIZED BY THIS BILL.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND CALIFORNIA
MULTIPLE REGULATORY AUTHORITIES
HAVE JURISDICTION OVER
BUSINESSES THAT HANDLE AND
GENERATE.
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND MATERIALS
THAT POSE A RISK TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
LOCALLY A CERTIFIED YOU IN A
CERTIFIED UNIFIED PROGRAM AGENCY
OTHERS KNOWN AS COOPER IT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING AND
ENFORCING HAZARDOUS MATERIAL IN
WAY FLAWS.
IN THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER HAS
GENERAL AUTHORITY TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND EXPAND THE
THORNY ONLY AFTER A COUNTY WIDE
EMERGENCY IS DECLARED.
CURRENTLY SOME FACILITIES THAT
EMIT HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES
CONTINUE TO OPERATE BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT MEET THE REGULATORY
MINIMUM STANDARDS TO CEASE
OPERATIONS IMMEDIATELY.
A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THIS TYPE OF
ATROCITY IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES BEGINS.
IT IS ACTUALLY BE EXIDE BATTERY
REFER RECYCLING FACILITY IN
VERNON CALIFORNIA WHICH
CONTINUES THE EXPOS FAMILIES AND
RESIDENTS OF NOT ONLY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY ONE BUT THREE OR
FOUR OTHER ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS AS
WELL AND SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
TO DANGERS TO DANGEROUS LEVELS
OF TALKS THAT LED.
TOXIC LEAD.
THE DELAY TO SHUT DOWN THE
FACILITY -- DOWN.
WITH THEIR LEAD EMISSIONS FROM
THE PLAN CONTAMINATED MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND OF A RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES ACROSS NUMEROUS
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING BOYLE
HEIGHTS.
ANY STYLE A AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
AS A RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS
AND FRUSTRATIONS EXPRESSED BY
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOLLOWING
A HEARING.
WHICH WE DID LAST YEAR.
THE BILL IS IMPERATIVE TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL AUTHORITIES CLOSEST
TO THE COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY
TOXIC POLLUTION.
CAN EXPEDITIOUSLY PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WILL ENABLE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT
THE FACILITY OR PORTION OF A
FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS THAT
HAVE EXPOSE OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
TOXIC HARMFUL MATERIALS UNTIL
THAT ISSUE IS CORRECTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- TWO
MINUTES EACH VENTURE SINCE THIS
ONLY SETS THE PENALTIES CIVIL OR
ADMINISTRATIVE BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND I'M
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT IF YOU GET THAT HINT.
OF THAT IS THE ISSUE BEFORE OUR
COMMITTEE AND IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE THAT WOULD BE
MOST APPRECIATED THE AMOUNT OF
THE PENALTY. FIVE FEET CALMLY
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WERE POWER
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL ALL
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE I AM TAKING
THE PLACE OF ONE OF OUR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS.
WHO ACTUALLY HAD TO JUMP ON A
PLANE -- DUE TO THE LATENESS OF
HOW WE GOT HERE SO -- I WILL DO
THE BEST I CAN I'M GOING TO BE
VERY BRIEF BECAUSE OF THAT.
I AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED IS ABOUT
BUILDING ON EXISTING LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER THIRTY TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION AGAINST LOCAL
THREATS TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S
HELP.
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE THE
CURRENT LONG STANDING AUTHORITY
TO IMMEDIATELY ORDER THE
TEMPORARY CLOSURE OF A
CONTAMINATED BEACH TO ORDER THE
CLOSURE OF A RESTAURANT FOR
INSANITARY CONDITIONS OR TO TAKE
ANY ACTION NECESSARY IN RESPONSE
TO FOOD AND WATER BORNE
ILLNESSES.
OR COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER
AUTHORITY OVER THESE ENTITIES IS
BASED ON AN ESTABLISHED
UNDERSTANDING THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT MUST PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF DISEASE OR THE
OCCURRENCE OF ADDITIONAL CASES
WHENEVER POSSIBLE.
HOWEVER WHEN A CHEMICAL THREAT
ENDANGERS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
LACKS STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
TAKE SIMILAR IMMEDIATE ACTION
AGAINST THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CREO EXPLAIN ITS FACE
NUMEROUS CRISES IN WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES RELEASE
CHEMICALS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
PRESENTING A SUBSTANTIAL
ENDANGERMENT TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO MY AND LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER AUTHORITY OVER
CHEMICAL THREATS WITH THIS
ESTABLISH AUTHORITY TO STOP
BIOLOGICAL THREATS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BILL I DRIED OUT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST LEARN
TO THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTORS THE COOPERS AND YOU
KNOW THE COOPER AS WELL.
THE CHAIR.
AND ALSO CHECK THE HEALTH
EXECUTIVES AUTHORITY ALSO NEED
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT VERY
QUICKLY THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH BILL WE DO NEED TO
DESPITE THE PLANS FOR OF LOOK
RULES WE HAVE WE DO HAVE GAPS IN
THE RULES.
AND THIS IS HOW WE PLUG THAT GAP
SO I JUST WANT TO STRESS THAT WE
HAVE WORKED WITH THE OPPOSITION
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THESE DUE
PROCESS.
EVEN THOUGH THE IS AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WE BELIEVE WE'VE
PROVIDED THAT DUE PROCESS IN
THESE AMENDMENTS AND THERE WAS A-LATE HIT -- LATE OPPOSITION FROM
CDA THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S WE
OBVIOUSLY WORK VERY VERY CLOSELY
WITH THEM WE SORRY THAT LETTER
CAME LATE WE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THEM AND WITH THE
CONSULTANTS OF YOUR COMMITTEE I
WILL DO THAT IN THE PROBES.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT ARE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARGOT PARKS ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION -- WE'RE HERE IN
EIGHTY OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
LATE NATURE -- OF OUR LETTER
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS IN THE SPONSORS -- ON
THIS NOT ONLY IS A LETTER LATE
WE'VE NEVER SEEN IT HOW IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN RECEIVED BY OUR
COMMITTEE ON YESTERDAY.
MARITA RESUBMIT ALRIGHT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND BUT SO THERE'S ONE
PROVISION -- THAT WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO WORK OUT AND THAT
RELATES TO THE SERVE THE DUE
PROCESS PROVISIONS MISTER MALONE
DESCRIBED IT I'M FOR THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS IN DEVELOPING OR
ESTABLISHING SOME TYPE OF
CRITERIA THAT THEY WILL.
USE WHEN TAKING ISN'T HORSEMEN
ACTIONS -- AGAINST A REGULATED
ENTITY SO I THINK THAT NETWORK
WE CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY I
HAVE GREAT HOPE THAT WE'LL GET
THERE BUT AT THIS TIME -- WE ARE
IN A OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND BUT JOURNAL THANK
YOU APPRECIATE THAT IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE A IN OPPOSITION OR
NEUTRALITY.
I'D SEEN NON.
A MOTION BY SENATOR DRAWS SO.
DID YOU BEAT -- YOU DID YOU DID
YOU TRY YOU -- YOU SUGGESTIVE
YES GOT IT ALL RIGHT -- THE FINE
YES -- VERY GOOD -- WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY SIR WHAT CASKEY ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS THING
IN HERE SEEING AND HEARING ON
THAT WOULD BE THE THIRD TIME.
BUT WE ALREADY.
EVERY ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO MOVE
IT WE VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT.
LOOKS LIKE WE GOT A LOT OF
ACTIVITY HERE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED SENATE APPROACH -- AND I
KNOW THAT YOU WILL COMMIT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO TRY TO IRON
OUT THESE THE SMALL KINKS THAT
EXISTS STARK.
I THINK THOSE REMOTELY DOABLE SO
WITH THAT THE MOTION HAS BEEN
MADE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT A.
B. FIFTEEN HUNDRED JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE BORDERS RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN AYE ON BURKE.
NUMBER OF IOWA CASKEY.
MY CASKEY AYE EIGHT TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CLOSE THE ROLLER BILLS OUT WILL
MOVE TO YOUR FINAL BILL WILL GET
TO THAT ONE NOW WHICH IS FILE
ITEM.
SIX FOUR AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE A HIGH
[inaudible]
GOOD EVENING.
YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- PROUD TO PRESENT TO
THEM THE BILL -- SEVENTEEN FIFTY
THREE A BILL THAT INSURES ALL
IMMIGRANTS NO MATTER IF THEY
COME FROM LATIN AMERICA ASIA
AFRICA OR ANY OTHER PART OF THE
WORLD ONLY RECEIVE.
HIGHLY IMPORTANCE LEGAL ADVICE
FROM INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE
LEGAL EDUCATION AND EXPERTISE TO
PROVIDE SUCH ASSISTANCE AND LET
ME JUST START BY ALSO SEEN.
BIG THANK YOU TO YOU AND TO THE
WONDERFUL STAFF OF YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH WITH
ME ON ON THIS BILL AND AND WITH
MY TEAM.
IN JUNE OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FEDERAL POLICY WAS MODIFY THAT
PUTS IMMIGRANTS AT GREATER RISK
OF DEPORTATION BY ALLOWING
OFFICIALS TO START THE
DEPORTATION PROCESS. FOR TONIGHT
IMMIGRATION PETITIONS AND TO
REFER CASES TO THE IMMIGRATION
AND CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS ICE.
ON CRIMINAL OR SECURITY GROUNDS
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO MY DISTRICT
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO THE US
CENSUS NEARLY 35% OF LA COUNTY.
I'LL LA COUNTY TEN MILLION
RESIDENTS WERE BORN IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY MYSELF INCLUDED.
ESTIMATES FURTHER INDICATE THAT
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS LIVE IN LA COUNTY
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
THESE VULNERABLE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES HIRING IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT OFTEN COST LESS THAN
HIRING ATTORNEY BUT THE RISK OF
POTENTIAL DEPORTATION A DENIAL
OF CITIZENSHIP.
OR RESIDENCY INVOLVED IN HIRING
A LOWER COST IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS FAR AWAY THE COST
BENEFIT.
THE CURRENT EXPAND THE
DISCRETION OF FEDERAL OFFICIALS
TO DENY IMMIGRATION APPLICATIONS
LEAVES NO ROOM FOR ERROR IN THE
ACCURACY.
THE MISSION AND COMPLETENESS OF
IMMIGRATION APPLICATIONS AND
EVEN IF ERRORS CAN BE RECTIFIED
AFFECTED IMMIGRANT VICTIMS OFTEN
LACK THE ABILITY TO CORRECT
MISTAKES TO BE IT FOR THE LACK
OF RESOURCES.
FEAR OF RETALIATION OR
GOVERNMENT DISTRESS AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE BY MAKE IT UNLAWFUL
FOR A PERSON OTHER THAN A
LICENSED ATTORNEY.
A PARALEGAL UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF AN ATTORNEY OR A
PERSON OR ORGANIZATION FEDERALLY
AUTHORIZED TO REPRESENT
INDIVIDUALS IN IMMIGRATION
MATTERS TO PROVIDE IMMIGRATION
RELATED SERVICES FOR A FEE IN
CALIFORNIA.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AS
CAN BANGKOK A EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER. TWO MINUTES SIR.
BEN I'M SURE GOOD EVENING CAN
BABCOCK EJECTED DRUCKER THE
PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN SANTA ANA
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO FUNDED LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATION AND THE
PRINCIPAL NONPROFIT PROVIDER OF
IMMIGRATION RELATED LEGAL
SERVICES IN ORANGE COUNTY.
IN MY THIRTY YEARS AS A LEGAL
AID LAWYER I'VE SEEN MANY
MODIFICATIONS.
TRYING TO STRENGTHEN THE
ORIGINAL IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS
ACT EACH SUBSEQUENT CHANGE
REPEATED THE ORIGINAL ACTS
FUNDAMENTAL FLAW OF ALLOWING NON
LAWYERS TO PRACTISE LAW WITHOUT
A LICENSE.
AN EXTREMELY COMPLICATED AREA
WHERE THE CONSEQUENCES OF A
MISTAKE CAN BE LIFE THREATENING.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO DIVORCE
IMMIGRATION FORM PREPARATION
FROM THE PRESENTATION FROM THE
PROVISION OF LEGAL ADVICE.
ALWAYS HAVE QUESTIONS DO I
QUALIFY FOR IMMIGRATION RELIEF
IS EVEN CITY FOR ME TO SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION WE SEE THESE AND
QUESTIONS LIKE THAN DAILY
WEATHER AT LARGE CITIZENSHIP
AFFAIRS.
AT THE ANAHEIM CONVENTION CENTER
SMALLER CLINICS IN SANTA ANA
WESTMINSTER AND ELSEWHERE AND
KNOW YOUR RIGHTS PRESENTATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY THE
ANSWER'S IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
INSTANCE CONSTITUTE LEGAL ADVICE.
OPPONENTS MAY ARGUE CURRENT
CAPACITY CANNOT FILL THE VOID
THE CONSULTANTS CAN NO LONGER
OPERATE BUT THE LEGISLATURE AND
BOTH THE BROWN AND NEWSOME
ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE HOPE CHANGE
THAT AND INCREASE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE.
BY PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
FOR IMMIGRATION RELATED LEGAL
SERVICES THROUGH THE ONE
CALIFORNIA FUND AND BY
INCREASING THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND
THOSE FUNDING STREAMS BOTH
ACCOMPANIED BY RIGOROUS
OVERSIGHT.
ALLOWED US ITS APPEAL SEE TO
BETTER SERVE THE COMMUNITY.
THE STATE SIMPLY SHOULD NOT
AUTHORIZE PERSONS NO MATTER HOW
WILL MEAN IT MIGHT BE A PRACTICE
IMMIGRATION WATER NOT LAWYERS OR
OTHERWISE AUTHORIZED BY FEDERAL
LAW. TO PROVIDE IMMIGRATION
SERVICES GIVEN THE THAT ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES ARE SO DRASTIC WE
WERE WE RECENTLY ASSIST RECLINER
PLIGHT FOR GREEN CARD WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF AN IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT.
WHO INCORRECTLY ADVISED HER
DURING THE APPLICATION PROCESS
BECAUSE OF THAT MISTAKE THE
CLIENTS NOW BEEN ISSUED A NOTICE
TO SHE SUBJECT TO DEPORTATION AT
ANY TIME?
WE'VE ADVICE RIVER OPTIONS AND
PLAN TO RIP JENNIFER IN ANY
FUTURE DEPORTATION PROCEEDINGS
THAT YOU COME TO US INITIALLY
THIS WOULD NEVER HAVE HAPPENED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
TWO MINUTES AT THE MOST.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE REGAL RIGHT YES --
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES -- BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ARE A SPONSOR OF A CO SPONSOR OF
AB FIFTY AND IT'S SEVEN FIFTY
THREE I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF IMMIGRANT
AFFAIRS.
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AND BUSINESS AFFAIRS.
ARE.
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS IN ADVANCE
IN THE WORLD BEING OUT FOR THE
TEN MILLION IMMIGRANTS WHO LIVE
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION OF
THOSE IMMIGRANTS -- WHO MAKE UP
THE COUNTY THEIR HOME?
OUR MOST CONSUMERS -- HIGHER AND
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT BECAUSE
THEY NEED SUBSTANTIVE HELP.
WITH IMMIGRATION -- THAT
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS ARE NOT
LEGALLY ABLE TO PROVIDE.
THIS PUTS CONSULTANTS IN THE
UNTENABLE POSITION OF EITHER
LETTING CONSUMERS A GAS HOW TO
PROCEED -- OR ATTEMPTING TO
ADVISE THEM IN VIOLATION OF THE
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS ACT.
BOTH ACTIONS CAN HAVE
CATASTROPHIC OUTCOMES FOR
CONSUMERS.
IN OUR DATA BEAR THIS OUT SINCE
TWENTY TWELVE OUR DEPARTMENT HAS
RECEIVED OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS.
INVOLVING CONSULTANTS.
WITH MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY OF THOSE COMPLAINTS IN
THE LAST YEAR ALONE.
OF HERE IT'S SAID THE COMPLAINTS
TYPICALLY INVOLVE CONSULTANTS
WERE NOT BONDED.
AS REQUIRED BY LAW THAT IS NOT
OUR EXPERIENCE OUR DATA SHOW THE
FOR CONSULTANTS WHO HAD FOUR OR
MORE COMPLAIN SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE THAT IS A REPEAT
OFFENDERS. 55% WERE OR ARE
BONDED.
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN THE LA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE HAS CHARGED NUMEROUS
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS.
WITH SERIOUS CRIMES INCLUDING
FELONIES THIS CONSULTANTS HAVE
VICTIMIZED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO COLLECTIVELY
LOST MORE THAN THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN WARSOP MANY LAWS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEGALIZE
THEMSELVES IN CONCLUSION SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX WE HAVE MADE
AT LEAST ELEVEN AMENDMENTS TO
THE I SEE A WITH OVER THIRTY
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES. TO
STRENGTHEN CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
HERE COMPLAINTS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS
AUTHORIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE CAN PROVIDE
IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THE PROPER HELP THEY NEED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I YES FOR YEAH.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THAT'S THE CENTER OF AB RECORDS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SEIU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANNUAL SHARP WITH THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN RESOURCE CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL AND I'LL BE AVAILABLE --
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK
YOU.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AND WHEN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMPLEMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MON CHAIRED MEMBERS DAN FILLS
ALL ON BEHALF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE PLEASE TO CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM MOST CRLA FOUNDATION
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
MADAM CHAIR TO ADD TO LET YOU
KNOW COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RACHEL ALSO THEY SELL YOU A
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE SUBJECT OF A WE HAVE A
CARELESS AS A COSPONSOR OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JIM LET JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO REGISTER HER SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THANK YOU.
ANTHONY LEE ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE SERRA IN
SUPPORT OF AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EACH STEP FORWARD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTER A EXCUSE ME GOOD
EVENING.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIRMAN
WOMAN -- MY NAME IS ONE CLOSELY
WILL BE AREAS.
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ONE STOP IMMIGRATION AN
EDUCATIONAL CENTER.
A NOT FOR PROFIT ENTITY.
AND ALSO REPRESENTING THE FULL
RIGHTS FOR IMMIGRANTS GOAL ONLY
XIN.
AN ORGANIZATION THE GROUPS A
WHOLE VARIETY OF DIFFERENT --
PRO IMMIGRATION ORGANIZATIONS
I'M ALSO A COMMISSIONER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR ACCESS TO
EDUCATION.
AND I'M HERE TO VOICE MY STRONG
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL --
ASKED PRESENTED I'M IN AGREEMENT
WITH THE INTENT OF THE BILL --
BUT NOT WITH THE WAY -- IT'S
GOING FORWARD -- THIS IS AN ANTI
IMMIGRANT BILL MASQUERADING AS A
PAROLE IMMIGRATION BILL IT COMES
AT THE WRONG TIME.
BECAUSE THIS IS A TIME WHEN
IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING PERSECUTED
YOU KNOW PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP'S -- POLICY OF ZERO
TOLERANCE AND HIS CONSTANT A
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENTS BUT SHORTLY --
THERE WILL BE MASS ARRESTS AND
DEPORTATIONS -- YOU KNOW IS
ACTUALLY A CALL FOR ALL THOSE
THAT CLAIM TO BE PRO IMMIGRATION
RIGHTS TO COME TOGETHER INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO ELIMINATE A SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE PROVIDING --
NEED IT SERVICES -- IN THE
COMMUNITY AGAIN -- WARNING
BILL BUT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER BOTH -- THOSE IN
FAVOR AND THOSE OF US THAT
OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE I AM
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN THAT THE
NONPROFIT -- COMMUNITY OF WHICH-I AM A PART OF IS NOT IN A
POSITION TO FILL THE GAP A LEAVE --
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS ARE
ELIMINATED AS THIS BILL PROPOSES
TO DO I DON'T THINK THAT
NONPROFITS CAN FILL THE GAP AND
ACTUALLY PROVIDE SERVICES NEEDED
AT THIS CRITICAL TIME WE OPERATE
AN OFFICE IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY.
AND AND AND AND ANOTHER ONE IN
LA AND AND AND I I I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE LOGIC OF WHY YOU
REMOTE CHECK IT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. SIX WITNESS.
YOU WERE HERE TWO YEARS AGO TOOK
A WIN THIS BILL CAME UP WE WERE
YOU NOT.
A YES.
I REMEMBER ALL RIGHT WELL
WELCOME BACK YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU -- MY NAME IS
SYLVIA TIE THIS IN THE MAIL.
CONSULTANT WHO HAD BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
I'M LEGALLY BONDED AND REGISTER
WITH THE STATE OF COLOR.
I HAVE PROVIDED NINE LEGAL
IMMIGRATION ASSIST. TO THOUSANDS
OF IMMIGRANTS IN THE COMMUNITY.
I BECAME IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT
I WORK AT THE DAVIS SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR THIRTEEN YEARS AS A
LIAISON CONSULAR.
ASSISTANCE STUDENTS TO TRANSIT
TO COLLEGE IN THE AND THE
PROCESS -- WHILE I HELP THEM I
FOUND OUT MANY OF THEM COULD NOT
APPLY TO COLLEGE BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT HAVE A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER.
DUE TO BEING UNDOCUMENTED.
THEY LET ME TOO THIS LED ME TO
INVESTIGATE AND LEARN HOW
PARENTS COULD BECOME US CITIZENS
AND THEN.
LEGALIZE THEIR COLLEGE PREP
CHILDREN I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT
MANY OF THE STUDENTS ARE COLLEGE
GRADUATES.
AND MOST OF THEM ARE NOW VOTING
CITIZENS.
ALL THIS LED ME TO SEE AND
UNDERSTAND THE NEED THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY HAD.
I FOUND OUT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAD SOME BY LOSS IN
ORDER TO BECOME AN IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT HOWEVER I EDUCATED
MYSELF FIRST.
I COMPLETED A COURSE WITH
IMMIGRATION LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER ATENDED PUBLIC MEETINGS
AT THE LOCAL IMMIGRATION OFFICE.
AND REGISTER WITH THE STATE
COMPLYING WITH THE STATE'S
REQUIREMENTS. TO THIS DAY EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
GET TRAINING AND MAINTAIN A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF SKILL.
I CONTINUE TO EDUCATE MYSELF BY
ATTENDING WORKSHOPS TAUGHT BY
IMMIGRATION LAWYERS.
AND I PAY MYSELF FOR ALL THIS
EXPENSES.
I CAN SAY THAT I HAVE EARNED AND
I HAVE EARNED THE TRUST OF THE
COMMUNITY.
AND TO AND THE PROOF IS THAT I
HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR MANY
YEARS IN THE SAME AREA.
MOST OF THE IMMIGRANTS.
ARE COMING IMMIGRATION COMMUNITY
INDUSTRIES COMPROMISE OF SINGLE
MOTHERS LIKE MYSELF.
WHO ARE IN DANGER OF BEING
UNEMPLOYED THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SORRY TO
CATCH YOU UP OKAY TO LONG DAY?
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
IF THEY COME FORWARD PLEASE WITH
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY.
IF YOU WOULD UP.
NO MAN IS CATTLE SO SO THE ONE
YOUR FROM DOWNEY CALIFORNIA
BEING TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AS
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT.
AMIR BLOWS TO THE BILL THANK YOU
OUT OF MY OFFICE NINETEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE THANK YOU SEE
THIS AND ADJUST YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE NEXT WITNESS.
AB AREAS FROM SAN DIEGO HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SERVICE.
THANK YOU.
HE HAD A BELLOW FROM JANET
LINCOLN TAXING THEM IN
OPPOSITION TO THANK YOU MA'AM.
UNTIL YOU CAN YOU CAN LOWER IT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GET YOUR
TIPTOES.
WHEN THEY ARE SAFE RUNS ON THE
ILL OR CAPS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
REBECCA RANGEL FROM HOPS
ASSOCIATION AND I OPALS THANK
YOU.
HAVE A SEAT AWARENESS -- FROM
HOPS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
WHETHER WE WILL MISS IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT FOR TWELVE YEARS FROM
TEN ANNA AND I OPPOSE I ASK YOU
FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NORMAL BURKE.
OUR DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
ADVOCATES AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU.
ALSO IF THE NORMAL HAVE FROM SAN
DIEGO -- FROM HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SERVICE ARE YOUR BOSS THANK YOU.
BIGELOW MENTHA SANTANA.
THANK YOU SIR.
BUT LETTER SURE NATIONAL NOTARY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
DOES ANY UP TORRANCE FROM MY
HARD AYE PPOSED TO THIS THANK
YOU MY HEART THANK YOU.
I AM THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUE ACOSTA I AGE K.
PEOPLE INCOME IN THE UNITED
STATES -- CITIZENS CLASSES AND A
STRONG OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GREGORY KILL ONE OF ON BEHALF OF
THE LATIN AMERICAN IMMIGRATION
ASSOCIATION AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
ROBIN OTHER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT I OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
MONICA TOP GET IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT FOR THIRTY YEARS AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WITH A BIGGER LABELS I OPPOSE
MY NAME IS GLENDA SILVA I'M.
REGISTER AND BONDED IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT AND THE CITY OF ANA
HANG. FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS THANK
YOU AYE OPPOSED AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JACQUELYN BARRIOS
FROM ANAHEIM I MEAN I'M
CONSULTANT FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THOSE GOOD THE
ADDRESS.
SACRAMENTO RESIDENT SOON TO BE A
CITIZEN THANKS TO A CONSULTANT
I'D STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE THANK YOU.
I WOULD BUT I HAS TO WORK WITH A
TIE THIS -- FOR TWENTY YEARS --
STONE OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ERIN RUBBER COSTS ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL NOTARY ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
ALRIGHT BRING THE BILL BACK TO
THE DíAS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
YES SENATOR Y. CASKEY.
I I GOT THIS LETTER FROM THIS
THE LEGAL.
SERVICES WITH KNOWLEDGE IS THAT
THEY'RE IN COMPETITION WITH
THESE CONSULTANTS AND THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT FRAUD BY NON
LAWYERS IS A HORRIBLE THING AND
BUT THERE'S AN UNMET NEEDS.
AND THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
WHICH IS MY QUESTION THIS I SIX
OH ONE A FORMER WHICH THEY SAY
IT'S A PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
FORM TAKES A LOT OF DECLARATIONS
AND TAX RETURNS IN LETTERS.
BUT THAT SOMETIMES THE YOU KNOW
THEY CHARGE FIVE THOUSAND BUCKS
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE
CONSULTANTS CHARGE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED BUCKS SOMETIMES THEY
WILL REFER.
THE THIS SERVICE TO BECAUSE THE
CLIENTS CAN PAY THEM TO THE
CONSULTANTS AND OTHER TIMES
CONSULTANTS WILL ADMIT THAT THIS
THIS TO TOUGH OF A CASE FOR US
TO HANDLE WE WILL REFER TO THE
LAWYERS.
THE IMMIGRATION LAWYERS AND THEY
SAY THAT THAT SORT OF HIS BEEN
THIS BALANCE THAT.
OF NOT PRACTICING LAW BUT
FILLING OUT FORMS CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT.
UNMET NEED FOR LACK OF FUNDS TO
PAY FOR SERVICES AT LEAST THIS
ONE LAW ALFA SAYS.
THERE'S SAID BALANCING ACT THAT
GOES ON SURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S AN UNMET
NEED.
THE SERVICE SHOULD BE PROVIDED
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF THE
ATTORNEY AND THE LAW OFFICE
SHOULD MAKE ITSELF RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THE OUTCOME THE I. SIX A
WHEN A IF APPROVED BY THE
CITIZENSHIP AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES REQUIRES THE INDIVIDUAL
TO GO ABROAD -- AND THEN
CONSULAR PROCESS IN ORDER TO
COME BACK TO THE US WITH LAWFUL
STATUS PEOPLE WHO DO THAT.
CAN GET STUCK ABROAD FOR YEARS
OR PERMANENTLY SO IT'S AN
EXTREMELY HIGH RISK SITUATION.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THERE IS A
CAPACITY CONCERN.
THE IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT
INDUSTRY IS NOT AND IS NEVER
GOING TO BE THE SOLUTION TO THE
STATE'S CAPACITY CONCERNS A
CAPACITY HAS GROWN DRAMATICALLY
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS BUT THIS
INDUSTRY IS NOT THE WAY TO DO IT
AND IT TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
OFFICE HAS A RELATIONSHIP.
IT SHOULD BE OVERSEEING THE WORK
AND MAKING ITSELF ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE OUTCOMES OF THOSE.
NON LEGAL PROVIDERS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OF OUR WILL THE CENTER MORNING
AND THEN A SENATOR ROSTER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS IN OUNCES REFLECTS A
SIMILAR BILL.
FAILED TO PASS THE SENATE LAST
YEAR.
HAVE THERE BEEN ANY CHANGES IN
THE DRAFTING OF THIS.
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR'S BILL.
THE THE LANGUAGES SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR -- THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
EXTERNAL -- CIRCUMSTANCES --
AMONG THEM THE THE HEIGHTENED
RISK FOR IMMIGRANTS THAT WAS
DESCRIBED ON AND A PUBLISHED
DECISION RECENTLY ON MAY SECOND --
BY THE CALIFORNIA OF FIFTH
APPELLATE DISTRICT THAT REALLY
E. DICTATES THAT -- THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SERVICES PROVIDED BY
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS ARE IN
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW -- AT
PRESENT TIME.
ON SO FOR THAT REASON WE ARE
PROCEEDING WITH THE THE LANGUAGE
AS CONSTITUTED IN THE PRIOR
VERSION.
I WOULD ALSO ADD SENATOR THAT --
THE SUPPORT.
FOR THIS PARTICULAR BILL HAS
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY THAN WHAT
IT WAS LAST YEAR IF YOU LOOK AT
THE ANALYSIS AND THE IN THE
INFORMATION FACT SHEET ON ON THE
BILL.
AS WELL.
I APPRECIATE THAT IN MY
EXPERIENCE.
HAVING PRACTICED IMMIGRATION ON
THE SALINAS VALLEY.
THE STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO'VE
BEEN MISLED IN -- CHARGED HUGE
SUMS OF MONEY LEADING. TO
NOTHING SOMETIMES TO DEPORTATION.
IS OUTRAGEOUS.
BY THE SAME TOKEN I THINK SOME
OF THE PEOPLE WE HEARD FROM HERE
TODAY.
OUR SINCERE AND EARNEST
COMMUNITY SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
WORKING WITH NON PROFITS --
TRYING TO MAKE A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE -- I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
THE NEED [inaudible] FOR BETTER
REGULATION.
LICENSING AND OVERSIGHT I WOULD
THINK A PATHWAY FOR SOME OF
THOSE WHO FEEL THAT.
THEY WILL LOSE SOME.
THEIR FUTURE OR THE ABILITY TO
KEEP DOING THE WORK THEY'VE BEEN
DOING.
WOULD BE TO AFFILIATE WITH AN
ATTORNEY UNDER WHOSE SUPERVISION.
THEY COULD WORK.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S AN
IMPOSSIBLE GOAL FOR THOSE THAT
ARE COMMITTED. TO FAIR -
REPRESENTATION.
UNDER THE GUIDANCE AND
SUPERVISION OF A SKILLED
ATTORNEY THERE'S ALSO RECOURSE
THAN FOR SOMEBODY.
WHO MIGHT BE MISREPRESENTED OR
MISLED?
THROUGH THE STATE BAR -- BASED
ON THAT SUPERVISING ATTORNEY I
AM TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL
TODAY I SUPPORTED OUT LAST YEAR --
I JUST THINK THE STAKES ARE SO
HIGH THE DEMAND IS SO GREAT.
BUT WITH THE CHANGE CIRCUMSTANCE
GETTING WORSE SINCE LAST YEAR IT
ALSO RAISES.
THE RISK OF EXPLOITATION THE
DESPERATION IS GREATER THAN EVER
BEFORE THE FEAR OF RAIDS AND
DEPORTATION.
AN WHILE THERE ARE THOSE THAT
ARE EARNEST AND WELL INTENTIONED.
IN THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT
THERE'S A RICH HISTORY OF PEOPLE
MORE THAN READY TO TAKE PEOPLE'S
MONEY -- IN PROVIDE NO SERVICE
THERE'S GOT TO BE A BETTER WAY
TO REGULATE THIS I THINK WORKING.
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
ATTORNEY WHO'S ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE STATE BAR -- WOULD BE A PATH
FORWARD FOR EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE TWO
WE HAVE CENTERS STERN CHINNOR
GONZALEZ IN ANSWER SENATOR
RUSSELL SENATOR STIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- ATTY I
WAS WRESTLING WITH HIS LAST YEAR.
IN THE SAME SORT OF
CIRCUMSTANCES SENATOR MONNING
POINTED OUT -- I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT THE NEED HAS GROWN.
ITEM IN THE STAKES ARE.
GETTING HIGHER.
BY THE DAY -- I WANTED TO GET
YOUR TAKE THOUGH ON SOME OF THE
AMENDMENT IDEAS THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED BY -- SOME OF THE FOLKS
IN THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
BECAUSE I WORRY ABOUT --
THROWING OUT THE GOOD WITH THE
BAD HERE AND TRYING TO FIND SOME
PATH TO SAY YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
CRACKED.
ON ILLEGITIMATE NO TADI OWES WHO
ARE EXTENDING THEMSELVES ARE
PRETENDING THAT THEIR LAWYERS
WHEN THEY'RE REALLY NOT --
WITHOUT.
UNDERCUTTING IMPORTANT.
SUPPLY SIDE ESSENTIALLY A WORK
FORCE TO HELP FOLKS THROUGH THE
MORE MINISTERIAL NON.
LEGAL PRACTICE ELEMENT SO AND
I'M LOOKING THROUGH SOME OF THE
AMENDS THAT APPARENTLY HAVE BEEN
OFFERED -- FROM CHANGING THE
TITLE IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT TO
IMMIGRATION FORMER ASSISTANT TO
REMOVING IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT
FROM PROVIDING CERTAIN SERVICES
LIKE ASYLUM AND WITHHOLDING.
OF REMOVAL AND VIA THE VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT ISSUES -- TO
SORT OF BEEFING UP THE MINIMUM
EDUCATION LEGAL EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS OR EVEN JUST
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS AT I
HAVEN'T SEEN PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION HERE BUT BUT EVEN YOU
KNOW.
EMPOWER CITIZENS TO GO AFTER
THESE ILLEGITIMATE ACTORS OR NOT
JUST PUTTING IT ALL IN SORT OF
THE COUNTIES ARE AG TO TAKE CARE
OF THIS STUFF SO JUST GET A
REACTION FROM YOU GUYS ABOUT --
TAKE ON SOME OF THOSE OFFERS IN --
WHERE YOU STAND ON IT?
SURE WE HAVE CONSIDERED THE
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE JUST DISCUSSED BUT THERE'S
ACTUALLY A CASE THE PEOPLE
VERSUS HEALTHY -- WHICH IS
ACTUALLY OF THIS YEAR -- THAT IS
PERTINENT TO THIS BILL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THIS TIME.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT ANY
AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
BEYOND THE CURRENT FEDERALLY
AUTHORIZED GROUPS TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES ACTUALLY
WOULD BE PREEMPTED BY FEDERAL
LAW.
AND SEND THAT SEN ON PAGE NINE
AND TEN OF THE BILL ANALYSIS.
I'M READING THAT CASE -- I MEAN
I I WENT THROUGH IT A LITTLE BIT
TRY TO DO MY HOMEWORK HERE IN.
IT.
IT'S SORT OF SAYS THAT.
IT ALSO SAYS -- THE ACT DOES NOT
PURPORT TO ALLOW ANYONE TO
VIOLATE FEDERAL LAW A PERSON
STILL MUST BE FEDERALLY
AUTHORIZED OR TO PROVIDE ANY
KIND OF REPRESENTATION BUT IT
DOES SAY YOU KNOW THAT A PERSON
WHO IS NOT COMPLY WITH OTHER
REQUIREMENTS CANNOT FILL OUT THE
FORMS.
DIDN'T SEEM TO SORT OF WHOLE
CLOTH THOUGH ELIMINATE OR
PREEMPT I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE CAN WRESTLE WITH THAT ONE
SECOND NO WE'RE SHORT ON TIME
HERE BUT I SENATOR BRIEFLY IF I
MAY YEAH I DID MENTION THAT IT
DOES REQUIRE THAT THE PERSON BE
FEDERALLY AUTHORIZED.
THERE IS NO CATEGORY OF
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT IN THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS IT DOES NOT
EXIST SO CALIFORNIA WE'RE TO
AFFIRMATIVELY AUTHORIZE THIS
GROUP -- TO PREPARE FORMS AND
SEVEN APPLICATIONS I'M IN A WAY
THAT THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS DO
NOT.
WE WOULD HAVE A PREEMPTION
PROBLEM THERE IS ONE EXTREMELY
NARROW EXCEPTION FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO.
BILLION BLANK SPACES UNPREPARED
FORMS UP FREE OF CHARGE OR FOR A
NOMINAL FEE WITHOUT HOLDING
THEMSELVES OUT AS BEING HAS
HAVING ANY EXPERTISE IN
IMMIGRATION PROCEDURE.
ON IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS DO
NOT ACT WITHIN THAT EXTREMELY
NARROW CONFINES OF THAT IS THE
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE.
ON WITH THIS BILL ELIMINATE
THOSE PEOPLE FROM DOING THAT
KIND OF WORK THOUGH.
THE BILL COULD NOT DO THAT IF
THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS
AUTHORIZE THAT -- BUT PRESUMABLY
WOULD NOT DO THAT.
SO THE THE ISSUE HERE IS
CALIFORNIA AUTHORIZING PROVIDERS
BEYOND THOSE SPECIFICALLY LISTED
IN THE REGULATIONS.
SO IF WE WERE TO AUTHORIZE LEGAL
TRAINING FOR EXAMPLE I'M AND
THEN INDICATE TO THE PUBLIC THAT
WE HAVE THIS CLASS IN CALIFORNIA
THEY CAN PREPARE FORMS AND
SUBMIT THEM. TO THE IMMIGRATION
SERVICE IN A WAY THAT THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS DON'T ALLOW
THAT WOULD BE PREEMPTED SENATE.
THEY ALLOW THE BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE THE ABILITY FOR FOR
FOR PEOPLE TO FILL OUT THE SORT
OF MINISTERIAL FORMS IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S WHOLE CLOTH ELIMINATES
IMMIGRATION CONSULTING FROM
DOING.
THAT KIND MINISTER WORK YOU'RE
SAYING THE FEDERAL CASE LAW
ALLOWS WELL THE FEDERAL
EXCEPTION IS FOR A NOTARY PUBLIC
FILLING OUT A PREPRINTED FORM
FREE OF CHARGE OR FOR A NOMINAL
FEE.
AND SO ON THAT IS THE ONE
EXCEPTION WITH.
SENATOR AND IF I MAY MAKE NO
THANK YOU -- I WOULD I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR POTS WELCOME THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE THE BILL
ACTUALLY ELIMINATES PEOPLE FROM
DOING THAT WORK IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE THAT'S IS THAT THE QUESTION
AND YES THIS BILL DOES HIS BILL
ELIMINATE PEOPLE FROM DOING
THEIR WORK WHAT YOU.
SAID IS THAT IT DOES BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT WITHIN THE FEDERAL
FRAMEWORK -- AND DO YOU AGREE
WITH THAT TEN OTHER STATES
ALREADY ALLOW IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS TO DO THIS WORK
INCLUDING THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA THEY HAVE NOT BEEN PRE
EMPTED.
AND FOR CALIFORNIA TO CREATE
THIS ACT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
AND FOR NO CHANGES TO HAPPEN
STATEWIDE OR FEDERALLY BUT NOW
ALL THE SEND IN THEIR CLAIMING
IT'S PREEMPTION.
THE COURT ONLY HELD THAT
IMPOSING PENALTIES ON
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS FOR
PRACTICING LAW WITHOUT A
PRACTICE.
THAT WE I'M SORRY WITHOUT AYE
WE'RE NOT THERE.
YET CLEARLY ON THAT YEAH LOOK
LET ME TRY TO SEE IF I CAN AND
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON BY
ELIMINATING THIS LAW DOES NOT
ELIMINATE.
THE ABILITY TO TO TO TO COMPLY
OR TO PARTICIPATING WITH THE
FEDERAL LAW.
CALLS.
FOR IS THAT CORRECT THAT IS
CORRECT THANK YOUR AND
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS
CURRENTLY DO NOT COMPLY WITH
WHAT THE ORIGIN ONLY HANDLES
REPRESENTATION UNDER FEDERAL
MATTERS.
OKAY THANK YOU -- CENTER
GONZALEZ.
YES I JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR THIS BOB THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I KNOW THAT -- YOU
KNOW I'VE MET WITH SOME OF THE
IN IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS AND I
KNOW THAT THIS ACT DEFINITELY
NEEDS AN UPGRADE -- I COME FROM
A DISTRICT THAT NOT ONLY HAS AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF LATINOS
IN THE DISTRICT BUT ALSO AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
CAMBODIAN REFUGEES.
WHO COME HERE SEEK ASYLUM AND
UNFORTUNATELY -- HAVING GIVEN
VERY BAD ADVICE -- FROM
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS AND I DO
BELIEVE VERY FIRMLY THAT WE NEED
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND
ENSURE THAT WE'RE GIVING AND
PROVIDING AS MUCH INFORMATION.
AS WE CAN AND ALSO ENSURING THAT
RATES ARE STANDARDIZED FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE I KNOW -- WE
HEAR IT EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
IT'S REALLY DOES DOES HEARTENING
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
COMMUNITY TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THIS SO.
I WOULD ALSO SAY AND THE
COMMITTEES -- ANALYSIS AS WELL
WAS PHENOMENAL I THINK OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF THIS I
THINK JUST IN ITSELF THE FORM
SELECTION FROM THE GET GO IS A
LEGAL PROCEDURE AND PROCESS THAT.
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE FOR ME
JUST HIT IT COMPLETELY SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR ROSS OF I'VE BEEN AROUND.
THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE IN THE
IMMIGRATION MOMENT MY ENTIRE
LIFE.
I AM NOT AND TURNING.
AND ALL OF THE WORK THAT I EVER
DID EITHER AS A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER ARE AS A UNION.
REPRESENTED OVER OFFICER.
ALWAYS HAD AN ATTORNEY. TO
REVIEW THE WORK.
ON IT WAS THE ONLY WAY TO REALLY
[inaudible]
BE SURE.
THAT WHAT WE WERE DOING WAS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. ONE THING
THAT MR GOOD DATA SAID WHICH I'M
TOTALLY THE AGREEMENT WITH IS WE
NEED CAPACITY.
WE NEED TO BUILD CAPACITY THIS
IS A TIME WHEN MUCH MUCH MORE
CAPACITY IS NEEDED IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
BUT SHOULD NOT COME AT THE COST
OF NOT DOING THE QUALITY
REPRESENTATION THAT OUR
COMMUNITY DESERVES.
AND ALL OF THE INDIVIDUAL CASES --
I'VE HEARD I'VE SEEN I'VE SAT
THROUGH ARE SO UNIQUE CASE BY
CASE BY CASE.
SO I CAN APPRECIATE THE
EXPERIENCE THAT HAS BEEN BUILT
UP.
BY EVERYONE HERE WHO TESTIFIED
THEY HAVE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE.
BUT THAT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY FROM
THE NEED TO HAVE THAT FINAL ROM
REVIEW.
UP BY AN ATTORNEY SO I I REALLY
THINK THAT FOR NOW THIS IS THE
WAY. TO GO BUT I URGE THAT WE
ALL KEEP TALKING -- TO THE
COMMUNITY OF IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS -- BECAUSE THEY
SHOULD NOT JUST BE SURE OF THE
SITE.
THEY PLAY A PART IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO USE THAT
EXPERTISE.
IN THIS MOMENT WHEN EVERYWHERE
WHAT WE NEEDED SO MUCH MORE THAN
WE EVER DID BEFORE SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU I THINK IN A NUTSHELL
WE NEED TO WE PROBABLY NEED TO
HAVE THESE FOLKS PARTICIPATING
BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
GOOD QUALITY PEOPLE AND I AGREE
WITH.
YOU FROM THE MOMENT YOU FILL OUT
THAT FORM YOU'RE PRACTICING LAW
YOU'RE MAKING DECISIONS.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IN THE
BUSINESS FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
WE KNOW THIS WELL BUT THEY'D BUT
TO HAVE THAT OVERSIGHT I THINK
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO
THAT WE CAN ASSURE.
ACCESSIBILITY AND QUALITY YOU
KNOW DO NO HARM SOMETIMES AND
WHEN WE FIND PEOPLE WHO RELIED
ON THOSE WHO ARE NOT QUALIFIED
AND THEY FIND THEMSELVES OUTSIDE
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF A POOR
LEGAL ADVICE SAID JETS.
ALMOST CRIMINAL SO -- HOPEFULLY
WE'LL FIGURE OUT SOME WAY THIS
IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THIS THIS
IS NOT THE FIRST RODEO ON THIS
BILL -- BUT I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS IN
THIS BILL TRIES TO ADDRESS SOME
SO.
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR TO RISE SO -- SENATOR
GONZALEZ I'M SOCIABILITY
PSYCHOLOGY SENATOR NOT ASSEMBLY
COULD BE A WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I AM
I THOUGHT ABOUT THIS BILL LONG
AND HARD BEFORE I DECIDED TO
TAKE IT ON I'VE SHARED MY STORY
BEFORE I AM A FORMALLY
UNDOCUMENTED.
YOUNG PERSON IN THIS COUNTRY OF
ON RECOGNIZE REFUGEE FROM EL
SALVADOR THIS IS A VERY REAL
ISSUE.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT I
TAKE LIGHTLY I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE OPPOSITION THAT CAME
TOAY THAT HAS MET WITH EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
AS WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
VOICES ARE HEARD -- I DO BELIEVE
THAT OVERSIGHT IS WHAT'S
NECESSARY -- TO THE POINT THAT
WAS MADE EARLIER ABOUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S ACTUALLY THE CASE FOR
THIS BILL.
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED TO
HAVE OVERSIGHT AND ANYONE THAT
FILLS OUT ANYTHING HAPPEN
RELATED TO DO WITH IMMIGRATION
AND HELPING PEOPLE STAY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
ILLEGALLY OR EVEN AN ATTEMPT TO
APPLY FOR RESIDENCY IN A POT AND
ATTEMPT TO APPLY FOR ITIZENSHIP.
IT'S WHAT WE NEED NOW.
JOBS AND CAREERS CHANGE LAWS
CHANGE WE'RE IN A TIME IN OUR
COUNTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THIS.
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
CHANGED AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
DO JUST THAT AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE IMMIGRATION
COMMUNITY IS PROTECTED AND I
WOULD NEVER EVER.
TAKE ON A BILL THAT WOULD HARM
THE IMMIGRATION COMMUNITY AND I
JUST WANT TO BE COMPLETELY
FORTHRIGHT AND HONEST ABOUT WHAT
THIS MEANS TO OUR OFFICE AND
WHAT THIS MEANS TO OUR COMMUNITY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS MADE BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE JACKSON
AYE JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN [inaudible]
I'M BURKE [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY?
WHITE HOUSE HE I FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE TO ZERO WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND NEXT UP WE HAVE -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM.
FOLLOW BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
AND I'M SORRY IS AS OF THIS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING WOULD BE UP.
IF HE WERE HERE BUT HE'S NOT SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE.
HI THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTY FILE ITEM FIFTY A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE GOOD
EVENING -- MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS -- THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF AUTHORS AMENDMENTS -- IN THE
ANALYSIS WHICH REMOVE THE
CALIFORNIA REALTORS OPPOSITION
AND I WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF
FOR YOUR HELP AND TO PATIENTS
WITH US ON THIS BILL.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE MAKESCLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE ELLIS
ACT THAT ARE INTENDED TO BOTH
ENSURE FAIRNESS FOR TENANTS.
AND REMOVE AMBIGUITY FOR BOTH
LANDLORDS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE ELLIS ACT WAS INTENDED AS A
MEANS FOR LANDLORDS TO EXIT THE
RENTAL BUSINESS.
BUT NOT AS AN END RUN AROUND
LOCAL PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS --
UNFORTUNATELY SOME LANDLORDS
HAVE USED THE LAW TO DO JUST
THAT LEADING TO UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION AND TO LEADING US.
TO REFORM THE THE LAW.
I IT WILL PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR
LANDLORDS THE REFORMS WILL
PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR LANDLORDS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND TENANTS AND PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL SECURITY FOR THOSE
WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE TO
DISPLACEMENT TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT IS BRIAN AUGUSTA.
RIGHT HERE WITH THE EYES AND
EARS TO SEE -- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS BRIAN
GUIDANCE YES YES MA'AM.
RIGHT AGAINST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND ALSO
SIGNAL MONITORING CONTROL BOARD
ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF THE
MEASURE -- THE BILL IS CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW -- WILL HELP --
INSURER CERTAINLY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND FOR LANDLORDS WITH AGO
REDUCE LITIGATION WE'RE PLEASED
TO HAVE WORKED WITH BOTH CA AND
THE REALTORS TO REMOVE ANY
CONCERNS ON THE BILL AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR NOT ABOUT.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
EACH STEP FORWARD NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
ANYA LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND YOUR HANDS WE WITH THE
CITIES OF LOS ANGELES AND SANTA
MONICA BOTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A CLEANING CHAIR JACKSON MEMBERS --
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS -- THE AMENDMENTS
CONTAINED IN THE ANALYSIS
SATISFIED CONCERNS WE JUST WANT
TO SINCERELY THANK THE AUTHOR IN
THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH US
WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE THANK YOU
AND SO YOUR ROOFTOP FOR
OPPOSITION -- YES -- VERY GOOD
OKAY THANK YOU.
SO WITH ENTHUSIASTIC NEUTRALITY
THEN I GUESS WE'RE GONNA.
GET HER AT ANY ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT OF BRINGING THE BILL
BACK ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MOTION BY SENATOR STERN THIS IS
A WE KNOW THE ELLIS ACT CAN BE
QUITE COMPLEX THANK YOU FOR
CLOSING SOME OF THESE LOOPHOLES
AND I THINK THE AMENDMENTS
FURTHER CLARIFY THE INTENT AND
AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
THERE IS NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
GOOD WORK ON THAT AND MY STAFF
FOR ASSISTING IN THAT PROCESS
AND WITH THAT.
WE HAVE IF YOU'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
CLOSE.
THIS HAS BEEN AND I THINK THREE
YEARS IN THE IN THE MAKING IT'S
BEEN QUITE US LOG IN TO WHO ARE
HAPPY TO GET TO THIS POINT
OBVIOUSLY NOT -- QUITE FINISHED
YET BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THE FINISH LINE IS
IN SIGHT THANK YOU HARD WITH
THAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY A. B.
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORDERS -- RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
SALAS AYE JONES.
WHERE CAN WE GET A MINING
[inaudible]
STERN.
STERN I BURKE.
NUMBER I WE CAL SKI.
BY KELSEY I WANT TO TRY THAT
AGAIN CENTER DERON SO SO THERE'S
NO QUESTION ABOUT ARE YOU VOTED.
BY ALL RIGHT YOU'RE ALSO I IT IT
ONLY COUNTS ONCE.
OKAY -- VOTE COUNTY IS. SIX TO
ZERO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE AB.
FOURTEEN OH FOUR A MENTOR
MEMBERS.
AND I BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
AMENDMENT.
YOU'VE AGREED TO THE AMENDMENT
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HELPING US.
TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS IN THIS
BILL MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DESERVED --
FIFTY ONE AB FORTINO.
FOR I'M SORRY GO AHEAD.
I THINK MANAGER THIS IS SIMPLE
BILL IS JUST ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
DISCLOSURE AND FAIRNESS PLAIN
AND SIMPLE AB FORTINO -- FOR
WOULD HOPE WOULD NOT DISCLOSE
THE FIRST COMPENSATION
ARRANGEMENTS BETWEEN NONPROFIT
HEALTH CARE -- CORPORATIONS AND
FOR PROFIT ENTITIES -- IT I
DON'T THINK WE COULD ARGUE THE
RISING EXECUTIVE COMPOSITION
REMAINS ISHAR HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY TODAY.
AND COMPOSITION OF FOR
COMPENSATION FOR HEALTHCARE
EXECUTIVES HAVE RISEN ABOUT 93%.
I BETWEEN THE YEARS A
200-052-2000 AND FIFTEEN AND
CONTINUES -- THE PUSH UP BY
HEALTH CARE COST.
A STUDY THAT FOUND NO LINK --
HOWEVER BETWEEN THE QUALITY OF
CARE AND EXECUTIVE COMPOSITION
IS AN INCREASE INCREASES -- IN
SPITE OF THIS NOT NONE THE LESS
NONPROFIT HEALTH CARE
CORPORATIONS ARE USING TO FOR
COMPOSITION PROGRAMS TO INCREASE --
COMPENSATION FOR THE CEOS
EXECUTIVES ABLE TO USE
RETIREMENT PLANS -- TO ALLOW
THEM TO DEFER SIGNIFICANT
PORTIONS OF THEIR INCOME AND AND
AVOID SIGNIFICANT TAX
LIABILITIES.
A TO PRISM PLAIN SIMPLE BILL
WE'RE NOT ASKING -- A NONPROFIT
DISCLOSE -- WHAT THEY DON'T
ALREADY DISCLOSE FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES I MEAN FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO DISCLOSE WHAT THEY
MAKE -- IN AND IT'S TRANSPARENCY --
WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING HIM TO
DISCLOSE A LIMITED INFORMATION
ON THE SUBSIDIES TO DEFERRED
COMPENSATION -- TO A FOR PROFIT
CORPORATION -- WE HAVE THE
WITNESS MADAM.
CHAIR IF YOU'RE OKAY WITH THAT --
ABSOLUTELY IF HE SAYS SPEAKS FOR
IN TWO MINUTES OR LESS.
BURGER MATT WAS A WITH AN S.
YEAH YOU YOU H. W. -- CHAIR
MEMBERS WE EXEMPT NONPROFIT FROM --
TAXES TO SUPPORT THEIR TERRIBLE
WORKS -- THESE TAX SUBSIDIES
THAT WE PROVIDE IS ESSENTIALLY --
FUNCTIONALLY NO DIFFERENT THAN
OUR CONSTITUENTS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WRITING A CHECK TO
THESE ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT THEY
CAN ACCOMPLISH THEIR CHARITABLE
WORK -- AND THIS IS A BIG CHECK
PARTICULARLY IN HEALTH CARE --
WHERE FOR EXAMPLE THE NONPROFIT
KAISER FOUNDATION WHICH TAKES IN
ABOUT EIGHTY BILLION DOLLARS
WITH THE REVENUE -- LAST YEAR --
IF THEY PAY TAXES LIKE A FOR
PROFIT ENTITY WOULD HAVE
CONTRIBUTED ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS --
THAT MONEY COULD BE USED TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE FOR
UNDERPRIVILEGED ARE UNDOCUMENTED
ANYTHING THAT YOU CHOOSE -- BUT
SOMETHING USE UNIQUE HOT IS
HAPPENING -- WITH OUR LARGEST
TAX SUBSIDIZED HEALTH INSURER
AND IT'S WORTH LOOKING INTO --
AS YOU KNOW -- KAISER IS NOT
JUST A SINGLE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION IN CALIFORNIA IT IS
COMPOSED OF FOUR DISTINCT LEGAL
ENTITIES TO A WHICH ARE FOR
PROFIT MEDICAL GROUPS.
THESE MEDICAL GROUPS ARE FOR
PROFIT BUSINESSES PRIVATELY HELD --
THAT PROVIDE DOCTOR AND MEDICAL
CARE TO THE FOUNDATION INSURANCE --
CUSTOMERS WELL WE DO NOT HAVE
INSIGHT BECAUSE THEY'RE
PRIVATELY HELD CORPORATIONS INTO
THE FINANCES OR INCENTIVES OF
THESE -- OF THESE FOR PROFIT
ENTITIES WE DO KNOW THAT THE FOR
PROFIT MEDICAL GROUP CHARGES
BILLIONS IN FEES TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE FOR THE FOUNDATION
PATIENTS.
WE KNOW THAT ON TOP OF THOSE
BILLIONS THEY ALSO -- CHARGE
SEPARATELY FOR NON POP FOR
EXECUTIVE RETIREMENT BENEFITS
AND OTHER COMPENSATION --
THROUGH THESE DEFERRED
COMPENSATION PLANS JUST TO SAY
THAT AGAIN JUST TO BE CLEAR IN
ADDITION TO PAYING FOR THE
DOCTOR SERVICES THEY PROVIDE
RETIREMENT AND PAID DIRECTLY THE
RETIREMENT -- SERVICES
SEPARATELY -- TO THAT --
EXECUTIVES OF THE FOR PROFIT
MISS.
IT IS SIGNIFICANT IT IS ALMOST A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND THAT IS BILLION WITH A B.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SIMPLY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
IF YOU COME FORWARD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
WINDOWS WITH US YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RONALD COLMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA ALSO
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WAS WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ON TWO HUNDRED HI GOOD EVENING --
AND HOW I GOT INVOLVED WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE IN OPPOSITION
TO A. B. -- FOURTEEN FOR THE
AUTHOR STATES THAT THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY HOWEVER LET'S BE CLEAR
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO TARGET
ONLY KAISER PERMANENT TAKE AND
THE PHYSICIANS WHO SERVE OUR
MEMBERS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE AMENDMENTS DO
NOT ADDRESS THE VERY SERIOUS
PRIVACY CONCERNS WE RAISED AND
WE STILL BELIEVE THIS
LEGISLATION UNFAIRLY TARGETS ARE
DOCTORS.
AND FOR THAT REASON WE REMAIN
OPPOSED.
IT IS UNCLEAR IF THE LISTING
OBLIGATION SUBSECTION A OF THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TO BE TREATED AS
A SEPARATE FROM THE BANDING
OBLIGATIONS IN SUBSECTION BE.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE KP TO
COLLECT AND SUBMIT FOR
PUBLICATION THE COMPENSATION
INFORMATION OF AT LEAST SIX
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
PHYSICIANS WHO PROVIDE EXCELLENT
CARE FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
K. F. H. P. HAS OFFERED A
PENSION BENEFIT TO A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF OUR PHYSICIANS KNOWN
AS THE COMMON PLANT.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CLEAR UP SOME
MISINFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THIS
PENSION PLAN IS.
THE COMMON PLAN IS ALREADY
PUBLICLY DISCO DISCLOSE IN THE
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS OF CAGE
CAMP H. P..
THE FINANCIAL PORTS GIVE
SUBSTANTIAL DETAIL ABOUT THE
POSITION PENSIONS INCLUDING THE
AMOUNT OF ACCRUED LIABILITIES
DESCRIPTION OF THE BENEFIT
AMOUNTS PAID.
AS DESCRIBED IN THE FINANCIAL
STATEMENT THE COMMON PLAN AS A
SEVEN POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
LIABILITY ON OUR BALANCE SHEET
IT IS AN UNFUNDED PROMISED BY
THE HEALTH PLAN TO PAY ELIGIBLE
PHYSICIANS A BENEFITS UPON
RETIREMENT.
ARE THE COMMON PLAN CONTRASTS
WITH THE RETIREMENT FOR OUR
UNION MEMBERS BECAUSE THOSE ARE
BACKED BY A GUARANTEED
CORPORATION.
FURTHER THE UNIVERSE TIME AND
PLANTS ARE FUNDED AND ARE
GUARANTEED BY THE THE COMMON
PLAN BENEFITS ARE NOT GOLDEN
PARACHUTES GOLDEN PARACHUTES ARE
CLAUSES IN CONTRACTS WITH
CERTAIN KEY EXECUTIVES THAT
ALLOW THEM TO RECEIVE LUCRATIVE
BENEFITS IF THEY ARE TERMINATED.
THIS PLAN CONSISTS OF RETIREMENT
BENEFITS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE A
BENEFIT SIMILAR TO THE UNION
PENSION PLANS WITH BENEFITS
DETERMINED BY YEARS OF SERVICE.
IF THIS BILL WERE TO BECOME LAW
OUR POSITION FINANCIAL
INFORMATION WOULD BECOME PUBLIC
VIOLATING FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS OF
PERSONAL PRIVACY THIS CLOSING
THIS THANK YOU.
EVEN IN ANGER GET GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES SORRY
THIS IS -- CRISTINA LOCKWOOD
COUNSEL WITH KAISER PERMANENTE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE SIMPLE BILL.
BUT EVERY COME AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR BRAND IN MARCH YOU
AT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I WE WERE GREATLY
OPPOSE THE BILL -- HALF FOR THE
REASONS STATED IN OUR LETTER
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND DAVID IS ALSO AMERICA'S
VISION GROUPS ALSO IN OPPOSITION --
WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATE
POSITION BUT WILL SIT DOWN WITH
THE OFTEN TALK ABOUT THOSE
CONCERNS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE DíAS I
WOULD LIKE -- TO RESPOND TO A
COUPLE ISSUES ONE IS THAT AS ONE
OF THE AMENDMENTS.
WE HAVE TAKEN THE INFORMATION SO
THAT IT CANNOT IDENTIFY.
ANY INDIVIDUALS -- IT TAKES BY
VIRTUE OF COMPENSATION LEVEL SO
THAT PRICE THINK TAT DEALS WITH
THE PRIVACY ISSUE.
OUR AND APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING
THAT.
AMENDMENT.
ENNIS I UNDERSTAND THE BILL IT
APPLIES EQUALLY TO ANY NONPROFIT
HEALTH CARE ENTITY WHICH OF
WITCHER SEVERAL IN THE STATE NOW
TO THE EXTENT THAT KAISER.
PERMANENTE IS THE ONLY NONPROFIT
HEALTH ORGANIZATION CARING
DEERRED COMPENSATION OF A FOR
PROFIT ORGANIZATION ON ITS
FINANCIALS WILL THEN.
THIS BILL MAY ONLY APPLY TO THEM
BUT IT IS NOT SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED TO ADD ONE SINGLE
COMPANY IT IS -- DIRECTED TO ADD
A PLAN AND APPROACH TO DEALING
WITH COMPENSATION BETWEEN AND
NOT FOR PROFIT AND THE FOR
PROFIT ARMS.
THE ART AND THE ALLEGATION I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TRUE OR NOT
IS THAT.
THERE'S AN ATTEMPT TO TRY TO
HIDE.
THAT COMPENSATION IN AN ENTITY
WHICH IS OTHERWISE NOT REQUIRED
TO REVEAL ITS ITS INFORMATION SO
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL TRIES TO
DEAL WITH.
AND I THINK IT DOES -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORED TAKING
THOSE AMENDMENTS OF FOR A DAY TO
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL -- WITH THAT
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
CENTER MORNING.
I THINK A QUESTION FIRST FOR YOU
MADAM CHAIR OR COMMITTEE STAFF.
SO THE AMENDMENT THAT PROTECTS
INDIVIDUAL IDENTITY.
AND GROUPS [inaudible]
THESE [inaudible]
LEVELS OF OF COMPENSATION.
DOES IT PROVIDE ANY -- CATEGORY
OF EMPLOYMENT EXECUTIVE
PHYSICIAN.
SO THERE IT WOULD BE SILENT AS
TO IN THE JOB CATEGORY.
THAT IS CORRECT IT DOESN'T
SIMPLY BY A DOLLAR AMOUNT.
WELL THEN ACROSS THROUGH THE
CHAIR PLAYSTATION. FOR THE
PROPONENTS.
IS THAT ACHIEVE THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT YOU THINK.
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE.
TO WELL LOOK I MA'AM MANAGER
PLEASE.
LOOK I TRUST THE WISDOM OF THE
COMMITTEE TO IT TO HELP US.
TO PROVIDE A BILL THAT DOESN'T --
CROSSOVER UP PRIVACY ISSUES AND
WE TAKE THOSE VERY SERIOUS IN A
PERFECT WORLD I'D WANT THAT
INFORMATION -- BUT BECAUSE WE
AGREE -- TO TO PROTECT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S PRIVACY -- Là
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHAT THE AMENDMENTS DO SO.
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED ITS LEAD TO
A TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TO
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TO
ONE MILLION THOSE WOULD BE
CATEGORIES.
AND AFTER THAT IT BECOMES A ONE
MILLION TO ONE MILLION AND A
HALF TO TWO MILLION TO TWO
MILLION A HALF.
UNTIL WE REACH -- POTENTIALLY UP
TO FIFTEEN MILLION IN TERMS OF
WAGES AND WHAT WE'RE BASICALLY
ASKING NOW THAT THE AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN IS.
CAN WE HAVE ON THE NONPROFIT
SIDE.
AGGREGATE NUMBERS WITHIN THOSE
CATEGORIES ABOUT WHAT THE
DEFERRED COMPENSATION IS US I
DON'T THINK IT BREACHES ANY
PRIVACY -- ISSUES AND AND LET ME
ALSO BE CLEAR.
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT SEEN IT'S
ILLEGAL.
WE'RE NOT SAYING DON'T DO IT.
WE'RE JUST SAYING IF YOU'RE
GOING TO RECEIVE NONPROFIT
STATUS -- AND IF YOU'RE GOING TO
REAP THOSE BENEFITS.
ARE IN IF YOU'RE GOING TO REPORT
ON YOUR OWN OFFICERS ON YOUR OWN
KEY EMPLOYEES ON YOUR OWN
EXECUTIVES IS A NONPROFIT.
THEN I THINK WE AS A PUBLIC HAVE
A RIGHT ALSO -- NO -- IN THESE
AGGREGATE NUMBERS.
HOW YOU ARE -- SUBSIDIZING
DEFERRED ON COMPENSATION.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I THINK YOU
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE THRUST OF
MY QUESTION I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
YOUR BILL.
I KNOW THAT.
JUST HAVING [inaudible]
AGGREGATED.
STAGES OF COMPENSATION --
WITHOUT KNOWING IS THAT GOING TO
PHYSICIANS EXECUTIVE.
SIX I THINK A IT'S A GOOD POINT
BECAUSE I'VE DONE SOME
LEGISLATION TRYING TO GET TO
SPECIFIC CATEGORIES TO DETERMINE.
IT GENDER SEGREGATION AND SO
FORTH THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY'RE I
THINK IS NOT THE GOAL OF THE
DESIGN OF THIS BILL.
IT'S REALLY TO GET TO WHY IS
THERE ALL THIS DEFERRED
COMPENSATION AND I GET THE OTHER
COMPONENT IS.
GOING FROM A NON PROFITS
REVENUES. TO FOR PROFIT.
ENTITIES OR INDIVIDUALS THANK
YOU.
BY TO GET APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING A TORY. TO GET LATE WERE
ALL GETTING A LITTLE GOOFY --
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IS OUR MOTION.
ALL RIGHT MOVE BY CENTER MINING --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BRIEFLY CLOSE.
I'M INTERESTED TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
VERY GOOD.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SHERMAN IT APPROACH
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
RUSSELL RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
BECAUSE I JONES.
JON SNOW MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN AYE ON BURKE.
NUMBER I WERE CASKEY.
CASKEY I SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN TO
ONE THE BILL IS OUT CLOSE THE
ROLE AND MOVING.
BACK I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
IN IS FASHIONABLE.
BOW TIE.
FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING -- FOR SOME JUST THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR HELP ON OUR BILL.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
FOR A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY THOUGHT
WHICH IS SOME BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS FOR GROCERY
DELIVERY THROUGH ONLINE
PLATFORMS.
WHAT THE DELIVERY PERSON HAS TO
HAVE A FOOD SAFETY TRAINING FOR
FOOD TO SPOIL EASILY?
LIKE MEAT AND DAIRY.
THE DELIVERY VEHICLE NEEDS TO
MEET VEHICLE SAFETY STANDARDS OF
HAVE LIABILITY INSURANCE.
ALSO WE IMPOSED BY DOING
RESPONSE TO ITS IN THE GROCERY
STORE IN THE ONLINE PLATFORM FOR
FOOD DELIVERY.
AND PERMIT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ENFORCE THE BILL AND DOPT.
REGULATIONS WITH THAT WE HAVE A
WITNESS -- MISTER TRICKLE FROM
YOUR SEAT AT THE WE THANK YOU OF
WITNESS HORSEPLAY IT WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CENTERS ON
NUMBER OF TRICK ON THE AFTER
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS SPONSOR THE BILL.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD -- TO
THE DOCTOR'S COMMENTS.
IS THAT THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
REGULATION OR STATUTE THAT
COVERS THE DELIVERY BY THIRD
PARTY COMPANIES.
THIS BILL FOR SIX TO FILL THAT
GAP AND IT'S IT'S A CONSUMER
PROTECTION MEASURE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FROM LEVEL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COME ON DOWN. TWO MINUTES
EACH GOOD EVENING.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CORPS IN
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF TECH MATT
IN OPPOSITION -- WE CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS --
ABSOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM AND WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND -- TRAINING
WHEN IT COMES TO FOOD DELIVERY
AND THE SAFE DELIVERY OF FOOD --
AND WHAT THOSE ODD TRAINING
MODULES COULD LOOK LIKE OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES ALREADY PROVIDE --
APPROPRIATE TRAINING MODULES FOR
THIS TYPE OF DELIVERY OF
GROCERIES OF THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY OF GROCERIES THERE'S TO
SPECIFIC IT'S AT THE LATE HOUR
OF JUST A NAME TO SPECIFIC
CONCERNS WE HAVE. WON THE
AMENDMENTS OF THE BILL THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL
AND NOW INCLUDE A MINIMUM
LIABILITY INSURANCE WHICH HAS
NOT BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE BILL AND TELL
THIS COMMITTEE -- EIGHT REQUIRES
A MINIMUM AMOUNT OF A MILLION
DOLLARS -- WHICH LOOKS LIKE
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE COMING
OUT OF THE T. AND C. Là BUT
WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE AND AND
THEY LOOK A LITTLE.
CONFUSING AS DRAFTED CURRENTLY
THE OTHER THING IT REQUIRES IS A
NINETEEN POINT INSPECTION
REQUIREMENTS -- WHICH WE
UNDERSTAND MAY BE APPROPRIATE IN
THE TNC CONTEXT WHEN THEY ARE --
DRIVING PASSENGERS BUT WHEN
YOU'RE DELIVERING DORITOS THAT
MAY NOT BE SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE AND UNLESS AND WE
BELIEVE IT'S UNNECESSARY AND
OVER BURDENSOME.
AND FINALLY THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH IS ABLE TO ASSESS
A CIVIL PENALTY OF UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
VIOLATION WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
EXCESSIVE ESPECIALLY WHEN.
THE DEPARTMENT DOESN'T HAVE TO
DO ANY GUIDANCE OF HOW WE WOULD
COMPLY WITH THIS NEW LAW.
SO WE ARE RESPECTFULLY STILL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
AARON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION --
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES
LEGISLATION -- ECHOING THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE HERE
WE BELIEVE IT'S AS A SOLUTION
LOOKING FOR A PROBLEM -- THE
FACT REMAINS THAT YOU KNOW IF
WE'RE HERE ABOUT -- SAFETY OF
FOOD THAT IS ONE THING ENTIRELY
AND AND I THINK WE'VE INDICATED
THAT WE ARE ALL FOR THAT AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO DO TO WORK TOWARDS
THAT.
THAT BEING SAID -- WE VIEW THIS
AS AN IMPEDIMENT TO THESE
COMPANIES THAT PARTNER -- THE
WITH WITH -- NOT ACTUALLY
PARTNER BUT UP PROVIDE SERVICES
TO THESE GROCERY COMPANIES THAT
ARE A LOT OF CASES -- UNION
SHOPS -- AND A LOT OF CASES
PROVIDE.
MORE BUSINESS THE SHOP SO -- WE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT LEGISLATION
THAT MAKES MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THAT -- MIGHT HAVE THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT OF THIS BILL IN IN TERMS
OF MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT --
FOR BRICK AND MORTAR GROCERS AT
TO DO THEIR BUSINESS THESE UP
THE APP PLATFORMS PROVIDE A NEW
MEANS -- TO GET MORE CUSTOMERS
INTO OUR VIRTUAL DOORS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT THIS ACTUALLY
MIGHT HAVE ANOTHER TEN A
CONSEQUENCE OF HAVING.
LESS CUSTOMERS INTO BRICK AND
MORTAR SHOPS MOST LIKELY YOU
HAVE SHE W. SHOPS AND DRIVE
BUSINESSES TO OTHER PLACES THAT
WILL HURT BOTH -- EMPLOYERS AND
AND OUR EMPLOYEE PARTNERS AND
FOR THAT REASONS AND AND OTHERS --
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES
MEASURE ASKING ABOUT THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION BUT I'M
SURE BENEFIT COME OUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
KEVIN KELLY WITH INTERNET
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
IN A FEW ON BEHALF A DOOR DASH
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
OUR GLASS IN ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE THE LIABILITY
FOR US THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HARD OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
DYESS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
RUSSELL.
A SENATOR WHY CASKEY HAVE A
QUESTION -- IT'S WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FOOD SAFETY WE HAVE ALL
THESE DELIVERIES TO COME FROM
RESTAURANTS THAT WOULDN'T BE
COVERED BY THIS BILL WHAT'S THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
GROCERY STORES AND RESTAURANTS
THIRD I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION IF.
YOU HAD THE LIVER IF ANY OF THE
GROCERY STORES DID THESE
DELIVERY.
THEY WOULD HAVE ABOUT TEN TO
TWENTY TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
REGULATION.
IT'S AN EXTENSION OF THE GROCERY
STORE.
AFTER BY BY ALL THE DIFFERENT
REGULATIONS THAT THEY A PIE BY
WITHIN THE GROCERY STORE OUTSIDE
THE GROCERY STORE.
THIS PROVIDES A MODICUM OF
CONSUMER SAFETY AS WELL AS
PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY AND TRIES
TO ALSO CREATE IN EVEN THIS
BETWEEN PLATFORMS THE THE
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD HAPPILY
TOOK IN THIS COMMITTEE.
REALLY WAS CONSISTENT WITH THOSE
WITH LIFT AND UBER SO AGAIN
WHILE -- IN THE STENSON
MENTIONED THE TNC MODEL WELL THE
YOU KNOW THE MOST PROFITABLE
PART OF THE UBER BUSINESS MODEL
IS AN ACTUALLY.
DRIVING YOU ARE ME IT'S ACTUALLY
UBER EATS.
SO AGAIN ON AS THEY IF THEY WERE
TO GET MORE INVOLVED IN THIS
PLOT FROM I THINK IT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE TO BE CONSISTENT AMONG
THE DIFFERENT PLATFORMS.
AND WE HAD WE WE SEE THIS IS A
VERY -- SMALLER NOT A REGULATION
SPECIALLY RELATIVE TO THE AMOUNT
OF REGULATION TO GROCERY STORES
FACE I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION
IS THE THE MODIFICATION OF THE
VEHICLE THAT'S REQUIRED.
UNDER THIS BECAUSE A LOT OF
THESE.
I WAS JUST USING WINDOWS LIVE
SERVICES OVER THE WEEKEND ISSUES
REGULAR TOYOTA.
CORONA SO I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT
WOULD.
AFFECT THAT SERVICE IF THE IF
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THESE.
YOU KNOW MODIFICATIONS.
FOR SAFETY.
SO THE THE PREVIOUS VERSION IF
I'M A MANAGER PLEASE -- THE
PREVIOUS THE FIRST VERSION OF
THE BILL.
I WANTED TO WE TRIED TO MIRROR
EXACTLY WHAT WHAT GROCERY STORES
HAVE TO DO WITH DELIVERIES.
IF A GROCERY STORE USE IT ON A
PLACE TO DO IT BECAUSE HE'S
DELIVERY STAFF HAVE A
REFRIGERATED VEHICLE THAT WAS
THE FIRST FOR THE BILL.
THAT WAS THE OPPOSITION RAISED
AS A CONCERN.
THE DRIVERS DON'T HAVE
REFRIGERATED VEHICLES OBVIOUSLY
IN THE FLOOD FROM SO WE REMOVE
THAT.
AND WE WONDER BRING CONSISTENCY
IN TERMS OF THE SAFETY OF THE
VEHICLE ITSELF OF THE VEHICLE
IT'S NOT A MODIFICATION IT'S A
VEHICLE INSPECTION.
WHICH MEMBERS THE VEHICLE
INSPECTION USED FOR UBER LIFT TO
MAKE SURE THE VEHICLE SAFE THAT
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF THE VEHICLE PER SE.
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
LIABILITY PROVISIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE IS FOR REQUESTED WHICH
DOCTORS ACCEPTED IN THE
SPONSORED ACCEPTED FLAT JUST TO
CLARIFY THAT.
ARE YOU DONE WITH QUESTIONS YES
THE CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I
DIDN'T REALLY I DIDN'T HAVE THIS
BILL ON MY RADAR COMING IN IT IT.
SEEMS IT PUSHED IT PUSH THE
ENVELOPE A BIT BUT I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AMENDMENT ADDED ON THIS
LIABILITY ISSUE SO.
I CERTAINLY OPEN VOTING FOR ON
THE FLOORS WANTED TO RAISE THAT
AND HOLD ON HOLDING OFF TODAY
BUT WILLING TO LOOK AT THAT I
JUST.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU MIGHT FIND
SOME DUPLICATION UNNECESSARILY
WHERE YOU'VE GOT ALREADY IF
YOU'RE TAKING PASSENGERS ON GET
THE INSURANCE POLICY BUT IF
THERE ARE NO PASSENGERS ON BOARD
AND JUST GROCERIES ON BOARD
OWNERS UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'D HAVE
A SIMILAR LIABILITY POSSIBLE LET
ME DIGEST A LITTLE FURTHER AND
VISIT.
BEFORE THE FORCE OF THANKS.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT JUST TO RESPOND TO THAT
THE ISSUE OF LIABILITY IS PART
OF A CHILD WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH YEARS.
THE DRIVERS OF SIMILAR TO RELIVE
DRIVERS ARE TREATED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS TO THEM
AND OF IN THE DELIVERY OF FOOD
OR PASSENGERS IS
DRIVER.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO PROTECT THE
DRIVERS -- TRYING TO EMULATE AS
MANY REGULATIONS AND LAWS THAT
APPLY TO EMPLOYEES TO THESE
DRIVERS IN THIS IS THE REASON
WHY.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
AMENDMENT TO ADD THE LIABILITY
INSURANCE OTHERWISE.
THE DRIVER WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE COURSE OF
DELIVERING FOR THE PLOT FROM
COMPANIES THAT AS A MATTER OF
FACT WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
DRIVERS UNDER.
DYNAMICS ARE IN FACT EMPLOYEES
AND THIS IS PART OF NINE OUT OF
TEN WE GET TO TOMORROW I DON'T
WANNA GET TO DYNAMIX TONIGHT
THANK YOU -- BUT WE KNOW DRIVERS
CAN CAUSE ACCIDENTS REGARDLESS
IF THEY HAVE PASSENGERS AND
THAT'S I THINK THE THE GIST OF
THAT.
ALL RIGHT -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS --
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION BY CENTER MORNING.
ALL I'M SO SORRY SENATOR ALSO
HAS ALREADY MOVE THE BILL --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN.
SHE THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEES HELPED US RESPECT
FRANCE RIGHT.
THANK YOU FIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY SEVEN A.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY JACKSON HI
JACKSON FIVE LARGEST RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WHAT HEALTHY I? FIVE TO ONE FIVE
TWO ONE THAT -- WITH ALL MEMBERS
PRESENT.
THE BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
I HOPE YOU'LL KEEP.
RECESSIONS GOING I DON'T THINK
WE'RE THAT FAR OFF THE THE TRACK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- RUBIO I THINK
YOU ARE NEXT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO RIP
TO PRESENTED AN A. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN AN ACT RELATING TO THE
ADVERTISING OF AN LICENSE CAMPUS
BUSINESSES.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
FORMALLY ACKNOWLEDGING THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN COMMENTS
TWO ONE FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS.
THE AMENDMENTS AGREED TO IN THE
PRIOR COMMITTEE STRIKE THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION FROM THE
BILL AND CREATE SOME FLEXIBILITY
IN THE ASSESSMENT OF CIVIL
PENALTIES. FOR THAT ENFORCEMENT
CAN BE FOCUSED ON BAD ACTORS AND
IT IS NOT USED TO HARSHLY PUNISH
HONEST MISTAKES.
AS YOU KNOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEGAN ISSUING
LICENSES AT THE BEGINNING OF
LAST YEAR FOR THE KIND OF ITS
BUSINESS TO OPERATE IN THE STATE.
DESPITE SOME SUCCESSES DURING
THE FIRST YEAR AND A HALF OF
LEGAL CELLS THE BLACK MARKET HAS
CONTINUED TO FLOURISH DRIVING
DOWN LEGAL SALES.
RESEARCH AND STUDIES HAVE
ESTIMATED THAT AS MUCH AS 80% OF
THE CAMERAS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
IS DONE VIA THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET.
IN ADDITION TO DWINDLING TAX
REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
PRESENTS SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT CANNABIS PRODUCTS SOLD AT
THESE LOCATIONS DOES NOT MEET
ESTABLISH QUALITY STANDARDS AND
EVADES THE STATE TESTING.
COMBINING THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
IS A KEY POLICY GOAL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR AS WE WORK
TO IMPLEMENT PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR THIS BILL HERE TODAY
WILL TARGET THE BLACK MARKET BY
CRACKING DOWN ON A SPECIFIC
PROBLEM THE ADVERTISING OF
ILLEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
CERTAIN PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PRACTICE OF ADVERTISING ILLEGAL
OPERATIONS FOR PROFIT.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WILL
CREATE SEVERAL POUND THE
PENALTIES FOR ENTITIES WOULD
DECIDE TO ADVERTISE THE LEGAL
OPERATIONS IN EXCHANGE FOR
PROFIT.
AS A LEGISLATURE WE CANNOT SAY
THAT WE ARE TAKING THE CANNABIS
UNDERGROUND MARKET SERIOUSLY IF
WE ALLOW THE END REULATED
PROMOTION AN ADVERTISEMENT OF
THE LEGAL.
BUSINESSES TO EXIST WITHOUT
CONSEQUENCE WE KNOW THAT THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS DRIVE BUSINESS
TOWARDS ILLEGAL OPERATIONS AND
MUST FIND A WAY TO RESTRICT THIS
PRACTICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY AND WITH ME HERE
TODAY I HAVE THE CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL MARVIN PINEDA ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED CANNABIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION.
AND ALABAMA THOUGHT TO RECALL ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH.
THE COMMENTER OVER TO RECALL ME
OFF THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL.
ON YOU IF YOU DOUBLES BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY FROM HELL TO HER
CALIFORNIA. ONE OF OUR PRINCIPAL
OBJECTIVES IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS INDUSTRY CRATES GOOD PAYING
JOBS.
LETTERS TO THE MIDDLE CLASS.
WHAT'S UNDER CUTTING THAT EFFORT
IS THE LIST OF MARKET PLACE.
WHEN A COMPANY GETS INTO THE
GETS IN THE CANISTERS BUSINESS
AND THEY DON'T HAVE A LICENSE
THEY DON'T GO THROUGH THE
TESTING PROCEDURES?
THEY DON'T PAID OF REQUIRED
WAGES IT DEPRESSES THE
MARKETPLACE AND LOWER THE WAGES
AS A RESULT.
THIS BILL IS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR EFFORTS TO BRING
GREATER ENFORCEMENT.
AND TO SERVE WITHOUT WITHOUT THE
JUST THE THE BAD ACTORS OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LEVEL.
IT WAS A TERRIBLE PUN THANK.
I WILL GET BACK TEN SECONDS AND
PASS EXCUSE ME THERE ARE TWO
WITNESSES ARE YOU WORKING IN
TANDEM YES.
OUR WATER SHOULD GO AHEAD THAN A
MIGHT BE AND I CALIFORNIA
ADVOCACY.
HERE WE HAVE WE SEE BE ABLE GIVE
MY REST THE TIME TO CHAIR KYLA.
HELLO MINISTER CALLING THE
PRESIDENT A CAN AS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION PROP SIXTY FOUR IS
PASSED TO REGULATE MEDICAL AN
ADULT USE CANNABIS.
AND THE OVERSIGHT OF NECESSARY
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS FOR NINE
LICENSE HOLDERS HAVE LEFT A
THRIVING ILLEGAL CANNABIS MARKET
THE ABILITY TO FLOURISH UNDER
THE GUIDANCE OF ONLINE
ADVERTISING PLATFORMS.
LIKE WE'D MAPS THEIR CONTACT
THEIR CONNECTING AND
FACILITATING THE SALE OF
ILLEGALLY GROWN AND MANUFACTURED
PRODUCTS THAT CONSUMERS -- CAN
GET THREE LEGAL RETAILERS AND
DELIVERY BUSINESSES THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES HAS TWO THOUSAND
ADVERTISE RETAIL LOCATIONS ON
THE TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO OF THOSE
LOCATIONS ARE LEGAL
OVERWHELMINGLY THE CONSUMERS ARE
CONFUSED WITH DECEPTIVE
ADVERTISEMENTS.
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO STRIP AWAY
THE MARKERS THAT DIFFERENTIATE A
LEGAL AND ILLEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESS THIS IS THE DELIBERATE
IGNORANCE OF WHO YOUR
ADVERTISING FOR AND IS A MAJOR
REASON FOR THIS BILL'S NECESSITY --
IF CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LOOK
THE OTHER WAY WHITE THE LEGAL
BUSINESSES SATURATE THE MARKET
MORE TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS ARE
FOLLOWING THE PROFITABLE
BUSINESS MODEL A SUPPORTING
THESE ILLEGAL BUSINESS IF.
THE SLIPPERY SLOPE OF MAKING
ENFORCEMENT AND TAX COLLECTION
NEAR IMPOSSIBLE OR JUST TOO
EXPENSIVE FOR LEGAL
MUNICIPALITIES.
LOTS OF RESTRICTED THIS KIND OF
ADVERTISING ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
BEFORE AN OWNER'S A BACK PAGE
DOT COM A SERVE JAIL TIME FOR
THEIR AIDING AND ABETTING
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY SO THIS IS NOT
A PRECEDENT SETTING CASE.
NOW THE TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TAKE
CONTROL THE LARGEST CAKE
COMMERCIAL CAM WITH MARKET IN
THE WORLD AND GUIDE THE LEGAL
MARKET TO A FACE AN EQUITY
POSITION FOR THE REST OF THE
WORLD EMULATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH THE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I GUESS THE LEGACY OF KINGS ON
BEHALF OF EASE THANK YOU. FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE
WITH IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
MELANIE GRIFFITH WITH KING
TUNNEL IT'S AN APARTMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE CMA THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION IS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING AARON NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTION ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO THE HUMBOLDT GROWERS.
ALLIANCE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING BRANCH THE ROBERT
HALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
IN HER MY STAR TESTIMONY
[inaudible]
JUST GETTING.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GEORGE
MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE AFTER
MENTIONED COMPANY WE'D MAPS --
WE DON'T DISAGREE THAT THERE IS
AN ABUNDANCE OF ON LICENSE
ENTITIES ADVERTISING ON THE
INTERNET.
INCLUDING ON SITES LIKE WE'D
MAPS.
BUT IT GOES BE MUCH BEYOND WE'D
MAPS IF YOU REALLY WANT TO GET
AFTER THAT GOES ACROSS ALL THE
ADVERTISING PLATFORMS ON THE
INTERNET.
ANYBODY HERE NOW IF YOU WANT TO
PULL OUT YOUR PHONE AND YELP.
CANNABIS DISPENSARIES IN
SACRAMENTO I DARE YOU TO FIND
THE LICENSE NUMBER ON ANY ONE OF
THOSE ADVERTISEMENTS.
GO TO GOOGLE GO TO YA WHO GO TO
BANG GO TO CRAIG'S LIST DO THE
SAME.
THE BILL IS SPECIFICALLY
TAILORED TO NOT APPLIED A
INTERNET PLATFORMS BUT TO APPLY
THE WEED MAPS ONLY WE ARE ONE
COG IN THIS.
PLATFORM ARENA -- IN FACT WE'RE
PROBABLY ONE OF THE SMALLEST
CARDS ALTHOUGH WE ARE.
CANNABIS SPECIFIC.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE GO RIGHT TO
THEIR SEARCH ENGINE TO START IF
THEY'RE GOING TO START A SEARCH.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT IS PRESS.
PRESIDENT SETTING THAT IN IT WAS
IT WAS A REFERENCE TO BACK PAGE
CONGRESS ACTUALLY CHANGE THE LAW.
AS A RESULT OF THE ADVERTISING
THAT WAS TAKING ON TAKING PLACE
ON BACK PAGE. TO EXPLICITLY
CARVE OUT PROSTITUTION SEX
TRAFFICKING.
THEY SPECIFICALLY DID THAT TO
EXEMPT OUT TO INCLUDE.
EXEMPTS THEM OUT OF TWO THIRTY
AND DENY THEM THE PROTECTIONS
THAT SECTION TWO THIRTY THE
COMMUNICATIONS DECENCY ACT
PROVIDES.
EVEN SO ASSUMING FOR THE SAKE OF
ARGUMENT TO SECTION TWO THIRTY
DID NOT APPLY AND THERE WASN'T A
PREEMPTION.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT HURDLES TO
COMPLIANCE WE'D MAPS ADVERTISERS
CONTENT PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED
THREE DIFFERENT TIMES TO ATTEST
TO THE FACT THAT THEY DO HAVE A
LICENSE THEY ARE REQUIRED.
TO FILE FILL A LICENSE NUMBER IN.
WE DO NOT VERIFY EVERY LICENSE
NUMBER NOR COULD WE IF WE WANTED.
TO THERE ARE MANY ISSUES WITH
THE FEAR OF CANNABIS CONTROLS
WEBSITES SUCH AS DOING BUSINESS
NAMES DOING BUSINESS AS NAMES
ARE NOT NECESSARILY LISTED.
SO GEORGE MILLER COULD HAVE AN A
LICENSE NUMBER BUT IT WOULD NOT
SHOW UP IS.
HIGH TIMES DISPENSARY SO OR NOR
ARE THE ADDRESSES NECESSARILY
REFLECTIVE OF THE BUSINESSES
THEMSELVES VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY.
ALL RIGHT OF OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS JIM YOU
WERE WITH A CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE STRICT
LIABILITY IMPOSED.
ON THE WEBSITE OPERATORS -- FOR
LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW
I WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE WE THINK WE'RE
CLOSE TO GETTING AN AMENDMENT
THAT ADDRESSES ARE CONCERNED.
BUT WE ARE STILL THINKING ABOUT
THAT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WERE IN
JENSEN ON BEHALF TECH THAT --
ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION BUT
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LIABILITY ON THE ADVERTISING
PLATFORM AND THINK THAT THE
BURDENS OF THIS BILL ARE MORE --
APPROPRIATELY PLACED ON THE
ADVERTISERS THEMSELVES THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OR BRING IT BACK TO THE DIET SO
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
SENATOR MONNING.
I'D JUST LIKE TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
A CHANCE TO RESPOND TO SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS MAYBE IN
YOUR CLOTHES BUT THEY RAISE SOME.
I THINK LEGITIMATE CONCERNS JUST
CURIOUS HOW YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MISTER MILLER'S CONCERNS SO ARE
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING -- TO
INCLUDE OTHER PLATFORMS AND IN
THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE THE CHAIR
OF THE MP -- INCLUDED OGHAM
TECHNIC NOW THOSE FOLKS SO WHEN
THEY WERE INCLUDED WE WORKED
WITH -- GOING TECHNIQUE AND THE
OTHER -- PLATFORMS AND WE REMOVE
THE OPPOSITION THEY STILL HAVE
CONCERNS BUT WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK IN TERMS OF MISTER MILLER --
WE HAD A CONVERSATION ABOUT --
HOW THE WORD TO TO VERIFY AND?
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY IS SO NEW
THAT EVEN -- TRYING TO OBTAIN
THE INFORMATION.
THEY CLAIM IT'S NOT EASY BUT IF
YOU HAVE -- TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IN YOUR PLATFORMS I AM SURE THAT
YOU CAN DEDICATE SOMEBODY -- TO
VERIFY THE LICENSES AND PART OF
THE DISCUSSION WAS THAT WHEN YOU
ADVERTISE -- YOU ARE REQUIRED TO
PRESENT -- EITHER AN AD AND I
ASKED THEM TO JUST INCLUDE AN
ADDITIONAL LINE TO PUT THE
LICENSE NUMBER AND HE IS CORRECT
NOT EVERYBODY DOES PUT THE
LICENSE NUMBER AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE INTENDING IS
THAT.
THEY DO AT LEAST DO THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE -- THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY -- TO FOR IN TERMS
OF THE FINES IF IT'S THE FIRST
TIME THERE'S WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT A SOLUTION SO THAT THEY
DON'T GET FIND THE FIRST TIME
BUT THE SECOND AND THAT AND ANY
SUBSEQUENT TIMES.
THEY WILL BE FINED AND SO FOR ME --
AND I THINK FOR FOR THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
ALL OF THE E. LEGAL SHOPS THAT
ARE BEING ADVERTISED AND SO.
WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
AT LEAST THE ONLINE PLATFORMS
ARE COMPLYING WITH THE WITH THE
REQUEST.
ADDITION IT DOES SOUND.
THAT RIGHT TO CURE THE FIRST
NOTICE OF VIOLATION YES YET TIME
TO REMEDY IT BEFORE THERE'S ANY
PENALTY YES AND THAT THAT WAS
PART OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
TOOK IN THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATOR STIRRED.
VERY BRIEFLY THOUGH IT JUST.
TO PUT A FINE POINT ON THAT SO.
YOU'RE SAYING THE OPPOSITION
SAYING THERE'S NO.
NO ACTUAL LICENSE NUMBER THAT
THEY COULD USE TO TRACK THAT.
NOW THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT TRUE
IN FACT LICENSES.
LICENSE DISPENSARIES ARE ISSUED
A LICENSE.
THE THE COMPLICATING PAR IS
ACTUALLY FINDING OUT ON THE
BUREAU'S SITE WHO THE LICENSEE
IS SO THEY ARE LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS ARE ISSUED A LICENSE
NUMBER.
THEY ARE ASKED BY OUR WEBSITE I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY ARE
ASKED BY THE OTHER WHETHER
THEY'RE ASK MY YELP OR NOT TO
POPULATE A FIELD WHERE THEY HAVE
WITH.
THE FOR OKAY THE E. FILL OUT
THINGS WE HAVE TO PUT YOUR
SOURCE CODE AND I'M RUNNERS NINE
BOXES ARE YOU FILL OUT.
YOU HAVE TO DO THAT ON OURS AS
WELL IT'S NOT ABOUT DEDICATING
SOMEBODY A WEED MAPS OR SOMEBODY
AT YELP OR SOMEBODY CRAIG'S LIST
TO GO CHECK IT.
IT'S A MATTER OF DEALING WITH
THE BUREAU'S OFTENTIMES THIRTY
DAYS OR MORE STILL ISSUE A
LICENSE BUT IT MAY BE THIRTY
DAYS BEFORE IT IS IT'S ON THE
WEBSITE OR FOR LICENSES REVOKED
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE BEFORE IT
COMES DOWN OFF THE WEBSITE.
WHEN YOU ISSUE A LICENSE TO
GEORGE MILLER BUT GEORGE
MILLER'S ACTUALLY DOING BUSINESS
AS?
YOU KNOW HIGH TIMES DISPENSARY.
AND I GO TO GO TO THE BUREAU'S
WEBSITE LOOK OF HIGH TIMES
DISPENSARY AND I CAN'T FIND
ANYTHING AND I PULL THEM DOWN
BECAUSE ARE NOT LICENSED AND
THEN I FIND OUT NOW.
GEORGE MILLER HAS GOT THE
LICENSE ACTUALLY HAS IT THAT THE
BUREAU JUST DOESN'T HAVE THE DBA.
SO LET'S HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE RAT AND MISSED MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND JUST WANT
TO START OFF WITH THIS PREMISE
PROP SIXTY FOUR WAS TRAPPED IN
WHEN SPUR OF THE BILL.
I FORGOT TO MENTION IS THE
UNITED MEDICAL MARIJUANA
COALITION FROM SAN DIEGO AT THE
LONG BEACH COLLECTIVE
ASSOCIATION THE COLLECTIVE
VALLEY CAM JUST COULD YOU ANSWER
COULD YOU RESPONSIBILITY MIGHT
MIGHT MY ANSWER TO THAT TO THAT
IS THAT THERE ARE.
ONLINE PLATFORMS THERE EVEN
PRESENT HERE IN THE ROOM THAT
OUR ADVERTISING ONLY FOR ILLEGAL
SHOPS THERE IS A WAY TO VERIFY
THAT ONLY AT THE BUREAU OF
CANADA'S CONTROL BUT IF YOU HAVE
A BUSINESS LICENSE NUMBER.
SO THAT ARE YOU MAN IT'S HOW IT
SO YOU COULD JUST CALL.
THE DEPARTMENT IN THEIR FIGHT
THE LICENSE NUMBER FOR EACH FOR
EACH AT ODD ODD DISPENSARY SO
IT'S VERY EASY AND CLEAR THAT
SPENT THAT THAT HAPPENED THAT
COULD BE DONE AND IS DONE BY LEE
FLEA.
AND OTHER ONLINE PLATFORMS SO --
WE WE DISAGREE WITH MISTER
MILLER AS A COULD BE DONE.
WHAT WE HAVE IS -- OVER
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED ODD ILLEGAL
DISPENSARIES BEING ADVERTISED ON
THE APP ONLINE PLATFORMS AND
THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT THIS
ADDRESSES PROP SIXTY FOUR DID
NOT CREATE ANY PENALTIES.
FOR OUR LANDLORDS OR ONLINE
PLATFORMS THAT ARE DOING ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES THERE ONLY ON
LICENSEES SO THAT'S WHY WHEN THE
BUREAU OF CANADA'S CONTROL ISSUE
A SEASON THIS IS LETTER.
LAST YEAR.
ENTITIES LIKE WE MAP THAT OUT TO
RESPOND BECAUSE THERE'S NO
PENALTIES THIS IS THE FIRST STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OUR ALL RIGHT THE SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS WE DO HAVE A
MOTION -- I WOULD JUST SIMPLY
ASK YOU TRY TO WORK OUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE VERY CLOSE TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS I THINK
THAT CENTER MONNING WAS.
INDICATING.
A CONCERN THAT.
AGAIN HOW DO WE MAKE SURE IF
WE'RE GONNA HAVE STRICT
LIABILITY WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE SOME.
CONDITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH IT
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE VERY
VERY CLOSE TO THAT KIND OF
RESOLUTION SO.
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR COMPLETING
THAT.
THE BILL I DO THINK THOUGH THAT
DEALS WITH A VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM THAT THE ADVERTISING BY
ON LICENSE CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
CAN REALLY POSE A HEALTH RISK
I'M TOLD THIS IS NOT.
YOUR MOTHER'S CANNABIS AND YOUR
MOTHER'S.
ANYWAY IT'S NOT IT'S NOT THE
CANNABIS OF THE THE OLD DAYS IF
YOU WILL -- AND THAT THEY CAN BE
LACED WITH ALL SORTS OF THINGS
AND WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THAT -- WE CAN PROTECT THE
PUBLIC IN PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE
SAME TIME SO WITH THAT THERE'S A
MOTION AND THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FOUR A.
B. FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ CONSOLES I
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN I BURKE.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY.
MY COUNTY I SEVEN ONE SEVEN TWO
ONE SEVEN TO ONE THE BILL IS OUT
WILL CLOSE ROLE THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR GOOD WORK ON
THIS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
GETTING TOWARDS THE END OF
SIMPLY MEMBER OR WHEN YOU HAVE A
SERIES OF BILLS UP.
WE'LL START WITH -- FILE ITEM.
SIXTEEN L. A. B..
FIVE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB.
FIVE TWO THREE THIS BILL IS IN
RESPONSE TO TROUBLING
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISM THAT
UNCOVERED THE PRACTICE OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
SELLING SENSITIVE A REAL TIME
DATA LOCATION OF THEIR
SUBSCRIBERS.
THIS INFORMATION WAS AND
PACKAGED AND RESOLD TO MIDDLEMAN.
ANYBODY WILLING TO PAY USUALLY
BOUNTY HUNTERS ARE OTHERS WITH
AN INTEREST IN FINDING AND
STOCKING INDIVIDUALS.
THIS BILL WILL PROHIBIT A
WIRELESS TELECOM PROVIDER OR ANY
DIRECT INDIRECT AN AFFILIATE OF
THE PROVIDER FROM DISCLOSING
CELL SITE LOCATION INFORMATION
TO ANY PARTY.
WITHOUT FIRST OBTAINING THE
SUBSCRIBERS EXPRESS CONSENT THE
BILL ALSO CONTAINS EXEMPTIONS
FOR NINE ONE ONE PURPOSES SO
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS CAN
LOCATE CALLERS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT UNDER CURRENT LAW THIS SAME
LOCATION INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE ONLY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- IN NON EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS WITH A SEARCH WARRANT.
IT'S AVERY IMPORTANT PROTECTION
DUE TO THE HIGHLY SENSITIVE
NATURE OF YOUR LOCATION WITH AB
FIVE TWO THREE CALIFORNIANS WILL
BE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR REALTIME
LOCATION AND DATA.
PROTECTED AND OUT OF THE HANDS
OF STRANGERS.
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK
CORRIVEAU THANK YOU OTHER ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ITEM.
I GUESS NOT -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IT'S STEP FORWARD
PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLTON PROCEED TI A WHERE THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY TRADE
ASSOCIATION -- WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR FOR THE
BETTER PART OF THIS YEAR -- AND
WE WERE CLOSE AND I THINK OUR
CLOSE.
TO IT WE'RE IN AGREEMENT THAT --
CELL SITE LOCATION INFORMATION
SHOULD BE OPT IN --
UNFORTUNATELY -- THE WAY THESE
AMENDMENTS HAVE HAVE.
HAVE THE EVOLVED.
HAS CREATED AN UNWORKABLE
SITUATION LIKE TO EXPLAIN
[inaudible]
FIRST CONTEXT.
THE IFORMATION THAT WAS.
THAT WAS USED WAS PROVIDED TO A
THIRD PARTY AGGREGATOR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THINGS LIKE ROADSIDE
ASSISTANCE AND FIRST ALERT -- IT
WAS AN EASIER WAY FOR ALL THE
CARRIERS TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION TO ONE ENTITY.
THEY CERTAINLY DID NOT EXPECT
NOR AUTHORIZE THE ENTITY TO SELL
IT TO ANYBODY OTHER THAN.
THOSE THAT THEY HAD CONTRACTED
THEM TO DO.
ONCE THEY DETERMINED THAT TO BE
THE CASE THEY STOPPED THE
PRACTICE SO IT IS NOT GOING ON
NOW SO.
IN EFFECT -- THE THE THE GOAL OF
OF OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUNS
BILL HAS BEEN HAS BEEN ACHIEVED --
BUT ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
WE'RE ONLY LOOKING AT YOUR
LOCATION INFORMATION
[inaudible]
FOR WIRELESS COMPANIES -- I
THINK IS FOLKS KNOW.
MANY OTHER ENTITIES HAVE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF YOUR LOCATION
INFORMATION OFTEN WITH MUCH MORE
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION.
CONNECTED TO IT.
AND THEY ARE NOT COVERED NOR
TREATED -- BY THIS BILL --
FURTHER MORE -- IT'S TECHNICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE. FOR A KERRY TO
PREVENT A SELL SIDE FROM
TRANSMITTING INFORMATION TO A
THIRD PARTY THEY PAYING ALL THE
TIME.
AND THERE ARE THIRD PARTY GROUPS
THAT HAVE THIRD PARTY SOURCES
THAT HAVE PRECISE LOCATION OF
CELL SITES SO.
IN EFFECT THERE'S NO WAY.
WE CAN ASK FOR CONSENT WHEN IT'S
IT IS AN AUTOMATIC.
WE KNOW SENDING OUT OF THE
SIGNAL -- WE CAN WORK ON THAT
BUT THAT IS A REALLY CONCERNED
AND THESE ARE THESE ARE
RELATIVELY NEW AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE DYESS -- I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THIS IS AN OPT IN I WISH WE
HAD MORE THEM WHEN IT COMES.
TO PROTECTING OUR INFORMATION
BUT THIS CLEARLY.
OF REQUIRES AN OPT IN TO PROVIDE
TO EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT.
THAT INFORMATION TO BE --
AVAILABLE.
AND YOU CAN OPT OUT ANYTIME YOU
WISH.
OF ALL OF THIS HAS TO BE
DISCLOSED TO THE CONSUMER
ANOTHER GOOD ITEM.
SECONDLY OF FOR MY FRIENDS FROM
THE CHAMBER AND SHE JACKET ALSO
PROVIDES FOR PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION.
AGAINST THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES FOR DELIBERATE
DELIBERATE VIOLATION SO IT
ACTUALLY PUT SOME TEETH INTO
THIS.
OF REQUIREMENT AND CERTAINLY
GIVES.
MEANING TO OUR RIGHTS AND PUTS
BAD ACTORS ON NOTICE THAT THEY
WILL BE HELD RESPONSIBLE.
THE NOTION THAT IT'S RISKS
REGARDING WIRELESS ONLY PERHAPS
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP AND GOING
FORWARD WE CAN HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS. FOR OTHER.
ENTITIES AND CERTAINLY OTHER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AT WORK FOR
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY.
HAS BEEN RELATIVELY FREE TO DO
WHAT IT WANTS AND THERE REALLY
BEEN NO WAITED OR KNOW.
A CONTAINMENT OF IT SO I THINK
THIS BILL DOES SAD AND I
APPRECIATE.
TO OF THE THE VARIOUS CONDITIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN.
PUT INTO THIS BILL AND I THINK
IT'S NARROWLY CRAFTED TO ADDRESS
AT THE VERY SPECIFIC PROBLEM OF
SELLING OURSELVES CELL.
SITE LOCATION INFORMATION HIS TO
MUCH SELLING GOING ON OF OUR
INFORMATION AND THIS.
COULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS.
OF WHO CAN BE TRACED AT ANY
MOMENT BY AN ABUSER AND A
VARIETY OF AREAS WHERE.
NOT ONLY IS OUR INFORMATION
BEING TAKEN BUT OUR LOCATION.
I THINK HE'S A VERY DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT SO.
I SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT AND DID.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
RUSSELL ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY OF THE MOTION OF
THE IS -- DO PASS.
THE SENATE APPROACH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I I JUST
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEE DID -- TO PUT THIS
LANGUAGE TOGETHER AND AND IT HAS
BEEN VERY DISTURBING TO READ THE
STORIES IN THE NEW YORK TIMES.
SIX MONTHS AGO AND THEN -- YOU
KNOW THEY THEY HAD IT ALL THE
TELECONFERENCE YOU SAID THEY
STOPPED THIS PRACTICE AND THEN
YOU HERE FOR A FEW MONTHS LATER
THAT IT'S STILL GOING ON SO --
WE DO WANT THIS TO STOP AS I
SAID IT THIS IS THE MOST
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE INFORMATION
WHEN YOU CAN TRACK PEOPLE LIVE
AND ESPECIALLY.
WORRISOME FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
RIGHT -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B.
FOR FIVE TWO THREE THE MOTIONS
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I A
JONES [inaudible]
MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN HI -- BURKE.
NUMBER I WOULD CAL SKI.
I KELSEY BY. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
TWO ZERO ALL MEMBERS ARE HERE
IT'S SO THAT BILL IS SO CLOSE
THE ROLE.
AND MOVE ON NOW TO OF FILE ITEM.
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU --
THE NEXT BILL I AM PROTECT
RESENTING IS -- AB.
EIGHT SEVEN THREE THIS IS THE
FIRST OF TWO BILLS THAT I'M
OFFERING THI YEAR AS A RESULT
OF EXTENSIVE WORK BY THE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE TO BRING THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY TOGETHER.
AND UNDERSTAND HOW TO IMPLEMENT
CCPA AND I AS AS YOU AS YOU
BEGIN THEN I WE'VE OFFERED OR
ASKED TO TO ACCEPT CERTAIN
AMENDMENTS THAT WE PROPOSE ARE
YOU AGREEING TO ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS I'M NOT GOING TO BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT.
OF FIVE I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR PUTTING -- EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
OF AS THE THE SECOND OF THE TWO
BILLS THE CHAMBER WORK
DILIGENTLY VERY DIFFERENT BILL.
HI YES -- THE CHAMBER WORK
DILIGENTLY TO DISTILL THE
NUMEROUS CONCERNS OF THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY INTO A SHORT
LIST OF CRITICAL ISSUES.
THAT WOULD IMPEDE THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY FOR PROVIDING
CALIFORNIANS WITH THEIR NEW
RIGHTS PROMISE BUT TO THEM BY
CCPA.
CCPA PASS THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROESS IN JUST ONE
WEEK DUE TO THE IMPENDING
DEADLINE TO REMOVE AN INITIATIVE
FROM THE BALLOT IN THE THREAT OF
A LIMITED FUTURE ABILITY TO
LEGISLATIVELY UPDATE THE
INITIATIVES PROPOSED PILOT
POLICY RIGHTS.
THERE WAS LITTLE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR DIVERSE STAKEHOLDER INPUT
AND THE RESULT IS A LOT THAT CAN
BE CONFUSING.
AND PRESENTS SOME SERIOUS
PRIVACY CONCERNS AND OPERATIONAL
CHALLENGES FOR BOTH BUSINESSES
AND CONSUMERS.
MANY OF US LEGISLATORS LAMENTED
THE NECESSITY A NECESSITY OF OF
THE PROCESS BUT IT WAS FLAWED.
AND WE WERE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THOSE WHO HAD OPERATIONAL
CONCERNS ABOUT CCPA BEFORE ITS
EFFECTIVE DATE.
THIS BILL TAKES ON TWO OF THOSE
CONCERNS TO THE DEFINITION OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
WHICH I'M HAPPY THAT THE CHAIR
AND I AGREE ON AND THE
DEFINITION OF DE IDENTIFIED WE
WORKED EARLY ON WITH ALISTAIR
MAKE THAGARD AND HIS GROUP
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY. TO MAKE SURE THE BILL
WAS MAKING THE INTENT OF CCPA
OPERATIONAL.
IN THE ASSEMBLY WE TOOK ALL OF
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
BRINGING HIS GROUP TO A NEUTRAL
STANCE AND THE EMAIL IS PASSED
AROUND THAT -- THAT SHOWS THAT.
WELL I WILL LET MY WITNESSES GET
INTO THE WORKING DETAILS OF THE
BILL THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THESE TWO
THRESHOLD CONSIDERATIONS.
AND MAKES THE CPA IMPLEMENTATION
MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
WORKABLE.
IT IS KEY THAT THE CCPA IS
WORKABLE BECAUSE IT SHOULD BE
THE MODEL FOR ALL STATES TO
ADOPT AVOIDING CALLS FOR FEDERAL
PREEMPTION.
THAT UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION
WOULD LIKELY BE FAR WEAKER.
BUT WE MUST EXPORT TO OUR SISTER
STATES A WORKING MODEL NOT ONE
THAT IS OVER BROAD AND HAS AND
TO DEFINITIONS.
THE DEFINITION OF DE IDENTIFIED
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO FIX AS
MANY IMPORTANT TYPES OF CONSUMER
RESEARCH ARE CONDUCTED WITH DE
IDENTIFIED DATA.
WE RECEIVED A LETTER THIS
MORNING OR THIS AFTERNOON I
SHOULD SAY SUPPORTING OUR DE
IDENTIFIED DEFINITION FROM JOHN
LEAVE AWAITS THE CHAIR OF THE
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION.
DURING OBAMA'S FIRST TERM HE
OVERSAW THE FTC'S LANDMARK
TWENTY TWELVE OF PRIVACY REPORT
AND THAT EACH OF YOU SHOULD HAVE
THAT.
LETTER AND PART OF IT STATES I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE CURRENTLY
DISCUSSING THE APPROPRIATE
STANDARD FOR WHAT CONSTITUTES DE
IDENTIFIED.
DATA AS PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY LAW.
MY BELIEF IS THAT AB EIGHT SEVEN
THREE CONTAINS A STRONG STANDARD
FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
AND HE AND HE ENDS WITH
THEREFORE.
A IT IS MY VIEW THAT THE
APPROACH A PROPOSED BY AB EIGHT
SEVEN THREE IS WELL SUITED TO
PROTECT CONSUMER PRIVACY.
I BELIEVE IT OFFERS THE RIGHT
LEGISLATIVE PATH.
FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND AGAIN
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN PASSED --
PASSED OUT TO YOU.
AND I'M PLEASED TO HAVE WITH ME
TODAY HAVE BOTH SERRA BOOT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND JUMP JIM HELP HEARD
FROM THE DLA PIPER OR FROM DLA
PIPER WARY AS A PARTNER AND CO
CHAIR.
OF THEIR GLOBAL DATA PROTECTION
PRIVACY AND SECURITY PRACTICE
THANK YOU.
OF WHO WANTS TO START.
A PLEASE OKAY.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SERIBU WITH CAL CHAMBER
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED IN THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY COMMITTEE AND
IT REFLECTS A COMPROMISE
PROPOSED BY CALIFORNIANS FOR
CONSUMER PRIVACY A GROUP FUND
FOUNDED BY ALISTAIR TAGGART.
ALTHOUGH THERE WERE OTHER
SERIOUS CONCERNS WE WISH TO
ADDRESS WITH THIS BILL INCLUDING
THE PRIVACY IMPLICATIONS OF
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS BEING ABLE.
TO ACCESS ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE HOUSEHOLD.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE IS NOW
BOIL DOWN TO JUST TWO FIXES
FIRST ADDING THE WORD REASONABLY
IN FRONT OF CAPABLE BEING
ASSOCIATED WITH IN THE
DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION. TO THIS LANGUAGE
PERSONAL INFORMATION IS ANY
INFORMATION THAT COULD IN THEORY
BE ASSOCIATED WITH SOMEONE.
THIS IS NOT WORKABLE OUR
PREFERENCE WAS TO REMOVE CAPABLE
BEING ASSOCIATED WITH FROM THE
LAW. TO COMPROMISE WE KEPT IT
NEARLY ADDED A REASONABLENESS
STANDARD WHICH WILL AT LEAST
ADDRESS OUR MOST EXTREME
CONCERNS AND WHICH MATCHES THE
REASONABLENESS STANDARD THAT
ALREADY EXISTS IN THE LAW FOR
LYNN COUPLE DATA.
SECOND AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE
FIXES THE DEFINITION OF DE
IDENTIFIED DATA.
THE AUTHORS OF THE CCPA INTENDED
A TRUE EXEMPTION FOR DE
IDENTIFIED DATA BECAUSE WE WANT
IT TO BE DE IDENTIFIED IT IS A
PRO PRIVACY PRACTICE TO
INCENTIVIZE BUSINESSES TO INVEST
IN THEIR RESOURCES TO DE
IDENTIFY THEIR DATA AND KEEP IT
DE IDENTIFIED BECAUSE DE
IDENTIFIED DATA IS FAR LESS
VULNERABLE TO COMPROMISE AND
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE DATA.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CZ P. STATES
THAT DE IDENTIFIED DATA MUST NOT
RELATE TO OR BE CAPABLE OF BEING
ASSOCIATED WITH A PERSON BUT
THOSE THINGS ARE ALWAYS TRUE OF
DE IDENTIFIED DATA AND THE TERM
LOSES ALL MEANING IF IT'S NOT
AMENDED.
SO AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREES
REVISED DEFINITION OF DE
IDENTIFIED WAS DRAWN FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION FTC'S
PRIVACY FRAMEWORK IT IS A WELL
TESTED WIDELY ACCEPTED PRO
PRIVACY APPROACH THAT REQUIRES
KEEPING DATA DE IDENTIFIED.
FURTHER AS PART OF OUR
COMPROMISE EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE INCLUDES ROBUST
REQUIREMENTS A BUSINESS MUST
MEET FOR THEIR DE IDENTIFIED
DATA TO QUALIFY FOR AN EXCEPTION.
THAT ARE EVEN STRONGER THAN THE
FTC APPROACH THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY FOR BUSINESSES TO
REALISTICALLY RACIALIZED THIS
LAW IT STRENGTHENS THE CCPA IT
IS PRO PRIVACY IT WILL MAKE
CONSUMER SAFER.
THANK YOU.
WHICH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY
NAME IS JIM HALPERT AND I'M IN.
PRIVATE PRACTICE ADVISING DOZENS
OF CLIENTS ON PRACTICAL
COMPLIANCE WITH CCPA. ONE OF THE
AREAS THIS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC IS THE NINE
DEFINITION OF DE IDENTIFIED DATA
THAT BOTH.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- OR NGUYEN AND
SERVE -- JUST ADDRESSED IT'S
ALMOST ENTIRELY CIRCULAR AN
EXTREMELY CONFUSING FOR ANY
CONSUMER WHO WOULD READ THE LAW
AND ALSO FOR BUSINESSES.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE WOULD FIX
THIS THE ALTERNATIVE WOULD NOT.
AND IF THIS IS REALLY A A
CRITICAL ISSUE INSTEAD OF
CLARIFYING THE DEFINITION DEAL
AMENDMENTS WOULDN'T CREATE
NARROW EXCEPTIONS ONLY TO THE
ACCESS DELETION AND RIGHT TO
KNOW RIGHTS.
BUT NO EXCEPTION TO THIS CCPA DO
NOT SELL REQUIREMENTS.
THIS MAY SEEM SENSIBLE AT FIRST
BUT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT ONCE
A BUSINESS RECEIVED A DO NOT
SELL REQUEST.
THEY WOULD NEED TO PROACTIVELY
RELAYING ALL DE IDENTIFIED DATA
IN RESPONSE TO THAT REQUEST THIS
IS NOT REQUIRED UNDER BY THE
CURRENT LAW.
AND WOULD ACTUALLY REQUIRE
LINKING IN ASSOCIATING ALL DATA
FOR THAT PURPOSE THIS WOULD MEAN.
BRINGING MORE DATA TOGETHER
CREATING SECURITY RISKS AND
INCENTIVES FOR BUSINESS IS
ACTUALLY TO USE THE DATA TO
MONETIZE IT EVEN IF THEY WEREN'T
SELLING IT.
SO THE NET EFFECT IS NOT TO
INCREASE PRIVACY THE AMENDMENTS
ALSO -- DON'T ADDRESS OF THE AN
ISSUE THAT DATE AB EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE DOES VERY WELL THEY DON'T
INCENTIVIZE THE IDENTIFYING DATA
THEY SIMPLY CREATE EXCEPTIONS TO
HAVING TO RESPOND TO REQUESTS.
UNDER AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE IF
THE DATA WERE EVER RE IDENTIFIED
IT WOULD BECOME FULLY SUBJECT TO
THE C. CPA AND ANY RECIPIENT WHO
READ AND A FIGHT IT.
WOULD NEED TO IMMEDIATE WOULD
VIOLATE THE C. SPEAKS CITY PA
LESS IT NOTIFIED EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT WHOSE DATA
HAD BEEN RE IDENTIFIED BECAUSE
IT WOULD BE COLLECTING
INFORMATION IN NEED TO PROVIDE
NOTICE.
AT OR BEFORE THANK YOU A TIME OF
COLLECTING YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
KEVIN KELLY WITH INTERNET
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY HIT WITH COUNTY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SEVEN MORE ON
BEHALF OF THE ADVANCED ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
AND THE CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
OR AGENTS OR TECH THEN SUPPORT.
RAINY PART CONSUMER DATE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
STEVE CARLSON CTA IN SUPPORT.
BENJAMIN POWER ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS AND SUPPORT.
BERNIE ROSCOE CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ART GLAD SHE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
MY PULLOUT CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
COMMINGLED WITH CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JIM WOOD
WITH A CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
JOHN CALDWELL CALIFORNIA HOTEL
LODGING ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA LINE TIME TO SEE IF.
CHRIS OSWALD ASSOCIATION
NATIONAL ADVERTISERS AND SUPPORT.
THAT CHOICE ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERACTIVE ADVERTISING BUREAU
IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS BOLGER THE ELECTRONIC
TRANSACTIONS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
KELLY ASKED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK.
HI GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR I'M
ARTEFACTS JOHNSON WITH COMMON
SENSE MEDIA AS CO SPONSORS OF
THE CCPA WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THIS YEAR WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AND
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
LAW.
INSTEAD ALL OF THE SURVIVING
PRIVACY BILLS WERE NOW
CONSIDERING OUR INDUSTRY
REQUESTS FOR EXCEPTIONS.
AS THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
ADVOCATES A WE'VE WORKED WITH
BILL AUTHORS WHO'VE BEEN SEEKING
REASONABLE CLARIFICATIONS
UNDERTAKEN IN GOOD FAITH.
NONETHELESS OTHERS ARE TRYING TO
WROTE THE LAW AND CUT BACK ON
CONSUMERS RIGHT. EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE IT REPRESENTS AN EROSION.
THIS BILL WOULD LIMIT WHAT IS
PROTECTED UNDER THE LAW AND IT
DOES NOT FALL THE FTC STANDARD
WHICH MY COLLEAGUE JAKE WILL
DISCUSS FURTHER.
UNDER THE CCPA.
COMPANIES ARE ABLE TO FREELY USE
AND SHARE DE IDENTIFIED
INFORMATION INFORMATION THAT
CANNOT REASONABLY BE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CONSUMER.
IT IS NOT PART OF THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN
REQUEST ACCESS TO OR SAY DON'T
SELL.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE IT LOWERS
THE THRESHOLD OF WHAT QUALIFIES
AS DE IDENTIFIED.
UNDER THE AUTHOR'S OWN
INTERPRETATION IT COULDN'T
EXCLUDE IP ADDRESSES
[inaudible]
DEVICE IDENTIFIERS.
BROWSER FINGERPRINTS AND WHAT A
BROWSER FINGERPRINT IS IS BITS
OF INNOCUOUS SEEMING INFORMATION
LIKE YOUR SCREEN RESOLUTION YOUR
OPERATING SYSTEM.
AND YOUR DEVICE MODEL THAT TAKEN
TOGETHER ARE USED TO UNIQUELY
IDENTIFY YOU AND YOUR DEVICE.
THERE IS A NEW YORK TIMES
ARTICLE ABOUT THIS JUST LAST
WEEK BECAUSE THIS IS HOW ADD
TECH COMPANIES ARE TRACKING US
UBIQUITOUSLY AND INVISIBLY
ACROSS THE WEB.
NOW THAT MORE PEOPLE ARE
BLOCKING COOKIES IN OTHER WORDS
THESE TRACKING TOOLS ARE USED BY
COMPANIES TO ABATE AND AVOID
PEOPLE'S PREFERENCES.
AND IF THEY ARE EXCLUDED FROM
CCPA PROTECTIONS THEY WILL
SIMILARLY BE USED BY COMPANIES
TO IGNORE IT CONSUMERS DO NOT
SELL PREFERENCE.
THE IDENTIFICATION IS NOT
PRIVACY PRODUCTIVE TECHNIQUE.
IF DE IDENTIFIED INFORMATION
THAT CAN IDENTIFY YOU THIS IS
PRECISELY THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT A LOT FOR THE
PERVASIVE TRAFFIC YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD EVENING -- MY NAME IS JACOB
SO I'M AN ATTORNEY AT THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE TECHNOLOGY AND CIVIL
LIBERTIES PROJECT ON I LIKE TO
TAKE YOU TAKE THREE POINTS AWAY
FROM MY TESTIMONY TODAY.
FIRST ELECTRONIC IDENTIFIERS OR
JUST A SENSITIVE AS REAL WORLD
IDENTIFIERS LIKE NAME ADDRESS IS
YOU GET SIMILAR PROTECTIONS AB.
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE PRINCE TO
TAKE THOSE AWAY.
SECOND THE LAW MUST PROTECT
AGAINST TECHNIQUES ALLOW SO
CALLED ANONYMIZED INFORMATION TO
BE RE ASSOCIATED WITH CONSUMER
HOUSEHOLD OR DEVICE THOSE
TECHNIQUES ARE POWERFUL TODAY.
GET MORE SOPHISTICATED AND THIRD
AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE DOES NOT
REPLICATE.
THE FTC STANDARD PROJECT ON
VACATION.
QUITE THE CONTRARY IS NARROWER.
IS LESS CLEAR.
AND IT IS.
LESS PROTECTIVE THAN THE
STANDARD LAID OUT IN THE FTC
REPORT.
IF THE COMMITTEE WISHES TO USE
THE FTC STANDARD THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ARE CLOSER.
THE POINT ONE WE PROTECT NAMES
AND ADDRESSES EVEN THOUGH NAMES
AND ADDRESSES DON'T NECESSARILY
ALWAYS REFER TO A SINGLE PERSON
MORE THAN ONE PERSON CAN LIVE IN
ADDRESS.
I. P. ADDRESSES WOULD BE
EXCLUDED ACCORDING TO THE AUTHOR
FROM THE DEFINITION.
FROM FROM PERSONAL INFORMATION
AND WOOD QUALIFIES DE IDENTIFIED
UNDER AB.
EIGHT SEVENTY THREE BUT I. P.
ADDRESSES CAN BE USED AND ARE
USED TO TRACK PEOPLE THE MOVE
ACROSS THE INTERNET.
THE SAME IS TRUE DEVICE
IDENTIFIERS.
PROBABLY ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM
OR HOLDING A CELLULAR PHONE.
AND THAT THE CELLULAR PHONE HAS
A DEVICE ID ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
BUT UNDER.
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY THREE THAT
DEVICE ID WOULD QUALIFY.
AS DE IDENTIFIED IF YOU YOU CAN
CONSIDER -- THE AUTHOR'S
INTERPRETATION.
THAT MOBILE PHONE IS ME MY
MOBILE PHONE IS ME AND ANYTHING
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH MY MOBILE
PHONE IS ASSOCIATED WITH ME.
PRIVACY MEANS PROTECTING THAT
INFORMATION JUST AS YOU WOULD
ANYTHING IT'S ABOUT ME.
LOCATION INFORMATION IS SIMILAR
AND I'LL REFER BACK TO THE NEW
YORK TIMES ARTICLE SHOWING TO
DETERMINE YOUR TIME THAT AND
LOOK ISN'T MAYES COMEDIAN ON
LIES.
AS FOR THE FTC STANDARD THANK
YOU.
YOUR TWO MINUTES FOR A PERHAPS
WILL BE SOME QUESTIONS AND WILL
BE ABLE.
TO A FURTHER ELABORATE ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE [inaudible]
YES.
TRACY ROSENBERG FROM OPEN
PRIVACY IN OPPOSITION THIS IS
NOT A PRIVACY PROTECTIVE BILL
THANK YOU.
MORE IN HONEY OF CONSUMER
REPORTS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
THE COURT ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARING
HOUSE WILL WE WOULD HAVE REMOVED
OPPOSITION WITH THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL AND
PRINT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE DíAS [inaudible]
SO.
I AM ALSO -- STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL HAD THE AUTHOR TAKEN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE PROPOSED
I THINK WE WOULD HAVE A GOOD
BILL.
BUT WHAT YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND
IS THE CCP A IS AN UMBRELLA.
AND PERSONAL INFORMATION IS
WITHIN THAT UMBRELLA.
DE IDENTIFIED INFORMATION IS NOT
IN THAT UMBRELLA.
IF IT IS DE IDENTIFIED IT IS
OUTSIDE THE PROTECTION OF THE
CCPA THAT'S WHY ALL OF THESE
BUSINESS GROUPS THE TECH GROUPS
AND WHAT HAVE YOU HAVE COMMON IN
SUPPORT.
BECAUSE THE LESS PERSONAL
INFORMATION THERE IS THE MORE
OPPORTUNITY THERE IS FOR THEM TO
TAKE THAT THE QUOTE UNQUOTE DE
IDENTIFIED INFORMATION.
AND SELL IT.
AND USE IT ANY WAY THEY WANT
WITHOUT THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
OF THE CCPA WATER HOSE
PROTECTIONS.
THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
INFORMATION IS BEING ACCUMULATED
ABOUT YOU.
THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO OPT OUT
OF THAT.
AND THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO
DELETE THAT INFORMATION.
IF IT'S CALLED DE IDENTIFIED
INFORMATION WHICH THIS BILL WILL
EXPAND AND TAKE.
A LOT OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
OUTSIDE THAT UMBRELLA PROTECTION.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY RIGHTS BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T FALL WITHIN THE CCPA
PROTECTIONS.
IS THAT A BASIC ANALYSIS A IS
THAT A SORT OF A VERY SIMPLISTIC
VIEW.
NOT SIMPLISTIC IT'S CORRECT PARK
WITH WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE CHECK IS IN THE MAIL OKAY.
SO TO PUT IT SIMPLY.
WHEN A CONSUMERS INFORMATION IS
CONSIDERED PERSONAL INFORMATION
IT'S A FOR THOSE PROTECTIONS?
IF IT'S DE IDENTIFY IF IT'S
DETERMINED TO BE DE IDENTIFIED
INFORMATION IT HAS NO
PROTECTIONS.
THIS BILL TAKES AND TRIES TO
EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF DE
IDENTIFIED NOW INFORMATION AT
ONE POINT COULD BE QUOTE ON
QUOTE DE IDENTIFIED BUT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT WITH THE
ALGORITHMS IN ALL OF THE
SOPHISTICATED INFORMATION.
OR TOOLS THAT ARE OUT THERE IN
THE INDUSTRY THAT DE IDENTIFIED
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT
PROTECTED THAT YOU HAVE NO RIGHT
TO KNOW ABOUT.
CAN YOU CAN IN FACT BE RE
IDENTIFIED I'M NOT SURE THAT'S
THE CORRECTTERM BUT WITH
ALGORITHMS THEY CAN FIGURE OUT
THE THATCH YOU.
AND THEN YOU ARE REALLY UP.
A CREEK WITHOUT A LADDER.
IS NOW.
BEING SENT OUT INTO WHO KNOWS
WHERE WITH YOUR SPECIFIC.
DATA AND PROFILE ON IT.
AND THAT IS WHY I THINK THIS IS
A A DANGEROUS BILL AGAIN THE C.
C. P. A FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS A
PRETTY WEAK KAPITI.
BUT IT'S WHAT WE'VE GOT.
AND THOSE WHO WORKED HARD ON THE
BILL LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR.
THERE WERE IS A A COMMITMENT
THAT WE WERE NOT OING TO DO
ANYTHING TO UNDERMINE IT IF WE
NEEDED TO CLARIFY WELL THEN
WOULD CLARIFY BUT I KNOW I HAD A
BILL EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT I
THOUGHT.
OF WHO HELPED WITH THE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM BUT DID
NOT TOUCH THE THE JUST THE BONES
OF THE CCPA ITSELF AND THAT'S
THE COMMITMENT THAT WE HAVE MADE --
THE BILL BECOMES EFFECTIVE WHAT
IS A JANUARY.
A JANUARY FIRST -- IT WILL BE IT
WILL BE A BILL THAT IS THE THE
TEMPLATE FOR THE NATION IF WE
START UNDER CUTTING IT NOW BY
TAKING AND EXPANDING THE
DEFINITION THAT PULLS
INFORMATION OUTSIDE OF THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE C. CPA.
WE HAVE THE WILL OF TAKEN WHAT I
THINK IS A WEEK CUP OF TEA AND
TURNED IT INTO WATER.
SO -- I APPRECIATE THAT THE
AUTHOR AND I HAVE DISAGREED -- I
DIDN'T SEE THIS LETTER UNTIL
SEVEN O'CLOCK TONIGHT BUT NONE
THE LAST YOU KNOW IF A GOOD
LAWYER WOULD SAY WELL WHAT IS MR
LIEBOWITZ.
A POSITION NOW WHO DOES HE
REPRESENT -- BUT I DO KNOW IS
THAT THE CO AUTHORS OF THE
ORIGINAL BILL ARE HERE IN VERY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO IT
COMMONSENSE MEDIA.
AND THE FRONTIER OF FOLKS -- OR
WHO WORKED ON IT WORKED ON THIS
BILL -- IT LAST YEAR TO GET IT
PASSED -- ARE NOW STRONGLY
OPPOSE BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT IS
SOMETIMES POLITELY REFERRED TO
IS A JAIL BREAK.
THAT'S MY PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
AND I'D LIKE IS AT A FAIRLY
ACCURATE DESCRIPTION OF OF HOW
YOU SEE THIS BILL AS WELL FOR
THIS THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MIGHT I RESPOND
NO SIR YOU CAN RESPOND WHEN
THEIR QUESTIONS ASKED SENATOR
MONNING.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
IN THE COMMITTEE STAFFS WORK ON
THIS.
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS.
ENGAGEMENT.
IN ALL THESE AREAS NOT JUST THAT
REPRESENTED IN THIS BILL I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR THE AUTHOR'S
RESPONSE.
OR I GUESS MY QUESTION THE
AUTHOR.
WHY DO YOU FIND THESE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS OBJECTIONABLE?
OF BY I WILL CERTAINLY GO
THROUGH THAT AND I I WANTED TO
CLARIFY A FEW THINGS THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE ACLU TALK
ABOUT.
THE DATA LIKE LET'S SAY I. P.
ADDRESSES AS SOON AS AN IP
ADDRESS IS.
IS ASSOCIATED WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
IT DOES BECOME PI AND AND THE
SECOND THING THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY IS THAT IF WE ARE GOING
TO SAY THAT.
NO INFORMATION THAT IS DE
IDENTIFIED CAN BE USED FOR
ANYTHING.
THEN WE HAVE A REALLY BIG
PROBLEM IN BEING ABLE TO DO
SCIENTIFIC DATA OR USE BIG DATA
TO IMPROVE -- IMPROVE LIVES IT
IS IT THERE IS NO THIS IS THIS
COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE AN EFFECT
ON RESEARCH THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE AN EXCESS A
AFFECT ON TRANSPORTATION THERE'S
ALL SORTS OF BIG DATA DE
IDENTIFIED DATA THAT WE CAN USE
FOR OUR OWN. FOR FOR THE BENEFIT
OF IMPROVING LIVES
UGH THE REASON THAT I AM NOT
WILLING.
TO TAKE THIS LANGUAGE IS FIRST
OF ALL THIS LANGUAGE.
HAS TAKEN SIX MONTHS OF
NEGOTIATION AND THE ACTUAL
AUTHOR OF THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION IT WAS -- ALISTAIR
MACTAGGART AND AFTER THAT WE
TOOK HIS AMENDMENTS HE DID GO --
NEUTRALIZE IT THE AMENDMENTS TO
THIS -- WERE SHARED WITH MY
OFFICE LESS THAN FORTY EIGHT
HOURS AGO.
AND WHILE THE WHOLE COALITION
HAS NOT HAD TIME TO FULLY
ANALYZE THE PROPOSAL THEIR
INITIAL READING.
OF THAT RESULTED IN A RESOUNDING
OBJECTIONS IS THAT IT WOULD GO
IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION AND
FOR OUR DE IDENTIFIED OF FIX AS
A MATTER OF FACT WE THINK THIS
FIX IS A WORSE THAN.
THE ORIGINAL BILL.
UNDER EXISTING.
LAW INFORMATION WHICH IS LINKED
OR ASSOCIATED WITH THE CONSUMERS
FREELY MARKETABLE INSURABLE
UNTIL A CONSUMER OFFICE OUT
VERSUS THE CPA.
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE WOULD
PROHIBIT THE SALE OR SHARING OF
NON LINKED TO OR NON ASSOCIATED
DATA ENTIRELY WHICH POSES
EXTREMELY LESS RISK TO PRIVACY.
BEEN LINKED TO OR ASSOCIATED
DATA AND AGAIN I THINK THAT
THERE IS.
AN INCREDIBLE PROBLEM IF WE SAY
IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE NOT GOING
TO ALLOW ANY USE OF DE
IDENTIFIED DATA.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT IN.
I'M SURE IF I COULD DIRECT A
QUESTION TO THE ACLU
REPRESENTATIVE BECAUSE I PLACE.
WHAT I'M GATHERING FROM THIS?
IS A DISAGREEMENT KIND OF AND
DEFINITION OF WHAT DOES
CONSTITUTE DE IDENTIFIED BECAUSE
I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
YOU SAID.
THE IDENTIFYING INFORMATION IN
HERE.
IT IDENTIFIES ME.
IF IT'S IN THE HANDS OF SOMEONE
ELSE MAYBE NOT WITH MY NAME OR
MY ADDRESS.
BUT I'M THE ONLY ONE THAT HAS.
THIS IDENTIFYING NUMBER IN THIS
DEVICE.
AND THAT.
ALLOWING THAT TO BE SHARED OR
PURCHASED OR CONSIDERED.
DE IDENTIFIED.
IS IN AN ACCURATE DESCRIPTION
COULD YOU CONFIRM OF FIVE GOT
THAT RIGHT OR SURE SURE SO --
THAT UNDER AB -- EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE SOMETHING LIKE A DEVICE ID
COULD BE CONSIDERED THE
IDENTIFIED -- AND THE FURY THERE
AND I THINK YOU'VE HEARD THIS
FROM -- FROM THE AUTHOR AND FROM
THE SUPPORTERS -- THAT THE IDEA
IS THAT THAT DEVICE IDENTIFIER
DOES NOT IS NOT ASSOCIATED WITH
INDIVIDUAL.
THE FACT IS THAT ANYTHING THAT
IS ASSOCIATED WITH MY DEVICE FOR
YOUR DEVICE IS ASSOCIATED WITH
ME OR YOU. FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU GO
TO A WEBSITE ON YOUR MOBILE
PHONE.
THAT WEBSITE CAN RECOGNIZE --
YOUR BROWSER TO YOUR DEVICE ID
OTHER INFORMATION ABOUT THAT --
CONNECTION AND THEN THEY CAN
SERVE YOU ADVERTISEMENTS -- TO
THE SAME PERSON BASED ON THE
BEATING THE SAME MOBILE PHONE
NOW.
THAT MOLD THAT BAD BUT WEBSITE
YOU'RE GOING TO DOESN'T KNOW
THAT YOU'RE SENATOR MONEY.
ALL IT KNOWS IS THAT YOU'RE
SOMEBODY COMING FROM YOUR PHONE.
THAT'S A QUICK WANT TO IDENTIFY
YOU TO RECOGNIZING YOU INTO
RESPONDING SPECIFICALLY TO YOU
AS A PERSON.
SO TO TAKE THAT A STEP FURTHER.
IF I MADE A AMAZON ORDER.
ON THIS [inaudible]
IN A SOMEBODY ELSE HAD ACCESS TO
THIS DEVICE IN ITS PRACTICES IT
COULD KNOW WHAT I ORDERED FROM
AMAZON WITHOUT NECESSARILY
KNOWING.
MY NAME OR MY ADDRESS.
BUT IT COULD.
THEN PROLIFERATE BACK TO THIS
DEVICE FURTHER ADVERTISING
RELATED TO THAT PURCHASE
PREFERENCE WHAT TO KNOW -- USING
FOR EXAMPLE A COOKIE IS THEN
YOU'DLOOKED AT A PARTICULAR --
PRODUCTS ON AMAZON I THINK WE'VE
ALL HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
BROWSING AROUND THE INTERNET
LOOKING AT A BLENDER OR
SOMETHING AND THEN HAVING THAT
SAME BLENDER SHOW UP ON
DIFFERENT WEBSITES.
NOW IT WORK WHOEVER WITH THE AD
NETWORK THAT SENDING YOU A
PICTURE OF THE BLENDER DOESN'T
KNOW YOUR NAME.
IT DOESN'T ASSIST MEAN I MIGHT
KNOW YOUR NAME BUT IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY KNOW YOUR NAME IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY KNOW YOUR
ADDRESS -- BUT IT DOESN'T KNOW
THAT YOU ARE THE PERSON.
WHO LOOK AT THAT POINT -- AND SO
IT IS COMPILING THIS LIST OF
INFORMATION NOW LOOK ALSO IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT BLENDERS IT'S
ABOUT WEBSITE YOU VISIT --
THINGS YOU SEARCH IN A SEARCH
ENGINE WHICH CAN REVEAL
RELIGIOUS COMMITMENTS POLITICAL
AFFILIATIONS.
YOUR YOUR THE THE THE YOUR FEARS
THAT YOU LOOK INTO A SEARCH
NGINE IT POTENTIAL MEDICAL
HEALTH ISSUES ALL THAT
INFORMATION.
CAN BE ASSOCIATED WITH YOUR THE
PERSON BUT ALSO WITH DEVICES.
UNDER THE BILL BEFORE US
[inaudible]
THAT.
ABILITY TO TRACK.
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS CELL
PHONE WOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED --
IF YOU TAKE A IDENTIFIED.
IF YOU TAKE A DEFINITION THE
IDENTIFIED DOES NOT INCLUDE IP
ADDRESSES IT DOESN'T INCLUDE
DEVICE ID'S.
THEY WOULD PERMIT THAT KIND OF
TRACKING.
THANK YOU NO FURTHER QUESTIONS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO AS CORRECT --
OR TWO SHARE THE FACT THAT THE
EXISTING DEFINITION OF THE AYE
FOR DE IDENTIFIED THE CURRENT IN
THE CURRENCY CPA.
DOES NOT PRECLUDE IN ANYWAY
RESEARCH.
SO WHAT WHAT THIS NEW DEFINITION
DOES IS IT NOW INCLUDES
INFORMATION THAT.
IS REASONABLY CAPABLE OF BEING
ASSOCIATED BACK TO US.
SO IT BASICALLY.
A EXPANDS THE INFORMATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE.
THE BECAUSE IT CAN BE REASONABLY
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT SAY PUT
THAT IN THE BILL -- FOR FURTHER.
UP WE'RE MAKING IT POSSIBLE
ADDITIONALLY POSSIBLE THAT THAT
WILL THAT INFORMATION WE'LL.
AND IS THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BE READY -- IDENTIFIED WITH US
SO IT'S IT'S BASICALLY EXPANDING
WHAT'S OUT THERE THAT DOESN'T
HAVE.
TO GIVE US THE PROTECTIONS OF
THE CCPA.
AN IN AN EXPANSIVE EVEN FURTHER
BY SAYING.
IT'S A IT'S INFORMATION IS
REASONABLY BE CAPABLE OF BEING
ASSOCIATED BACK TO US FURTHER.
A KIND OF INTRUDING IF YOU WILL
OR OR EXACERBATING THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE CCPA I THINK
SENATOR STERN HAD A QUESTION AND
CENTER JONES AND THEN CENTER.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I
WANTED TO GET SOME RESPONSE FROM
I THINK THE OPPOSITION ABOUT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED
ABOUT THE FROM THE AUTHOR.
ABOUT THE STATE OF CURRENT LAW
UNDER THE SEA CPA AND AND THE
PRIVACY RISKS.
OF SORT OF FORCING THE READ
LINKING TO PERSONAL INFORMATION --
THAT WAS MY FIRST QUESTION AND
SECOND I DIDN'T KNOW IF I DIDN'T
SEE THE EMAIL FROM -- MR MAKE
TAGGART'S ORGANIZATION WHO WE WE
SORT OF RELIED ON IS THE
ESSENTIAL ARCHITECT OF THIS
WHOLE MEASURE DO WE HAVE A COPY
THAT I I GOT WE GOT THAT ONE
FROM.
A MISTER LIEBOWITZ BUT I DON'T I
FOURTH THERE'S A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM MR MAKE TAGGART'S GROUP
HERE.
SEE HERE.
NOW. THREE TAGS ARE THERE IS
THERE ANY REPRESENTATIVE.
OF CAN I JUST YOU MIND IF WE
JUST GET THAT COMMENT REAL QUICK
ON WHAT WHY YOU ALL WENT NEUTRAL
HERE AND A LITTLE BACKGROUND
THERE.
HAPPY TO THROUGH THE CHAIR OF
THAT'S OKAY -- DOUG SUPERZOOM
HAVE A CALIFORNIA'S FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY WE DID WITHDRAW OUR
OPPOSITION BASED UPON AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
PRIVACY COMMITTEE -- WE DO THINK
THAT THE DEFINITION A CHANGES
THAT WERE DONE IN ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY COMMITTEE TO THE
DEFINITION OF DE IDENTIFIED --
MORE CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH THE
TWENTY TWELVE FTC DEFINITION WE
DO CONTEST THAT THE THE READING
OF THAT LANGUAGE WOULD ALLOW --
ONE TO SIMPLY SEPARATE AN I. P.
ADDRESS OR SU DONNA MAIS A PIECE
OF DATA AND SUGGEST THAT IS
ACTUALLY DE IDENTIFIED -- WE
THINK THAT THE FTC LAID OUT
TECHNOLOGICAL -- STRATEGIES A
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW YOU
ACTUALLY DE IDENTIFIED DATA BUT
THAT'S THE REASON THAT WE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION AND I
COMMITTEE AND IS ONE OF THE
CLERK.
BUT IT.
SO THAT SORT OF A LINES THEN I
GUESS WITH THE WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM THE FORMER FTC
CHAIR BUT ANYTHING THAT YOU'D
REYES THIS PRIVACY CONCERN OF
THE STATE OF CURRENT LAW.
I'M YOU MINOR JUST ARTICULATED
THAT ONCE MORE THAN MAYBE
GETTING SOME RESPONSE FROM THE
OPPOSITION THERE.
FIRST OF ALL IF IF I MIGHT BE
PERMITTED TO TO RESPOND -- THE
DEFINITION OF DE IDENTIFIED IN
THE C. C. P. A CURRENTLY HAS FOR
CONDITIONS.
THAT OUR TECHNICAL THE THE IS A
SURE THAT THE SCENARIO THAT THE
CHAIRED.
RAISED WILL NOT HAPPEN AT WITH
OUTSIDE BE OUTSIDE OF THE CCPA.
FIRST OF ALL IT SAYS THAT THE
THERE NEED TO BE TECHNICAL
SAFEGUARDS THAT'S NOT JUST RULES
THESE ARE TECHNICAL RESTRICTIONS.
THAT PROHIBIT RE IDENTIFICATION
OF THE CONSUMERS DATA THERE ALSO
HAVE TO BE BUSINESS PROCESS SEES
THAT SPECIFICALLY PROHIBIT.
WE IDENTIFICATION THE DATA IF
ANY OF THESE THINGS IS IS NOT
MATT THEN THE DATA BECOMES
PERSONAL DATA.
FURTHERMORE IT HAS THERE HAVE TO
BE MET BUSINESS PROCESSES USED
TO PREVENT HEATED BURDEN RELEASE
OF THE DATA AND THERE HAS TO BE
NO ATTEMPT MADE. TO IDENTIFY THE
DATA SO THE ENTIRE PARADE OF
HORRIBLE'S THAT WAS PRESENTED.
DON'T ACCORD WITH THE LANGUAGE
OF THIS AMENDMENT THE THE BILL
THAT'S BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE ALL THE SAFEGUARDS THAT
MR SUBER'S REFERENCE.
NEED TO BE IN PLACEFOR THIS.
EXCEPTION TO APPLY I APPRECIATE
THAT I MEAN I'M STARTING GETTING
AT THIS OTHER ISSUE THOUGH OF
THE REELING KING DON'T KNOW THE
THE THE RETHINKING THE READ MY
JUST REITERATING WHAT THAT
CONCERN IS AND THEN GETTING
HERE'S THE CONSERVE HERE'S THE
CONCERN.
IF ONE NEEDS IF THERE IS THE DE
IDENTIFIED DATA -- DEFINITION
WHICH IS CURRENTLY HOPELESSLY
VAGUE IT JUST IT IT SAYS
ANYTHING THAT'S NOT PERSONAL
DATA.
IT I AT THE PERSONAL DATA
DEAFNESS IS EXTREMELY BROAD
COUNTS IS DE IDENTIFIED THE
RESULT IS THAT ANY INFORMATION
THAT IS CAPABLE OF BEING
ASSOCIATED WITH.
AN INDIVIDUAL IF AN INDIVIDUAL
FILES A ONE OF THESE VERY
POSITIVE RIGHTS REQUEST UNDER
CCPA WHICH I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THEIR GREAT IDEAS PLEASE WHICH
LICENSES FOR THIS QUESTION IF
THAT REQUEST IS MADE THE
BUSINESS HAS.
TO SEARCH ALL AROUND ACROSS ALL
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE BUSINESS
EVERY CHANNEL STATE SUPPORT DESK.
VIDEO. FOR US STORE FOOTAGE TO
WILL BE A CHECK FOR SHOPLIFTERS
ONLINE INFORMATION THAT'S BEING
SUBMITTED AND OF PHONE CALLS
THAT COME IN AND HAS TO FIND ALL
THAT DATA.
AND DELETE IT SO THEY HAVE TO
HAVE THE CAPE OR BOARD SEND IT
BACK TO THE CONSUMER THEY HAVE
TO HAVE THE CAPABILITY OF
FINDING ALL THEIR DATA THEY HAVE
TO MAP ALL THEIR DATA.
AND ONCE THEY COMBINED THAT DATA.
IT'S VERY COSTLY THE BUSINESS
INCENTIVE FOR THE BUSINESS IS TO
CONTINUE TO USE IT ONCE THEY PUT
IT ALL TOGETHER SO YOU WIND UP
WITH DATA LINKS I DON'T MEAN TO
CUT YOU OFF BUT I GUESS I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET IT.
GET TO THE HEART OF IT IN PLAIN
PLAIN ENGLISH IS ESSENTIALLY
CURRENT LAW.
MAYBE YOU CAN CLEAR BY THE
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES YOU TO GO.
GET DEEPER INTO.
CONSUMERS PRIVATE DATED TO THEN.
RIGHT NOW THE DEFINITION IS A
CAPABLE OF YOU KNOW PERSONAL
IDENTIFICATION FOR KATE.
I PERSONAL INFORMATION IT'S
CAPABLE OF IDENTIFIED -- BEING
IDENTIFIED WITH HER SO THAT.
ADDING THE REASONABLY AND I'D
THE WAY I'D LIKE TO LOOK AT IT
IN THE EXAMPLE IN THE SHEET IS
THAT IF YOU'RE IN A DEPARTMENT
STORE AND YOU'RE USING A CREDIT
CARD -- THE DEPARTMENT STORE HAS
AND YOU DO TELL NOW THE
DEPARTMENT STORE THAT YOU WANT --
TO A RIGHT YOU WANT TO BE
FORGOTTEN YOU KNOW THE RIGHT TO
BE FORGOTTEN SO THEY GO IN AND
REYES ALL THE RECORDS THEY HAVE
ABOUT YOU ALL THE PURCHASES THAT
YOU MADE THAT THEY THEY ARE RACE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY THAT THE
KID THEY CAN REASONABLY
ASSOCIATE WITH YOU.
BUT IF YOU GET RID OF THE
REASONABLY THEN THEY HAVE TO
START GETTING ADDITIONAL PIECES
OF DATA TO TRY TO DELETE THOSE
SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU GO TO THE
STORE CAMERA NOW YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO USE.
A FACIAL RECOGNITION BECAUSE
WHAT IF YOU'RE ON THE STORE
CAMERA OR WHAT IF THERE'S A
CAMERA NEAR THE DRESSING ROOM
AND THEN WE YOU BUT IF THERE'S A
CAMERA NEAR THE BATHROOM NOW YOU
HAVE.
TO IDENTIFY.
OF IDENTIFIED EVERY BIT OF
INFORMATION THAT THE DEPARTMENT
STORE HAS TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE --
TO DELETE SO THAT'S WHY THE
DEFINITION OF CAPABLE IS IT
COULD BE RIGHT NOW IT'S GOOD AND
AND IT COULD BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO PULL TOGETHER IT'S REALLY
ANTI PRIVACY OR COULD BE IN THE
FUTURE YOU KNOW IT COULD BE ALL
OF A SUDDEN.
YOU USE SOME RANDOM COMPUTER AT
YOUR BUSINESS AND OF NOW NOW
WITH YOU KNOW IN THE FUTURE THAT
BUSINESS -- THAT THAT NOW THEY
CAN OF LINK THAT I. P. ADDRESS
TO YOU AND NOW THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE STORE US TO GO OUT SO
THAT'S WHY WE WE IN OUR
AMENDMENTS.
THAT WE REQUESTED THEY TAKE
ALLOWED THE ADDITION OF
REASONABLY TO PERSONAL
INFORMATION TO CLARIFY THAT IT'S
A SIMPLE CLARIFICATION.
WE PUT IN NOT THE BLOWING UP OF
THE ENTIRE DEFINITION DE
IDENTIFIED.
AND I THINK DID YOU WANT.
TO RESPOND TO THAT YES I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT THE CONCERNED
ABOUT HAVING TO COME THROUGH
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE TO CONNECT
PEOPLE.
THE AMENDMENT.
OFFERED THE COMMITTEE WE WOULD
ACTUALLY MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
ROUTINE VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
FOOTAGE AND RE IDENTIFY PEOPLE
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE C. CPA
THE REQUIRES READ ON A VACATION.
ALSO JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT MR
SUBER'S COMMENT ABOUT THE
INTERPRETATION OF THE LANGUAGE
OF THE SEE THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
CONSUMER PRIVACY HAD OFFERED.
AND HE CONTESTED THE
INTERPRETATION OF THE LANGUAGE
HE HE WAS CONTESTING THE
AUTHOR'S.
INTERPRETATION OF THE LANGUAGE I
SHE SHARED IN HER AND TEN AN
EXPLANATION OF THE BILL.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO READ
IT THAT WAY EITHER BUT THAT'S
THE WAY.
IT'S BEING THAT'S THE WAY IT'S
READ AND THAT'S THE WAY THE
AUTHORS READING AND THAT'S THE
WAY WE BELIEVE THE COURT WOULD
READ ITS INTENT TO EXCLUDE IP
ADDRESSES [inaudible]
WHICH SO I DON'T SO I JUST.
THE WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY WERE INTENDING TO OFFER
SOMETHING THAT THEY BELIEVED
WOULD EXCLUDE IP ADDRESSES FROM
THE DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
HOWEVER THAT IS HOW IT'S BEING.
TAKEN BY THE AUTHOR AND HOW IT
IS BEING.
AND PUSH MAY INDUSTRY AND THEN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE OFFERED
CORRECTED THAT.
THOSE WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE
OFFERED AND BY THE WAY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR FOR
QUITE SOME TIME SO -- BUT SE
JUST GOT THE IMMENSE TWO DAYS
AGO.
OF THE FINAL AMENDMENTS THIRDS
BEEN A NEGOTIATION IS YOU KNOW
PART OF THE REASON THAT
SOMETIMES THESE ANALYSES COME AT
THE LAST MINUTE IS THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING. TO WORK ON THE
GOSHEN SO IT WASN'T LIKE THESE
WERE SOMETHING OUT OF THE CLEAR
BLUE THIS WAS THE FINAL GIVEN
TAKE.
OUR AFTER HAVING GONE BACK AND
FORTH OVER THE VARIOUS CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED THIS IS
BEEN A LOT.
THIS IS BEEN A OF ON GOING IN A
FAIRLY LENGTHY.
PROCESS.
THE SENATE US SENATOR JOHN
SHOULD YOU WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION AND I'M SURE -- IN MY
ANSWERS TURNED ADDRESS ON MY I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROPONENTS.
AT A YOU KNOW EQUAL TIME TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED IN THE DIET
BECAUSE IT SEEMED LIKE THEY WERE
KIND OF GETTING CUT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION SO.
I APPRECIATE CENTER STERN --
BRINGING THAT BACK TO THEM --
YOU KNOW I WASN'T HERE FOR THIS
IS PAID NEGOTIATIONS SO I'M
TRYING.
TO NO CATCH UP.
WITH ALL OF YOU ON THIS I
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE TODAY --
I WAS SATISFIED WITH THE BILL AS
IT WAS ORIGINALLY WRITTEN -- SO
IF THE IF IT'S APPROPRIATE AND
THE AND THE AUTHOR ONCE A MOTION
ON I'M HAPPY TO MAKE THAT MOTION --
AND THEN I JUST YOU KNOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN HER CLOTHES SHE HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY IF THERE'S
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS THAT ARE
RAISED BY -- EITHER THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OR THE
OPPOSITION THAT SHE HAS A FAIR
OPPORTUNITY TO THE CLOSINGS
ALWAYS TO PROVIDE THAT
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU SENATOR --
SENATOR -- BURKE.
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED.
A VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS HERE.
I DO BILL
I THINK OF THE CENTER JONES HAS
ALREADY DONE THAT -- ALL RIGHT --
AGAIN.
SO THAT WE'RE CLEAR -- WELL THE
MASSES FOR THEIR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT.
OF SENATOR THE TWO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
OF I'D I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS AND YOU KNOW
WE DO OF MUCH MORE AGREEMENT
THAN NOT THAT'S THE MAKING SURE
THAT THE DEFINITION OF DE
IDENTIFIED IS IS WORKABLE IS --
CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT TO ME AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE SPENT SIX
MONTHS.
OF ON THIS EFFORT AND NOW I DO
WANT -- TO ONCE MORE A REITERATE
THAT ONCE INFORMATION S RE
IDENTIFIED IT'S NOW PERSONAL
INFORMATION UNDER CCPA WHICH
MEANS AGAIN YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
TO BE FORGOTTEN ONE FINAL THING
IS GPR WHICH PASSED IN EUROPE
AND THAT WAS AFTER VERY
EXTENSIVE EFFORTS.
HAS A VERY LOW COMPLIANCE RATE
RIGHT NOW ALLEN I THINK IT IS
CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT THAT
CALIFORNIA GET A RIGHT THAT WE
MAKE IT.
IT MAKES THE CPA WORKABLE FOR
NOT ONLY OUR GOOGLE'S WHO ARE
ALREADY TRYING.
TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW THAT WE
MAKE IT OF WORKABLE FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES HERE BECAUSE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
EVERY BUSINESS UNDERSTANDS HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO PROTECT OUR
PRIVACY AND WHAT I WANT TO SEE
IS THAT AND REITERATING THIS
AGAIN I WANT TO SEE OTHER STATES
FOLLOW CALIFORNIA'S LEAD WITH A
REALLY WORKABLE.
A SOLUTION THAT PROTECTS THE
PRIVACY OF CALIFORNIANS AND
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND IF WE DO
NOT GET IT RIGHT THERE WILL BE
FEDERAL PREEMPTION THE THE THERE
WILL BE SO MUCH PRESSURE FROM
THE TECH COMPANIES IF WE HAVE
THIS BIG PATCHWORK.
OF OF OF LAWS THROUGHOUT THE
STATES THERE WILL BE FEDERAL
PREEMPTION SO -- I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL I THINK AND I APPRECIATE
THE MOTION THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT THAT
YOU WANT TO MAKE [inaudible]
I APPRECIATE [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
AND THAT I HAVE YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
WITH THAT -- YEAH -- BY THE
AUTHOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK.
I CAN REALLY IN FACT.
TAX LOOPHOLES.
PART OF OUR PRIVACY --
INFORMATION.
IT WAS.
HARD MEDIATION RIGHT NOW RIGHT
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS SOLD HAVE.
ALL OF THIS IS JUST GONE OUT
THERE.
WERE TRYING TO HOLD BACK.
AND FROM THAT.
WHEN I HEAR THAT?
EXPENSIVE CAN'T DO IT.
HI I. N. R. E. BECAUSE
EVERYTHING IS SOLD OUT THERE BY
THE PLEASE.
YEAH AB SO BELIEVE THAT.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO DO THIS.
I THINK IT'S A MATTER OF I WOULD
REALLY -- BOB -- AS DIFFICULT AS
THAT MIGHT ALL RIGHT -- SAID
HERMIONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND JUST
TO BE CLEAR I APPRECIATED THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH THE AUTHOR
A FEW DAYS AGO A WEEK AGO I
FORGET EXACTLY WHEN NOW -- BUT I
SHARE THE SAME CONCERN VOICED BY
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR DRAW SO.
IF YOU WERE TO ACCEPT THE CHAIRS
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS I WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE -- I WON'T BE
SUPPORTIVE WITHOUT ACCEPTING
THOSE AMENDMENTS JUST TO BE
CLEAR THANK YOU [inaudible]
BY OF YOU'VE CLOSED.
WE'VE HAD A COUPLE OTHER OF
STATEMENTS HERE I SHOULD GIVE
YOU THE RIGHT.
TO MAKE A FINAL COMMENT.
I WOULD JUST APPRECIATES -- I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU THE MOTION.
IS PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE AB
EIGHT SEVEN THREE JACKSON NO.
JACKSON NO BORDERS -- RUSSELL.
TO ROSS SO NO GONZALEZ
[inaudible]
JONES.
JONES I'M MONNING.
MORNING NO STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY.
REALLY TO THREE HOTELS THREE
APPLIES THREE KNOWS THE MEASURE
FAILED [inaudible]
YEAH.
WELL FOR WHAT RECONSIDERATION
I'VE -- THAT'S ALL.
TAKE RECONSIDERATION REGARD FOR
RECONSIDERATION IS REQUESTED AND
GRANTED.
AND I BELIEVE OF THAT'S ALL
RIGHT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FOR WHAT.
IS THE LAST [inaudible]
ONE HELLO -- GALLAGHER YOU'RE
GOING TO GALLAGHER TM.
YEAH YEAH YEAH OKAY.
OKAY ELEVEN O'CLOCK ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT -- THE SECOND TO LAST
ITEM WE HAVE IT IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PERKS -- FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT AB [inaudible]
EIGHT FORTY SIX GOOD EVENING.
A GOOD EVENING I KNOW IT'S LATE.
AND I WANNA SAY FIRST OF ALL OF
THE CHAIRS PREVIOUS COMMENTS
THIS BILL DOES NOT UNDERMINE THE
CCPA.
AND I HAVE HERE -- DOCUMENTS TO
BE HANDED OUT TO EVERYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE. TO SHOW THAT THE
SPONSOR OF THE ORIGINAL PRIVACY --
PROPOSITION.
HAS MOVED WITH OUR AMENDMENTS TO
NEUTRAL.
SENATORS AB EIGHT FORTY SIX
CLARIFIES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT IS NOT
INTENDED TO PROHIBIT BUSINESSES
FROM OFFERING CONSUMER LOYALTY
PROGRAMS.
WITH THE CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE
C. C. PA BUSINESSES ARE
QUESTIONING WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO WITH OUR CUSTOMER
LOYALTY PROGRAMS AND ARE SEEKING
CLARITY IN THE LAW. TO CONTINUE
THEIR OFFERINGS CONSUMERS FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE APPRECIATE
THESE PROGRAMS WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AIRLINE MILES OR
POINTS -- ACCUMULATED FOR FREE
ITEMS IN THE GROCERY STORE 80%
OF AMERICANS BELONG TO AND
BENEFIT.
FROM AT LEAST ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS AB EIGHT FORTY SIX IS
INTENDED TO CONTINUE TO GIVE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THE ABILITY
TO JOIN THESE PROGRAMS.
AND BENEFITS FROM THE REWARDS.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THAT
ALISTAIR MAKE THAGARD IN
CALIFORNIA FOR CONSUMER PRIVACY
ON AMENDMENT LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
MOVE THEM TO NEUTRAL.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
THROUGH THOSE NEGOTIATIONS AB
EIGHT FORTY SIX WOULD STRIKE ONE
FOUR NINE EIGHT POINT ONE TWO
SIX EIGHT TWO ON FUNCTIONALITY
FROM THE LANGUAGE ENSURING.
AND ALSO ENSURE CONSUMERS CAN
OPT OUT OF THE SALE OF THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION PURSUANT.
TO SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT POINT
ONE TWO ZERO AND STILL MAINTAIN
THEIR ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
ALSO TO ENSURE THAT BUSINESSES
ARE STILL COMPLYING WITH
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT POINT ONE
TWO FIVE BE AND THE NON DISK
DISCRIMINATION SECTION OF CCPA
WHICH I HAVE SPOKEN TO MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
IT IS ALSO THE CLARIFY THAT A
CONSUMER WHO VOLUNTARILY OPT OUT
OF A PROGRAM A REQUEST THE
DELETION OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION ONCE THEY LEAVE THE
PROGRAM.
BIRDS ARE INTO SEVENTEEN NINETY
EIGHT POINT.
ONE OH FIVE SHE DOES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I'M NOT CLEAR DID YOU SAY
YOU'RE GOING TO ACCEPT OUR
AMENDMENTS NOW I I'LL GO THROUGH
EXACTLY WHAT WE WILL ACCEPT AND
WHAT WE ARE NOT PROPOSING TO
ACCEPT IN JUST A MOMENT.
I'M ALSO WE'RE CLARIFYING THAT A
CONSUMER WHO VOLUNTARILY ON
SADDAM PROGRAM YOUR QUEST THE
DELETION OF THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION ONCE THEY LEAVE THE
PROGRAM PERCENT IN.
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT THOSE
WERE THOUGHTFUL AND CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATED MOMENTS WITH THE
OPPOSITION THE COMMITTEE NOW SIX
SUGGEST ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
BEYOND THE LANGUAGE AGREED UPON
WITH THE OPPOSITION.
I CAN COMMIT TO ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS E. ON PAGE
NINE OF THE ANALYSIS.
AS WELL THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT
TO STRIKE THE FUNCTIONALITY
PROVISION OF THE BILL LISTEN ON
PAGE.
TEN HOWEVER PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
DE AND ASKED.
AT SPECIFICALLY AFTER WOULD
ENACT GREATER RESTRICTIONS ON
LOYALTY PROGRAMS AND ANY OTHER
CCPA REQUIRED ON ANY OTHER
REGULATIONS OF DATA.
PARAGRAPH X. F. STATES THAT
BUSINESSES SHALL NOT OFFER A
LOYALTY PROGRAM WITHOUT EXPRESS
SICKLY EXPRESSLY IN HIS
VICIOUSLY PROVIDING CONSUMERS
WITH THE OPTION TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM.
ON EQUAL TERMS WITH OTHER
PARTICIPANTS WITHOUT CONSENTING
TO THE SHARING OR SALE OF THE
CONSUMERS PERSONAL INFORMATION
WITH THIRD PARTIES.
THIS LANGUAGE WOULD INTRODUCE AN
UNDEFINED TERM OF SHARING INTO
THE CCPA WITH THE RESTRICTION ON
LOYALTY PROGRAMS.
FURTHERMORE IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT
DEFINES THIRD PARTIES IN THIS
PROVISION ANY AMBIGUITY COULD
OPEN BUSINESSES UP TO POSSIBLE
LITIGATION FOR EXAMPLE.
MARRIOTT LET'S SEE A MARRIOTT IS
OWNED BY A PRIVATE. ONE OF THE
PROPERTIES OWNED BY A PRIVATE
COMPANY THEN NOT ONE PROPERTY
COULD NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE
LOYALTY PROGRAMS OF THE ENTIRE.
PROPERTIES SO THAT'S A VERY
SIMPLE EXAMPLE OF WHAT WOULD BE.
PUT INTO QUESTION AS A RESULT OF
THE AMENDMENTS.
I AM WILLING TO TAKE TWO OF THE
FOUR PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WITH
THE COMMITMENT TO CLARIFY AND
WORKING ON BOTH THE N. F..
SHOULD THEM SHOULD THE THIS MOVE
OUT OF COMMITTEE.
CENTERS AB EIGHT FORTY SIX IS A
STRAIGHT FOR A BILL CONSUMERS
APPRECIATE LOYALTY PROGRAMS.
AND PARTS OF MY DISTRICT EVERY
DOLLAR COUNTS.
IT MY CONSTITUENTS CAN EARN
SOMETHING RETURN FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THEY SPEND MORE KNOWING
THEIR PRIVACY IS STILL PART
BEING PROTECTED WHY SHOULD THEY
BE DENIED THIS BENEFIT. TO
ASSUME THAT MINORITIES ARE
PEOPLE OF LOW MEANS ARE NOT
INTELLIGENT ENOUGH OR THOUGHTFUL
ENOUGH TO MAKE EDUCATED
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR LIVES IS
INSULTING AND IT'S A NARRATIVE
IN THIS BUILDING.
THAT NEEDS TO STOP.
BUSINESSES NEED TO CLARITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO OFFER THESE PROGRAMS TO
PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA WITH
VARYING SOCIAL ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS IN NEEDS.
WITHOUT THIS BILL BUSINESSES MAY
NOT CONTINUE TO OFFER CONSUMER
TO LOYALTY PROGRAMS RESIDENTS OF
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I. BUT
ON THIS BILL IS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED BY THE NEGOTIATED
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
HIGHLY BENEFICIAL PROGRAMS. TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH PLEASE.
ORDER GLASS THE NUMBER HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FORTY SIX BECAUSE IT DOES
CLARIFY THE LAW.
AND SAYS THAT RETAILERS CAN
OPERATE AND OTHERS CAN OPERATE
LOYALTY PROGRAMS WITHOUT RUNNING
AFOUL OF CCPA WE UNDERSTAND
THERE SEVERAL PROVISIONS OF THE
LAW THAT ALLOW FOR THE
OPERATIONS THE PROGRAMS BUT THE
CONFUSING LANGUAGE IN THE NON
DISCRIMINATION SECTION.
LEAVES US QUESTIONING WHAT WE
CAN AND CANNOT DO WE JUST WANT
THE CLARITY WHICH AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX GIVES US.
AS THE AUTHOR NOTED MANY
CONSUMERS CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THESE PROGRAMS IN FACT THE
BILL SPECIFICALLY REFERENCES
THAT CONSUMERS.
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAMS IN
OTHER WORDS CONSUMERS ARE MAKING
THEIR OWN DECISION ON WHETHER TO
JOIN OR NOT IF THEY WE DON'T
WANT TO SHARE THEIR DATA OR THEY
DON'T DO ALTHOUGH THE VOTE THE
REWARDS ARE WORTH EARNING.
FACE THEN THEY SIMPLY CHOOSE NOT
TO PARTICIPATE OFTEN LOYALTY.
PROGRAMS ARE EXTREMELY POPULAR
IN FACT I WOULD BET THAT ALL OF
YOU ARE A MEMBER OF THE LEAST
ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
PERHAPS MANY OF THEM.
IT'S NOT ACCURATE TO SAY THAT
PROGRAMS FORCE PEOPLE FOR PEOPLE
TO GIVE UP THEIR DATA GIVEN THE
WIDE RANGE OF PROGRAMS FROM TOP
OF THE LINE HOTEL CHANGE
ENTICEMENTS LIKE FLASH CLASS ARE
FREE FLIGHTS. TO DESIGNER
FASHION SHOWS THESE PROGRAMS
DON'T JUST TARGET THE POOR.
CONSUMERS ACCESS THE SOCIAL
ACCOUNT CONSUMERS ACROSS THE
SOCIO ECONOMIC.
SPECTRUM APPRECIATE THE
DISCOUNTS AND SPECIAL OFFERS
THEY RECEIVE AND OUR MEMBERS USE
REWARDS FOR ONE SIMPLE PURPOSE
TO CREATE CUSTOMER LOYALTY WE DO
NOT SELL CUSTOMER DATA IN FACT
WE'VE AGREED TO LANGUAGE
CLARIFYING JUST THAT.
THE CONSUMERS WANT TO OPT OUT OF
HAVING THEIR DATA SOLD.
WERE WILLING INSTEAD LONGER
PROGRAMS WILLING TO ALLOW THAT
WE WORK TO GOOD FAITH WITH THE
SERVER TAG OR TO REACH A
COMPROMISE THAT IS SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE COMMITTEES SEEKING.
BUT COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS GO TOO
FAR IT MAKES NO SENSE TO HAVE
GREATER RESTRICTIONS ON DEBT
HELD BY OFTEN LOYALTY PROGRAMS
AND OTHER DATA GEVORK GOVERNED
BY CCPA WE'RE ASKING FOR A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD. TO THE GREEN
OFFER THESE PROF UP -- THESE
POPULAR PROGRAMS WE ASK YOU TO
PASS A BEAT FORTY SIX AS A
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED BY THE
YANKEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MADAM AND TEAR -- AND
MEMBERS -- KELLY ASHER THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE SOME OF
THE COMMENTS AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
COME TOGETHER WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE THESE
CLARIFYING.
AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE EXCITED
THAT.
WE ARE NOW ABLE -- TO HOPEFULLY
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE AND NOT LIMIT
THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE
CONSUMER.
IN LOYALTY PROGRAMS.
AND WE THINK THAT THIS IS A
NEEDED FIX TO THE CCPA TO ENSURE
OUR CUSTOMERS CAN KEEP RECEIVING
THESE BENEFITS OTHER LOYAL
SHOPPING.
I'M YOU KNOW THE GROCERY
INDUSTRY IS VERY COMPETITIVE AND
WE HAVE VERY SMALL MARGINS AND
SO OUR CUSTOMERS ARE A TOP
PRIORITY FOR US.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE KEEPING PRICES LOW AND
THINGS LOW FOR THEM AND SO IF
THERE IS A WAY WE CAN DO THAT
THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
ENSURE TO DO THAT -- I WOULD
ALSO JUST LIKE -- TO MAKE A NOTE
THAT WE AND THE GROCERY INDUSTRY
ARE ALREADY SUBJECT TO THE
SUPERMARKET CLUB CARD ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHICH DOES
PUT PARAMETERS AROUND WHAT WE
CAN DO WITH THE INFORMATION.
FROM OUR LOYALTY REWARDS
PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NAME AND AFFILIATION
PLEASE PETER CALLOUSED ON BEHALF
OF WALGREENS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
EFFORTS TO REACH A COMPROMISE
THANK YOU. SEVEN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF TARGET AND THE HOME
DEPOT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STOMACH
TOMORROW HERE BEHALF OF THE
HELPERS AND SAFE WAY THE SECOND
LARGEST UNIONIZED EMPLOYER IN
THE STATE.
AND BEST BUY -- THESE PROGRAMS
HELP WAS THE STATE A CREDIT
AGAINST NON UNIONIZED
COMPETITORS.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
MAX ROBBINS THE ON BEHALF OF THE
GAP HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRIS OSWALD WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF NATIONAL
ADVERTISERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IF CARLSON CTIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU -- CAL CHAMBER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SEVEN MORE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FEELS
INCONVENIENCE ALLIANCE AS WELL
AS CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BERNIE OROZCO CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU.
KELLY HAD A BATH CONTIENE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JOHN CALDWELL CALIFORNIA HOTEL
LODGING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AND A HUMMER ON BEHALF THE
ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MIKE BULLARD SEJAK SUPPORT THANK
I TOURISM WE HAVE THE
INTERACTIVE ADVERTISING BUREAU
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MAUREEN
MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER
REPORTS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION.
BECAUSE IT FORCES CONSUMERS TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN AFFORDABLE
NECESSITIES AND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS TO PRIVACY.
WE HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH LOYALTY
PROGRAMS THAT RELY ON THE
INTERNAL TRACKING UPDATE UP
COMPANIES ARE FREE.
TO KEEP TRACK OF CONSUMER
PURCHASES AND OFFERS CONSUMERS
BENEFITS BASED ON THAT -- AND
IT'S EASY PA HAS NO IMPLICATIONS
ON THAT WHATSOEVER BUT THIS BILL
IS NOT ABOUT REWARDING CONSUMER
LOYALTY IT'S ABOUT.
GIVING COMPANIES THE RIGHT TO
CHARGE CONSUMERS MORE FOR
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE CCPA.
INCLUDING OPTING OUT OF SALE
THEIR INFORMATION TO THIRD PARTY
DATA BROKERS THAT COULD HAVE
IMPLICATIONS FOR CONSUMERS IN
WAYS THEY COULDN'T REASONABLY
ANTICIPATE.
COMPANIES SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO CHARGE CONSUMERS OR MONETIZE --
BASIC RIGHTS THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
ALTHOUGH.
pSAFETY RATES TO ENSURE THAT POOR
PEOPLE CAN'T BE FORCED.
TO BUY -- PRODUCTS THAT ARE
HARMFUL TO THEM -- THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ARE NOT
ARE IDEAL SCENARIO BUT WE THINK
THAT THEY WOULD GO A LONG WAY --
TO ENTERING A COMPROMISE AND
MAKE SURE THAT CONSUMERS CAN
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE
CCPA WITHOUT BEING PENALIZED IN.
ANYWAY -- IT WITHOUT THAT WOULD
RESULT FOR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLACED
YES -- MINUTES HI TRACY CREWS IN
BURKE FROM OAKLAND PRIVACY WE
CAME IN THIS EVENING WHICH WITH
TO CONCERNS ABOUT EIGHT FORTY
SIX ONE OF THEM HAS BEEN.
AMENDED OUT WHICH WAS THE
FUNCTIONAL QUICK REQUIREMENT FOR
THE USE OF DATA WHICH WE WANT TO
SAY WAS CATEGORICALLY A BACK
DOOR.
TO PAY TO PRIVACY WHICH WE DID
AGREE TO TAKE YES AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
AND THE SECOND CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE -- IS WITH THE AMENDMENT OF
THE AUTHOR IS NOT TAKING AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID WE'RE BASICALLY
LOOKING AT UTILIZING PEOPLE X..
FOR EXERCISING THE RIGHTS THAT
ARE GRANTED TO THEM UNDER THE
CPA AND WHAT KIND OF A RIGHT.
IS IT IF YOU BASICALLY HAVE TO
PAY IN ORDER TO EXECUTE IT.
I WOULD SAY IN GENERAL THAT
LOYALTY PROBLEMS ARE BY THE
PROGRAMS ARE BY THEIR VERY
DEFINITION OPT IN I MEAN MOST
PEOPLE DON'T END UP AND ROLLED
IN A FREQUENT FLYER PLAN WITHOUT
ACTUALLY TAKING SOME ACTION TO
DO THAT.
BUT THE QUESTION IS SORT OF WHAT
PEOPLE ARE OPTING IN CHIU AND DO
THEY UNDERSTAND THE FULL EXTENT
OF WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
YES TO A POTENTIALLY WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING NO TO MOST OF US
MIGHT THINK THAT WE MIGHT BE
SOLD SOME ADVERTISEMENTS FOR
HOTEL ROOMS BUT WE MAY NOT THINK
THAT ARE INFO IS GOING OUT. TO
FIFTY DIFFERENT DATA BROKERS SO
THE QUESTION OF SORT OF WHAT
WE'RE AGREEING TO AND WHETHER WE
IN FACT HAVE THE RIGHT TO GET
OUT OF THAT AGREEMENT.
WITHOUT PAYING IS WHATWE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IN AS I
UNDERSTAND IT LOYALTY PROGRAM IN
AN OF THEMSELVES ARE NOT
PREVENTED.
FROM PRECEDING.
ARE WITHOUT CCPA SO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS REALLY THE
RIGHT TO CHARGE PEOPLE FOR
OPTING OUT AND I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD SUPPORT THAT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OUR OUR FAX JOHNSON WITH COMMON
SENSE MEDIA OF WITH THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TAKEN WE
WOULD REMOVE OPPOSITION BUT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
JACOB SO WITH THE CITY OF
CALIFORNIA WE WOULD ALSO REMOVE
OPPOSITION WITH COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BUT WERE POST.
THANK YOU.
ACCORDING TO THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION OF PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARING HOUSE ALSO
OPPOSED ABSENT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS DOCTORS I
HAVE A CALIFORNIA'S FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY WE ARE POSTED ON PRINT
DO APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND THE SPONSORS ON
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE DISCUSSED.
BEFORE AND I THINK WE'LL LOOK AT
WHATEVER FIX OUT HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR HERE WE
ARE TRYING TO GET TO A POINT --
AND I THINK OUR AMENDMENTS TO I
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE --
TAKING THE TO THE FORE BUT THE
OTHER TWO ARE EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT.
SO I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE I
THINK WE'RE ALL PART OF THESE --
PROGRAMS -- I WAS THINKING BACK
TO THE GOOD OLD DAYS TO IT WE
HAVE RETAILERS AND GROCERS HERE.
AND I MEMBERS I DON'T THINK TOO
MANY OF YOU REMEMBER SNH GREEN
STAMPS -- THERE YOU GO.
AND THE BLUE CHIPS STAMPS YOU GO
TO THE STORE AND YOU BUY CERTAIN
PRODUCTS AND YOU GET STAMPS REAL
RELATIVE TO THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
IS SPENT OR WITH THE PRODUCT YOU
BINDING BROUGHT IT HOME YOU GOT
TO LOOK AT IN AND PUT IN THE
BOOK AND YOU GET.
A BOOK SHE CAN GET A TOASTER.
THAT'S A LOYALTY PROGRAM.
BUT YOU KNOW EXACTLY.
OR WE KNEW WAY BACK THEN BEFORE
ALL THIS INFORMATION GATHERING
THAT'S WHAT YOU GOT YOU GOT A
TOASTER AND YOU WENT BACK TO THE
STORE AND YOU DID YOUR SHOPPING
AND YOU GOT ANOTHER TOASTER
WHATEVER IT WAS THAT YOU WANTED.
TODAY IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT
WORLD LOYALTY PROGRAMS ARE VERY
DIFFERENT -- THEY'RE A GREAT
THING I THINK THOSE OF US WHO.
HAVE TO FLY UP HERE EVERY WEEK
FOR ON SOUTHWEST AIRLINES WE OPT
INTO THEIR LOYALTY PROGRAM.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF BEING ABLE --
TO TO HAVE MY HUSBAND IS MY
COMPANION. TO ACCRUE MILES SO
THAT I CAN GO VISIT MY GRAND
KIDS -- BUT BUT PART OF THAT IS
WHAT IS HAVE ME THAT I'M IN A
LOYALTY PROGRAM I MEAN IT'S
LOYALTY I'M EXPRESSING MY
LOYALTY TO THE COMPANY.
IN EXCHANGE FOR WITH WHICH I GET
BENEFITS WHAT I DON'T KNOW.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TELL US
NOW IS WHAT THEY'RE DOING WITH
THAT INFORMATION.
AND I THINK THAT IS PART OF THE
ISSUE HERE.
SO THE THE THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL UP MAKES IT CLEAR
THE BUSINESS CAN OFFER SPECIAL
PERKS TO MEMBERS OF THEIR
FREQUENT FLYER PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE OR DISCOUNTS TO THEIR
GROCERY.
STORE REWARDS PROGRAM AND I
SMILE WHEN I THINK ABOUT IT YOU
KNOW THE IT HE SAID FOR THOSE
STAMPS JUST TASTED SO BAD -- AND
I CAN STILL TASTE IT BUT IT WAS
FUN YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU HAD A
BOOK IN YOU COULD BUY SOMETHING
WITH IT.
A BOOK OF STAMPS BUT THAT YOU
DON'T DO THAT ANYMORE BUT THIS
BILL HOWEVER DOES NOT CONSTRAIN
WHAT THE BUSINESS CAN DO WITH
PERSONAL INFORMATION THAT IT
THEN COLLECTS AS PART OF THE
PROGRAMS. FOR EXAMPLE IF I'M
GOING TO TAKE A TRIPLET SAY TO
HAWAII ON MY FREQUENT FLYER
MILES.
USING OF MYSELF WHICH MILES --
DO I KNOW THAT THE IN ADDITION
SUDDENLY I'M GOING TO START
GETTING ALL THESE ADS FOR
HAWAIIAN SHIRTS OR FOR A FLIP
FLOPS OR MAYBE HOTELS TO STAY IN
HAWAII.
NOW I MAY WANT TO DO THAT I MAY
SAY THIS IS A GREAT ADDITION BUT
I WANT TO AT LEAST HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO SAY THAT OR NOT AND IF
I AM GOING TO OPT OUT OF THEIR
PROGRAM.
I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO THEN AND
THIS IS PART OF WHAT THE BILL
CURRENTLY DOES.
IS IF I OPT OUT.
I CAN'T GET THE SAME BENEFITS.
AND AND THAT IS A PROBLEM IF I
WANT MY PRIVACY THEN I HAVE TO
PAY FOR MY PRIVACY WE HAVE
SITUATIONS TODAY WITH GROCERY
STORES YOU ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN.
FINANCIAL DISTRESS AND THEY GO
GROCERY SHOPPING OF COURSE
THEY'RE GOING TO AGREE TO THE TO
THE COUPONS OR WHATEVER THEY'RE
GOING TO GET THEY NEED THEY NEED
THAT.
THEY NEED THAT LOAF OF BREAD --
BUT IF THEY SAY BUT I DON'T WANT
YOU USING MY INFORMATION TO WELL
THEN THEY DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
THEY'VE GOT TO PAY MORE.
AND THAT IS WHERE I THINK THE
BIG PROBLEM IS THAT AT LEAST I
HAVE AND I WANT TO ASK THESE
FOLKS -- A ON THE PRIVACY THING
I DO YOU SELL YOUR INFIRMITY I
ALL THAT INFORMATION WOULD LIKE
NOT EXCUSE ME DO YOU SELL THAT
INFORMATION AND ALL ENTRANTS OR
DO YOU SELL THE INFORMATION THAT
YOU GET.
WHEN PEOPLE SIGN UP FOR THESE
REWARDS PROGRAMS?
MARK REPLIES RAFTER RETAILERS NO
WE DO NOT SELL THE INFORMATION.
SO IF YOU DON'T SELL IT THEN WHY
WOULD YOU WHY DO YOU CARE
WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE ARE WANT
TO OPT OUT WHY DO YOU WHY DO YOU
WANT TO MAKE THEM.
WHAT YOU WANT TO SAY TO THEM
THAT THEY CAN'T PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM IF THEY OPT OUT OR
THE GONNA HAVE TO PAY MORE?
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE REWARDS WE NEED YOU SOONER
JACKSON I'LL JUST HAVE TO GO
ALONG WITH YOUR EXAMPLE IF YOU
WANT TO BE ABLE TO USE YOUR
WORDS TO GO TO HAWAII.
THAN SOUTHWEST AIRLINES GOING TO
NEED TO KNOW IS YOU THAT HAS
EARNED THOSE REWARDS SO THAT'S
THE RIGHT [inaudible]
THAT'S GREAT.
THAT THAT ISN'T THE PROBLEM I
DON'T MIND IT YOU KNOW IN FACT
YOU NEED TO KNOW BECAUSE IT'S ME
BARRING THE TAKING THE TRIP WHAT
WHAT HAPPENS IN ADDITION IS.
THAT INFORMATION THEN THEN YOU
GO AHEAD AND YOU WANT TO START
SHOWING ME I START GETTING
INFORMATION FROM TRIPADVISOR BUT
GOOD RESTAURANTS -- TO GO TO WAR
I STARKID RETIREMENT HERE'S A
COUPON IF YOU'LL COME TO OUR
RESTAURANT WHEN YOU'RE IN HAWAII.
I I NEED TO KNOW THAT YOU'RE
DOING THAT.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU.
IT'S MADAM CHAIR IT IS MY BILL
AND SO I WOULD LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND BECAUSE
IT AND AND YOU WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO RENEGE ON EXCUSE ME.
YOU WILL HAVE A CHANCE RESPOND I
WANTED TO ASK THE INDUSTRY
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SELL THE
INFORMATION AGAIN YOU'RE SAYING
YOU DON'T.
OKAY SO WE DO NOT SO -- FOR USE
A RETAIL EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE
PROVIDED A COUPON FOR SOMETHING
WE KNOW YOU WANT TO BUY IT'S
BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU WANT TO BUY
NOT BECAUSE WE'RE PROVIDING.
ARE YOUR DATA TO THAT
MANUFACTURER SO WE KNOW THAT YOU
LIKE.
BEAUTIFUL BLUE JACKETS SO WE MAY
SERVE YOU COUPONS OR NOT HOWEVER
SAME ONE FASHION FROM THE STATE.
WE WE MAY SERVE YOU -- OFFERS OR
ADVERTISE JET BLUE JACKETS YOU
THROUGH YOUR LOYALTY MEMBERSHIP
BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU LIKE BLUE
JACKETS BUT WE'RE NOT PROVIDING
THAT SAME INFORMATION TO THE
DESIGNER WHO CREATES THOSE
JACKETS.
OKAY TANK YOU YOU MAY RESPOND
AT THE END OF THE CPPCC PA WE
ALREADY ARE DICTATED WE'RE NOT
ASKING TO CHANGE THAT WERE
ACTUALLY WILLING TO IT HERE TO
THE CURRENCY CPA WHICH SELLS
WHAT CAN OR CAN'T BE SHARED SO
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO EXPAND THAT.
HOW AND WE ALSO ARE NOT AGREEING
TO SELL THE INFORMATION SO EVEN
IF WE NEEDED TO MAKE THAT CLEAR
AGAIN IN THIS BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE ARE HAPPY TO DO
THAT HOWEVER THE CCPA WE'VE
ALREADY MADE THAT AGREEMENT
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO EXPAND THAT?
AND THE OPPOSITION I WANT TO
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH THEM WE'RE
NOT THERE THEY'RE CONCERNED THAT
WERE SELLING THE INFORMATION
WE'RE NOT SELLING THE
INFORMATION WE ARE HEARING TO
THE C. CPA IN THIS BILL WE'RE
NOT EXPANDING IT WERE STAYING TO
IT.
AS POOR THE HAND OUT WE GAVE TO
YOU AND THIS NOTION THAT THAT WE
ARE SELLING POOR PEOPLE
SOMETHING THAT THEY DON'T WANT.
I CAN'T EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE THEY DID SAY THAT AND SO
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THERE'S
NO SALE HERE THERE'S NO SALE TO
JOIN THE LOYALTY PROGRAM WE ALL
JOIN THEM AND WE ALL KNOW YOU
DIDN'T HAVE TO BUY ANYTHING TO
GET INTO.
THEM SO YOU ALL HAVE PROOF OF
THAT IN YOUR OWN CURRENT
EXPERIENCE AND THE OPPOSITE I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CLEAR ABOUT.
THAT WE WE AGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THE FACT THAT THIS
DATA SHOULD NOT BE SOLD WE ARE
HEARING TO NOT.
AND THEN THE SECOND CONCEPT OF
BEING SOLD POOR PEOPLE BEING
SOLD SOMETHING THAT THEY DON'T
WANT IS NOT PART OF THIS PROP
THAT IF I DON'T THINK WAS WHAT
THEY DID SAY THAT ACTUALLY AS I
JUST ON MY LOOK VERY CALL IT
THEM CLARIFY THERE BUT SO WOULD
YOU.
TAKEN AMENDMENT TO RESTRICT ALL
SALES THAT YOU WON'T BE SELLING
ANY OF THIS INFORMATION TO THIRD
PARTIES.
YEAH I WOULD.
WE TAKE THAT A MOMENT ABSOLUTELY
AND BY THE WAY WE ACTUALLY SAID
IN THE STATEMENT WE'RE WILLING
TO CONTINUE TO CLARIFY WHAT
SHARE MEANS.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THERE IS A
THERE IS IF THIS IS NOT CLEAR
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
CLARIFY NOT MAKE THINGS MORE.
CONFUSING.
I RESPECT WHAT WAS DONE IN THE
C. C. P. AND I RESPECT THAT THE
WORK THAT YOU ALL DID LAST YEAR
I REALLY DO -- WHEN I WENT TO MY
DISTRICT AND TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THE LOYALTY PROGRAMS ARE
GOING AWAY OVER ALL THE OTHER
BILLS I WAS WORKING ON?
PEOPLE'S FIRST ALERT WAS THAT
RAIN AND SO I RESPECT THE WORK
THAT WAS DONE ON CCPA I DON'T
WANT TO CHANGE IT I'M NOT TRYING
TO LOOSEN IT.
I AM JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS MORE CLEAR SO A MEMO
THAT WERE PROPOSED UNFORTUNATELY
FOR US.
PARTS OF THEM WERE NOT
COMPLETELY CLEAR BUT WE ARE
FULLY COMMITTED TO WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE THAT SOME
OF THESE ISSUES THAT HAVE LEFT
AND LEFT UNCLEAR.
ARE MADE MORE CLEAR SO WOULD YOU
TAKE A MOMENT TO RESTRICT ALL
SALES FOR PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE
IN THESE LOYALTY PROGRAM SO YOU
WON'T BE SELLING THE ITEM I DO.
IT'S MY REAL THE COULD LOOK I
UNDERSTAND NO NO NO I OF AYE IF
YOU WILL I WILLING TO DO THAT I
THINK THAT MAKES CARE OF A LOT
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE.
YEAH RIGHT IT'S VERY GOOD APP
BUT IT IS WE ARE NOT GOING TO
SELL THE INFORMATION.
OKAY KNOW WHAT I THINK THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL.
WHAT WE SHARE IS COMPLICATED AND
THAT'S WHY WE WANTED TO CLARIFY
SHARE -- SORRY THROUGH THE CHAIR
BECAUSE I'M ANSWER THAT'S OKAY
PLEASE FEEL FREE.
I'M SURE IT THE PROBLEM IS IS
THE WAY IT'S DEFINED IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WERE GIVEN
SHARES AND CLEAR SO LIKE SO WHAT
HAPPENS ISN'T THERE ARE
INSTANCES IN WHICH SHARE MAY BE.
THE MAJOR CORPORATION HAS A
PRIVATE LITTLE PORTION THAT HAS
MORE LIKE I SAID MORE MARRIOTT
HOTELS.
ON THIS AFFECTS HOTEL WORKERS
RIGHT THIS WE HAVE ANOTHER HOTEL
THAT THERE'S A AND THAT.
SPECIFIC PROPERTY AS A PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
ACCORDING TO THE MOMENT THAT WE
WERE GIVEN IT WOULDN'T ALLOW US
TO SHARE THOSE THOSE POINTS WITH
THAT PARTICULAR HOTEL WHICH GETS
SUPER COMPLICATED.
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
CONVERSATION OF WHAT SHARE MEANS
WE JUST WANTED TO BE CLEAR I'M
NOT PASSING A BILL TO MAKE IT
MORE UNCLEAR I'M PASSING A BILL
TO MAKE IT MORE CLEAR -- AND
MIGHT LIKE I SAID MY GOAL IS NOT.
TO TO ANA DISMISSED THE CCPA AND
I THINK THAT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE MICK JAGGER AND NEUTRAL
SHOWS THAT WE HAVE DONE THE WORK
TO DO THAT [inaudible]
BUT I STILL IT THEY HAVE TO BE
FUNCTIONAL AND LIKE I SAID.
IN MY DISTRICT THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAMS
AND EVERY DOLLAR COUNTS EVEN FOR
MYSELF BE CLEAR I'M A SINGLE
MOTHER AND JUST LIKE THAT JUST
LIKE THE SENATOR SAID.
I USE MY CREDIT CARD TO GET
SOUTH WEST POINT AND NOT TELL MY
DAUGHTER GETS HERE.
EVERY WEEK BECAUSE I'VE USE THAT
CREDIT CARD NUMBER ON THOSE
POINTS.
THESE POINTS BATTERY PEOPLE AND
LOYALTY MATTERS TO COMPANIES AND
TO PEOPLE AND THE BENEFITS THAT
COME WITH THAT ARE IN.
ARE IMPORTANT AND WE ALL AGREE
ON THAT AND I THINK WE ALL AGREE
ON THAT.
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEANER CENTER
MONEY.
THE CLEAR FINE -- IT DOES SOUND
LIKE THE AUTHORS WILLING TO HAVE
EXPLICIT LANGUAGE THAT
INFORMATION CAN'T BE SOLD --
WHICH I THINK ADDRESSES A LOT OF
THE CONCERNS I ALSO THINK JUST
TO BE CLEAR MY UNDERSTANDING.
WHEN?
OPPONENTS SUGGESTED THAT YOU HAD.
TO YOU HAD TO PAY FOR THE FOR
THE PRIVILEGE OF WHAT WAS
OFFERED.
I UNDERSTOOD THAT IN A DIFFERENT
WAY NOT THAT YOU HAD.
TO PUT DOWN MONEY HERE RIGHT IT
CHECKER HAVE SOMETHING TAKEN OUT
OF YOUR CREDIT CARD.
BUT RATHER IF YOU WANT TO
EXERCISE THE ABILITY TO OPT OUT.
THE YOU LOSE THEN THE BENEFIT OF
BEING A MEMBER OF THE LAW AND I
GET THAT AND THAT'S WHAT LOYALTY
IS.
I MEAN THAT IS THE PROCESS RIGHT
I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S WHAT YOU
BUT REFER TO IT WHEN YOU
SPENDING YOUR MONEY WITH SOME
YOU GET A DISCOUNT.
BUT CURRENTLY THERE'S NO COST TO
BE A MEMBER OF THE LOYALTY.
PROGRAM.
BUT IF YOU WANT.
TO ASK THAT YOUR INFORMATION NOT
BE SHARED OR SOLD.
YOU CAN LOSE THE BENEFIT AND
THAT'S NOT RIGHT AND IT IS IT'S
IT'S A LOSS OF THE BENEFIT OF
BEING LOYAL TO A SPECIFIC.
COMPANY OR AT AND BY THE WAY
THAT'S A BENEFIT AND IF YOU
DON'T WANT IT. TO IS SOON THEN
I'M TOO STUPID TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER NO NO DON'T IT WHETHER I
AM TOO I CAN'T EVALUATE IF IT'S
MORE IPORTANT TO ME. TO SHARE
TO MAKES TO TO HAVE THAT LOYALTY
AND TO BE PART OF THAT PROGRAM
OR WHETHER IT'S BETTER FOR ME TO
OPT OUT AND NOT BE PART OF THAT.
SHOULD BE MY CHOICE RIGHT.
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT THE
WAY YOU'RE CHARACTERIZING IT.
IT'S IF I WANT TO PROTECT MY
PRIVACY RIGHT.
I'M GONNA SACRIFICE THE BENEFITS
AND NOT YOUR CHOICE.
IT IS A THAT RESULTS CHOICE THAT
WE ARE ADDING ACOSTA I'M GIVING
UP A BENEFIT TO PROTECT MY
PRIVACY.
AND THAT IS A CHOICE WE WE MAKE
WE MAKE CHOICES EVERY DAY WE
MAKE A CHOICE WHETHER WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO WORK TO THIS
MORNING WE MAKE ALL SORTS OF
CHOICES AND YES.
I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU AND I'M
NOT GOING TO DENY THAT THAT IF
NOT WANT YOUR INFORMATION IN
THEIR DATABASE.
THEN YOU CHOICE CHOOSE TO PAY
THE PRICES THAT EVERYONE ELSE
PAYS.
I AGREE THAT THAT IS TO BE ONE
OF THE BENEFITS OF BEING A LOYAL
CUSTOMER OF ANYTHING WHEN I WALK
INTO A RESTAURANT.
THAT I GO TO ALL THE TIME AND MY
GUY SEES ME HE SAYS ALL.
WOULD YOU LIKE A FREE APPETIZER
TODAY THAT'S MUCH HE OFFERS THAT
BECAUSE I COME THERE ALL THE
TIME RIGHT AND HE GIVES THAT TO
ME FOR COMING ALL THE TIME.
IT IS A CHOICE THAT THAT YOU
MAKE I CAN'T AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE.
FEEL LIKE LESS OF A SACRIFICE IF
I KNEW.
MEETING A MEMBER THAT LOYALTY
CLUB.
DID NOT.
I HAD THE ASSURANCE THAT MY
INFORMATION WOULDN'T BE SOLD SO
PERHAPS WHAT WE CAN DO TO
CLARIFY AND THAT'LL HELP US SORT
OF KIND OF A NARROW THE
CONVERSATION.
IS IF YOU WOULD TAKE IN ADDITION
TO THOSE TWO AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE AGREED TO AN AMENDMENT THAT
SAYS.
THAT -- DID.
THAT UNDER THESE LOYALTY
PROGRAMS THESE COMPANIES WOULD
RESTRICT THE ALL SELLING OF
INFORMATION GATHERED AS PART OF
THE PROGRAM WOULD YOU ACCEPT
THAT.
ALL RIGHT I THINK IF THAT'S THE
CASE I THINK THAT THAT HELPS US
TREMENDOUSLY AND AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I AM VERY GOOD.
OUR ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AS
AMENDED -- CENTER SIR ANYBODY
ELSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT IS THE BILL'S
PASSING AYE I WON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT.
IT'S GOING TO PASS.
OKAY GOOD WELL THANK YOU SEE --
CREATIONS ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
AS AMENDED THE TWO THAT WERE
ACCEPTED PLUS THE AMENDMENT --
THAT RESTRICTS THE SELLING OF
ALL INFORMATION GATHERED AS PART
OF A LOYALTY PROGRAM
[inaudible]
GOOD.
ARE YOU.
GOOD WITH THAT.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND FOR EVERYONE TO GO HOME
AND SLEEP WELL.
AMEN.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION -- TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HALLELUJAH --
PLEASE SIR CALL ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB
EIGHT FORTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON HI.
JACKSON HI BURGESS TO RUSSELL.
HI GONZALEZ THE BULLS EYE JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN AYE AMBER.
AMBER I WOULD CASKEY WHAT HAS HE
AYE EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
ALL.
WE HAVE ONE LAST BILL.
AWESOME.
AWESOME AWESOME.
FINAL BILL WILL WAIT A SECOND
FOR PEOPLE TO LEAVE WHEN WE DO
THAT
[inaudible]
I ARIEL FUNCTIONS NICE TO MEET
YOU.
I'LL BE GOING TO ANSWER THE HARD
QUESTIONS THAT [inaudible]
S..
I THINK HE'S TAKING THAT I THINK
IS.
AM PRESENT FOR YEAH.
DON'T ASK ME HARD QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR JONES ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER YOU
WILL E OUR CLOSER TODAY FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN THIS IS AB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AND I UNDERSTAND
YOU'LL BE TAKING OR THE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
YOU'RE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS.
ON PAGE SIX COMMENT.
ONE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES THING THAT CORRECT.
I'M SORRY IS THAT ACCURATE YES
WE ARE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER IS
ACCEPTING THE MINUTES THAT IS
ACCURATE.
AND WITH ME HERE TODAY IS THERE --
FOX JOHNSON IF WE HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES OPERATORS OF
SOCIAL MEDIA WEBSITES OR
APPLICATIONS TO USE A METHOD
THAT INCLUDES REASONABLE MEASURE
MEASURES TO ENSURE A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN.
IS PROVIDED CONSENT BEFORE CHILD
OF THIRTEEN YEARS OF AGE OR
UNDER CAN CREATE AN ACCOUNT THIS
WAS PART OF THE C. CPA.
ALSO I THINK JUDY PR HAS
SOMETHING SIMILAR THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
ANY ANY SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION COMMENT
COMMONSENSE IS SUPPORTING WITH
THE AMENDMENTS.
I'M SORRY COMMON SENSE IS
SUPPORTING OFTEN THEY CAN THANK
YOU GREAT.
A SUPPORT.
OF ANY SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
THE REGULARS INTERNET
ASSOCIATION JUST BRIEFLY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS --
STRICTLY PROHIBITING USE OF THE
INFORMATION.
WE THINK THAT PARENTS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO ALLOW FOR THE USE AND
CONSENT AN OPT INTO THE
CONTINUED USE OF SOME OF THE
INFORMATION WE AGREE WITH AUTHOR
CINEMAS WHO'VE BEEN WORKING
EXTENSIVELY.
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER
ABOUT CONFORMING THE BILL TO CAL
THE FEDERAL STANDARD AND IT WILL
WORK TO ADDRESS THE NEW
AMENDMENT.
COURTNEY JOHNSON WITH TECH THAT
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF THE
INTERNET SENSATION THANK YOU --
WITH CAL CHAMBER ECHOING THE
SAME COMMENTS THANK YOU.
MY NOTES SAY NO OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT.
A CLOSER PROBES MERE.
OR IS IT IS IT AND THE MOTIONS
PASS THE FLORA PASTOR PROBES.
S. TO THE FLOOR ALL RIGHT -- ANY
QUESTIONS ANYBODY. TO HAVE A
MOTION.
SORRY MOVE BY CENTER ON BURKE.
DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION JUST.
THE HOUSE THAT IT IS THE MEMON
WORKER I'M SO SORRY FOR NOT
BEING.
MATT FURTHER IN THE WEEDS ON A
YEAH.
SURE SO WHAT THE AMENDMENT DOES
IS IT SAYS THAT INFORMATION
PROVIDED FOR PURPOSES OF FOR
FRONTAL CONSENT SHALL NOT BE
RETAINED OR USED FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSES.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
LAW COP I WHICH PROTECTS
CHILDREN IN THIS INSURES THAT A
A PHOTO IDENTIFICATION CARD IN
WHICH BECAUSE SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANY MIGHT RUN OFFICIAL
RECOGNITION OR SOMETHING TO
VERIFY THAT YOUR PARENT OF A
CHILD.
IS NOT THEN USE FOR OTHER
COMMERCIAL PURPOSES IT'S ALL IF
IT'S PROVIDED FOR PARENTAL
CONSENT PURPOSES ONLY USED FOR
SUCH PURPOSES [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANKS.
WHEN A CLOSE I I WILL CLOSE
QUICKLY I HAD MY OWN --
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER
TRICKED ME INTO PRESENTING IT
FARM SO I ASKED FOR A VOTE.
HE'S A HE'S A VERY SHREWD
CHARACTER ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT JACKSON
JACKSON AYE BORDERS TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES I'M MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN HI --
BURKE NUMBER I WOULD CAL SKI.
CASKEY BY. EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS CHAO WILL CLOSE ROLE
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE TIME. FOR EVERYONE WHO
MAY HAVE MISSED A VOTER TO AND I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY ALL OF US
AT SOME POINT BEING OUT OF THE
ROOM.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD.
AND LET'S START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR GOING TO GIVE THE
SECRETARY MOMENT TO JUST GET
ORGANIZED.
YOU KNOW I YOU MISS ME JEANS.
VOTED ON EVERYTHING EVER KNOWN
AS WELL I THINK SOME HERE.
DO YOU WANT ME TO READ.
CAN I JUST DOUBLE CHECK.
AND I THINK WE HAVE ONE STRAIGHT
A STUDENT WHO WAS HERE
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE HEARING IN
BROUGH TO SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THAT'S A YEAH PERFECT ATTENDANCE.
I'M HOPING SO YEAH.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL AND I WOULD THINK
THE SERGEANTS FOR A YOUNG
PERSON'S JOB THIS WAS A VERY
TOUGH HEARING THIS MORNING DOWN
IN. TWENTY FORTY WITH HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE IN THE HALLWAY
AND THE SAME HERE THANK YOU
ENOUGH I THINK IT'S A MOMENT TO
TO THANK THE EXTRAORDINARY STAFF
THAT I AM HONORED.
TO WORK WITH FOR THEIR I I THINK
I THINK I'M GONNA MISS THOSE
FIVE AM TEXTS THAT I'VE BEEN
GETTING OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
DAYS THESE FOLKS HAVE BEEN
WORKING NONSTOP AND DOING AN
EXTRAORDINARY JOB AND THANK YOU
TO OUR A CHIEF AND TO THE
WONDERFUL STAFF FOR THEIR
AMAZING.
WORK THIS YEAR REALLY AWESOME.
YOU CAN GO AND OUR PUBLIC.
DO YOU STAY UP UNTIL FIVE IN THE
MORNING TO THESE.
YOUR VOICE YOUR DISTRICT -- GET
THEIR ENERGY ON EXCELLENT
EXCELLENT TWELVE ALWAYS HAPPY
BRING THEM DOWN ANY TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE READY TO GO.
YES MA'AM WE ARE READY READY
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS JONES.
JONES I AM MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I EIGHT ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDARS ARE.
NEXT IS FILE ITEM -- ONE AB NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MOTION AS HE PASSES A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
JONES.
JON SNOW MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN I SEVEN
TO ONE THAT TO THE BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM TO AB.
TWENTY FIVE TWO YES I WILL DO
THAT THANK YOU -- FILE ITEM TO
AB TWENTY FIVE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS SURE
VOTING I GORGEOUS.
JONES.
JONES I'M MONNING.
MORNING I STERN STERN AYE THE
TODAY TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B.
FORTY FOUR TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR VOTING
ON A GORGEOUS JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN AYE SEVEN TO ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM FOR A. B..
FIFTY ONE DO PASS TO APPROACH --
HERE.
I DON'T THINK I WAS HERE FOR
THAT -- ONE FOUR ZERO CURRENTLY
THE CURRENT VOTERS FORTY ZERO OF
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B.
FIFTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON AYE
JACKSON AYE BORDERS JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN HI SEVEN
TO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT TO PASS TO APPROACH SURE
VOTING HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS.
MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN I BURKE.
NUMBER I WENT CAL SKI.
I KELSEY I SEVEN SEVEN TWO ONE
THE BILL ITSELF I'LL ITEM SIX AB
ONE SEVENTY FIVE TO PASS TO
APPROACH YOUR VOTING I ORDERS.
JONES JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN AYE ON
BURKE.
NUMBER BY SEVEN TO ONE THAT BILL
IS SHOCKED.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB ONE
SEVENTY NINE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING
ON GORGEOUS JONES.
JONES I'M MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN HI.
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE -- ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB THREE OH TWO TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROACH PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN STERN HI SEVEN
ONE THAT BILL IS SHELVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB.
THREE THIRTY THREE OF WAS AND
CONSENT.
I THINK THAT WAS ON CONSENT
WITHOUT OUR CONSENT.
NO NO NO NO. TO PASS TO APPROACH.
SHARE VOTING HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS MORNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN AYE EIGHT SEVEN TO ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM TEN
AB THREE SEVENTY SIX TO PASS TO
A PROBST YOU'RE VOTING AYE.
FORGES JONES.
NUMBER TEN FILE FILE ITEM TEN AB.
THREE SEVENTY SIX JONES NO
MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN AYE
SEVEN TO ONE THE BILL IS SHOCKED
FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
OF CHAIR VOTING HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS PORGES.
JONES JONES NO STERN.
STERN AYE SEVEN TO ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM TWELVE AB THREE
EIGHTY FOUR DO PASSED TO
APPROACH.
OF ACCOUNT IS FOUR TO ZERO CHAIR
VOTING ON GORGEOUS JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
NUMBER.
NUMBER HI SIX TO ONE THE BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM THIRTEEN A BEFORE --
THREE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
OF THE VOTE COUNT IS SIX TWO ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MEMBERS.
FORGES STERN -- FILE EITHER
THIRTEEN A BEFORE -- THREE STERN
AYE. SEVEN TWO ONE THE BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB.
FOUR FOUR SIX IT WAS PULLED.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. FIVE OH
SIX TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
THE VOTE COUNT IS SIX TO ZERO
CHAIR VOTING I PLEASE GO. SEVEN
A SURE EXCUSE ME CHAIR VOTING I
GORGEOUS RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I A TWO ZERO THE BILL
ITSELF FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
FIVE THIRTY NINE TO PASS TO
APPROACH.
VOTE COUNTY IS -- SIX TO ZERO
CHAIR VOTING I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FORGES JONES.
JONES NO STERN.
STERN AYE SEVEN A ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB SIX
OH TWO TO PASS TO APPROACH THE
VOTE COUNT IS FIVE TWO ZERO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BORDERS JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I SEVEN TO WALK BY A TWO
ZERO EXCUSE ME THAT BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM TWENTY AB SIX SEVENTY
THREE THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE VOTE COUNTY IS SIX TO ZERO
PLEASE CALL THE CHAIR VOTING I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FORGES JONES [inaudible]
NUMBER.
NUMBER I HAVE.
AM DESERVE SEVEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO OKAY.
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B..
SEVEN TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO A PROBES.
I'M SORRY TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE COUNT IS
FIVE TO ONE SURE VOTING I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FORGES.
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I ON BURKE.
NUMBER I SEVEN ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR A. B.
SEVEN THIRTY MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
THE VOTE COUNT IS.
THREE TO ONE AND SEE WHICH ONES
OF ARM CHAIR HADN'T VOTED SO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
JACKSON HI JACKSON ON A BORDERS.
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN [inaudible]
STERN I VOTE COUNT IS SIXTY TO
SIXTY TWO THE BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
ME
.
SECOND SECOND HALF HERE WE GO --
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX AB EIGHT
HUNDRED TO A TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE COUNT IS.
SEVEN TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING I
GORGEOUS UMBERG.
NUMBER I EIGHT TWO ZERO THEIR
BILLS ARE FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AS AMENDED -- BEAU COUNT IS --
FIVE TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
FORTUS JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN ICE SEVEN TO ONE THAT
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE
AB EIGHT SEVENTY THREE NO
[inaudible]
NEVER MIND.
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE AB NINE
ELEVEN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROACH THE VOTE COUNTY IS SIX
TO ZERO PLEASE -- CHAIR VOTING I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I AM BURKE.
NUMBER EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT BILL
IS SHOCKED FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
AB NINE THIRTY ONE TWO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROACH.
THE VOTE COUNTY IS OF FOUR TO
ONE THE CHAIR VOTING I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FORGES
TO WRESTLE. TO WRESTLE I AM
BURKE. FIVE TWO ONE FIVE TO ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FOUR I'M SORRY.
THIRTY EIGHT ALTHOUGH ONE SECOND
WITH.
I CAN'T CAN RIGHT TO ONE
COLLEGES ARE BACK IN FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO AB NINE THIRTY ONE
COULD CATCH KEVIN.
DO PASSES AMENDED TO APPROACH.
THE FINAL VOTE COUNT IS SIX TO
ONE THE BILL IS OUT.
NEXT IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
THIRTY EIGHT AB ELEVEN FORTY TWO
TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE COUNT IS
FIVE TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING I
FORGES JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
THE ACCOUNT IS SIX TWO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE A. B.
ELEVEN FORTY SIX TO PASS A TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF ACCOUNT IS
FIVE TWO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
FORGES JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN HI EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM FORTY AB --
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO PAST AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE COUNT
TO SIX TO ONE SURE VOTING OUR
BORDERS RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I HAVE SEVEN ONE THAT
BILL ITSELF FILE ITEM FORTY ONE
A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS THE
VOTE COUNT AS SIX TO ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BORDERS STERN.
STERN OF ONLY SEVEN ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM FORTY TWO
A. B.. ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE
COUNT IS FOUR TO ONE SURE VOTING
I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN AYE ON BURKE.
NUMBER I EIGHT A SEVEN TO ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE A. B. TWELVE THIRTY TO DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE EQ.
THE VOTE COUNT IS SIX TO ZERO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BORDERS MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN AYE A TWO ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR A.
B. TWELVE FIFTY NO I'M SORRY
CONSENT CONSENT CONSENT HOLD.
FILE ITEM FIFTY A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE FLOOR THE VOTE COUNT IS
SIX TO ZERO THAT YOU'RE VOTING I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS A FILE ITEM FIFTY A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS PURCHASE
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING I SEVEN ONE THAT BILL IS
CHAU NEXT IS FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO
A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN DO PAST
APPROPRIATIONS OF ACCOUNTS FIVE
TO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN [inaudible]
STERN I SEVEN ONE THE BILL
ITSELF FILE ITEM.
FIFTY THREE THE END FILE WHERE
IT FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATOR PROBES.
THE VOTE COUNT IS FORTY ZERO
CHAIR VOTING I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN AB
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO GORGEOUS
JONES.
JON SNOW MONNING.
MORNING I STERN.
STERN AYE ON BURKE.
THE ACCOUNT IS SIX TWO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM SIXTY A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY FOUR TWO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF ACCOUNT IS FOR
TWO ZERO CHAIR VOTING ON
GORGEOUS JONES.
JONES NO MONNING MONNING AYE
STERN.
STERN I ON BURKE.
FILE ITEM SIXTY AB FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR BY A ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
OKAY WILL WILL GIVE ME A MOMENT.
NUMBER AYE RIGHT THE NEW ONE
SEVEN A ONE THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY ONE AB FIFTY FIFTEEN SIXTY
FOUR DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF ACCOUNT AS
FIVE TO ZERO SURE VOTING I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
JONES.
JONES I MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
WHILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY ONE A
BEAUTIFUL OF THE TIRE.
YES JEAN SIXTY FOUR ARE GOOD
STERN AYE HE TWO ZERO EIGHT TWO
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT WE WE GET
JUST A FEW MORE HANG IN THERE
FOLKS.
ALL RIGHT FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE VOTE COUNT THE USER IS --
THREE TWO ZERO SURE DID NOT VOTE
AT THAT HASN'T VOTED YET PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY THREE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORCHERS JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I AND ONE SEVEN TWO ONE
THE BILL ITSELF.
ALL RIGHT THE NEXT ITEM UP IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE TO PASS A
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTE COUNT
IS.
FIVE TWO ZERO SURE VOTING I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FORGES JONES.
JONES NO STERN [inaudible]
A MARK -- AT THE VOTE COUNT IS.
FIVE TWO FIVE TO ONE AND THE
BILL IS OUT.
OUR LAST ITEM FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SIX AB SEVENTEEN NINETY DO
PASSES AMENDED.
IT WAS CALLED. SIXTY FIVE A
SPONSOR -- AB. SEVENTEEN NINETY
NUMBER.
SIXTY SIX OUR DO PASSES AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR THE VOTE
COUNT IS SIX TO ONE SURE VOTING
AYE.
FORGES TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I'D SEVEN TO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT AND WE ARE DONE.
WORD TURNED